in recent years deep learning and NLP
have made a big difference in the world
for example computers are now really
good at recognizing pictures almost as
good as people also in NLP a model
called gpt3 can write like a person and
answer questions as well this helps make
chat bards and translations better the
these Technologies are also helping in
medicine education and more making
things more Innovative and better they
are changing our world a lot and with
significant change comes a chance to
make high paying career in this field
people with knowledge of deep learning
and NLP are in high demand across the
globe and if you want to join them then
you are definitely at the right place
hey everyone welcome to Simply learn and
in this video we will take you through
the Deep deep learning and NLP course in
a very well structured and precise way
but before we begin remember to
subscribe to our Channel because we
bring the best videos for you daily also
hit the Bell icon to never miss any
updates from us also if you want to
become a successful deep learning or
machine learning expert and gain
handsome salary packages then look at
the wide range of EI and machine
learning courses by simply learn in
collaboration with topnotch universities
across the globe by enrolling in any of
these certification programs you will
learn in demand skills such as machine
learning deep learning NLP computer
vision reinforcement learning generative
AI prompt engineering chat GPD and much
more so what are you waiting for hurry
up and enroll now and year of experience
is preferred to enroll in these courses
find the course Link in the description
box so without any further delay let's
hand over this session to our training
experts hey everyone in this video we'll
be talking about n LP in the next 10
minutes so what can you expect from this
video what's in it for you first we'll
give you a basic understanding of NLP
we'll tell you why we need NLP and we'll
talk about what NLP exactly is next
we'll look at NLP pipelines NLP
pipelines cover the basic processes
involved in text passing in NLP which
means converting text to a form suitable
for machines to understand as humans
would understand it and finally we'll
talk about some real world applications
of NLP which are all around us and a lot
more common than you might have realized
so let's get started so what exactly is
NLP before we talk about NLP let's talk
about how humans talk and interact with
each other humans communicate with each
other mostly via speech or text to
convey your intent to someone you may
directly talk to them or send them a
message the human way of communicating
is known as as natural language around
the globe many languages are spoken and
messages are shared virtually every
single day all these conversations
feedbacks and messages are data in
themselves this data is extremely
valuable as it can give us customer
information and insight into human
sentiment however this data is not
useful to computers as it is not in a
form that can be understood by machines
machines communicate using ones and
zeros and not via words they cannot
understand English French or Spanish
only
binary and this is where NLP comes into
the picture NLP stands for natural
language processing natural language
processing is a branch of artificial
intelligence that deals with the
interactions between humans and
computers using the natural language the
ultimate objective of NLP is to read
decipher understand and make sense of
human languages in a manner that is
valuable and to build systems that can
make sense of text and perform tasks
like translation grammar checking or
topic classification NLP basically is
the task of processing written forms of
languages and making a computer
understand them companies are
increasingly using NLP equipped tools to
gain insights from data and to automate
routine tasks a sentiment analyzer for
instance can help Brands detect emotions
in text such as negative comments on
social media
NLP at the end of the day is nothing
more than a cumulation of artificial
intelligence computer science and the
human language the next topic that we'll
be looking at are NLP
pipelines so what exactly are pipelines
a pipeline is a set of data processing
Elements which are connected in series
where the output of one element is the
input of the next one it basically
represents the various steps which have
to be taken in our computation and the
the order in which they
occur in this pipeline we are going to
be parsing our data parsing means
converting our data from one form to
another in this case we are passing our
input Text data to a file which can be
understood by a computer the text is
first broken into segments and the
segments are then converted into even
smaller
tokens the word stems of all of these
tokens are found for followed by finding
the root words of these stems in a
process known as
lemmatization we will then recognize
which part of speech the word belongs to
which means if the word is a verb a noun
or a pronoun and finally we will
separate the instances of everyday
popular entities from our words to
better understand what the sentence is
trying to convey the final file that
we'll get will be a file which will be
understood by a computer segmentation
the first process of a pipeline is
segmentation now what exactly is
segmentation sentence segmentation or
text segmentation is basically dividing
the given text into logically
decipherable units of information we
divide the sentence into its constituent
Subs sentences usually along the
punctuations like full stops or commas
or along line breaks and Page components
for HTML files dividing a document into
its constituent sentences allows us to
process it without losing its Essence
and the necessary information that it
contains in this case let's consider a
sentence the lemonade quenched her
thirst but not her longing after
sentence segmentation we are going to
divide the sentence into two the first
sentence is going to be the lemonade
quenched her thirst and the second one
is going to be but not her longing the
next step of our pipeline is called
tokenization tokenization is nothing but
the process of dividing a sentence into
its constituent words the sentence that
is given to us will be separated and all
the words in the sentence will be stored
separately this is done so we can
understand the syntactic and semantic
information contained in each sentence
thus we decipher the relevance of a
sentence by analizing it word by word
thereby making sure that no loss of
information occurs the computer does not
understand punctuations and special
characters hence we can remove any
punctuations and special characters
which may occur let's take a part of a
previously segmented sentence over here
let's consider the lemonade quenched her
thirst after tokenization we are going
to separate every single word in this
sentence so after tokenization we are
going to get five different tokens the
lemonade quenched her and thirst all all
of these are going to be treated as
separate entities after tokenization we
perform stemming stemming is a process
of obtaining the word stems of a word
word stems are also known as the base
form of a word and we can create new
words by attaching a fixes to them in a
process known as inflection stemming is
a process of recognizing the word stems
of individual words this is done by
removing affixes such as in s ed etc for
example consider our sentence jump jump
is the word stem of various different
words like
jumping jumped and jumps if we remove
all of these affixes we will get our
basic word stem which is Jump this is
basically what we want at the end of
stemming the next process in our
pipeline is called lemmatization
lemmatization is the process of figuring
out the root form or root word which is
nothing but the most basic form also
known as is the LMA of each word in the
sentence lemmatization is very similar
to stemming where we remove word affixes
to get the base form of a word the
difference is that the root word is
always a word which is present in the
dictionary but the root stem may not be
so lemmatization uses a knowledge Base
called word net let's consider three
different words went going and gone at
the end of the day all of these words
have originated from a single word
which is go in this case go is our LMA
all the other words which are derived
from go can be traced back to it the
next part of our pipeline is called part
of speech tagging part of speech tagging
is a process of converting a sentence to
different forms it can be a list of
words or a list of
tuples the tag in case of is a part of
speech tag and signifies whether the
word is a noun adjective verb and so on
we have basically splitting our verbs
into the grammatical components to
understand the meaning of any sentence
or to extract relationships and to build
a Knowledge Graph part of speech tagging
is a very important step as the same
word can have different part of speeches
in different
sentences for example let's consider the
sentence give me your answer in this
sentence answer is a noun but if we
consider another sentence answer the
question over here answer will be a verb
using part of speech tagging we can take
our different tokens and find the
different part of speech that it belongs
to in this case the is a determiner
lemonade is a noun quenched is a verb
her is a pronoun and thirst is a noun
the final step in our NLP pipeline that
we are looking at here is nothing but
named entity recognition named entity
recognition also known as named entity
identification entity chunking and
entity extraction is a subtask of
information extraction that seeks to
locate and classify named entities which
are mentioned in unstructured text into
predefined categories extracting the
main entities in a text helps us sort
unstructured data and detect important
information which is crucial if you have
to deal with large data sets the
subcategories that we are considering
are person whether the named entity is a
person whether it's a quantity like
kilograms a
location an
organization the name of a movie or
whether it's a monetary value like
dollars or
Euros so far we've looked at what NLP is
and how we can perform natural language
processing but what are some
applications of it and where is it used
in the real world
one of the applications of NLP is in
chat Bots chat Bots can help you solve
issues while performing natural language
generation in other words they can hold
a conversation in plain English a
chatbot is nothing but a software
application which can be used to conduct
an online chat conversation either
through text or speech in place of
providing direct contact with a life
human agent you might have seen those
talk to one of our agents section on
websites those are usually chat Bots a
lot of companies also use WhatsApp chat
Bots to make the process seem less
mechanical another application of NLP is
speech recognition probably the most
popular example of NLP in action are
virtual assistants like Google assist
Siri and Alexa natural language
processing understands and translates
the human language like Hey Siri where
is the nearest gas station into numbers
making it easy easy for machines to
understand they recognize when you are
talking converting speech to text and
understand what you requested over the
years virtual assistants have become
streamlined enough to be able to emulate
human speech patterns almost flawlessly
another application of NLP is autoc
correction autoc correction also known
as text replacement replace as you type
or simply autocorrect is an automatic
data validation function commonly found
in word processors and text editing
interfaces for smartphones and tablet
computers it acts as a spell check and
corrects any spellings or grammar
mistakes which may arise as you are
typing some language check softwares
like grammarly paper rator reverso and
others can even check how unique and
engaging your articles are and all of
this is done using NLP hello everyone
welcome to this video on the natural
language processing engineer NLP
engineer road map by simply learn to
stay updated with our content make sure
to subscribe to our YouTube channel and
hit the Bell icon so in this video we
will Begin by examining the role of NLP
engineer progressing further our Focus
will shift toward the Essential
Knowledge and Skills required to excel
as an NLP engineer having
comprehensively explored these subjects
we will then proceed to explore the
inesis and consing of a professional
career road map tailored specifically
for individuals aspiring to become
accomplished anlp engers on that note if
you are an aspiring AIML engineer then
there is no better time to train
yourself in the exciting field of
machine learning if you are looking for
course that covers everything from the
fundamental to Advanced Techniques like
machine learning algorithm development
and unsupervised learning look no
further than our keltech program
partnership with IBM this AIML boot camp
in collaboration with keltech will help
you advance your career as AIML
specialist the AIML boot camp includes
live classes delivered by industry
expert handson L industry relevant
projects and master classes by celtech
Professor key features of this amazing
machine learning course includes ear up
to 22 cus from keltech ctme online
convocation by celtech ctm program
director simply career service helps you
get notice by top hiring companies on a
boot cam certificate from CeX ctm
industry relevant project in three
domains CeX ctm Circle membership 25
plus Hands-On project across industry
verticals with integrated Labs so why
wait join now seats are filling fast
find the course link from the
description box below so without any
further Ado let's get started so what is
NLP engineer an asure language
processing NLP engineer is a
professional responsible for crafting
and cting computer system that can
process assess and produce humanlike
language NLP branches out into numerous
captivating domains including semantic
analysis sentiment analysis face
recognition machine translation and
speech recognition the reach of NLP
extent across a diverse spectrum of
application notably featuring virtual
assistant chat boards sentiment analysis
customer service interaction and
language translation the task of NLP
engineer involves ER acting these
Innovative application and seemingly
embedding them into the existing
framework the average salary for NLP
engineer in India is 10 lakh per year
and in the US average annual salary for
NLP engineer is
$120,000 so moving forward let's see
skills required as an NLP engineer so
becoming an NLP engineer entails
acquisition of a diverse set of
application and knowledge some of these
encompasses first one is Proficiency in
programming Mastery of at least one
programming language such as python Java
or C++ coupled with a solid graphs of
data strcture algorithm and principle of
software engineering the second one is
grasp of machine learning building a
strong foundation in machine learning
algorithm and compassing both supervised
and unsupervised learning familiarity
with Advanced Techniques like CNN and
RNN is is vital the third one is NLP
techniques cultivating a deep
understanding of NLP techniques which
encompasses facets like text
pre-processing santing and semantic
analysis and the intricate domain of
sentiment analysis the fourth one is NLP
libraries and Frameworks navigate easily
through NLP libraries and Frameworks
such as natural language toolkit nltk
spy Stanford code NLP and genim
harnessing their capabilities to
streamline your NLP and davors the fifth
one is data science acuma developing a
sound GPS of data science principles and
compassing facet such as data
visualization statical analysis and the
Art of data manipulation armed with
these multifaced skill set you will be
primed to embark on a journey as an
accomplished NLP engineer ready to
navigate the complexity of natural
language processing and contribute to
the exciting world of NLP Innovation
moving forward let's see the
professional NLP engineer road map here
is a comprehensive professional
trajectory for those aspiring to become
NLP Engineers the first one is
Educational Foundation embark on your
journey by pursuing a degree in
compitent fields such as computer
science Linguistics or artificial
intelligence many accomplished NLP
Engineers hold Advanced degrees either a
master or PhD in these domains the
second one is internship or entry-level
Venture considering immersing yourself
in Practical experience through
internship or entry-level job within the
industry these opportunities not only
equ with the Hands-On expertise but also
Aid in conting a robust portfolio the
third one on the list is skills and
knowledge acquisition develop a
comprehensive grasp of essential
proficiency request of NLP engineer this
encompasses programming processes and
machine learning and anal techniques and
data science the fourth one is portfolio
development curate a diverse portfolio
teaming with projects that illuminate
your capabilities and expertise projects
like suffocated chatboard a sentiment
analysis tool or a language model can
sustain your aptitude for solving real
World NLP challenges and validate your
skill set for potential employers the
fifth one is networking EndWar engage in
conference meetups and industries event
to forge connection with fellow NLP
professionals the sixth one is
specialization consideration Ponder the
prospect of specialization in specific
NLP realm be it machine translation
speech recognition or conversational
agent this specialization not only
differentiate you in the job market but
also enables you to attain exper
within a particular need in summation
the part toward becoming an NLP engineer
entails a fusion of educational
attainment hands-on experience and the
Mastery of electric area of skills and
knowledge domains hello everyone and
welcome to this new video on NLP
engineer salary with the world advancing
towards a more informed and databased
future learning skills that help us to
be relevant in the job market is crucial
one such skill in the field of data and
AI is natural language processing let us
start by understanding what NLP is
natural language processing or NLP is a
branch of artificial intelligence or AI
that deals with understanding and
manipulating human language it seeks to
develop algorithms and systems that can
understand and process both structured
and unstructured language data to
support decision making processes LLP is
a field that has been gaining momentum
in recent years thanks to advance in
machine learning algor ithms and the
availability of large data sets such as
social media conversations customer
reviews and medical records NLP is used
in various applications such as language
translation sentiment analysis text
summarization and text generation if you
want to master NLP and become an expert
NLP engineer then you should enroll an
amazing Ai and machine learning program
by calch ctme you will gain skills like
machine learning deep learning re
enforcement learning NLP generative AI
prompt engineering chat GPT and more
this Ai and machine learning boot camp
includes live classes delivered by
industry experts Hands-On Labs industry
relevant projects and master classes by
calch instructors so hurry up what are
you waiting for enroll the course now
find the course Link in the description
box so before we move ahead consider
subscribing to Simply learn and hit the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
us so let's move ahead by knowing what
does NLP include at its score NLP
involves a series of steps number one is
pre-processing the first step in NLP is
to prepare the language data for
analysis this involves activities such
as cleaning tokenization and
normalization of the text Data step two
involves feature extraction the next
step is to extract relevant features
from the prepared data this involves
identifying keywords stems and parts of
speech tags that are important for the
task at hand step three involves model
training the extracted features are then
used to train a machine learning model
such as neural networks or a support
Vector machine to predict the target
variable and the last step is model
evaluation once the model is trained it
needs to be evaluated to ensure it
performs well on new data now let's move
ahead by knowing NLP job roles and
responsib ities are several job roles
that involves NLP and each role is
focused on different aspects of NLP here
are some most common NLP job roles the
number one is NLP engineer this role
involves developing and implementing NLP
Solutions including building machine
learning models designing pipelines and
developing apis NLP Engineers typically
have a background in engineering or
computer science and have knowledge of
machine learning algorithms software
development and dat data structures the
next we have is text analytics
specialist this role involves analyzing
large amount of Text data to extract
useful information text analytics
Specialists typically have a background
in data analysis statistics and machine
learning and they use NLP tools and
techniques to process and analyze text
Data language model engineer this role
involves developing and improving
natural language processing models such
as language models and machine
translation models language model
Engineers typically have a background in
computer science machine learning and
natural language processing on number
four we have NLP researcher this role
involves conducting Research into new
NLP methods and techniques NLP
researchers typically have a background
in computer science machine learning and
natural language processing and they
publish their research in various
academic journals and conferences and
the most awaited let's start with salary
of NLP Engineers let us now discuss the
salary of NLP engineers in India and USA
for the sake of better understanding we
will split up the salary ranges based on
the experience level of a professional
so let's start with entry-level NLP
engineers in India the salary ranges
from 2.5 million rupees to 5 million
rupees however in us the salary ranges
between $60,000 to $90,000 per year
enter level NLP Engineers typically have
background in computer science
engineering or a related field and have
some experience with NLP but may not
have yet worked on large scale
Enterprise projects moving towards
mid-level NLP Engineers these Engineers
earn 5 million to 8 million rupees per
year however in United States they earn
between $90,000 to
$120,000 per year mid-level NLP
Engineers have few years of experience
working on NLP projects and and are
typically comfortable working on both
Technical and business related aspects
of NLP projects they may have some
leadership responsibilities and are
often responsible for ensuring that NLP
projects are completed on time and to
speec next we have a senior level NLP
Engineers these Engineers earn up to 8
million rupees to 15 million rupees in
India per year however in United States
they earn between
$120,000 to
$165,000 per year senior level NLP
Engineers have extensive experience
working on Enterprise level NLP projects
and are often considered authorities in
NLP Technologies methods and tools they
may serve as subject matter experts lead
teams of Engineers and other NLP
professionals and be responsible for
ensuring the long-term success of NLP
projects human versus artificial
intelligence humans are amazing let's
just face it we're amazing amazing
creatures we're all over the planet
we're exploring every niit and Nook
we've gone to the Moon uh we've got into
outer space we're just amazing creatures
we're able to use the available
information to make decisions to
communicate with other people identify
patterns and data remember what people
have said adapt to new situations so
let's take a look at this so so you can
get a picture you're a human being so
you know what it's like to be human
let's take a look at artificial
intelligence versus the human artificial
intelligence develops computer systems
that can accomplish tasks that require
human
intelligence so we're looking at this
one of the things that computers can do
is they can provide more accurate
results this is very important recently
I did a project on cancer where it's
identifying
markers and as a human being you look at
that and you might be uh looking at all
the different images and the data that
comes off of them and say I like this
person so I want to give them a very
good um Outlook and the next person you
might not like so you want to give them
a bad Outlook well with artificial
intelligence you're going to get a
consistent prediction of what's going to
come out interacts with humans using
their natural language we've seen that
as probably the biggest development
feature right now that's in the
commercial Market that everybody gets to
use as we saw with the example of Alexa
they learn from their mistakes and adapt
to new environments so we see this
slowly coming in more and more and they
learn from the data and automate
repetitive learning repetitive learning
has a lot to do with the neural networks
you have to program thousands upon
thousands of pictures in there and it's
all automated so as today's computers
evolved it's very quick and easy and
affordable to do this what is machine
learning and deep learning all about
imagine this say you had some time to
waste not that any of us really have a
lot of time anymore to just waste in
today's world and you're sitting sitting
by the road and you have a whole lot of
and a whole lot of time passes by here's
a few hours and suddenly you wonder how
many cars buses trucks and so on passed
by in the six hours now chances are
you're not going to sit by the road for
six hours and count buses cars and
trucks unless you're working for the
city and you're trying to do City
Planning and you want to know hey do we
need to add a new truck route maybe we
need a Bicycle Link we have a lot of
bicyclists here that kind of thing so
maybe City Planning would be great for
this
machine learning well the way machine
Learning Works is we have labeled data
with
features okay so you have a truck or a
car a motorcycle a bus or a bicycle and
each one of those are labeled it comes
in and based on those labels and
comparing those features it gives you an
answer it's a bicycle it's a truck it's
a motorcycle this look a little bit more
in depth on this in the model here it
actually the features we're looking at
would be like the tires someone sits
there and figures out what a tire looks
like takes a lot of work if you try to
try to figure the difference between a
car tire a bicycle tire a motorcycle
tire uh so in the machine learning field
this could take a long time if you're
going to do each
individual aspect of a car and try to
get a result on there and that's what
they did do that was a a very this is
still used on smaller amounts of data
where you figure out what those features
are and then you label them deep
learning so with deep learning one of
our Solutions is to take a very large
unlabeled data set and we put that into
a training model using artificial neural
networks and then that goes into the
neural network itself when we create a
neural network and you'll see um the
arrows are actually kind of backward but
uh which actually is a nice point
because when we train the neural network
we put the bicycle in and then it comes
back and says if it said truck it comes
back and says well you need to change
that to bicycle and then it changes all
those weights going backward they call
it back propagation and let it know it's
a bicycle and that's how it learns once
you've trained the neural network you
then put the new data in and they call
this testing the model so you need to
have some data you've kept off to the
side where you know the answer to and
you take that and you provide the
required output and you say okay is this
is this neural network working correctly
did it identify a bike as a bike a truck
as a truck a motorcycle as a motorcycle
let's just take a little closer look at
that determin what objects are present
in the data so how does deep learning do
this and here we have the image of the
bike it's 28x 28 pixels that's a lot of
information there um could you imagine
trying to guess that this is a bicycle
image by looking at each one of those
pixels and trying to figure out what's
around it uh and we actually do that as
human beings it's pretty amazing we know
what a bicycle is and even though it
comes in as all this information and
what this looks like is the image comes
in it converts it into a bunch of
different nodes in this case there's a
lot more than what they show here and it
goes through these different layers and
out comes and says okay this is a
bicycle a lot of times they call this
the magic Black Box why because as we
watch it go across here all these
weights and all the math behind this and
it's not it's a little complicated on
the math side you really don't need to
know that when you're programming or
doing working with the Deep learning but
it's like magic you you don't know you
really can't figure out what's going to
come out by looking what's in each one
of those dots and each one of those
lines are firing and what's going in
between them so we like to call it the
magic box uh so that's where deep
learning comes in and in the end it
comes up and you have this whole neural
notwork it comes up and it says okay we
fire all these different pixels and we
connects all these different dots and
gives them different weights and it says
okay this is a bicycle and that's how we
determine what the object is present in
the data with deep learning machine
learning we're going to take a step into
machine learning here and you'll see how
these fit together in a minute the
system is is able to make predictions or
take decisions based on past data that's
very important for machine learning is
that we're looking at stuff and based on
what's been there before we're creating
a decision on there we're creating
something out of there we're coloring a
beach ball we're telling you what the
weather is in Chicago what's nice about
machine learning is a very powerful
processing capability it's quick and
accurate outcomes so you get results
right away once you program the system
the results are very fast and the
decisions and predictions are better
they're more accurate they're consistent
you can analyze very large amounts of
data some of these data things that
they're analyzing now are pedabytes and
terabytes of data it would take hundreds
of people hundreds of years to go
through some of this data and do the
same thing that the machine learning can
do in a very short period of time and
it's inexpensive compared to hiring
hundreds of people so it becomes a very
affordable way to move into the future
is to apply the machine learning to
whatever businesses you're working on
and deep Learning Systems think and
learn like humans using artificial
neural networks again it's like a magic
box performance improves with more data
so the more data the Deep learning gets
the more it gives you better results
it's scalability so you can scale it up
you can scale it down you can increase
what you're looking at currently you
know we're limited by the amount of
computer processing power as to how big
that can get but that envelope
continually gets pushed every day on
what it can do problem solved in an end
in method so instead of having to break
it apart and you have the first piece
coming in and you identify tires and the
second piece is identifying uh labeling
handlebars and then you bring that
together that if it has handlebars and
tires it's a bicycle and if it has
something that looks like a large Square
it's probably a truck the neural
networks does this all in one network
you don't really know what's going on in
all those weights and all those little
bubbles uh but it does it pretty much in
one package that's why the neural
network systems are so big nowadays and
coming into their own best features are
selected by the system and it this is
important they kind of put it as it's on
a bullet on the side here it's a subset
of machine learning this is important
when we talk about deep learning it is a
form of machine learning there's lots of
other forms of machine learning data
analysis but this is the newest and
biggest thing that they apply to a lot
of different packages and they use all
the other machine learning tools
available to work with it and it's very
fast to test um you put in your
information you then have your group of
uh test and then you held some aside you
see how does it do it's very quick to
test it and see what's going on with
your deep learning and your neural
network are they really all that
different AI versus machine learning
versus deep learning Concepts of AI so
we have concepts of AI you'll see
natural language processing uh machine
learning an approach to create
artificial intelligence so it's one of
the subsets of artificial intelligence
knowledge representation automated
reasoning computer vision robotics
machine learning versus AI versus deep
learning or Ai and machine learning and
deep
learning so when we look at this we have
ai with machine learning and deep
learning and so we're going to put all
together we find out that AI is a big
picture we have a collection of books it
goes through some deep learning the
Digital Data is analyze text mining
comes through the particular book you're
looking for maybe it's a genre books is
identified and in this case uh we have a
robot that goes and gives a book to the
patron I have yet to be at a library
that has a robot bring me a book but
that will be cool when it happens uh so
we look at some of the pieces here this
information goes into uh as far as this
example the translation of the
handwritten printed data to digital form
that's pretty hard to do that's pretty
hard to go in there and translate
hundreds and hundreds of books and
understand what they're trying to say if
you've never read them so in this case
we use the Deep learning because you can
already use examples where they've
already classified a lot of books and
then they can compare those texts and
say oh okay this is a book on automotive
repair this is book on robotic building
the Digital Data is in analyzed then we
have more text mining using machine
learning so maybe we'd use a different
program to do a basic classify uh what
you're looking for and say oh you're
looking for auto repair and computers so
you're looking for automated cars once
it's identified then of course it brings
you the
book so here's a nice summation of what
we were just talking about AI with
machine learning and deep learning deep
learning is a subset of of machine
learning which is a subset of artificial
intelligence so you can look at
artificial intelligence as a big picture
how does this compare to The Human
Experience in either uh doing the same
thing as a human we do or it does it
better than us and machine learning
which has a lot of tools uh is something
that learns from data past experiences
it's programmed it's uh comes in there
and it says hey we already had these
five things happen the one should be
about the same and then uh then there's
a lot of tools in machine learning but
deep learning then is a very specific
tool in machine learning it's the
artificial neural network which handles
large amounts of data and is able to
take huge pools of experiences pictures
and ideas and bring them together real
life
examples artificial intelligence news
generation very common nowadays as it
goes through there and finds the news
articles or generates the news based
upon on the news feeds or the backend
coming in and says okay let's give you
the actual news based on this there's
all the different things Amazon Echo
they have a number of different Prime
music on there of course there's also
the Google command and there's also
Cortana there's tons of smart home
devices now where we can ask it to turn
the TV on or play music for us that's
all artificial intelligence from front
to back you're having a human
experience with these computers and
these objects that are connected to the
processing machine learning uh spam
detection very common machine learning
doesn't really have the human
interaction part so this is the part
where it goes and says okay that's a
Spam that's not a Spam and it puts it in
your spam
folder search engine result refining uh
another example of machine learning
whereas it looks at your different
results and go and it uh is able to
categorize them as far as this had the
most hits this is the least viewed this
has five stars um you know however they
want to wait it uh all exam good
examples of machine learning and then
the Deep learning uh deep learning
another example is as you have like a
exit sign in this case is translating it
into French sorti I hope I said that
right um neural network has been
programmed with all these different
words and images and so it's able to
look at the exit in the middle and it
goes okay we want to know what that is
in French and it's able to push that out
in French French and learn how to do
that and then we have chatbots um I
remember when Microsoft first had their
little paperclip um boy that was like a
long time ago that came up and you would
type in there and chat with it these are
growing you know it's nice to just be
able to ask a question and it comes up
and gives you the answer and instead of
it being were you just doing a search on
certain words it's now able to start
linking those words together and form a
sentence in that chat box types of AI
and machine
learning types of artificial
intelligence this in the next few slides
are really important so one of the types
of artificial intelligence is reactive
machines systems that only react they
don't form memories they don't have past
experiences they have something that
happens to them and they react to it my
washing machine is one of those if I put
a ton of clothes in it and they had all
clumped on one side it automatically
adds a weight to reciter it so that my
washing machine is actually a reactive
machine working with whatever the load
is and keeps it nice and so when it
spins it doesn't go thumping against the
side limited memory another form of
artificial intelligence systems look
into the past information is added over
a period of time and information is
shortlived when we're talking about this
and you look at like a neural network
that's been programmed to identify cars
it doesn't remember all those pictures
it has no memory as far as the hundreds
of pictures you process through it all
it has is this is the pattern I use to
identify cars as the final output for
that neural network we looked at so when
they talk about limited memory this is
what they're talking about they're
talking about I've created this based on
all these things but I'm not going to
remember any one
specifically theory of Mind systems
being able to understand human emotions
and how they affect decision making to
adjust their behaviors according to
their human understanding this is
important because this is our pagemark
this is how we know whether it is an
artificial intelligence or not is it
interacting with humans in a way that we
can understand uh without that
interaction is just an object uh so we
talk about theory of mind we really
understand how it interfaces that whole
Fe in web development user experience
would be the term I would put in there
so the theory of mind would be user
experience how is the whole UI connected
together and one of the final things is
as we get into artificial intelligence
is systems being aware of themselves
understanding their internal States and
predicting other people's feelings and
act appropriately so as artificial
intelligence continues to progress uh we
see ones are trying to understand well
what makes people happy how would they
increase our happiness uh how would they
keep themselves from breaking down if
something's broken inside they have that
self-awareness to be able to fix it and
just based on all that information
predicting which action would work the
best what would help people uh if I know
that you're having a cup of coffee first
thing in the morning is what makes you
happy as a robot I might make you a cup
of coffee every morning at the same time
uh to help your life and help you grow
that'd be the self-awareness as being
able to know all those different things
types of machine learning and like I
said on the last slide this is very
important this is very important if you
decide to go in and get certified
machine learning or know more about it
these are the three primary types of
machine learning the first one is
supervised learning systems are able to
predict future outcome based on past
data requires both an input and an
output to be given to the model for it
to be trained so in this case we're
looking at anything where you have 100
images of a bicycle and those 100 images
you know are bicycle so it's they're
preset someone already looked at all 100
images and said these are pictures of
bicycles and so the computer learns from
those and then it's given another
picture and maybe the next picture is a
bicycle and it says oh that resembles
all these other bicycles so it's a
bicycle and the next one's a car and it
says it's not a bicycle that would be
supervised learning because we had to
train it we had to supervise it
unsupervised learning systems are able
to identify hidden patterns from the
input data provided by making the data
more readable and organized the patterns
similarities or anomalies become more
evident uh you'll heard the term cluster
how do you cluster things together some
of these things go together some of
these don't this is unsupervised where
can look at an image and start pulling
the different pieces of the image out
because they aren't the same the human
all the parts of the human are not the
same as a fuzzy tree behind them CU it's
slightly out of focus which is not the
same as the beach ball it's unsupervised
because we never told it what a beach
ball was we never told it what the human
was and we never told it that those were
trees all we told was hey separate this
picture by things that don't match and
things that do match and come together
and finally there's reinforcement
learning systems are given no training
it learns on the basis of the reward
punishment it received for performing
its Last Action it helps increase the
efficiency of a tool function or a
program reinforced learning or
reinforcement learning is kind of you
give it a yes or no yes you gave me the
right response no you didn't and then it
looks at that and says oh okay so based
on this data coming in uh what I gave
you was a wrong response so next time
I'll give you a different one comparing
machine learning and deep learning so
remember that deep learning is a
subcategory of machine learning so it's
one of the many tools and so they we're
grouping a ton of machine learning tools
all together linear regression K means
clustering there's all kinds of cool
tools out there you can use in machine
learning enables machines to take
decisions to make decisions on their own
based on past data enables machines to
make decisions with the help of
artificial neural networks so it's doing
the same thing but we're using an
artificial neural network as opposed to
one of the more traditional machine
learning tools needs only a small amount
of training data this is very important
when you're talking about machine
learning they're usually not talking
about huge amounts of data we're talking
about maybe your spreadsheet from your
business and your totals for the end of
the year when you're talking about
neural networks you usually need a large
amount of data to train the data so
there's a lot of training involved D if
you have under 500 points of data that's
probably not going to go into machine
learning or maybe have like the case of
one of the things 500 points of data and
30 different fields it starts getting
really confusing there in artificial
intelligence or machine learning and the
Deep learning aspect really shines when
you get to that larger data that's
really
complex works well on a lowend systems
so a lot of the machine learning tools
out there you can run on your laptop
with no problem and do the calculations
there where with the machine learning
usually needs a higher end system to
work it takes a lot more processing
power to build those neural networks and
to train them it goes through a lot of
data we're talking about the general
machine learning tools most features
need to be identified in advanced and
manually coded so there's a lot of human
work on here the machine learns the
features from the data it is provided so
again it's like a magic box you don't
have to know what a tire is it figures
it out for you the problem is divided
into parts and solved individually and
then combined so machine learning you
usually have all these different tools
and use different tools for different
parts and the problem is solved in an
endtoend manner so you only have one
neural network or two neural networks
that is bringing the data in and putting
it out it's not going through a lot of
different processes to get there and
remember you can put machine learning
and deep learning together so you don't
always have just the Deep learning
solving the problem you might have a
solving one piece of the puzzle with
regular machine learning and most
machine learning tools out there they
take longer to test and understand how
they work and with the Deep learning
it's pretty quick once you build that
neural network you test it and you know
so we're dealing with very crisp rules
limited resources you have to really
explain how the decision was made when
you use most machine learning tools but
when you use the Deep learning tool
inside the machine learning tools the
system takes care of it based on its own
logic and reasoning and again it's it's
like a magic Black Box you really don't
know how it came up with the answer you
just know it came up with the right
answer a glimpse into the future so a
quick glimpse into the future artificial
intelligence be using it to detecting
crimes before they happen humanoid AI
helpers which we already have a lot of
there'll be more and more maybe it'll
actually be Androids that'd be cool to
have an Android that comes and gets
stuff out of my fridge for me machine
learning increasing efficiency in health
care that's really big in all the forms
of machine learning better marketing
techniques any of these things if we get
into the Sciences it's just off the
scale machine learning and artificial
intelligence go everywhere and then the
subcategory Deep learning increased
personalization so what's really nice
about the Deep learning is it's going to
start now catering to you that'll be one
of the things we see more and more of
and we'll have more of a hyper
intelligent personal assistant I'm
excited about that in this lesson you
are going to understand the concept of
text
mining by the end of this lesson you
will be able to explain text mining
execute text processing
task so let's go ahead and understand
text mining in detail let's first
understand what text mining is text
mining is the technique of exploring
large amounts of unstructured Text data
and analyzing it in order to extract
patterns from the text Data it is aided
by software that can identify Concepts
patterns topics keywords and other
attributes in the data it utilizes
computational techniques to extract and
summarize the high quality information
from unstructured textual resources
let's understand the flow of text mining
there are five techniques used in text
mining system information extraction or
text
pre-processing this is used to examine
the unstructured text by searching out
the important words and finding the
relationships between them
categorization or text transformation
attribute generation categorization
technique labels the text document under
one or more categories classification of
Text data is done based on input output
examples with
categorization clustering or attribute
selection clustering method is used to
group text documents that have similar
content clusters are the partitions and
each CL cluster will have a number of
documents with similar content
clustering makes sure that no document
will be omitted from the search and it
deres all the documents that have
similar content visualization technique
the process of finding relevant
information is simplified by
visualization technique this technique
uses text Flags to represent a group of
documents or a single document and
compactness is indicated using colors
visualization Tech technique helps to
display textual information in a more
attractive way summarization or
interpretation or evaluation
summarization technique will help to
reduce the length of the document and
summarize the details of the documents
it makes the document easy to read for
users and understand the content at the
moment let's understand the significance
of text
mining document clustering document
clustering is an important part of text
mining it has many applications in
Knowledge Management and information
retrieval clustering makes it easy to
group similar documents into meaningful
groups such as in newspapers where
sections are often grouped as business
Sports politics and so on pattern
identification text mining is the
process of automatically searching large
amount of text for text patterns and
recognition of features features such as
telephone numbers and email addresses
can be extracted using pattern matches
product insights text mining helps to
extract large amounts of text for
example customer reviews about the
products mining consumer reviews can
reveal insights like most loved feature
most hated feature improvements required
and reviews of competitor products
security monitoring text mining helps in
monitoring and extracting information
from news articles and reports for
national security purposes text mining
Mak sure to use all of your available
information it is a more effective and
productive knowledge discovery that
allows you to make better informed
decisions automate information intensive
processes gather business critical
insights and mitigate operational
risk let's look at the applications of
text
mining speech recognition speech
recognition is the recognition and
translation of spoken language into text
and vice versa
speech often provides valuable
information about the topics subjects
and concepts of multimedia content
information extraction from speech is
less complicated yet more accurate and
precise than multimedia content this
fact motivates content-based speech
analysis for multimedia Data Mining and
retrieval where audio and speech
processing is a key enabling
technology spam filtering spam detection
is an important method in which textual
information contained in an email is
extracted and used for
discrimination text mining is useful in
automatic detection of spam emails based
on the filtering content using text
mining an email service provider such as
Gmail or Yahoo mail checks the content
of an email and if some malicious text
is found in the mail then that email is
marked as spam and sent to the spam
folder sentiment analysis if it is done
in order to determine if a given
sentence expresses positive neutral or
negative sentiments sentiment analysis
is one of the most popular applications
of text analytics the primary aspect of
sentiment analysis includes data
analysis of the body of the text for
understanding the opinion expressed by
it and other key factors comprising
modality and mood usually the process of
sentiment analysis works best on text
that has a subjective context than on
that with only an objective context
e-commerce
personalization text mining is used to
suggest products that fit into a user's
profile text mining is increasingly
being used by e-commerce retailers to
learn more about the consumers as it is
the process of analyzing textual
information in order to identify
patterns and gain insights e-commerce
retailers can Target specific
individuals or segments with
personalized offers and discounts to
boost sales and increase Customer
Loyalty by identifying customer purchase
patterns and opinions on particular
products let's look at natural language
toolkit library in
detail natural language toolkit is a set
of open-source python models that are
used to apply statistical natural
language processing on human language
data let's see how you can do
environment setup of
nltk go to Windows start and launch
python interpreter from Anaconda prompt
and enter the following commands enter
command python to check the version of
python installed on your system enter
import nltk to link you to the nltk
library available to download then enter
nltk doownload function that will open
the nltk download window check the
download directory select all package
pages and click on download this will
download nltk onto your python once you
have downloaded the nltk you must check
the working and functionality of it in
order to test the setup enter the
following command in Python Idol from
nltk Doc Corpus import Brown brown. word
parenthesis
parenthesis the brown is an nltk Corpus
that shows the systematic differ
between different genres available words
function will give you the list
available words in the genre the given
output shows that we have successfully
tested the nltk installed on
python let's Now understand how you can
read a specific module from nltk corpora
if you want to import an entire module
from nltk corpora use asterisk symbol
with that module name import command
enter the command and from nltk book
import asterisk it will load all the
items available in nltk book module now
in order to explore Brown Corpus enter
the command nltk do Corpus import Brown
this will import Brown Corpus on the
python enter brown. categories function
to load the different genres available
select a genre and assign that genre to
a variable using the foll ing syntax
variable name is equal to brown. wordss
categories is equal to genre name now in
order to see the available words inside
the selected genre just enter the
defined variable name as a
command let's understand text extraction
and pre-processing in
detail so let's first understand the
concept of
tokenization tokenization is the process
of removing sensitive data and placing
unique symbols of identification in that
place in order to retain all the
essential information concerned with the
data by its security it is a process of
breaking running streams of text into
words and sentences it works by
segregating words using punctuation and
spaces text extraction and
pre-processing
engrams now let's look at what engram is
and how it is helpful in text mining
engram is the simplest model that
assigns these probabilities to sequences
of words or sentences engrams are
combinations of adjacent words or
letters of length n in the source text
so engram is very helpful in text mining
when it is required to extract patterns
from the text as in the given example
this is a sentence all of these words
are considered individual words and thus
represent unigrams A2 gram or byr is a
two-word sequence of words like this is
is a or a sentence and a three gram or
trigram is a three-word sequence of
words like this is a or is a
sentence let's Now understand what stop
words are and how you can remove
them stop words are natural language
words that have negligible meaning such
as a and and or the and other similar
words these words also will take up
space in the database or increase the
processing time so it is better to
remove such words by storing a list of
stop words you can find the list of stop
words in the nltk data directory that is
stored in 16 different languages use the
following command to list the stop words
of English language defined in nltk
Corpus importing nltk will import the
nltk Corpus for the that instance enter
from nltk Doc Corpus import Stop wordss
will import Stop wordss from nltk Corpus
Now set the language as English so use
set function as set under braces
stopwords do wordss set genre as English
stop words are filtered out before
processing of natural language data as
they don't reveal much information so as
you can see in the given example before
filtering the sentence the tokenized
ation of stop word is processed in order
to remove these stop words and the
filtering is applied in order to filter
the sentence based on some
criteria text extraction and
pre-processing
stemming stemming is used to reduce a
word to stem or base word by removing
suffixes such as helps helping helped
and helper to the root word help the
stemming process or algorithm is
generally called a stemmer the there are
various stemming algorithms such as
Porter stemmer Lancaster stemmer
snowball stemmer Etc use any of the
stemmers defined under nltk stem Corpus
in order to perform stemming as shown in
the example here we have used Porter
stemmer When You observe the output you
will see that all of the words given
have been reduced to their root word or
stem text extraction and pre-processing
litiz lemmatization is the method of
grouping the various inflected types of
a word in order that they can be
analyzed as one item it uses vocabulary
list or morphological analysis to get
the root word it uses word net database
that has English words linked together
by their semantic relationship as you
can observe the given example the
different words have been extracted to
their relevant morphological word using
lemmatization text extraction and
pre-processing POS
tagging let's now look at different part
of speech tags available in the national
language toolkit Library a POS tag is a
special label assigned to each token or
word in a Text corpus to indicate the
part of speech and often also other
grammatical categories such as tense
number either plural or singular case
Etc POS tags are used in text analysis
tools and algorithms and also in Corpus
searches so look at the given example
here Alice wrote a program is the source
text given the POS tags given are Alice
is a noun wrote is a verb a is an
article and program is an adjective look
at the given example to understand how
posos tags are defined so the given
sentence or paragraph contains different
words that represent different parts of
speech we will first use tokenization
and removal of Stu stop words and then
allocate the different POS tags these
are shown with different words in the
given sentence POS tags are useful for
lemmatization in building named entity
recognition and extracting relationships
between
words text extraction and pre-processing
named entity recognition now let's
understand what named entity recognition
is all about Neer seeks to extract a
real world entity from the text and
sorts it into predefined categories such
as names of people organizations
locations Etc many real world questions
can be answered with the help of name
entity recognition were specified
products mentioned in complaints or
reviews does the Tweet contain the name
of a person does the Tweet contain the
person's address as you can see in the
given example Google America Larry Page
Etc are the names of a person place or
an organization so these are considered
named entities and have different tags
such as person organization GP or
geopolitical entity
Etc NLP process
workflow now you have an understanding
of all nltk tools so now let's
understand the natural language
processing workflow step one
tokenization it splits text into pieces
tokens or words and removes punctuation
step two stop word removal it removes
commonly used words such as the is are
Etc which are not relevant to the
analysis step three stemming and litiz
it reduces words to base form in order
to be analyzed as a single item step
four POS tagging it tags words to be
part of speech such as noun verb
adjective Etc based on the definition
and context step five information
retrieval it extracts relevant
information from the
source M1 Brown Corpus problem statement
the Brown University standard Corpus of
present-day American English also known
popularly as brown Corpus was compiled
in the 1960s as a general Corpus in the
field of Corpus Linguistics it contains
500 samples of English language text
totaling roughly 1 million words
compiled from Works published in the
United States in
1961 we will be working on one of the
subset data set and perform text
processing tasks let us import the nltk
library and read the
ca10 Corpus import
nltk we will have to make sure that
there are no slashes in between hence we
will use the replace function within
pandas for the
same
let's have a look at the data
once
tokenization after performing sentence
tokenization on the data we
obtain
similarly after applying sentence
tokenizer the resulting output shows all
individual words
tokens stop word removal let's import
the stop word library from nltk Doc
purpose import Stop
words we also need to ensure that the
text is in the same case nltk has its
own list of stop wordss we can check the
list of stop wordss using stopwords do
wordss and English inside the
parentheses map the lowercase string
with our list of word
tokens
let's remove the stop words using the
English stop wordss list in
nltk we will be using set checking as it
is faster in Python than a
list by removing all stop wordss from
the text we
obtain often we want to remove the
punctuations from the documents too
since python comes with batteries
included we have string. punctuation
from string import
punctuation
combining the punctuation with the stop
words from
nltk remove stop words with
punctuation stemming and
lemmatization we will be using stemming
and lemmatization to reduce words to
their root form for example walks
walking walked will be reduced to their
root word walk importing pter stemmer as
the stemming library from nltk do stem
import Porter
stemmer printing the stem
words import the wordnet litier from
nltk do stem
printing the root
words we also need to evaluate the POS
tags for each token
create a new word list and store the
list of word tokens against each of the
sentence tokens in data 2 for I and
tokenized also we will check if there
were any stop wordss in the recently
created word
list we will now tag the word tokens
accordingly using the POS tags and print
the tagged
output for our final text processing tag
ask we will be applying named entity
recognition to classify named entities
in text into predefined categories such
as the names of persons organizations
locations expressions of times
quantities monetary values percentages
Etc
now press the tagged sentences under the
chunk parser if we we set the parameter
binary equals true then named entities
are just tagged as NE otherwise the
classifier adds category labels such as
person organization and
gpe create a function named as extract
entity names along with an empty list
named as entity
names we will now extract named entities
from a nltk chunked expression and store
them in the empty created
above
again we will set the entity names list
as an empty list and we'll extract The
Entity names by iterating over each tree
in chunked
sentences
great we have seen how to explore and
examine the Corpus using text processing
techniques let's quickly recap the steps
we've covered so far One Import the nltk
library two perform tokenization three
perform stemming and lemmatization four
remove stop words five perform named
entity
recognition structuring sentences
syntax let's first understand what
syntax is syntax is the grammatical
structure of sentences in the given
example this can be interpreted as
syntax and it is similar to the ones you
use while writing codes knowing language
includes the power to construct phrases
and sentences out of morphemes and words
the part of the grammar that represents
a speaker's knowledge of these
structures and their formation is called
syntax phrase structure rules are rules
that determine what goes into a phrase
that is constituents of a phrase and how
the constituents are ordered constituent
is a word or group of words that operate
as a unit and can be used to frame
larger grammatical units the given
diagram repres presents that a noun
phrase is determined when a noun is
combined with a determiner and the
determiner can be optional a sentence is
determined when a noun phrase is
combined with a verb phrase a verb
phrase is determined when a verb is
combined optionally with the noun phrase
and prepositional phrase and a
prepositional phrase is determined when
a preposition is combined with a noun
phrase a tree is a representation of
syntactics structure a formulation of
senten or strings consider the given
sentence the factory employs 12.8% of
Bradford County what can be the Syntax
for pairing this statement let's
understand this a tree is produced that
might help you understand that the
subject of the sentence is the factory
the predicate is employes and the target
is
12.8% which in turn is modified by
Bradford County syntax parses are often
a first step toward deep information
extraction or semantic understanding of
text rendering syntax
trees download the corresponding exe
file to install the ghost script
rendering engine based on your system
configuration in order to render syntax
trees in your notebook let's understand
how you can set up the environment
variable once you have downloaded and
installed the file go to the folder
where it is installed and copy the path
of the file now go to system properties
and under Advanced properties you will
find the environment variable button
click on that to open the popup box tab
of the environment now open the bin
folder and add the path to the bin
folder in your environment
variables now you will have to modify
the path of the environment variable use
the given code to test the working of
syntax tree after the setup is
successfully installed
called structuring sentences chunking
and chunk
parsing the process of extraction of
phrases from unstructured text is called
chunking instead of using just simple
tokens which may not represent the
actual meaning of the text it is
advisable to use phrases such as Indian
team as a single word instead of Indian
and team as separate words the chunking
segmentation refers to identifying
tokens and labeling refers to
identifying the correct tag these chunks
correspond to mixed patterns in some way
to extract patterns from chunks we need
chunk parsing the chunk parsing segment
refers to identifying strings of tokens
and labeling refers to identifying the
correct chunk type let's look at the
given example you can see here that
yellow is an adjective dog is a noun and
the' is the determiner which are chunked
together into a noun phrase
similarly chunk parsing is used to
extract patterns and to process such
patterns from multiple chunks while
using different
parsers let's take an example and try to
understand how chunking is performed in
Python let's consider the sentence the
little mouse ate the fresh cheese
assigned to a variable named scent using
the word tokenize function under nltk
corpora you can find out the different
tags associated with the sentence
provided so as you can see in the output
different tags have been allocated
against each of the words from the given
sentence using
chunking NP chunk and
parser you will now create grammar from
a noun phrase and will mention the tags
you want in your chunk phrase within the
function here you have created a regular
expression matching the string the given
regular expression indicates optional
determiner followed by optional number
of adjec jective followed by a noun you
will now have to parse the chunk
therefore you will create a chunk parser
and pass your noun phrase string to it
the parser is now ready you will use the
parse parenthesis parenthesis within
your chunk parser to parse your sentence
the sentence provided is the little
mouse ate the fresh cheese this sentence
has been parsed and the tokens that
match the regular expressions are chunk
together into noun phrases
NP create a verb phrase chunk using
regular Expressions the regular
expression has been defined as optional
personal pronoun followed by zero or
more verbs with any of its type followed
by any type of adverb you'll now create
another chunk parser and pass the verb
phrase string to it create another
sentence and tokenize it add POS tags to
it so the new sentence is she is walking
quickly to the mall and the POS tag has
been allocated from nltk corpora now use
the new verb phrase parser to parse the
tokens and run the results you can look
at the given tree diagram which shows a
verb parser where a pronoun followed by
two verbs and an adverb are chunk into a
verb
parse structuring sentences
chinking chinking is the process of
removing a sequence of tokens from a
chunk how does chunking work the whole
chunk is remove removed when the
sequence of tokens spans an entire chunk
if the sequence is at the start or the
end of the chunk the tokens are removed
from the start and end and a smaller
chunk is retained if the sequence of
tokens appears in the middle of the
chunk these tokens are removed leaving
two chunks where there was only one
before consider you create a chinking
grammar string containing three things
chunk name the regular expression
sequence of a chunk the regular
expression sequence of your here
in the given code we have the chunk
regular expression as optional personal
pronoun followed by zero or more
occurrences of any type of the verb type
followed by zero or more occurrences of
any of the adverb types the
regular expression says that it needs to
check for the adverb in the extracted
chunk and remove it from the chunk
inside the chinking block with open
curly braces and closing curly braces
you have created one or more
adverbs you will now create a parser
from nltk do
regex parser and pass the grammar
to it now use the new parser to
parse the tokens sent three and run the
results as you can see the parse tree is
generated while comparing the syntax
tree of the parser with that of
the original chunk you can see that the
token is Qui quickly adverb chined out
of the chunk let's understand how to use
context free
grammar a context-free grammar is a four
Tuple sum ntrs where sum is an alphabet
and each character in sum is called a
terminal NT is a set and each element in
NT is called a non-terminal r the set of
rules is a subset of NT times the set of
sum u n t s the start symbol is one of
the symbols in NT a context free grammar
generates a language L capturing
constituency and ordering in CFG the
start symbol is used to derive the
string you can derive the string by
repeatedly replacing a non-terminal on
the right hand side of the production
until all non-terminals have been
replaced by terminal symbols let's
understand the representation of context
free grammar through an example in
context free grammar grammar a sentence
can be represented as a noun phrase
followed by a verb phrase noun phrase
can be a determiner nominal a nominal
can be a noun VP represents the verb
phrase a can be called a determiner
flight can be called a noun consider the
string below where you have certain
rules when you look at the given context
free grammar a sentence should have a
noun phrase followed by a verb phrase a
verb phrase is a verb followed by a noun
a verb can either be Saul or met noun
phrases can either be John or Jim and a
noun can either be a dog or a cat check
the possible list of sentences that can
be generated using the rules use the
join function to create the possible
list of sentences you can check the
different rules of grammar for sentence
formation using the production function
it will show you the different tags used
and the defined context free grammar for
the given sentence demo two structuring
sentences problem statement a company
wants to perform text analysis for one
of its data sets you are provided with
this data set named tweets. CSV which
has tweets of six US Airlines along with
their sentiments positive negative and
neutral the tweets are present in the
text column and sentiments in Airline
sentiment column we will be retrieving
all tags starting with at the rate in
the data set and save the output in a
file called references. txt let us first
import the pandas library and read the
tweets data
set
extract the features text and Airline
sentiment we will iterate through the
data set using reg X find the relevant
tweets now we will import the itertools
module it returns efficient
iterators
the result is stored in a file named
references.
txt let's extract all noun phrases and
save them in a file named noun phrases
for left Carro Airline sentiment right
Carro review.
txt
here left carrot Airline uncore
sentiment right carrot has three
different values positive negative and
neutral so three files will be
created
now we will iterate all the leaf nodes
and assign them to noun phrases
variable
this means that the functions in iter
tools operate on iterator to produce
more complex
iterators using the map function we will
get all the noun phrases from the
text
putting it into
list create creating a file name in the
name of review.
txt
great we have now seen how to explore
and examine the Corpus using text
processing techniques hello everyone and
welcome to the video on large language
models large language models are
basically very Advanced artificial
intelligence systems that can process
and generate massive amounts of text
Data they are designed to learn from and
understand natural human language and
can be used to perform a wide range of
language related task such as
translation speech recognition and
automatic summary generation one of the
key advantages of large language models
is their ability to learn from vast
amounts of data which allows them to
generate highly accurate and realistic
responses to complex natural language
prompts additionally they can be trained
on multiple languages simultaneously
which means they can be used to perform
language translation between different
pairs of languages making them an
invaluable tool for businesses and
organizations that work with people from
diverse cultural backgrounds not just
language related task but llms can also
have the potential to revolutionize
Fields such as research science and
Healthcare by allowing researchers to
quickly analyze and process vast amounts
of complex text Data they can accelerate
progress in areas such as drug Discovery
Healthcare Diagnostics and AI
development that being said large
language models also present some
challenges for instance they require a
significant amount of compute resources
which can be prohibitively expensive for
some organizations additionally because
they are trained on huge amounts of data
they may inadvertently reinforce biased
or discriminate KN patterns in language
use which is something that researchers
and Engineers are continuously working
to address overall large language models
are an exciting and rapidly developing
field with tremendous potential to
transform the way we live work and
communicate so if you want to embark on
a journey of AI and ml then try giving a
short to our postgraduate program in Ai
and ml that is in partnership with IBM
this artificial intelligence course
covers the latest tools and Technologies
from the AI ecosystem and features
master classes by celtech faculty and
IBM experts hecaton and ask me anything
sessions this program showcases celtech
ctm is excellence and IBM's industry
progess the artificial intelligence
course covers key Concepts like
statistics data science with python
machine learning deep learning NLP and
reinforcement learning through an
Interactive Learning model with live
sessions and roll now analog exciting a
anml opportunities the link is mentioned
in the description box below and with
that having said hey everyone everyone
welcome to Simply lear's YouTube channel
but before we dive into that don't
forget to like subscribe and share in
this video we will cover topics like
what are large language models after
that we'll look at what large language
models used for and after that we'll
cover how are large language models
trained after this we'll look at how do
large language models work and at the
last we'll see some applications of
large language models so without any
further Ado let's get
started
so we'll start with what are the large
language models large language models
such as gpt3 generative pre-trained
Transformer 3 are Advanced artificial
intelligence systems designed to
understand and generate humanik text
these models are built using deep
learning techniques and have been
trained on vast amounts of text Data
from the internet these models use self
attention mechanisms to analyze the
relationships between words or tokens in
a text enabling them to capture
contextual information and generate
coherent responses these models use
self- attention mechanisms to analyze
the relationship between different words
or tokens in a text enabling them to
capture contextual information and
generate coherent responses these models
have significant implications for a wide
range of applications including virtual
assistants chat boards content
generation language translation and
aiding in research and decision making
processes their ability to generate
cerent and contextually appropriate text
has led to advancement in natural
language understanding and human
computer interaction now we'll see what
are language models used for so large
language models are utilized in
scenarios where there is limited or no
domain specific data available for
training these scenarios include both
few short and zero short learning
approaches which rely on the model's
strong inductive bias and its capability
to derive meaningful representations
from a small amount of data or even no
data at all now we'll see how are large
language models trained large language
models typically undergo pre-training on
a broad or and compassing data set that
shares statistical similarities with the
data set specific to the Target task the
objective of pre-training is to enable
the model to acquire high level features
that can later be applied during the
fine-tuning phase for specific task and
the training process of a large language
model involves several steps the first
is text pre-processing the textual data
is transformed into a numerical
representation that can be effectively
processed by the model this conversion
mol techniques like tokenization
encoding and creating input sequences
the next we have is random parameter
initialization the model's parameters
are initialized randomly before the
training process begins the next is
inputting numerical data the numerical
representation of Text data is fed into
the model for processing the the models
architecture typically based on
Transformers allows it to capture the
contextual relationships between the
words and tokens in the text and the
next is loss function calculation a loss
function is employed to measure the
discrepancy between the model's
predictions and the actual next word or
token in a sentence the model aims to
minimize this loss during training and
the next is parameter optimization the
model's parameters are adjusted through
optimization techniques such as gradient
descent to reduce the loss this involves
calculating gradients and updating the
parameters accordingly gradually
improving the model's performance and
the next is iterative training the
training process is repeated over
multiple iterations or OCS until the
models outputs achieve a satisfactory
level of accuracy on the given task or
data set by following this training
process large language models learn to
capture linguistic patterns understand
context and generate coherent responses
enabling them to excel at a wide range
of language related task and now we'll
see how do large language models work so
large language models leverage deep
neural networks to generate outputs
based on patterns learned from the
training data typically a large language
model adopts a Transformer architecture
which enables the model to identify
relationships between words in a
sentence irrespective of the position in
the sequence in contrast to recent
neural networks that is RNN that rely on
recurence to capture token relationships
Transformer neural networks employ self
attention as their primary mechanism
self attention calculates attention
scores that determines the importance of
each token with respect to other tokens
in the text sequence facilitating the
modeling of intricate relationships
within the data now we'll see
applications of large language models
large language models have wide range of
applications across various domains and
here are some notable applications the
first one is natural language processing
large language model are used to improve
natural language understanding task such
as sentiment analysis named entity
recognition text classification and
language modeling the next is chat
boards and virtual assistants large
language models power conversational
agents chat boards and virtual
assistants providing more interactive
and humanlike interactions with users
and the next is machine translation
large language models have been used for
automatic language translation enabling
the translation of text between
different languages with improved
accuracy and the next we have is
sentiment analysis large language models
can analyze and classify the sentiment
or emotion expressed in a piece of text
which is valuable for market research
brand monitoring and social media
analysis and the next we have is content
recommendation these models can be
employed to provide personalized content
recommendations enhancing user
experience and engagement on platforms
such as news websites or streaming
services these applications High
highlight the versatility and potential
impact of large language models in
various domains improving language
understanding Automation and interaction
between humans and computers the term
generative AI has emerged seemingly out
of nowhere in recent months with a
notable search in interest according to
Google Trends even within the past year
the spike in curiosity can be attributed
to the introduction of generative models
such as d 2 B and
chgb however what does generative a and
tail as a part of our introductory
series on generative AI this video will
provide a comprehensive overview of a
subject starting from the basics the
explanation Will C to all levels of
familiarity ensuring that viewers gain a
better understanding of how this
technology operates and its growing
integration to our daily lives
generative AI is after all a tool that
is based on artificial intelligence a
professional who El it seats to switch
careers with AI by learning from the
experts then try giving a short simply
Lear postgraduate program in Ai and
machine learning from from per
University in collaboration with IBM the
link in the description box should
navigate to the homepage where you can
find a complete overview of the program
being offered take action upskill and
get ahead what is generative AI
generative AI is a form of artificial
intelligence possesses the capability of
to generate a wide range of content
including text visual audio and
synthetic data the recent excitement
surrounding generative AI stems from the
userfriendly interfaces that allow users
to effortlessly create high quality text
graphics and video within a seconds now
moving forward let's see how does
generative AI Works generative AI begin
a prompt which can take form of text
image video design audio musical notes
or any input that AI system can process
various AI algorithm that generate new
content in response to the given prompt
this content can range from essay and
problem solution to realistic created
using images or audio of a person in the
early stages of generative AI utilizing
the technology involved submitting data
through an API or a complex process
developers need to acquaint them with a
specialized tool and writing application
using programming language like python
some of the recent and fully operational
generative AIS are Google Bart D open AI
chat GPT Microsoft Bing and many more so
now let's discuss chat GPT D and B which
are the most popular generative AI
interfaces so first is DAL
2 which was developed using open as GPT
implementation in 2021 exemplify a
multimodel AI application it has been
trained on a v data set of images and
their corresponding textual description
Dal is capable of establishing
connection between various media forms
such as Vision text audio it
specifically links the meaning of words
to visual elements open a introduced an
enhanced version called d 2 in 2022
which empowers user to to generate
imagery in multiple Styles based on
their prompts and the next one is chat
GPT in November 2022 chat GPT and AI
power chatbot built on open AI GPD 3.5
implementation gained immense popularity
worldwide open AI enabled user to
interact with and fine tune the chat box
text response through a chat interface
with interactive feedback unlike earli
version of GPT that was solely
accessible via an API CH gbt brought a
more Interactive eriod on March 14 2023
open a released GPT 4 chat GPT integrate
the conversational history with a user
making a genuine dialogue Microsoft
impressed by the success of new chgb
interface announced a substantial
investment in open Ai and integrated a
version of GPT into its Bing search
engine and the next one is Bard Google
bard Google was also an earlier Fortuner
in advancing Transformer AI techniques
for language process processing protein
analysis and other content types it made
some of these model open source for
researchers but were not made available
through a public interface in response
to Microsoft integration of GPT into
Bing Google hardly launched a public
facing chat Bo named Google B bar deut
was met by an error when the language
model incorrectly claimed that the web
telescope was the first to discover a
planet in a foreign solar system as a
consequences Google stock price suffered
a significant decline Meanwhile my
Microsoft implementation of chat GPT and
GPT powered system also face criticism
for producing inaccurate result and
displaying ER actic behavior in their
early irritation so moving forward let's
see what are the use cases of generative
AI generative AI has broad applicability
and can be employed across a wide range
of use cases to generate diverse form of
content recent advancement like GPT have
made this technology more accessible and
customizable for various application
some notable use cases for generative AI
are as follows chatbot implementation
generative AI can be utilized to develop
chatbots for customer service and
Technical Support enhancing interaction
with users and providing efficient
assistance the second one is language
dubbing enhancement in the dam in the
realm of movies and educational
accountant generative AI can contribute
to improving dubbing in different
languages ensuring accurate and high
quality translation and the third one is
content writing generative AI can assist
in writing email respon resp dating
profiles resumes and term papers
offering valuable support and generating
customized content tailor to specific
requirement and the fourth one is Art
generation leveraging generative AI
artists can create photo realistic
artwork in various Styles enabling the
exploration of new artistic expression
and enhancing creativity the fifth one
is product demonstration videos
generative AI can hun to enhance protect
demonstration video making them more
engaging visually appealing and
effective in showcasing product features
and benefits so generative AI
versatility allow it to employ it in
many other application making it a
valuable tool for Content creation and
enhancing user experience across diverse
domains so after seeing use cases of
generative AI let's see what are the
benefits of generative AI so generative
AI offers extensive application across
various business domains simplifying the
interpration and comprehension of
existing content while also enabling the
automated creation of a new content
developers are ly exploring ways to
leverage generative AI in order to
enhance the optimize existing workflows
and even to reshave workflows entirely
to harness the potential of Technology
fully implementing generative AI can
bring numerous benefits including
automated content creation generative AI
can automate the manual process of
writing content saving time and effort
by generating text or other form of
content the next one is efficient email
response responding to emails can be
made more efficient with generative AI
reducing the effort required and
improving response time and the third
one is enhanced technical support
generative AI can improve responses to
specific technical queries providing
accurate and helpful information to
users or customers and the fourth one is
realistic person Generation by
leveraging generative AI it becomes
possible to create realistic
representation of people enabling
applications like virtual characters or
avatars and the fifth one is coherent
information summarization generative AI
can summarize complex information into a
coherent narrative distilling key points
and making it easier to understand and
communicate complex concept the
implementation of generative AI offers a
range of potential benefits steamingly
process and enhancing content Creation
in various areas of business operation
so after seeing advantages of generative
AI let's move forward and see what are
the limitations of generative AI early
implementation of generative a serve as
Vivid examples highlighting the numerous
limitation associated with this
technology several challenges arise from
the specific approaches employed to
implement various use gifts for instance
while a summary of a complex topic May
more reader friendly than explanation
incorporating multiple supporting
sources the ease of readability comes at
the expense of transparent identifying
the information sources so the first one
is when implementing or utilizing a
generative AI application it is
important to consider the following
limitation I repeat the first one is
lack of source identification generative
AI does not always provide clear
identification of content Source making
it difficult to trace and verify origin
of the information the second one is
assessment of bias assessing the bias of
original sources used generative AI can
be challenging as it may be difficult to
determine the underlying perspective or
agenda of the data utilized in the
training process the third one is
difficulty in add identifying inaccurate
information generative AI can generate
realistic content making identifying
inaccuracy or falsehoods within the
generated output harder and the fourth
one is adaptability to a new
circumstances understanding how to fine
tune generative AI for a new
circumstances or specific context can be
complex requiring careful consideration
and expertise to achieve desired result
and the fifth one is glossing over bias
Prejudice and hatred generative AI
results May amplify or prep petate
biases prejudices or hateful content
present in the training data requiring
Vigilant scrutiny to prevent such issues
so awareness of these limitation is
crucial when the implementing of
utilizing generative AI as it helps
users and developers critically evaluate
and mitigate potential risk and
challenges associated with the
technology so future of generative AI
furthermore advances in AI development
platforms will contribute to the The
Accelerated progress of research and
development in the realm of generative
AI the development will Encompass
various domains such as text images
videos 3D contact drugs Supply chains
logistic and business processes while
the current stand loan tools are
impressive the true transformative
impact generative AI will realize while
these capabilities are seemingly
integrated into into the existing tools
with regular use so deep learning is
considered to be a part of machine
learning so this diagram very nicely
depicts what deep learning is at a very
high level you have the all-encompassing
artificial intelligence which is more a
concept rather than a technology or a
technical concept right so it is it is
more of a concept at a very high level
artificial intelligence under the herd
is actually machine learning and deep
learning and machine learning is a
broader concept you can say or a broader
technology and deep learning is a subset
of machine learning the primary
difference between machine learning and
deep learning is that deep learning uses
neural networks and it is suitable for
handling large amounts of unstructured
data and the last but not least one of
the major differences between machine
learning and deep learning is that in
machine learning the feature extraction
or the feature engineering is done by
the data scientists manually but in deep
learning since we use neural networks
the feature engineering happens
automatically so that's a little bit of
a a quick difference between machine
learning and deep learning and this
diagram very nicely depicts the relation
between artificial intelligence machine
learning and deep learning now why do we
need deep learning machine learning was
there for quite some time and it can do
a lot of stuff that probably what deep
learning can do but it's not very good
at handling large amounts of
unstructured data like images Voice or
even text for that matter so traditional
machine learning is not that very good
at doing this it traditional machine
learning can handle large amounts of
structured data but when it comes to
unstructured data it's a big challenge
so that is one of the key
differentiators for deep learning so
that is number one and increasingly for
artificial intelligence we need image
recognition and we need to process
analyze images and voice that's the
reason deep learning is required
compared to let's say traditional
machine learning it can also perform
complex uh algorithms more complex than
let's say what machine learning can do
and it can achieve best performance with
large amounts of data so the more you
have the data let's say reference data
or label data the better the system will
do because the training process will be
that much better and last but not least
with deep learning you can really avoid
the manual process of feature extraction
those are some of the reasons why we
need deep learning some of the
applications of deep learning deep
learning has made major inroads and it
is a major area in which deep learning
is applied is health care and within
Health Care particularly oncology which
is uh basically cancer related stuff one
of the issues with cancer is that a lot
of cancers today are curable they can be
cured they are detected early on and the
challenge with that is when a
Diagnostics is performed let's say an
image has been taken off a patient to
detect whether there is cancer or not
you need a specialist to look at the the
image and determine whether it is the
patient is fine or there is any onset of
cancer and the number of Specialists are
limited so if we use deep learning if we
use automation here or if we use
artificial intelligence here then the
system can with a certain amount of the
good amount of accuracy determine
whether a particular patient is having
cancer or not so the prediction or the
detection process of a disease like like
cancer can be expedited the detection
process can be expedited can be faster
without really waiting for a specialist
we can obviously then once the
application once the artificial
intelligence detects or predicts that
there is an onset of cancer this can be
cross checked by a doctor but at least
the initial screening process can be
automated and that is where the current
focus is with respect to deep learning
in healthcare what else robotic is
another area deep learning is majorly
used in robotics and you must have seen
nowadays robots are everywhere humanoids
the industrial robots which are used for
manufacturing process you must have
heard about sopia who got citizenship
with Saudi Arabia and so on there are
multiple such robots which are knowledge
oriented but there are also industrial
robots are used in Industries in the
manufacturing process and increasingly
in security and and also in defense for
example image processing video is fed to
them and they need to be able to detect
objects obstacles and so on and so forth
so that's where deep learning is used
they need to be able to hear and make
sense of the sounds that they are
hearing that needs deep learning as well
so robotics is a major area where deep
learning is applied then we have
self-driving cars or autonomous cars you
must have heard of Google's autonomous
car which has been tested for millions
of miles and and pretty much incident
free there were of course a couple of
incidents here and there but it is uh
considered to be fairly safe and there
are today a lot of Automotive companies
in fact pretty much every automotive
company worth its name is investing in
self-driving cars or autonomous cars and
it is predicted that in the next
probably 10 to 15 years these will be in
production and they will be used
extensively in real life right now they
are all in R&D and in test phases but
pretty soon these will be on the road so
this is another area where deep learning
is used and how is it used where is it
used within autonomous driving the car
actually is fed with video of
surroundings and it is supposed to
process that information process that
video and determine if there are any
obstacles it has to determine if there
are any cars in the side will detect
whether it is driving in the lane also
it has to determine whether the signal
is green or red so that according it can
move forward or wait so for all these
video analysis deep learning is used in
addition to that the training overall
training to drive the car happens in a
deep learning environment so again a lot
of scope here to use deep learning
couple of other applications are machine
translation so today we have a lot of
information and very often this
information is in one particular
language and more specifically in
English and people people need
information in in various parts of the
world it is pretty difficult for human
beings to translate each and every piece
of information or every document into
all possible languages there are
probably at least hundreds of languages
or if not more to translate each and
every document into every language is uh
pretty difficult therefore we can use
deep learning to do pretty much like a
realtime translation mechanism so we
don't have to translate everything and
keep it ready but we train applications
or artificial intelligence systems that
will do the translation on the Fly for
example you go to somewhere like China
and you want to know what is written on
a sign board now it is impossible for
somebody to translate that and put it on
the web or something like that so you
have an application which is trained to
translate stuff on the fly so you
probably this can be running on your
mobile phone on your smartphone you scan
this this the application will instantly
translate that from Chinese to English
that is one then there could be web
applications where there may be a
research document which is all in maybe
Chinese or Japanese and you want to
translate that to study that document or
in that case you need to translate that
so therefore deep learning is used in
such situations as well and that is
again on demand so it is not like you
have to translate all these documents
from other languages into English in one
short and keep it somewhere that is
again an pretty much an impossible task
but on a need basis so you have systems
that are trained to translate on the
flag so Mission translation is another
major area where deep learning is used
then there are a few other upcoming
areas where synthesizing is done by
neural nets for example music
composition and generation of music so
you can train a neural net to produce
music even to compose music so this is a
fun thing this is still upcoming it it
needs a lot of effort to train such
neural land it has been proved that it
is possible so this is a relatively new
area and on the same lines colorization
of images so these two images on the
left hand side is a grayscale image or a
black and white image this was colored
by a neural or a deep learning
application as you can see this done a
very good job of applying the colors and
obviously this was trained to do this uh
colorization but yes this is one more
application of deep learning now one of
the main major secret source of deep
learning is neural network deep learning
works on neural network or consists of
neural network so let us see what is
neural network neural network or
artificial neural network is designed or
based on the human brain now human brain
consists of billions of small cells that
are known as neurons artificial neural
networks is in a way trying to to
simulate the human brain so this is a
quick diagram of biological Neuron a
biological neuron consists of the major
part which is the cell nucleus and then
it has some tentacles kind of stuff on
the top called dendrite and then there
is like a long tail which is known as
the axon further again at the end of
this axon are what are known as synapses
these in turn are connected to the
dendroid of the next neuron and all
these neurons are interconnected with
each other therefore they are like
billions of them sitting in our brain
and they're all active they're working
they based on the signals they receive
signals as inputs from other neurons or
maybe from other parts of the body and
based on certain criteria they send
signals to the neurons at the other end
so they they get either activated or
they don't get activated based on so it
is like a binary Gates so they get
activated or not activated based on the
inputs that they receive and so on so we
will see a little bit of those details
as we move forward in our artificial
neuron but this is a biological neuron
this is the structure of a biological
neuron and artificial neural network is
based on the human brain the smallest
component of artificial neural network
is an artificial neuron as shown here
sometimes is also referred to as a
perceptron now this is a very high level
diagram the artificial neuron has a
small central unit which will receive
the input if it is doing let's say image
processing the inputs could be pixel
values of the image which is represented
here as X1 X2 and so on each of the
inputs are multiplied by what is known
as weights which are represented as W1
W2 and so on there is in the central
unit basically there is a summation of
these weighted inputs which is like X1
into W1 + X2 into W2 and so on the
products are then added and then there
is a bias that is added to that in the
next uh slide we will see that passes
through an activation function and the
output comes as a y which is the output
and based on certain criteria the cell
gets either activated or not activated
so this output would be like a zero or a
one binary format okay so we will see
that in a little bit more detail but
let's do a quick comparison between
biological and artificial neuron just
like a biological neuron there are
dendrites and then there is a cell
nucleus and synapse and and an axon we
have in the artificial neuron as well
these inputs come like the dendrite if
you will act like the dendrites there is
a like a central unit which performs the
summation of these uh weighted inputs
which is basically W1 X1 W2 X2 and so on
and then a bias is added here and then
that passes through what is known as an
activation function okay so these are
known as the weights W1 W2 and then
there is a bias which will come out here
and that is added the bias is by the way
common for a particular neuron so there
won't be like B1 B2 B3 and so on only
weights will be one per input the bias
is common for the entire neuron it is
also common for or the value of the bias
Remains the Same for all the neurons in
a particular layer we will also see this
as we move forward and we see deep
neural network where there are multiple
neurons
so that's the output now the whole
exercise of training a neuron is about
changing these weights and biases as I
mentioned artificial neural network will
consist of several such neurons and as a
part of the training process these
weights keep changing initially they are
assigned some random values through the
training process the weights the whole
process of training is to come up with
the optimum values of W1 W2 and WN and
then the B for for or the bias for this
particular neuron such that it gives an
accurate output as required so let's see
what exactly that means so the training
process this is how it happens it takes
the inputs each input is multiplied by a
weight and these weights during training
keep changing so initially they're
assigned some random values and based on
the output whether it is correct or
wrong there is a feedback coming back
and that will basically change these
weights until it starts giving the right
output that is represented in here as
Sigma I going from 1 to n if there are n
inputs wi into x i so this is the
product of W1 X1 W2 X2 and so on right
and there is a bias that gets added here
and that entire thing goes to what is
known as an activation function so
essentially this is Sigma of
wixi plus a value of bias which is a b
so that entire thing goes as an input to
an activation function now this
activation function takes this as an
input gives the output as a binary
output it could be a zero or a one there
are of course to start with let's assume
it's a binary output later we will see
that there are different types of
activation functions so it need not
always be binary output but to start
with let's keep Simple so it decides
whether the neuron should be fired or
not so that is the output like a binary
output 0 or one all right so again let
me summarize this so it takes the inputs
so if you're processing an image for
example the inputs are the pixel values
of the image X1 X2 up to xn there could
be hundreds of these so all of those are
fed as so these are some values and
these pixel values again can be from 0
to 56 each of those pixel values are
then multiplied with what is known as a
weight this is a numeric value can be
any value so this is a number W1
similarly W2 is a number so any ually
some random values will be assigned and
each of these weights are multiplied
with the input value and their sum this
is known as the weighted sum so that is
performed in this kind of the central
unit and then a bias is added remember
the bias is common for each neuron so
this is not the bias value is not one
bias value for per input so just keep
that in mind the bias value that is one
bias per neuron so it is like this
summation plus bias is the output from
this section this is not the complete
output of the neuron but this is a bias
for output for step one that goes as an
input to what is known as an activation
function and that activation function
results in an output usually a binary
output like a zero or a one which is
known as the firing of the neuron okay
good so we talked about activation
function so what is an activation
function an activation function
basically takes the weighted sum which
is we saw W1 X1 w2x x to the sum of all
that plus the bias so it takes that as
an input and it generates a certain
output now there are different types of
activation functions and the output is
different for different types of
activation functions moreover why is an
activation function required it is
basically required to bring in
nonlinearity that's the main reason why
an activation function is required so
what are the different types of
activation functions there are several
types of activation functions but these
are the most common ones these are the
ones that are currently in use sigmoid
function was one of the early activation
functions but today reu has kind of
taken over so reu is by far the most
popular activation function that is used
today but still sigmoid function is
still used in many situations these
different types of activation functions
are used in different situations based
on the kind of problem we are trying to
solve so what exactly is the difference
between these two sigmoid giv gives the
values of the output will be between 0
and one threshold function is the value
will be zero up to a certain value and
beyond that this is also known as a step
function and beyond that it will be one
in case of sigmoid there is a gradual
increase but in case of threshold it's
like also known as a step function
there's a rapid or instantaneous change
from 0 to one whereas in sigmoid we will
see in the next slide there is a gradual
increase but the value in this case is
between 0 and 1 as as well Now reu
function on the other hand it is equal
to basically if the input is 0 or less
than zero then the output is zero
whereas if the input is greater than
zero then the output is equal to the
input I know it's a little confusing but
in the next slides where we show the
relu function it will become clear
similarly hyperbolic tangent this is
similar to sigmoid in terms of the shape
of the function however while Sig goes
from 0 to 1 hyperbolic tangent goes from
-1 to 1 and here again the increase or
the change from minus1 to 1 is gradual
and not like threshold or step function
where it happens instantaneously so
let's take a little detailed look at
some of these functions so let's start
with the sigmoid function so this is the
equation of a sigmoid function which is
1x 1 + e ^ of - x so X is the value that
is the input it goes from 0 to -1 so
this is sigmoid function the equation is
5X = 1 by 1 + e ^ of - x and as you can
see here this is the input on the x-
axis as X is the value is coming from in
fact it can also go negative this is
negative actually so this is the zero so
this is the negative value of x so as X
is coming from negative value towards
zero the value of the output slowly as
it is approach approaching zero it it
slowly and very gently increases and
actually at the point let me just use a
pen at the point here it is it is 05 it
is actually 05 okay and slowly gradually
it increases to one as the value of X
increases but then as the value of X
increases it tapers off it doesn't go
beyond one so that is the speciality of
sigmoid function so the output value
will remain between 0 and 1 it will
never go below zero or above one okay
then so that is sigmoid function now
this is threshold function or this is
also referred to as a step function and
here we can also set the threshold in
this case it is that's why it's called
the threshold function normally it is
zero but you can also set a different
value for the threshold now the
difference between this and the sigmoid
is that here the change is Rapid or
instantaneous as the x value comes from
negative up to 0 it remains zero and at
Zer it pretty much immediately increases
to one okay so this is a mathematical
representation of threshold function 5x
is equal to 1 if x is greater than equal
to 0 and 0 if x is less than zero so for
all negative values it is zero since we
have set the threshold to be zero so as
soon as it reaches zero it becomes one
you see the difference between this and
the previous one which is basically the
sigmoid where the increase from 0 to one
is gradual and here it is instantaneous
and that's why this is also known as a
step function threshold function or step
function this is a reu reu is one of the
most popular activation functions today
this is the definition of reu 5x is
equal to Max of X comma 0 what it says
is if the value of x is less than zero
then 5x is um zero the moment it
increases goes beyond zero the value of
5x is equal to X so it doesn't stop at
one actually it goes all the way so as
the value of X increases the value of y
will also increase infinitely so there
is no limit here unlike your sigmoid or
threshold or the next one which is
basically hyperbolic tangent okay so in
case of reu remember there is no upper
limit the output is equal to either zero
in case the value of x is negative or it
is equal to the value of x so for
example here if the value of x is 10
then the value of y is also 10 right
okay so that is reu and there are
several advantages of reu and it is much
more efficient and uh provides much more
accuracy compared to other activation
functions like sigmoid and so on so
that's the reason it is very popular all
right so this is hyperbolic tangent
activation function the function looks
similar to sigmoid function the curve if
you see the shape it looks similar to
sigmoid function but the difference
between hyperbolic tangent and sigmoid
function is that in case of sigmoid the
output goes from 0 to 1 whereas in case
of hyperbolic tangent it goes from
minus1 to 1 so that is the difference
between hyperbolic tangent and sigmoid
function otherwise the shape looks very
similar there is a gradual increase
unlike the step function where there was
an instant increase or instant change
here again very similar to sigmoid
function the value changes gradually
from minus1 to 1 so this is the equation
of hyperbolic tangent activation
function yeah so then let's move on this
is a diagrammatic representation of the
activation function and how the overall
data or how the overall progression
happens from input to the output so we
get the input from the input layer by
the way the neural network has three
layers typically there will be three
layers there is an input layer there is
an output layer and then you have the
hidden layer so the input come from the
input layer and they get processed in
the hidden layer and then you get the
output in the output layer so let's take
a little bit of a detailed look into the
working of a neural network so let's say
we want to classify some images between
dogs and cats how do we do this this is
known as a classification process and we
are trying to use neural networks and
deep learning to implement this
classification so how do we do that so
this is how it works so you have four
layer neural network there is an input
layer there is an output layer and then
there are two hidden layers and what we
do is we provide labeled training data
which means these images are fed to the
network with the label saying that okay
this is a cat the neural network is
allowed to process it and come up with a
prediction saying whether it is a cat or
a dog and obviously in the beginning
there may be mistakes a cat may be
classified as a dog so we then say that
okay this is wrong this output is wrong
but every time it predicts correctly we
say yes this output is correct so that
learning process so it will go back make
some changes to its weights and biases
we again feed these inputs and it will
give us the output we will check whether
it is correct or not and so on so this
is a iterative process which is is known
as the training process so we are
training the neural network and what
happens in the training process these
weights and biases you remember there
were weights like W1 W2 and so on so
these weights and biases keep changing
every time you feed these which is known
as an Epoch so there are multiple
iterations every iteration is known as
an Epoch and each time the weights are
dated to make sure that the maximum
number of IM images are classified
correctly so once again what is the
input this input could be like thousand
images of cats and dogs and they are
labeled because we know which is a cat
and which is a dog and we feed those
thousand images the neural network will
initially assign some weights and biases
for each neuron and it will try to
process extract the features from the
images and it will try to come up with
the prediction for each image and that
prediction that is calculated by the
network is compared with the actual
value whether it is a cat or a dog and
that's how the error is calculated so
let's say there are, images and in the
first run only 500 of them have been
correctly classified that means we are
getting only 50% accuracy so we feed
that information back to the network
further update these weights and biases
for each of the neurons and we run this
these inputs once again it will try to
calculate extract the features and it
will try to predict which of these is
cats and dogs and this time let's say
out of, 700 of them have been predicted
correctly so that means in the second
iteration the accuracy has increased
from 50% to 70% all right then we go
back again we feed this maybe for a
third iteration fourth iteration and so
on and slowly and steadily the accuracy
of this network will keep increasing and
it may reach probably you never know 90%
95% and there are several parameters
that are known as Hyper parameters that
need to be changed and tweaked and that
is the overall training process and
ultimately at some point we say okay you
will probably never reach 100% accuracy
but then we set a limit saying that okay
if we receive 95% accuracy that is good
enough for our application and then we
say okay our training process is done so
that is the way training happens and
once the training is done now with the
training data set the system has let's
say seen all these thousand images there
for what we do is the next step like in
any normal machine learning process we
do the testing where we take a fresh set
of images and we feed it to the network
the fresh set which it has not seen
before as a part of the training process
and this is again nothing new in deep
learning this was there in machine
learning as well so you feed the test
images and then find out whether we are
getting a similar accuracy or not so
maybe that accuracy May reduce a little
bit while training you may get 98% and
then for test you may get 95% but there
shouldn't be a drastic drop like for
example you get 98% in training and then
you get 50% or 40% with the test that
means your network has not learned you
may have to retrain your network so that
is the way neural network training works
and remember the whole process is about
changing these weights and biases and
coming up with the optimal values of
these weights and biases so that the
accuracy is the maximum possible all
right so little bit more detail about
how this whole thing works so this is
known as forward propagation which is
the data or the information is going in
the forward Direction the inputs are
taken weighted summation is done bias is
added here and then that is fed to the
activation function and then that is
that comes out as our output so that is
forward propagation and the output is
compared with the actual value and that
will give us the error the difference
between them is the error and in
technical terms that is also known as
our cost function and this is what we
would like to minimize there are
different ways of defining the cost
function but one of the simplest ways is
mean square error so it is nothing but
the square of the difference of the
errors or the sum of the squares of the
difference of the errors and this is
also nothing new we have probably if
you're familiar with machine learning
you must have come across this mean
Square eror now there are different ways
of defining cost function it need not
always be the mean square error but the
most common one is this so you define
this cost function and you ask the
system to minimize this error so we use
what is known as an optimization
function to minimize this error and the
error itself sent back to the system as
feedback and that is known as back
propagation and so this is the cost
function and how do we optimize the cost
function we use what is known as
gradient descent so the gradient descent
mechanism identifies how to change the
weights and biases so that the cost
function is minimized and there is also
what is known as the rate of the
learning rate that is what is shown here
as slower and faster so you need to
specify what should be the learning rate
now if the learning rate is very small
then it will will probably take very
long to train whereas if the learning
rate is very high then it will appear to
be faster but then it will probably
never what is known as converge now what
is Convergence now we are talking about
a few terms here convergence is like
this this is a representation of
convergence so the whole idea of
gradient descent is to optimize the cost
function or minimize the cost function
in order to do that we need to repres
ENT the cost function as this curve we
need to come to this minimum value that
is what is known as the minimization of
the cost function now what happens if we
have the learning rate very small is
that it will take very long to come to
this point on the other hand if you have
large Higher Learning rate what will
happen is instead of stopping here it
will cross over because the learning
rate is high and then it has to come
back back so it will result in what is
known as like an oscillation so it will
never come to this point which is known
as convergence instead it will go back
and forth so these are known as Hyper
parameters the learning rate and so on
and these have to be those numbers or
those values we can determine typically
using trial and error out of experience
we we try to find out these value so
that is the gradient descent mechanism
to optimize the cost function and that
is what is used to train our neural
network this is another representation
of how the training process works and
here in this example we are trying to
classify these images whether they are
cats or dogs and as you can see actually
each image is fed in each time one image
is fed rather and these values of X1 X2
up to xn are the pixel values within
this image okay so those values are then
taken and for each of those values a
weight is Multiplied and then it goes to
the next layer and then to the next
layer and so on ultimately it comes as
the output layer and it gives an output
as whether it is a dog or a cat remember
the output will never be a named output
so these would be like a zero or a one
and we say Okay zero corresponds to dogs
and one corresponds to cats so that is
the way it typically happens this is a
binary classification we have similar
situations where there can be multiple
classes which means that there will be
multiple more neurons in the output
layer okay so this is once again a quick
representation of how the forward
propagation and the backward propagation
works so the information is going in
this direction which is basically the
forward propagation and at the output
level we find out what is the cost
function the difference is basically
sent back as part of the backward
propagation and gradient descent then
adjust the weights and biases for the
next iteration this happens iteratively
till the cost function is minimized and
that is when we say the whole the
network has converged or the training
process has converged and there can be
situations where convergence may not
happen in rare cases but by and large
the network will converge and after
maybe a few iterations it could be tens
of iterations or hundreds of iterations
depending on what exactly the number
number of iterations can vary and then
we say okay we are getting a certain
accuracy and we say that is our
threshold maybe 90% accuracy we we stop
at that and we say that the system is
trained the train model is then deployed
for production and so on so that is the
way the neural network training happens
okay so that is the way classification
Works in deep learning using neural
network and this slide is an animation
of this whole process as you can see the
forward propagation the data is going
forward from the input layer to the
output layer and there is an output and
error is calculated the cost function is
calculated and that is fed back as a
part of backward propagation and that
whole process repeats once again okay so
remember in neural networks the training
process is nothing but the finding the
best values of the weights and biases
for each and every new neuron in the
network that's all training of neural
network consists of finding the optimal
values of the weights and biases so that
the accuracy is maximum so first we'll
understand the basics and starting with
the basics we'll start with what is deep
learning so deep learning often touted
as an attempt to replicate human brain
learning operates through intricate
mathematical functions enabling
computers to perform tasks similar to
humans for instance it underpins
groundbreaking Technologies like
driverless cars as well as voice
activated assistance such as cityi and
Amazon Alexa in practice deep learning
empowers computers to learn directly
from various data formats such as images
text or audio through this process
computer model achieve remarkable
accuracy occasionally surpassing human
level performance it's not just about
mimicking human cognition it's about
harnessing the immense computational
power to expect whil amounts of data and
extract meaningful patterns the backbone
of deep learning consist of neural
networks interconnected nodes that
process data through layers each layer
refining the representation of the data
training these networks involve
adjusting parameters to minimize errors
and improve accuracy a process
resembling the human learning experience
Albert on a vastly accelerated scale
while data and computational challenges
exist the field continues to evolve
research and Innovation are driving deep
learning for forward opening doors to
improved image recognition natural
language understanding medical
Diagnostics and more the promise of
unsupervised learning and the
integration of deep learning into
diverse Industries paints an exciting
future for this transformative
technology impacting the way we interact
with machines and pushing the boundaries
of what's possible so this was all about
the basics and about the Deep learning
now we'll see why we should learn deep
learning so it's a game changer in
various aspects offering
state-of-the-art performance scalability
with data reduced feature engineering
and transferability across task firstly
deep learning shines where traditional
machine learning algorithm struggle
speech recognition image classification
and object detection are areas with deep
learning algorithms like CNN
convolutional neural networks and reant
neural networks RNN Excel due to their
specialized architectures pushing the
boundaries of what's achievable moreover
as data becomes abundant deep learnings
performance perance continues to improve
unlike classical machine learning
algorithms which plate in performance
with more data deep learning algorithms
thrive on it offering a scalable
solution for the ever expanding data
sets another significant Advantage is
the reduced need for intricate feature
engineering traditional methods often
require complex manual feature
extraction in deep learning the emphasis
is on learning directly from the data
reducing the burden of feature
engineering and making it more
accessible for beginners
additionally deep learning models are
transferable pre-rain networks such as
vgg16 rest Nets and mobile net can be
leveraged as feature extraction tools
for related task this accelerates model
training and enhances performance
especially when faced with limited data
and computational resources in a sense
deep learning empowers you with cutting
it skills enabling you to tackle complex
problems scale with data and Achieve
impressive results without the need for
extensive feature engineering its
transferability across task provide a
strategic Advantage making it an
invaluable skill for modern Ai and
machine learning practitioners so these
were the points that show us why we
should learn deep learning and before
moving on to the railro and before
moving on to the road map to become a
deep learning engineer we have a course
offering for you that is if you are one
of the aspiring deep learning
enthusiasts looking for online training
or a professional who sits to switch
careers in deep learning by learning
from the experts then try giving short
to celtech a ml boot camp that is in
collaboration with simply learn and the
link to this boot camp is mentioned in
the description box below that will
navigate you to the Boot Camp Page where
you can find a complete overview of the
program being offered now moving on to
the road map to become an deep learning
engineer so learning deep learning as a
beginner involves several essential
steps each building upon the previous to
develop a comprehensive understanding
and practical skills in this field so
the first is learn and master python so
python is the foundation for many deep
learning libraries and Frameworks start
by mastering python syntax data
structures and basic programming
Concepts it's essential to be
comfortable with python as you will use
it extensively for coding deep learning
models and moving on to the next step
that is mathematics for deep learning
develop a solid understanding of the
mathematical Concepts behind deep
learning this includes linear algebra
that includes vectors matrices
operations then we have calculus in that
we have differentiation integration and
then we have statistics that includes
probability and distributions these
concepts are vital to grasp the inner
workings of neural networks and then we
have neural networks the third step that
is dive into the core of deep learning
understanding neural networks explore
topics like lose functions that is how
the model measures its performance
activation functions that is which add
nonlinearity to the network then we have
weight initialization that is critical
for model convergence and the vanishing
or exploding gradient problem that is a
challeng in deep networks then we have
the next step that is architectures so
familiarize yourself with various neural
network architectures start with feed
forward neural networks which form the
basis for many models progress to Auto
encoders convolutional neural networks
CNN for image task recent neural
networks RNN for sequential data
Transformers for NLP task SES networks
for similarity comparision generative
ADV veral networks GN for generating
data and explore evolving architectures
like neat neuro evolution of augmenting
topologies and now moving on to the next
step that is learning tools and
Frameworks so learn to work with popular
deep learning tools and Frameworks
familiarize yourself with tensorflow P
torch caras and ml flow these tools
simplify model development and
management so after this step you should
learn the model optimization so
understand techniques for model
optimization this includes distillation
that is knowledge transfer from large
models to smaller ones quantization
reducing model size without significant
loss of performance and neural
architecture search that is automated
methods to find Optimal Network
architectures then you should have
Hands-On projects to practice on that is
apply what you have learned by working
on Hands-On projects start with simple
task and gradually tackle more complex
problems implement the different
architectures you have learned use the
Frameworks and experiment with model
optimization techniques by following
this structured approach you will build
a strong foundation in deep learning
enabling you to create train and
optimize neural networks for various
tasks the combination of theoretical
understanding and practical experience
gained from Hands-On projects will equip
you to explore Advanced topics and
contribute to the exciting field of deep
learning and the field of deep learning
is rapidly evolving so stay updated with
the latest research papers new
techniques and emerging Technologies
engage with the AI community Through
forums blogs and conferences and
consider joining AI focused online
communities and attend conferences like
neural PS cvpr or icml and there you
have it the Deep learning engineer road
map remember this journey requires
dedication continuous learning and a
passion for solving complex problems
whether you are aiming to work in indust
research or both this road map will set
you on the right path so as we dig
deeper into looking at the theory behind
the neural network and we kind of flip
back and forth between these because
there's two huge aspects of it one is
from the outside what are you seeing and
what's going on from the inside so you
can find to do what you need to do and
give the best results you can and we
start off with uh what do we feed we
feed an unlabeled image to a machine
which identifies it without any human
intervention and so you can see here we
have we have a circle that comes in at
784 pixels and it comes in by 28x 28 and
you can see how it colors in the um the
circle on there and we put a triangle in
the Triangle in also comes in as 28x 28
and it has 784 pixels so you'll see
between these two both of them are
784 pixels this machine is intelligent
enough to differentiate between the
various shapes so that's what we want to
use our neural network to do is to say
hey this is a circle this is a triangle
that's more of a categorical you can
also do a regression model where you're
actually putting out float value or a
numerical value we'll be looking at the
true false or the categorical model
mostly because that's where you usually
start at the different there is no real
difference when you as far as the way
the internal functioning goes when you
start flipping between them other than
well we'll talk about that in just a
minute so you can actually go between
the two quite easily and the neural
network provides this capability so
we're going to use this capability to
look between those two one of the things
I want you to note in here is that we're
looking at 784 pixels we're looking at
784 inputs that's very different than
stock with a high low or last year's
cells based on date we're looking at
just a couple of numbers and they're
very clear they're numbers they're very
clear what they are which is something
You' put into a machine learning linear
regression model this is a step up from
that in that we're looking at complex
patterns and how do you figure those
complex patterns out so a neural network
is a system modeled on the human brain
and we looked at that comparing the two
let's go ahead and look deeper into the
neural network itself we have our inputs
coming in so the inputs are fed to a
neuron that processes the data and gives
us an output input and output this is
the most basic structure of a neural
network known as a perceptron so if you
see the term perceptron that's what
we're talking about we're talking about
this single node that has inputs and an
output however neural networks are
usually much more complex let's start
with visualizing a neural network as a
black box and I always love that symbol
it's a black box it's kind of magical we
have our inputs coming in in and we want
certain outputs the Box takes inputs
processes them and gives an output let's
have a look at what happens within this
box and you can see me there in my uh
secret agent getup I got my hidden hood
and everything I guess I'm part of the
uh black skull or something like that
group uh so let's take a look at what
happens within this magic box and
remember we're skipping back and forth
between the theory of what's going on in
the box which you have to know how to
fine-tune and how to build versus
looking at it from the outside we're
programming this box and we have an
input and an output to the box as a
whole within the Box exists a network
that is a core of deep learning and you
can see here we're showing one layer and
we have our grid coming in the network
consists of layers of neurons each
neuron is associated with a number
called the bias and you can think of the
bias uh if you overly simplify this and
we're doing a linear regression model
this is your Y intercept in your ukian
geometry you have to have something that
offsets it and so you always have a bias
in these set cells neurons of each layer
transmit information to neurons of the
next layer over channels and so you can
see each of our layers going through
from left to right these channels are
associated with numbers called weights
these weights along with the biases
determine the information that is passed
over from the neuron to neuron so just
like the bias is your Y intercept in
ukian Geometry you could look at the an
one weight remember this is very
complicated so we're not looking at just
one weight you could look at the weight
as your slope of the line or if you're
doing X equals uh m y + C it would be
the M value neurons of each layer
transmit information to neurons of the
next layer and you can see here is a
light up going across into the final
layer and then to the output and in this
case the output is going to be either uh
a square in this one or it might light
up the other one which is a circle the
output layer emits a predicted output so
in this case we're looking at a
classification uh true false is it a
circle is it a triangle is it a square
let's now go deeper what happens Within
in the neuron so we're going to dig
deeper and start getting a little bit
closer to some of the math don't worry
you don't have to be a calculus expert
or know your differential equations even
though this is one giant differential
equation you don't need to understand
those to understand what's going on
within each neuron the following
operations are performed the product of
each input and the weight of the channel
it's passed over is found this is simply
addition we're going to sum up the
weight times the output from the
previous channel and plus the bias some
of the weighted products is comp this is
called the weighted sum bias unique to
the neuron is added to the weighted sum
the final sum is then subjected to the
particular function and we'll discuss
those that particular function that part
is really important because those
functions uh have a huge impact on how
well your model performs under different
conditions the final sum is then
subjected to a particular function this
is the activation function so if you
ever hear the term activation function
that's what we're talking about what
activates this cell and what doesn't as
we did dig deeper into activation
function an activation function takes
the weighted sum of the input as its
input adds a bias and provides an output
and a lot of times you'll actually see
one formula for the sum of the weight
the weighted sum and the bias you'll
just see that as a single line of
everything added together and here we've
broken it apart because it makes it
clear that this bias is not computed the
same as the weighted sums here are the
most popular types of activation
function and I always find these
interesting because at one point I was
sitting at a table with a gentleman who
was finishing his PhD he was in his last
year and he said he went through all
this stuff and he ended up just trying
the four different activation functions
on this particular problem he was
working on so knowing the math behind it
doesn't necessarily mean you're going to
know it right away uh so even somebody
who might have a PhD and be doing the
calculations on this comes back out of
it and ends up just trying the different
uh activation functions to see what's
going to make a difference and a lot of
times that's a final step that's the
kind of thing where you you built your
whole model you've come back and you're
like wait a minute can I do a better
deal with a sigmoid function or the
threshold or the rectifier knowing what
they're doing is important so you can
explain it to somebody else and again
you probably do this on a small set of
data if you're working with big data uh
you don't want to take down the full
server Farm just to test out your three
different series you take a small
portion of that data test it and then
you put it through to the big data so
let's take a look at this we have the
sigmoid function and it's used for
models where we have to predict the
probability as an output it exists
between zero and one and you'll see
that's true of all of our um activation
functions we're working with either the
cell's on or off it's true or false and
there might be a little variation in
there which as an output could be used
to compute uncertainty in your solution
so if you're getting a 7 with this
activation function it might be well I'm
not sure if that's really a square or
I'm not sure that's really a triangle
and that might be a flag for it to be
looked at by a human Observer at least
in today's models where we're at right
now and you can see here we have the
formula simply equals 1 over 1 + e to
Theus X where X is your value coming in
and it's going to give you a result that
looks very similar to the graph on there
which is somewhere between zero and one
um and right in the middle you can see
that there's a huge uh kind of you can
go through all the different values and
uncertainties involved so the sigmoid
function is probably the default of most
of them uh the next one is the threshold
function it is a threshold based
activation function if x value is
greater than a certain value the
function is activated and fired else not
pretty straightforward yes no true false
um I don't want to test for
improbabilities I just want a straight
answer I don't want to know if there's a
partial value on there it either is true
or it's false and the rectifier function
it is the most widely used activation
function I would debate that um
rectifier is pretty common one although
I see the the sigmoid function is used
to be the basic one but it's up there
the rectifier function is very commonly
used it gives the output of x if x is
positive and z otherwise and you can see
here again just like um uh it's either
kind of get a value going up there so
max of X of0 so it's it's again it's
like the threshold function yes no true
false uh it's either zero or it's uh
some kind of progressive value and then
we have the rectifier function I would
argue with this because the sigmoid
function used to be the most common one
but with the rectifier function uh it
now says it is the most commonly used or
widely used activation function and
gives an output of x if x is positive
and zero otherwise this is kind of nice
cuz it now says absolutely not or it
gives you a value of probability now
when I say a value of probability be
very careful there I'm not saying that
it's going to tell you this is 75%
chance of being a circle I'm going to
tell you that it says hey if this says
0.1 it probably needs to be looked at or
0 2 or. 3 it's going to depend on your
data as to what that value means in
general that just means it's flagging it
that if it's not a one then chances are
it needs to be looked at by a person and
re-evaluated and there's a hyperbolic
tangent function this function is
similar to sigmoid function is bound to
a range of minus1 to one so you can see
there's our 1 - e- 2x and 1 plus over 1
plus e to Theus 2x again it's very
similar to the sigmoid function the
bonus of the hyperbolic function is you
have that variable coming through the
middle so again you can look at it and
you have a little bit more weight as far
as you can process that down the line
that's a little bit more advanced than
than what we're looking at right now and
a lot of times it's not even necessary
in a lot of our different uh uses for
these activation functions now we looked
at activation functions and I kind of
said those are a little bit like a black
box because even if you know all the
math a lot of times you end up just
playing with them to find out what works
and it also depends on what model you're
working with whether you need a flat yes
no true false or you need to have
something in the middle that says hey
this isn't quite a one you might need to
process this with the human intervention
and you can look at that one example
would be self-driving cars you don't
want a car to be yes no I'm going to go
through the the light you want it to be
like okay if it's uh almost yes maybe we
stop and have human intervention so we
don't get an accident cost function is
something you can really see and measure
and is very important the cost value is
the difference between the neural Net's
predicted output and the actual output
from a set of labeled training data so
we have our group of data that's a
square circle and since we're looking at
geometrical shapes we've had somebody
already labeled that data they've
already said this is a triangle this is
a square and so if this is coming up and
it's giving us it's saying a square is a
triangle and it's saying a triangle is a
circle the output is wrong and so that
output can then be measured and the
versus the actual output and that's the
cost uh you might also hear this as
error because that's the error value
being returned how far off is it and
what we're looking for is the least cost
or the least error value and it's
obtained by making adjustments to the
weights and biases iteratively
throughout the training process and this
this is called back propag a and we're
going to look in that a little deeper as
we look into an example it's really hard
to see when you're just looking at
arrows without actual numbers and where
the flow is coming from but you can look
at this is here's our inputs they put
out a prediction the prediction comes
out and says hey we've already labeled
this data CU we're in training mode and
the training data is off this is the
cost can we send that error or that cost
back and adjust those weights and we do
it in very small increments across large
amounts of data so that those weights
minimize is that cost or that error but
what happens Within These neurons so
let's look at a little example of this
kind of helps if you have some kind of
visual let's build a neural network that
predict bike prices based on a few of
its features and we'll see here we have
our CC our mileage and our abs and these
are our three input layers and then we
have the bike price and the output layer
now it doesn't do us very good to just
uh pump it in from the beginning and
pump it out and to be honest I would use
a machine learning linear regression
model on this since these are just
straight numbers numbers but because we
want a simple example we're going to put
this through and show you as a neural
network what that looks like and we got
to put a hidden layer in there the
hidden layer helps in improving the
output accuracy and you could look at
this as a bunch of ores so it might say
hey when we compare these three values
on the first hidden layer neuron we're
looking at one set of features and then
we might wait them in the second one so
these are a bunch of different ores kind
of how the math comes out in behind the
scenes and then they go out of course to
the bike prer or the output layer and
each of the connections have a weight
assigned with it and you'll see here we
have a mileage CC with the weight one
and weight two going into our first
neuron and you'd also have your abs
going in there and so X1 * weight 1 + X2
time weight 2 plus the bias of one and
step two is our activation the
activation function coming in there when
does this fire and the neuron takes a
subset of the inputs and processes it
and then we go through we do that with
the um second hidden layer neur on and
the third one and so on so you process
each layer in order going forward now
when I told you this is in its infant
stage they now have neurons that fire
into the same layer or back a layer so
that you now have a Time series and
there's all kinds of wild things that
they're experimenting with on these
layers this basic setup has been around
since the mid90s it's only now because
of our technology that it's open to
almost everybody to play with it and
that's why I say this is in an infant
stage in development is this basic math
is here but what we can do with it is
amazing and what they're actually doing
with all these different things is
amazing and so we're just at the
beginning of how to use all these
different Tools in our deep learning in
our neural networks uh and so once we
have our hidden layer computed the
information reaching the neurons in the
hidden layer is subjected to the
respective activation function and so
each one of these fires an activation
output uh and then those are each
weighted to the final output layer so
the processed information is now sent to
the output layer once again over
weighted channels and you could look at
this as each one of these is um I always
look at this as like a group of people
they're all looking at the bulletin
board and the first person says this is
what I project sales for the company in
the second person and the third and so
on and then their perspectives are
weighted based on their expertise so
your accountant might have a very high
weight where the um maybe your janitor
has a very low weight because their
expertise is not in accounting and then
that goes into the output layer and once
in the output layer it goes uh the
output which is the predicted value is
compared against the original value so
now we have our output layer and since
we have like already a list of uh bikes
with their the different setups and what
their value is we can now generate an
error from this the cost function
determines the error and prediction and
reports it back to the neural network so
this is the cost this is how far off it
is this is your error coming back and as
you can see this is a back propagation
going on so now our error is going in
reverse because we know we're not
completely correct on this particular
channel the weights are adjusted in
order to reduce the error so each time
we go back we are changing those weights
to reduce that error and we change them
in small increments you don't want to
fit one input remember you might have a
data pool with a terabyte of data you
don't want to solve for the first set of
data that comes in and that be the main
solution because everything else will be
off this is going to confuse you that's
also called the bias so we have the bias
in the cell where we're adding a value
the kind of like the Y intercept and we
have a bias of the whole neural network
which means it is weighted towards one
set of answers so we want to make small
changes in these weights so we don't
create a bias and the weights are
adjusted in order to reduce the error or
the cost the network is now trained
using the new weights once again the
cost is determined and back propagation
is continued until the cost cannot be
reduced any further so let's go ahead
and plug in values and see how our
neural network works so here we come in
here and initially our channels are
assigned assigned with random weights
this is important because if you assign
them all with the same weight you might
be able to reproduce it but it turns out
that if I put all my weights as one or
all my weights as zero it takes longer
to train where if you have random
weights they already have like a little
bit of adjustment in or is built in and
that will give us a better answer and
train faster our first neuron takes a
value of mileage and CC as inputs so
here comes our computation whatever
those inputs are and we do that again
with the second neuron with those values
coming in you can see here we have
weight three and so on and then our
third neuron coming down and of course
our fourth neuron so we're adding all
these different values coming in here in
our hidden layer the process value from
each neuron is sent to the output layer
over weighted channels so again here's
our weights coming in and we have N1 N2
N3 and N4 once again the values are
subjected to the activation function and
a single value is emitted as the output
on comparing the predicted value to the
actual value we clearly see that our
Network requires training so here we
have it that our bike price uh we put
out we thought it was worth uh 2,000 on
our random weights and the bike actually
was 4,000 on there guessing that's not
Us doll because that'd be a very
expensive bike but maybe it is there's
some $2,000 $4,000 bikes out there the
cost function is calculated and back
propagation takes place and this is
pretty simple you can look at that as
our um we're subtracting one value from
the other we Square it and then we take
half of that and that is propagated back
up and each layer generates its own
errors let's go back one cuz you have
your predicted Y and your actual y that
goes back to the first layer and then
based on the value of the cost function
certain weights are changed so when we
look at the next layer that error is not
the original 4,000 minus 2000 squar
divided two this error is based on the
error of each cell generated how far off
is that cell as far as its weights we're
not going to show you it's actually a
very complicated differential equation
and you can probably write it out if you
wanted to you just write out each
formula that goes into the next level
and you add them all together and you
can write it out all the way through
computers make it so you don't have to
and our neural network is considered
trained when the value for the cost
function is minimum so when we get our
error way down as low as we can that's
when our neural network is trained and
there I mean just recently they've come
up with all kinds of different means for
measuring that particular value a little
bit beyond the scope of today's neural
network but you can actually you can
actually see it know how far do you do
this until the um neural network doesn't
need to be trained anymore and you can
overtrain a neural network now the tools
that we're looking at automatically let
you know when to stop which is really
nice and that is just like I said we're
at the beginning stages in neural
networks it's just really cool what they
can do now and how much of it's
automated and how much of it is
experimental right now let's take a look
at gradient descent but what approach do
we take to minimize the cost function so
here we have a nice error thing coming
in this is our cost or our error uh
let's start with plotting the cost
function against the predicted value and
so you can see they fed in multiple y's
and these are the errors coming in and
the cost of each of these inputs and
changes going on note we start at a
random point on the curve so usually you
put in you know you pick up your data
and you randomly pick where to start in
your data a lot of times you just run it
from the beginning because you're going
through so much data is not that big of
a deal but you start with one point
going in so your forward propagation
goes through you're going to go ahead
and find your cost or your error it
points out on the curve and you can see
how we're plotting it right here since
the gradient at this point is positive
we may move right so we're going to move
a little bit to the right on here and
this time the gradient is negative we
move a little bit to the left eventually
we try out the point where the gradient
is zero this is the least value of cost
function you have to be a little careful
with this because this particular I mean
they make it look nice and simple in
this graph sometimes these curves look
like stair steps and so there is global
minimums and and then there is local
there might be a local point where the
gradient is zero but it's not the global
one uh so it might be way off to the
left where it just happens to step down
a little bit and you think you're in the
right gradient and with that we have all
the right weights and we can say our
network is trained so here we have um
just some major these are some of the
big names out there right now in
development for deep learning platforms
tensorflow which we'll actually do an
example in in a minute deep learning for
J which is in the Java platform uh so if
you're Java programmer uh by the way
tensorflow is accessed most people are
using python to access it but it is a
system that's kind of separate from a
lot of the programming languages which
makes it a lot more um flexible as far
as use deep learning for J is Java based
and then cross is just exploding right
now and this is interesting cross is uh
working with tensor flow it actually can
sit on top of tensor flow and it can
also do its own thing uh so if you're
studying deep learning you're getting
into it you want to know the basics of
tensor flow but you also are going to
want to know the upper level of carass
sitting on top of tensor flow we're just
looking at tensor flow today though in
our example and there's also torch on
there there's a bunch more that we
didn't list on here um even sklearn or
the Side Package in Python has a neural
network you can program a very basic one
and it is the same basic one that you
could do in tensorflow if you stripped
everything out of it and then tensorflow
has a lot of tools they've added in and
so has carass but we're going to be
looking specifically at tensorflow in
our example and tensor flow is an open-
Source tool used to define and run
computations on what they call tensors
very common language now so you more and
more we see the term tensor as being a
standard in the uh deep learning
language and this was originally
developed by Google so let's take a
little bit big in there what are tensors
tensors are just another name for arrays
so a tensor of Dimension five you can
see here we have a b k m q whatever so
it's an array coming in and the tensor
of Dimension 54 more like a picture very
common to see that in a picture you can
also see a tensor even more detailed in
a picture as we go to the next one
tensor of Dimension 333 this is 3D space
you might have a picture that also has
colors that might be the third dimension
you might have four dimensions because
you have both your grid and your
different color channels and your zplot
you can see where you can now process a
very high level set of data coming in
whether as an image or features they
could be features that have nothing to
do with images so there's a lot of stuff
you can do now with the tensor coming in
thus is where the term tensor flow comes
from so we have um right now the tensor
flow is the most popular library in deep
learning and I did mention carass now
works with tensorflow so there's a lot
of stuff you can do between the two uh
it's an open-source software Library
developed by Google uh so they hit a
roadblock and they realized hey this is
an infant stage technology you know we
thought it was going to be the next
greatest thing and we were going to have
a ho on it but it's really infant as far
as how it's applied and what we can do
with it let's open source it so
everybody can work on it uh let's take
it to the next level and that's really
what open source does to a lot of these
uh packages when they release them and
you can run on either a CPU or a GPU so
when we look at the details if you have
your graphic processing units um what's
nice about those is they run a lot
faster the downside is you have to play
with them a little bit to get them up
and running and it's a hardware upgrade
when we run it I'll be running it in the
CPU mode I have played with it in my GPU
on my personal computer you know it does
increase theice processing uh but I did
run into some version problems with my
Python and stuff like that and when I
did finally work it out I went back to
the CPU cuz it didn't increase my speed
enough for what I was working on but in
a larger group you might be able put
that on if you're working with a larger
stack of computers you might want to run
it in the GPU you can create a data flow
graphs that have nodes and edges so
there's our edges coming in we didn't
talk about edges but that's very up
oncoming way of looking at your
analytical data as how do different
nodes connect what are those edges look
like in between them and it's used for
machine learning applications such as
neural networks it is mostly a neural
network but they have all kinds of tools
which sit on top of our basic neural
network they have new stuff evolving
into the tensor flow Library so it's
very much uh just exploding great time
to jump into tensorflow there's all
kinds of cool things are doing with it
and all kinds of cool applications you
can now use tensorflow for so let's take
a look at implementation in tensorflow
and we're going to build a neural
network to identify handwritten digits
using the uh mnist database or the mnist
database and that stands for modified
National Institute of Standards and
Technology database it is a collection
of 70,000 handwritten digits and the
digit labels identify each of the digits
from 0 to 9 this is a cool example
because it's simple enough that you
could actually run this through some
basic machine learning categorizing
algorithms and train them and you'll get
about the same answer because again it's
it's simple grid the digits on the grid
don't have a huge amount of variation
like you would say an automated driving
car looking at the environment so you
could still do this with a lot of your
um different linear models and stuff
like that you can solve this and you'll
get about the same answer when I run a
comparison between tins or flow and
between some basic uh regression models
or category models uh in machine
learning they came up pretty even as far
as their output uh so this is kind of
where we start to see the complexity of
something coming in uh in this case a 10
answer you know or a grid of information
where the Deep learning model does as
good as the regular models and when you
get past this kind of complexity and
features suddenly the neural networks
come up with better answers better
Solutions and a better build and that's
why there's such a move into neural
networks is we live in a complicated
world and it's just really cool we can
do with this so the handwritten digits
from the um nist database they come in
the data set is used to train the
machine a new image image of a digit is
fed and the digit is identified um and
if you've looked at any of our other
machine learning tools where we're doing
training uh where we train our uh model
to fit and then you test it out this
will look pretty familiar uh and there
is some tools out there for say
untrained categorizing uh where it's
just looking for features that fit
together so there are tools that don't
need that training but this is where uh
when we talk about neural networks we do
need to train them and this is what
we're looking at so for this I'm going
to use the Anaconda Navigator just
because it's a very nice visual tool you
might be in py charm or one of your
other idees for editing python because
we're are looking at Python tensorflow
and under Anaconda we have the notebook
which is something we use pretty
regularly and they have the Jupiter lab
the Jupiter lab is the Jupiter notebook
but with tabs and a few new features so
we'll be using the Jupiter lab today and
under the environment you'll want to go
ahead and and uh if you haven't yet uh
you'll see that I have a number of
different setups in here right now I
have the python version 36 and the
tensor flow in this case I have tensor
flow 1.12 if we scroll down you can see
that uh here we go tensorflow and it's
version 1.12 and in here if you haven't
yet you'll need to install those go in
and just open our terminal and U if
you've never used the anaconda or if
you're in your other thing you might
have something simple like pip cond is
what I use for my install and you can
simply do cond install tensor that
should bring in the most current version
now when I installed this a few months
ago python version I'm not going to run
this because I already have installed on
here python version 3.7 the newest one
out still had a couple glitches with the
tensor flow I believe they fixed it as a
writing of this but um I'm going to
stick with 36 just so I don't get any
surprises on there so this is python
version 36 with in tensor flow 1.12 on
here and if you haven't installed it yet
you also want to install numpy for this
example that's numbers python or uh Nu
mpy you can just simply run install on
there keep in mind if you're in Anaconda
uh and you've created one of these
environments specific to this keep with
cond if you're going to use cond if
you're going to use pip keep with Pip
don't install one package with Pip and
one under cond because that's how they
track those version numbers and how they
fit together and you can end up with a
problem they don't pip doesn't see cond
and vice versa uh so just keep that in
mind when you're running your installs
we'll go ahead and open up Jupiter left
and we're going to launch that so here's
my Jupiter lab one of the really cool
features of Jupiter lab is you have tabs
now so you can open up multiple
notebooks this is nice cuz I have my
notes I'm working on and then our actual
window we're looking in and we'll go
ahead and zoom in a little bit here
there we go so you have a nice U
hopefully easy to see fonts and then
we'll go ahead and do a simple or get
our Imports out of the way um and so
we're going to import our tensor flow as
TF uh that's pretty much a standard for
tensor flow numpy our numbers python as
py and we'll import our Matt plot
Library as PLT again these are very
common so if you see TF or py or PLT
this is a standard that most people use
do you have to no you could just do
import numpy instead of doing as py and
then from tensorflow do
examples. tutorials this is always nice
because they actually include data set
we're going to play with so we're going
to import input data so there's our data
coming in that's all we're doing is um
telling it this is where it's coming
from and if we're going to tell where
it's coming from we need to go ahead and
create a variable with that information
in it and we'll just call this uh MN
nist or minced you know I don't really
know how they pronounce that I should
probably look that up it's a very common
data set to use and there's our input
data and we're going to read data sets
and this is um if you look at this we
imported input data from our tensor flow
and so this is a tensor flow read
statement for their Tut tutorials so
this isn't like some special python
setup this is just their setup makes it
easy to pull it in so once we get into
their data sets we need to go and tell
out what kind of data set and again this
is what we brought in but it's going to
be the nince data and this part is very
important one hot equals true this means
that instead of importing a value from 0
to 9 we evaluate the data set it's going
to bring it in as one hot when you see
one hot encoder we're flattening that
out and we have true false for zero true
false for one true false for two so our
output if you remember from our output
from the slide we did earlier uh in this
case I grabbed the one for bike price
doesn't really matter which one we use
this has one output so we have a bike
price on this we're going to have
instead of one output we're going to
have 10 outputs representing each of the
digits in there and this code really
isn't going to show us anything it's
good to see what we're actually looking
at so um let's go ahead and do a figure
a x equals go into our plot Library
subplots 10 comma 10 and that is if you
remember we talked about tensor tensor
being data coming in this is a 10x10
Grid or 100 pixels on there and if we're
going to display it uh let's go do k0
for I in range 10 just a simple Loop
through on the data let's do what is it
for J in range 10 so I actually
misquoted that 10 uh 10 x 10 is not the
actual ual size of the pixels uh the
actual pixels are going to be um when we
look at the shapes we'll get into that
in just a second here we'll take a quick
look at shape on there uh turns out
they're uh what are they are I believe
28 by 28 uh so let's take a look at that
and we're just going to plot these what
are we looking at what are we working
with as a data scientist you should
always be looking back at your data and
seeing what it looks like and get that
human perspective because you just never
know you know the the computer might put
something out that looks makes no sense
and and uh at that point you want to go
back and reevaluate what you did uh so
we're going to go ahead and plot we're
going to plot 10 digit you know 10 of
the digits by 10 of the digits and
here's our ax we'll create the JJ on our
subplots and we're going to do an image
show we're going to look at the training
image for images of K and then we want
to reshape this we're going to reshape
this and we're going to reshape this 28
by 28 that's how I knew I had it wrong
it's CU I look down my notes I was like
oh no that says 28 it's not 10 x 10 and
I should know that already cuz I've done
enough messing with this data set that I
should have remembered uh but it's 28 by
28 and the aspect we're going to do is
Auto and this is all if you look at this
here's our variable nist the NY is
coming from data set uh so this is all
part of the TF tensor flow learning or
examples tutorial in there and then
we'll go ahead and do uh K plus equals 1
so we just keep paging through our
different um images and let's see what
that looks like let's go ahead and do a
plot show uh and we'll go ahead and run
this so we can take a look and see what
we have here and so we have a nice plot
here and you you can just see that we
have uh some random numbers showing up
in each one of these little subplots if
you're wanting a copy of this code put a
note down in the YouTube video and let
us know or come visit us at www.s
simplylearn outcom and we'll send you
out a copy of what we're working on you
get a copy of that for your own setup uh
so now we've taken a look we can just
see we have here's our pictures that are
coming on WE plotted them so we have an
idea of what we're looking at let's go
ahead and uh print let's look at the
shape of the features uh so when we have
this we have our nist train images and
we'll do the shape on there let's take a
look and just see what we're looking at
uh as far as uh our count and everything
and so you can see here we have 55,000
that's basically how many images we have
and this by 784 and in this data set
there's also our labels so let's take a
look at that we have our nits train
labels shape let's take a look and see
what that looks like uh and there we
have 10 because there's 10 digits so we
brought in that's our output we're
looking at and so we have there we go
55,000 they match they should match
because you should have equal numbers in
both of those you know here's our data
end and here's our answer if you
remember this is uh a bunch of zeros and
with one each each one will be 00001
would be what letter four or something
like that so let's take a look at what
our one hot encoding did for the first
observation and this is when we're
exploring data you really want to dig in
there and just see what the heck am I
looking at so we're going to look at the
labels and this would be the first label
that comes up and we'll go ahead and run
this and we look at that you can see
this is what I'm talking about 0 0 or 1
is 0o two is 0 three is 0 four is0 five
is z 6 is z 7 equals 1 so our very first
label is a seven but our very first
label comes up that it's a seven and so
we don't have like 0o through nine we
have a bunch of zeros and just the one
to mark it as a seven on here so now we'
kind of looked a quick look at the data
and in here you might ask some questions
like what is 784 24 * 24 remember that's
the size of our grid on there or our
tensor coming in so 784 is a setup on
there and we've gone through all this
viewing the data we'll go ahead and
start looking at our tensor flow so
let's take our X variable this is going
to be our training set we'll do a
placeholder and then we're going to have
these come in as float now if I remember
correctly they're actually you know zero
or one for the values because they're
either but we have them coming in as a
float value and we have a little bit of
a shape coming in here and there's our
784 uh so let it know that this is
what's what our input is for our tensor
flow and this is our training set so
we'll just put a label on there to help
us uh track that train set and then W
and with W we'll go ahead and do TF
variables and we'll do this as uh zeros
variables T have zeros and we'll set
this as as 784 by 10 10 being the output
784 being our number of variables in and
this is our weights remember we have a
bias in there too and I'll go back over
this in just a second as we see how that
fits together in our tensor flow and
we'll do this one um with our variables
again we have 10 so we're going to do
the bias we're do it the same kind of
format and setup on here and so we'll do
that as as TF Zer of 10 so we just
create an array of 10 there and this is
our bias so with these three lines um
and there's actually they're coming out
with the eager execution which would
bypass some of what we're doing but this
is important to understand is the first
thing you have to do with tensor flow is
we have to allocate a space for the
variables and our TF placeholder and our
TF variable with our weights and our
biases this actually hasn't done
anything yet so all it is is
placeholders that's why it's okay to use
zeros um you could have just as easily
used ones or anything else and it
wouldn't matter the next stage is to go
ahead and set up some of the functions
going on but before we do that just note
that this hasn't done anything even if I
execute it all it's done is created PL
placeholders until we do the final
initialization and so we need to go
ahead and set up we'll do y tf. nn.
softmax and the code for this is tf. MM
xw +b and this is our uh sum let's just
put a note here so we can keep track of
what's going on we're finding weighted
sum of inputs plus the bias uh so
there's our plus b the bias and then we
need to go ahead keep um let's do ycore
and again another placeholder and this
this one will set um it's actually will
put in as TF placeholder on here TF
placeholder float none1 there's our one
hot incoder going on there so our 10
values coming out and we'll do a cross
entropy on here and this is going to be
minus TF reduce sum and we'll do y
here's our y underscore which is
remember we have your y output and your
actual output uh so this will be our
Yore times the TF log of Y and then
finally um before we do the actual
initialization of all our variables
we'll set up our train step this equals
our gradient descent Optimizer very
important remember we looked at that
chart on our um uh slides and so we've
set up all these formulas and here's our
gradient descent Optimizer and as it
keeps looking it keeps looking for that
zero value that's what we're doing with
that particular formula so let's take a
look and see what we're doing here we
just put together all of our pieces for
tensor flow and you know the devil's in
the um details we have here our training
set coming in we have to put a
placeholder on there we have our
variables with their weights we have our
biases coming out and then we put in our
uh the weighted sum so here's uh summize
our summation here then we have our y
variable output so there's our Y how it
works and then of course the actual
output on there and then we have our
cross entropy coming in and that's our
minus tf. reduce sum the y * the TF log
of Y and then in the training step
gradient descent Optimizer and we're
using a 0.01 in this and we're going to
minimize cross entropy so we're going to
let it do all the work so once we've set
up all of these different layers we've
allocated for them we need to go ahead
and initialize them so we're going to do
an init TF initialize and it's going to
be all variables uh one of the cool
things is they're in the process of
doing away with this so all these steps
would be bundled into one instead of
having to had placeholders you
initialize them in the same process
going on and and then finally everything
in tensorflow is based on your session
now this is changing that there's other
options to be able to run this but we
want to go ahead and do uh session
there's our TF which is's a TF session
and then we want to go ahead and do
session run and what are we going to run
well we did initialization of all our
variables uh so this is what we're
running and this is where actually once
we do this we actually create our
tensorflow object so this whole piece of
code right here is our tensor flow
object we have our input coming in with
our weighted variables coming in our
soft Max for our metal going out how
does it add it together for our y value
uh then we have the actual uh float
value coming out checking on our all the
way down so you can see all the
different stages going through that
we're setting up um and this is one of
the reasons that a lot of people like
tensor flow is because you can designate
all these different pieces one step at a
time this is also one of the reasons
people don't like tensor flow is because
you have to designate all the different
layers is coming down and there's a lot
of steps being made right now to
minimize this to make it either easier
to automate it or to allow you to do
more complicated things and all those
steps are still at play so it's worth
looking into the more advanced version
of what's going on with carass on top of
tensorflow it's also important to
understand what's going on in these
individual levels if you're going to
play with them it's important to
understand hey what's going on with the
uh finding the weighted sum of the
inputs plus the bias because there's
other ways to do that there's all kinds
kind of other tools in there now but
this is the basic setup that you want to
do on a tensor flow coming in and we
want to go ahead and just run and a knit
our tensor flow so let's go ahead and do
that let's run this we do get a warning
here because uh there's a move to use
Global variables this is one of the
changes they're making but it as far as
this example is not going to make a
difference because we're doing once we
initialize it this is initializing our
variables and again these are only
placeholders up here until we initialize
them and I would highly suggest put a
note down there or or go over to Simply
learn.com and let know and have them
email you a copy of the code so you can
actually play with this code right here
because this is the body of what's going
on in tensorflow this is the build in
neural networks and then once we've done
that now comes kind of the fun part is
we need to go ahead and train it uh so
we've created our tensor flow we've
created our uh Network and now we need
to go ahead and train it uh so let's put
together that training code and let's
just do uh for I in range U 1,000 0 to
1,000 so we're just going to look at uh
the first 1,000 in our training and the
way we pull that data from our mint's
train next batch of 100 uh so you look
at this we're going to be doing groups
of 100 and then there's going to go
through a thousand of them this is very
important that tens or flow builds this
in this is one of the downsides of doing
sklearn or one of the older packages is
they don't let you batch groups in uh
they wanted to have it all up front and
then you have to build your own batch
programs right now uh this lets us go
ahead and do that you can see here we
have batch of s batch y of s and so
there's our X and our y you can look at
this as our training of X and our train
of Y or the data in and the answer in uh
and then we simply do our session run uh
so here's our session that we've created
we're going to run it and we want to do
the train step remember we initialized
our train step up here in our TF and so
there's our train step feed it's a
dictionary dictionary coming in which
we're going to create right here uh is X
is our batch X of our sample comma and
our y underscore is going to be our
batch of our y sample uh and so this
goes through and we've now hit the Run
button and we've trained our session
we've trained this setup on here and
once we've trained it then we need to go
ahead and find out how good our accuracy
was and actually start running some
predictions through there uh so we'll go
ahead and create a a correct prediction
and this is where our tf. equal we'll
use our argmax y of one and TF argmax of
Y of underscore of one to help us get
the correct predictions on there and
then we want to use that to feed into an
accuracy and so our accuracy is going to
be TF reduce uh mean and we'll take that
and we'll do um a cast and this is the
correct prediction that we're sending in
there and it is a uh float value keep it
simple and let's go ahead and print this
out so we can see where we're looking at
uh so what are we printing out uh we
need to do a session run this session
runs going to be on the accuracy where
did accuracy comes from this is our
we're casting our t PF on there with the
correct predictions on that so here's
our accuracy feed in so it needs a
dictionary for the data coming in we're
going to create our dictionary and X
just going to be our nist test images
and Y underscore there is going to be
our nest. test labels let me just double
check and make sure I have that typed in
there correctly there we go and let's go
ahead and run that and see what comes up
and we end up with a
9165 for our accuracy which means our
trained neural network does a pretty
good job letting us know what these
different symbols are and guessing that
a seven and a three and a four uh
something that as humans we kind of take
for granted I even have trouble reading
this so I don't know if I would be able
like that first one I would sit there
for a long time figuring out that's a
seven versus a two that could have
easily been a two to me seeing see me do
a pretty good job analyzing this data
and this is used to analyze something
very complicated on these images very
different than uh just a straight value
of cost of sales and here's our return
and our marketing uh we can now create
this nice neural network that does all
kinds of cool things now let's move on
to the differences between tensorflow
kasas and py the first difference that
we'll be looking at is called level of
API there are two main types of apis a
lowlevel API and a high level API API
stands for application programming
interface a lowlevel application
programming interface is generally more
detailed and allows you to have more
detailed control to manipulate functions
within them on how to use and Implement
them while a high level API is more
generic and simple and provides more
functionality with one command
statements than a lower level API
highlevel interfaces are comparatively
easier to learn and to implement the
models using them they allow you to
write code in a shorter amount of time
and to be less involved with the details
in this case tensor flow is a high and
lowlevel API pure tensor flow is a
lowlevel API while tens of flow wrapped
in Keras is a high level
API kasas in itself is a high level API
which uses multiple low-level apis as a
back end and simplifies the operation of
these low-level apis py torch is a
low-level API the next criteria that
we'll be looking at is speed tensor flow
is very fast and is used for high
performances caras is slower as it works
on top of tensorflow not only does it
have to wait for tensorflow to finish
implementation it then starts its own
implementation meanwhile py torch works
at the same speed as tensorflow as both
of them are both low-level apis now
kasas is a rapper class for tensor flow
and has added abstraction
functionalities on top of tens oflow
which make it slower than tens oflow and
py torch in computation speed both t
tensor flow and py torch are almost
equal and in development speed caras is
faster as it has built-in
functionalities which can significantly
reduce your development time the next
difference is on the
architecture tens of flow is not very
easy to use and even though it provides
caras as a framework that makes it work
easier tensorflow still has a very
complex architecture which is hard to
use meanwhile kasas has a simpler
architecture and is easier to use it
provides a high level of abstraction
which makes implementation of programs
in Keras significantly easier pych on
the other hand also has a complex
architecture and the readability is less
when compared to kasas tensorflow uses
computational graphs which makes it very
complex and hard to interpret but it has
amazing computational ability across
platforms pyo is a little hard for
beginners but is really good for
computer vision and deep learning
purposes data sets and debugging tensor
flow works with large data sets due to
its high execution speed and debugging
is really hard intensive flow due to its
complex nature meanwhile kasas only
works with very small data sets as its
speed of execution is low programs do
not require frequent debugging in kasas
as they are relatively simpler and py
toch can manage high level tasks in
higher Dimension data sets and is easier
to debug than both kiras and tensor flow
next we'll be looking at ease of
development as we said before tensor
flow works with many hard Concepts such
as computational graphs and tensors
which means that writing code in tensor
flow is very hard it is generally used
by people when they are doing research
work and really need very specific
functionalities kasas on the other hand
provides a high level of abstraction
which makes it very easy to use it is
best for people who are just starting
out with python and machine learning py
toch is easier than tens of flow but is
still comparatively hard than caras it
is not very easy to learn for beginners
but is significantly more powerful than
just plain caras ease of deployment
tensor flow is very easy to deploy as it
uses tensor flow serving tensorflow
serving is a flexible high performance
serving system for machine learning
models designed for production and ments
tensorflow serving makes it easy to
deploy new algorithms and experiments
while keeping the same server
architecture and apis tensorflow serving
provides outof thebox integration with
tensorflow models but can be easily
extended to serve other types of models
and data in kasas model deployment can
be done with either tensorflow serving
or flask which makes it relatively easy
but not as easy as you as it would be
with tensor flow and py to pyo uses pyo
mobile which makes deployment easy but
again for tensor flow deployment is way
easier as tensorflow serving can update
your machine learning backend on the fly
without the user even realizing there's
a growing need to execute ml models on
edge devices to reduce latency preserve
privacy and enable new interactive use
cases in the past Engineers used to
train models separately they would then
go through a multi-step error prone and
often complex process to train the
models for execution on a mobile device
the mobile runtime was often
significantly different from the
operations available during training
leading to inconsistent developer and
eventually user experience all of these
frictions have been removed by pyo
Mobile by allowing a seamless process to
go from training to deployment by
staying entirely within the py toch
ecosystem it provides an end to end
workflow that simplifies the research to
production environment for mobile
devices in addition it paves the way for
privacy reserving features via Federated
learning
techniques at the end of the day the
question that really matters is which
framework should you use kasas tensor
flow or py
to now tensor flow has implemented
various levels of abstraction to make
implementation of deep learning and
neural networks easy this has also made
debugging easier kasas is simple and
easy but not as fast as tensil flow it
is more user friendly than any other
deep learning API however and is easier
to learn for beginners pyo on the other
hand is the preferred deep learning API
for teachers but it is not as widely
used in production as tensor flow is it
is faster but it has lower GPU
utilization at the end of the day the
framework that we would suggest that you
use is 10
flow why while py toch may have been the
preferred deep learning library for
researchers tsor flow is much more
widely used in day-to-day production
pyo's ease of use combined with the
default eager execution mode for easier
debugging predestines it to be used for
fast hacky Solutions and smaller scale
models but tensor flows extensions for
deployment on both servers and mobile
devices combined with the lack of python
over overhead makes it the preferred
option for companies that work with deep
learning models in addition the
tensorflow board visualization features
offers a nice way of showing the inner
workings of your model to say your
customers meanwhile between tens of flow
and caras the main difference isn't in
performance tensorflow is a bit faster
due to less overhead but also the level
of control you would like kasas is much
easier to start with than plain tensor
flow but if you want to do something
with kasas that doesn't come out of the
box it'll be harder to implement that
tens of flow on the other hand allows
you to create any arbitrary
computational graph providing much more
flexibility so if you're doing more
research type of work tensor flow is the
sure route to go due to the flexibility
that it provides so many things out
there that the 1.0 really needed so when
we start talking about tensor flow 1.0
versus 2.0 um I guess you would need to
know this for um a legacy programming
job if you're pulling apart somebody
else's code the first thing is that
tensorflow 2.0 supports eager execution
by default it allows you to build your
models and run them instantly and you
can see here from tensor flow one to
tensor flow 2 uh we have um almost
double the code to do the same thing so
if I want to do um with tf. session or
tensorflow session um as a session the
session run you have your variables your
session run you have your tables
initializer and then you do your model
fit um X train y train and then your
validation data your x value yv value
and your epics and your batch size all
that goes into the fit and you can see
here where that was all just compressed
to make it run easier you can just
create a model and do a Fed on it uh and
you only have like that last set of code
on there so it's automatic that's what
they mean by the eager so if you see the
first part and you're like what the heck
is all this session thing going on
that's tensorflow 1.0 and then when you
get into 2.0 it's just nice and clean if
you remember from the beginning I said
coros uh on our list up there and uh
cross is the high level API in tensor
flow 2.0 cross is the official highlevel
API of tensorflow 2.0 it has
incorporated cross as tf. cross cross
provides a number of model building apis
such as sequential functional and
subclassing so you can choose the right
level of abstraction for your project
and uh we'll hopefully touch base a
little bit more on this sequential being
the most common uh form that is your
your layers are going from one side to
the other so everything's going in a
sequential order
functional is where you can split the
layers so you might have your input
coming on one side it splits into two
completely Mo different models and then
they come back together U and one of
them might be doing classification the
other one might be doing just linear
regression kind of stuff or a neural
basic uh reverse propagation neural
network and then those all come together
into another layer which is your uh
neural network reverse propagation setup
subclassing is the most complicated as
you're building your own models and you
can subclass your own models into carass
so very powerful tools here this is all
the stuff that's been coming out
currently in the tensorflow coros setup
a third big change we're going to look
at is it in tensorflow
1.0 uh in order to use TF layers as
variables uh you would have to write TF
variable block so you'd have to
predefine that in tensor flow 2 you just
add your layers in under the sequential
and it automatically defines them as
long as they're flat layers of course
this changes a little bit as a more
complicated um tensor you have coming in
but all of it's very easy to do and
that's what 2.0 does a really good job
of and here we have um a little bit more
on the scope of this and you can see how
tensorflow one asks you to do um these
different layers and values if you at
the scope and the default name you start
looking at all the different code in
there to create the variable scope
that's not even necessary in tensor 2.0
so you'd have to do one before you do do
what you see the code in 2.0 in 2.0 you
just create your model it's a sequential
model and then you can add all your
layers in you don't have to pre-create
the um uh variable scope so if you ever
see the variable scope you know that
came from an older version and then we
have the last two which is our API
cleanup and and the autograph uh in the
API cleanup tensor flow one you could
build models using TF Gans TF app TF
contrib TF Flags Etc in tensor flow 2 uh
a lot of apis have been removed and this
is just they just cleaned them up
because people weren't using them and
they've simplified them and that's your
TF app your TF flags and your TF logging
are all gone uh so there's those are
three Legacy features that are not in
2.0 and then we have our TF function an
autograph feature in the old version uh
tensorflow 10 the python functions were
limited and could not be compiled or
exported reimported so you were
continually having to redo your code and
you couldn't very easily just um uh put
a pointer to it and say here let's reuse
this in tensorflow 2 you can write a
python function using the TF function to
mark it for the jit compilation for the
python jit so that tensorflow runs it as
a single graph autograph graph feature
of TF function helps to write graph code
using natural python
syntax uh now we just threw in a new
word in you graph uh graph is not a
picture of a person uh you'll hear graph
x and some other things graph is what
are all those lines that are connecting
different objects so if you remember
from before where we had uh the
different layers going through
sequentially each one of those wh lined
arrows would be a graph x that's where
that computation is taken care of and
that's what they're talking about and so
if you had your own special code or
python way that you're sending that
information forward you can now put your
own function in there instead of using
whatever function they're using in
neural networks this would be your
activation function although it could be
almost anything out there depending on
what you're doing next let's go for
hierarchy and architecture and then
we'll cover three basic Tools in tensor
flow before we roll up our sleeves and
dive into the example so let's just take
a quick look at tensor flow tool kits in
their hierarchy at the high level we
have our objectoriented API so this is
what you're working with you have your
TF carass you have your estimators this
sits on top of your TF layers TF losses
TF metrics so you have your reusable
libraries for model building this is
really where tins or flow shines is
between the carass uh running your
estimators and then being able to swap
in different layers you can your losses
your metrics all of that is is so built
into tensorflow makes it really easy to
use and then you can get down to your
lowlevel TF API um you have extensive
control over this you can put your own
formulas in there your own procedures or
models in there uh you could have it
split we talked about that earlier so
with the 2.0 you can now have it split
One Direction where you do a linear
regression model and then go to the
other where it does a uh neural network
and maybe each neural network has a
different activation set on it and then
it comes together into another layer
which is another neural network so you
can build these really complicated
models and at the low level you can put
in your own apis you can move that stuff
around and most recently we have the TF
code can run on multiple platforms and
so you have your CPU which is uh
basically like on the computer I'm
running on I have uh eight cores and 16
dedicated threads I here they now have
one out there that has over a 100 cores
uh so you have your CPU running and then
you have your GP which is your graphics
card and most recently they also include
the TPU setup which is specifically for
tensorflow models uh neural network kind
of set up so now you can export the TF
code and it can run on all kinds of
different platforms for the most um
diverse setup out there and moving on
from the hierarchy to the architecture
in the tensorflow 2.0 architecture uh we
have uh you can see on the left this is
usually where you start out with and 80%
of your time in data science is spent
pre-processing data making sure it's
loaded correctly and everything looks
right uh so the first level in tensor
flow is going to be your read and
pre-processed data your TF data feature
columns this is going to feed into your
TF Cross or your pre-made estimators and
kind of you have your tensorflow Hub
that sits on top of there so you can see
what's going on uh once you have all
that setup you have your distribution
strategy where are you going to run it
you going to be running it on just your
regular CPU are you going to be running
it uh with the GPU add it in um like I
have a pretty highend graphics card so
it actually grabs that GPU processor and
uses it or do you have a specialized TPU
setup in there that you paid extra money
for uh it could be if you're and later
on when you're Distributing the package
you might need to run this on some
really high processors because you're
processing at a server level for uh
let's say n you might be processing this
at a um a distribute you're Distributing
it not the distribution strategy but
you're Distributing it into a server
where that server might be analyzing
thousands and thousands of purchases
done every minute um and so you need
that higher speed to give them a um to
give them a recommendation or a
suggestion so they can buy more stuff
off your website or maybe you're looking
for uh data fraud analysis working with
the banks you want to be able to run
this at a high speed so that when you
have hundreds of people sending their
transactions in says hey this doesn't
look right someone's scamming this
person and probably has their credit
card so when we're talking about all
those fun things we're talking about
saved model this is we were talking
about that earlier where it used to be
when you did one of these models it
wouldn't truncate the float numbers the
same and so a model going from one you
build the model on your com machine in
the office and then you need to
distribute it and so we have our tensor
flow serving Cloud on premium that's
what I was talking about if you're like
a banking or something like that
now they have tensorflow light so you
can actually run a tensorflow on an
Android or an iOS or Raspberry Pi a
little breakout board there in fact they
just came out with a new one that has a
built-in this just a little mini TPU
with the camera on it so it can
pre-process a video so you can load your
tensorflow model onto that um talking
about an affordable way to beta test uh
a new product uh you have the tensorflow
JS which is for browser and node server
so you can get that out on the browser
for some simple computations that don't
require a lot of heavy lifting but you
want to distribute to a lot of end
points and now they also have other
language binding so you can now create
your uh tensorflow backend save it and
have it accessed from C Java go C rust r
or from whatever package you're working
on so we kind of have an overview of the
architecture and what's going on behind
the scenes and in this case what's going
on as far as Distributing it let's go
ahead and take a look at uh three
specific pieces of tensor flow and those
are going to be constants variables and
sessions uh so very basic things you
need to know and understand when you're
working with the tensor flow uh setup so
constants in tensor flow in tensor flow
constants are created using the function
constant uh in other words they're going
to stay static the whole time whatever
you're working with the Syntax for
constant uh value dtype 9 shape equals
none name constant verify shape equals
false that's kind of the syntax you're
looking at and we'll explore this with
our hands on a little more in depth uh
and you can see here we do zal tf.
constant 5.2 name equals x uh dtype is a
float that means that we're never going
to change that 5.2 it's going to be a
constant value and then we have our
variables and tensor flow uh variables
and tensor flow are in memory buffers
that store tensors and so we can declare
a 2x3 tensor populated by ones you could
also do constants this way by the way so
you can create a a um an array of ones
for your constants I'm not sure why you
do that but you know you might need that
for some reason um in here we have V
equals tf.
variables and then in tensorflow you
have tf. On's and you have the shape
which is 23 which is going to create a
nice uh 2x3 um array that's filled with
ones and then of course you can go in
there and their variables so you can
change them it's a tensor so you have
full control over that and then you of
course have uh sessions in tensorflow a
session in tensor flow is used to run a
computational graph to evaluate the
nodes and remember when we're talking
about graph or graph x we're talking
about all that information then goes
through all those arrows and whatever
computations they have that take it to
the next node and you can see down here
uh where we have import tensor flow as
TF if we do x equals a tf. constant of
10 we do yal a TF constant of 2.0 of
20.0 and then you can do zal tf.
variable and it's a tf. addx comma y uh
and then once you have that setup in
there you go ahead andit your TF Global
variables initializer with TF session as
session you can do a session run nit and
then you print the session run
y uh and so when you run this you're
going to end up with of course the uh 10
+ 20 is 30 and we'll be looking at this
a lot more closely is we actually roll
up our sleeves and put some code
together so let's go ahead and take a
look at that and for my coding today I'm
going to go ahead and go through
anaconda and then I'll use specifically
the Jupiter Notebook on there and of
course this code is going to work uh
whatever platform you choose whether
you're in a notebook um the Jupiter lab
which is just a Jupiter notebook but
with tabs for larger projects we're
going to stick with Jupiter notebook pie
charm uh whatever it is you're going to
use in here uh you know you have your
spider and your QT console for different
programming environments the thing to
note um is kind of hard to see but I
have my main Pi
36 right now when I was writing this
tensor flow Works in Python version 36
if you have python version 37 or 38
you're probably going to get some errors
in there uh might be that they've
already updated and I don't know it and
I have an older version but you want to
make sure you're in Python version 36
and your environment and of course in
Anaconda I can easily set that
environment up make sure you go ahead
and and um pip in your tensor flow or if
you're in Anaconda you can do AA install
tensor flow to make sure it's in your
package so let's just go ahead and dive
in and bring that up this will open up a
nice browser window I just love the fact
I can zoom in and zoom out depending on
what I'm working on making it really
easy to adjust um a demo for the right
size go under new and let's go ahead and
create a new Python and once we're in
our new python window this is going to
leave it Untitled uh let's go ahead and
import import tensor flow as TF uh at
this point we'll go ahe and just run it
real quick no errors yay no errors I I
do that whenever I do my imports because
I I unbearably will have opened up a new
environment and forgotten to install
tensor flow into that environment uh or
something along those lines so it's
always good to double check
uh and if we're going to double check
that we also it's also good to know uh
what version we're working with and we
can do that simply by um using the
version command in
tensorflow which uh you should know is
is probably intuitively the TF _ uncore
verore
uncore and you know it always confuses
me because sometimes you do tf. version
for one thing you do TF doore verore for
another thing uh this is a double
underscore in tensor flow for pulling
your version out and it's good to know
what you're working with we're going to
be working in tensorflow version
2.1.0 and I did tell you that the um we
were going to dig a little deeper into
our constants and you can do an array of
constants and we'll just create this
nice array um AAL tf. constant and we're
just going to put the array right in
there 43 61 uh we can run this and now
that is what a is equal to and if we
want to just double check that uh
remember we're in Jupiter notebook where
we can just put the letter a and it
knows that that's going to be print um
otherwise you you surround it in print
and you can see it's a TF tensor it has
the shape the type and the and the array
on here it's a 2X two array and just
like we can create a constant we can go
and create a variable and this is also
going to be a 2X two array and if we go
ahead and print the V out we'll run that
uh and sure enough there's our TF VAR
variable in
here uh then we can also let's just go
back up here and add this in here um I
could create another tensor and we'll
make it a constant this
time and we'll go and put that in over
here uh we'll have BTF constant and if
we go and print out uh V and B let me go
and run that and this is an interesting
thing that always that happens in here
uh you'll see right here when I print
them both out what happens it only
prints the last one unless you use print
commands uh so important to remember
that in Jupiter notebooks but we can
easily fix that by go ahead and print
and suround V with brackets and now we
can see with the two different variables
we have uh we have the 3152 which is a
variable and this is just a flat uh
constant so it comes up as a TF tensor
shape two kind of two and that's
interesting to note that this label is a
tf. tensor and this is a TF variable so
that's how it's looking in the back end
when you're talking about about the
difference between a variable and a
constant the other thing I want you to
notice is that in variable we capitalize
the V and with the constant we have a
lowercase C little things like that can
lose you when you're programming and
you're trying to find out hey why
doesn't this work uh so those are a
couple little things to note in here and
just like any other array in math uh we
can do like a concatenate or concatenate
the different values here uh and you can
see we can take um a B concatenated you
just do a tf. concat values and there's
our AB axis on one hopefully you're
familiar with axes and how that works
when you're dealing with matrixes and if
we go ahead and print this out uh you'll
see right here we end up with a tensor
so let's put it in as a constant not as
a variable and you have your array 4378
and 6145 it's concatenated the two
together and again I want to highlight a
couple things on this our axis equals
one this means we're doing the columns
um so if you had a longer array like
right now we have an array that is like
you know has a shape one Whatever It Is
2 comma 2 um axis zero is going to be
your first one and axis one is going to
be your second one and it translates as
columns and rows if we had a shape let
me just put the word shape here um so
you know what I'm talking about and it's
very clear and this is I'll tell you
what I spent a lot of time looking at
these shapes and trying to figure out
which direction I'm going in and whether
to flip it or whatever um so you can get
lost in which way your Matrix is going
and which is column which is rows are
you dealing with the third Axis or the
second axis um axis one you know 0 1 2
that's going to be our columns uh and if
you can do columns then we also can do
rows and that is simply just changing
the concatenate uh we'll just grab this
one here and copy it we'll do the whole
thing over um contrl
copy crl V and changes from axis one to
axis zero and if we run that uh you'll
see that now we can catenate by row as
opposed to column and you have 4 3 6 1 7
8 4 7 so it just brings it right down
turns it into rows versus columns you
can see the difference there your output
this really you want to look at the
output sometimes just to make sure your
eyes are looking at it correctly and
it's in the format um I find visually
looking at it is almost more important
than understanding what's going on uh
because conceptually your mind just just
too many dimensions sometimes the second
thing I want you to notice is it says a
numpy array uh so tensor flow is
utilizing numpy as part of their format
as far as Python's concerned and so you
can treat you can treat this output like
a numpy array cuz it is just that it's
going to be a numpy array another thing
that comes up uh more more than you
would think is filling U one of these
with zeros or ones and so you can see
here we just create a tensor tf.
zeros and we give it a shape we tell it
what kind of data type it is in this
case we're doing an integer and then if
we um print out our tensor again we're
in Jupiter so I can just type out tensor
and I run this you can see I have a nice
array of um with shape 3 comma 4 of
zeros one of the things I want to
highlight here is integer 32 if I go to
the um tensorflow data types I want you
to notice how we have float 16 float 32
float 64 uh complex if we scroll down
you'll see the integer down here of 32
the reason for this is that we want to
control how many bits are used in the
Precision this is for exporting it to
another platform uh so what would happen
is I might run it on this computer where
python goes does a float to indefinite
however long it wants wants to um and
then we can take it but we want to
actually say hey we don't want that high
Precision we want to be able to run this
on any computer and so we need to
control whether it's a TF float 16 in
this case we did an integer
32 we could also do this as a float so
if I run this as a float 32 uh that
means this has a 32bit Precision you'll
see 0 point whatever and then to go with
uh
zeros we have ones if we're going from
the opposite side and so we can easily
just create a tensor flow with
ones you might ask yourself why would I
want zeros and ones and your first
thought might be to initiate a new
tensor usually we initiate a lot of this
stuff with random numbers because it
does a better job solving it if you
start with a uniform uh set of ones or
zeros you're dealing with a lot of bias
so be very careful about starting a
neural network uh for one of your rows
or something like that with ones and
zeros on the other hand uh I use use
this for masking you can do a lot of
work with masking you can also have uh
it might be that one t a row is masked
um you know zero is is false one is true
or whatever you want to do it um and so
in that case you do want to use the
zeros and ones and there are cases where
you do want to initialize it with all
zeros or all ones and then swap in
different numbers as the as the um
tensor learns so it's another form of
control but in general you see zeros and
ones you usually are talking about a
mask over another array and just like in
uh numpy you can also uh do reshapes so
if we take our remember this is shaped 3
comma 4 maybe we want to swap that to 4
comma 3 and if we print this out you
will see let me just go and do that
contrl V let me run that and you'll see
that the the order of these is now
switched instead of uh four across now
we have three across and four
down and just for fun let's go back up
here where we did the ones and I'm going
to change the ones to um tf. random
uniform uh and we'll go and just take
off well we'll go and leave that we'll
go and run this and you'll see now we
have uh
0441 and this way you can actually see
how the reshape looks a lot different uh
0411 5.71 and then instead of having
this one it rolls down here to the
0.14 and this is what I was talking
about sometimes you fill a lot of times
you fill these with random numbers and
so this is the random. uniform is one of
the ways to do that now I just talked a
little bit about this float 32 and all
these data types uh one of the things
that comes up of course is recasting
your
data um so if we have a dtype float 32
we might want to convert these two
integers because of the project we're
working on um I know one of the projects
I've worked on ended up wanting to do a
lot of roundoff so that it would take a
dollar amount or a float value and then
have to run it off to a dollar amount so
we only wanted two decimal points um and
in which case you have a lot of
different options you can multiply by
100 and then round it off or whatever
you want to do there's a lot of or then
convert it to an integer with one way to
round it off uh kind
of cheap and dirty
trick uh so we can take this and we can
take the same tensor and we'll go ahead
and create a um as an integer and so
we're going to take this tensor we're
going to tf. cast it and if we
print tensor uh and then we're going to
go ahead and
print our tensor let me just do a quick
copy and paste and when I'm actually
programming I usually type out a lot of
my stuff just to double check it uh in
doing a demo copy and paste works fine
but sometimes be aware that uh copy and
paste can copy the wrong code over
personal choice depends on what what I'm
working on and you can see here we took
um a float 32 4.6 4.2 and so on and it
just converts it right down to a integer
value uh so our integer 32 setup and uh
remember we talked about um a little bit
about
reshape um as far as flipping it and I
just did uh 4 comma 3 on the reshape up
here and we talked about axis zero axis
one uh one of the things that is
important to be able to do is to take
one of these variables we'll just take
this last one tensor as
integer and I want to go ahead and
transpose it and so I can do um we'll do
a equals tf. trans
pose and we'll do our tensor integer in
there and then if I print the A out and
we run this you'll see it's the same
array but we've flipped it so that our
columns and rows are flipped this this
is the same as reshaping uh so when you
transpose you're just doing a reshape
what's nice about this is that if you
look at the numbers The Columns when
when we went up here and we did the
reshape they kind of roll down to the
next row so you're not maintaining the
structure of your Matrix so when we do a
reshape up here they're similar but
they're not quite the same and you can
actually go in here and there's settings
in the reshape that would allow you to
turn it into a
transform uh so when we come down here
it's all done for you and so there are
so many times you have to transpose your
digits that this is important to know
that you can just do that you can flip
your rows and columns rather quickly
here and just like numpy you can also do
multip your different math functions
we'll look at multiplication and so
we're going to take matrix
multiplication of tensors uh we'll go ah
and create a as a constant
5839 and we'll put in a vector v 4 comma
2 and we could have done this where they
matched where this was a 2X two array um
but instead we're going to do just a 2x1
array and the code for that is your tf.
matat mole uh so Matrix multiplier and
we have a * V and if we go ahead and run
this let's make sure we print out our av
on
there and if we go ahead and run this uh
you'll see that we end up with 36x 30
and if it's been a while since you've
seen The Matrix math uh this is 5 * 4 +
8 * 2 um 3 * 4 + 9 *
2 and that's where we get the 36 and 30
now I know we're covering a lot really
quickly as far as the basic
functionality uh so the Matrix or your
Matrix multiplier is a very commonly
used backend tool as far as Computing um
uh different models or linear regression
stuff like that one of the things is to
note is that just like in um numpy you
have all of your different math so we
have our TF math and if we go in here we
have um functions we have our cosiness
absolute angle all of that's in here so
all of these are available for you to
use in the tensor flow model and if we
go back to our example and let's go
ahead and pull um oh let's do some
multiplication that's always good we'll
stick with our um AV our um constant a
and our vector
v and we'll go ahead and do some bitwise
multiplication and we'll create an AV
which is a * V let let's go and print
that
out and you can see coming across here
uh we have the 42 and the
5839 and it produces uh 20 32
618 and that's pretty straightforward if
you look at it you have four time uh 5
is 20 four time 8 is uh 32 that's where
those numbers come
from uh we can also quickly create an
identity
Matrix which is basically um your main
values on the diagonal being ones and
zeros across the other side let's go
ahead and take a look and see what that
uh uh looks like we can do let's do this
uh so we're going to get the shape um
this is a simple way very similar to
your numpy you can do a do shape and
it's going to return a tuple in this
case our rows and columns and so we can
do a quick uh
print we'll do rows
oops and we'll do
columns
and if we run this uh you can see we
have three rows uh two
columns and then if we go ahead and
create an identity
Matrix the
oops the script for that hit a wrong
button there the script for that looks
like
this where we have the number of rows
equals rows the number of columns equals
columns and D type is a 32 and then if
we go ahead and just print out our
identity you can see we have a nice
identity column with our ones going
across here now clearly we're not going
to go through every math module um
available but we do want to start
looking at this as a prediction model
and seeing how it functions so we're
going to move on to a more of a um
Direct setup where we can actually see
the full tensor flow in use for that
let's go back and create a uh new
setup and we'll go in here new Python 3
module there we go bring this out so it
takes up the whole window CU I like to
do that hopefully you made it through
that first part and you have a basic
understanding of tensor flow as far as
being uh a series of numpy arrays you
got your math equations and different
things that go into them
we're going to start building a full um
setup as far as the numpy so you can see
how uh carass sits on top of it and the
different aspects of how it works the
first thing we want to do is we're going
to go and do a lot of imports uh date
times warning scipi scipi is your um uh
math so the backend scientific math uh
warnings because whenever we do a lot of
this you have older versions newer
versions
um and so sometimes when you get
warnings you want to go ahead and just
suppress them we'll talk about that if
it comes up on this particular setup and
of course date time pandas again is your
data frame think rows and columns we
import it as PD numpy is your uh numbers
array which of course tensor flow is
integrated heavily with caborn for our
graphics and the caborn as SNS is going
to be set on top of our map plot Library
which we import as npl
and then of course we're going to import
our matap plot Library pip plot as PLT
and right off the bat we're going to set
some graphic colors um patch Force Edge
color equals true the style we're going
to use the 538 style you can look this
all up there's when you get into map
plot Library into Seaborn there are so
many options in here it's just kind of
nice to make it look pretty when we
start the um when we start up that way
we don't have to think about it later on
uh and then we're going to take we have
our uh uh mlrc we're going to put a
patch Ed color dim Gray Line width again
this is all part of our Graphics here in
our setup uh we'll go ahead and do an
interactive shell uh node interactivity
equals last expression uh here we are PD
for pandas options display Max columns
so we don't want to display more than 50
um and then our map plot library is
going to be inline this is a Jupiter
notebook thing the map plot library in
line uh then warnings we're going to
filter a warning
and we're just going to ignore warnings
that way when they come up we don't have
to worry about them not really what you
want to do when you're working on a
major project you want to make sure you
know those warnings and then uh filter
them out and ignore them later on and if
we run this it's just going to be
loading all that into the background uh
so that's a little backend kind of stuff
then what we want to go ahead and do is
we want to go ahead and import our
specific packages U that we're going to
be working with which is under carass
now remember carass kind of sits on
tensor flow so when we're importing
carass and the sequential model we are
in effect importing um tensor flow
underneath of it uh we just brought in
the math probably should have put that
up above and then we have our cross
models we're going to import sequential
now if you remember from our uh slide
there was three different options let me
just flip back over there so we can have
a quick uh recall on that and so in
carass uh we have sequential functional
and subclassing so remember those three
different setups in here we talked about
earlier and if you remember from here we
have uh sequential where it's going one
tensor flow layer at a time you go kind
of look at think of it as going from
left to right or top to bottom or
whatever Direction it's going in but it
goes in One Direction all the time where
functional can have a very complicated
graph of directions you can have the
data split into two separate um tensors
and then it comes back together into
another
tensor um all those kinds of things and
then subclassing is really the really
complicated one where now you're adding
your own subclasses into the tensor to
do external computations right in the
middle of like a huge flow of data uh
but we're going to stick with sequential
it's not a big jump to go from
sequential to functional uh but we're
running a sequential tensor flow and
that's what this first import is here we
want to bring in our sequential and then
we have our layers and let's talk a
little bit about these layers this is
where cross and tensor flow really are
happening this is what makes them so
nice to work with is all these layers
are pre-built uh so from carass we have
layers import dents from carass uh
layers import
lstm when we talk about these layers uh
carass has so many built-in layers you
can do your own layers the dense layer
is your standard neural network U by Def
default it uses Ru for its
activation and then the lstm is a long
shortterm memory layer since we're going
to be looking probably at sequential
data uh we want to go ahead and do the
lstm and if we go into to um carass and
we look at their layers this is the
carass website you can see as we scroll
down for the coros layers that are built
in we can get down here and we can look
at let's see here we have our layer
activation our layers um activation
layer weight layer weight there a lot of
stuff in here we had the ru which is the
basic activation that was listed up here
for layer activations you can change
those and here we have our core layers
and our dense layers you have an input
layer a dense layer um and then we've
added more customized one with the
long-term short-term memory layer and of
course you can even do your own custom
layers in carass there's a whole
functionality in there if you're doing
your own thing what's really nice about
this is it's all built in uh even the
convolutional layers this is for
processing Graphics there's a lot of
cool things in here you can do um this
is why cross is so popular it's open
source and you have all these tools
right at your fingertips so from Cross
we're just going to import a couple
layers the dense layer um and the long
short-term memory layer and then of
course from uh sklearn our s kit we want
to go ahead and do our minmax scaler
standard scaler for pre-editing
data and then metrics just so we can
take a look at the errors and compute
those let me go ahead and run this and
that just loads it up we're not
expecting anything from the output and
our file coming in is going to be air
quality. CSV let's go ahead and take a
quick look at that this is in Open
Office it's just a standard you know you
do excel whatever you're using for your
spreadsheet and you can see here we have
uh a number of columns uh number of rows
it actually goes down to like 8,000
the first thing we want to notice is
that the first row is kind of just a
random number put in going down probably
not something we're going to work with
the second row um is bandang I'm
guessing that's a reference for the
profile if we scroll to the bottom which
I'm not going to do because it takes
forever to get back up they're all the
same uh the same thing with the status
the status is the same we have a date so
we have a sequential order here uh
here is the jam which I'm going to guess
is the time stamp on there so we have a
date and time we have our 03 coo NO2
reading s SO2 no CO2 vo um and then some
other numbers here pm1 PM 2.5 pm4
pm1 10 uh without actually looking
through the data um I mean some of this
I can guess is like temperature humidity
I'm not sure what the PMS are U but we
have a whole slew of data here uh so
we're looking at air quality as far as
an area and a region and what's going on
with our date time stamps on there and
so codewise we're going to read this
into a pandas data frame so our data
frame uh DF is a nice abbreviation
commonly used for data frames equals pd.
read CSV and then our the path to it
just happens to be on my D drive uh
separated by spaces and so if we go
ahead and run this we'll print out the
head of our data and again this looks
very similar to what we were just
looking at um being in Jupiter I can
take this and go the other way uh make
it real small so you can see all the
columns going across and we get a full
view of it um or we can bring it back up
in size that's pretty small on there
overshot um but you can see it's the
same data we were just looking at uh
we're looking at the number we're
looking at the profile which is the
Bandung the um date we have a timestamp
our 03 count Co and so forth on here uh
and this is just your basic pandas
printing out the top five rows we could
easily have done uh three
rows uh five rows 10 whatever you want
to put in there by default that's five
for pandas now I talk about this all the
time so I know I've already said it at
least once or twice during this video
most of our work is in pre- formatting
data what are we looking at how do we
bring it together uh so we want to go
ahead and start with our date time uh
it's come in in two columns we we have
our date here and we have our time and
we want to go ahead and combine that and
then we have uh this is just a simple
script in there that says combined date
time that's our formula we're
building our we're going to submit our
um Panda's data frame and the tab name
when we go ahead and do this uh that's
all of our information that we want to
go ahead and create and then goes for
ION range DF uh shape zero so we're
going to go through um the whole setup
and we're going to list tab a pin DF
location I and here is our date uh going
in there and then return the numpy array
list tab D types date time 64 that's all
we're doing we're just switching this to
a date time stamp and if we go ahead and
do DF date time equals combined date
time and then I always like to uh print
we'll do DF head just so we can see what
that looks like and so when we come out
of this uh we now have our setup on here
and of course just added it onto the far
right here's our date time you can see
the format's changed uh so there's our
we've added in the date time column and
we've brought the date over and we've
taken this format here and it's an
actual variable with a 0000 on here well
that doesn't look good so we need to
also include the time part of this and
we want to convert it into hourly data
uh so let's go ahead and do that uh to
do that uh to finish combining our date
time let's go ahead and create a uh a
little script here to combine the time
in there same thing we just did we're
just creating a numpy turning a numpy
array and C forcing this into a datetime
format and we can actually spend hours
just going through uh these conversions
how do you pull it from the Panda's data
frame how do you set it up um so I'm
kind of skipping through it a little
fast because I want to stay focused on
tensor flow and carass keep in mind this
is like 80% of your coding when you're
doing a lot of this stuff is going to be
reformatting these things resetting them
back up uh so that it looks right on
here and uh you know it just takes time
to to get through all that but that is
usually what the companies are paying
you for that's what the big bucks are
for and we want to go ahead and uh a
couple things going on here is we're
going to go ahead and do our date time
we're going to reorganize some of our
setup in here convert into hourly data
we just put a pause in there um now
remember we can select from DF our
different columns we're going to be
working with and you're going to see
that we actually dropped a couple of the
columns those ones I showed you earlier
they're just repetitive data uh so
there's nothing in there that exciting
and then we want to go ahead and we'll
create a uh second data frame here let
me just get rid of the DF head and df2
is we're going to group by date time and
we're looking at the mean value and then
we'll print that out so you can see what
we're talking about uh we have now
reorganized this so we put in date time
03 Co so now this is in the same order
um as it was before and you'll see the
date time now has our 0 0 uh same date
one 2 3 and so on so it's group the data
together so it's a lot more manageable
and in the format we want and in the
right sequential order and if we go back
to um there we go our air quality uh you
can see right here we're looking at um
these columns going across we really
don't need since we're going to create
our own date time column we can get rid
of those these are the different Columns
of information we want and that should
reflect right here in the columns we
picked coming across so this is all the
same columns on there that's all we've
done is reformatted our data grouped it
together by date and then you can see
the different data coming out uh set up
on there uh and then as a data scientist
first thing I want to do is get a
description what am I looking at uh and
so we can go ahead and do the df2
describe and this gives us our um you
know describe gives us our basic uh data
analytics information we might be
looking for like what is the mean
standard
deviation uh minimum amount maximum
amount we have our first quarter second
quarter and third quarter um numbers
also in there uh so you can get a quick
look at a glance describing the data or
descriptive analysis
and even though we have our quantile
information in here we're going to dig a
little deeper into that uh we're going
to calculate the quantile for each
variable uh we're going to look at a
number of things for each variable we'll
see right here q1 uh we can simply do
the quantile
.25% which should match um our 25% up
here and we're going to be looking at
the Min the max um and we're just going
to do this is basically we're breaking
this down for each uh different
variable in there one of the things is
kind of fun to do uh we're going to look
at that in just a second let me get put
the next piece of code in here um got
clean out some of our um we're going to
drop a couple thing our um last rows and
first row because those have usually
they have a lot of null values and the
first row is just are titles uh so
that's important it's important to drop
those rows in here and so this right
here as we look at our different
quantiles again it's it's the same we're
still looking at the 20 25 quantile here
we're going to do a little bit more with
this um so now that we've cleared off
our first and last rows we're going to
go ahead and go through all of our
columns and this way we can look at each
uh column individually and so we'll just
create a q1 Q3 min max uh Min IQR Max
IQR and calculate the quantile of I of
df2 we're basically doing uh the math
that they did up here but we're
splitting it part um that's all this is
and this happens a lot because you might
want to look at individual uh if this
was my own project I would probably
spend days and days going through what
these different values mean one of the
biggest data science uh things we can
look at that's
important is uh use your use your common
sense you know if you're looking at this
data and it doesn't make sense and you
go back in there and you're like wait a
minute minute what the heck did I just
do at that point you probably should go
back and double check what you have
going on now uh we're looking at this
and you can see right here here's our
attribute for our 03 so we broken it
down uh we have our q1 5.88 Q3 10.37 if
we go back up here here's our 58 we've
uh rounded it off 10.37 is in
there so we've basically done the same
math uh just split it up we have our
minimum and our Max IQ R and that's
computed uh let's see where is it here
we go uh q1 minus 1.5 * IQR and the IQR
is your Q3 minus q1 so that's the
difference between our two different
quarters and this is all uh data science
um as far as a hard math we're really
not we're actually trying to focus on
carass and tensor flow you still got to
go through all this stuff I told you 80%
of your programming is going through and
understanding what the heck uh happened
here what's going on what does this data
mean and so when we looking in that
we're going to go ahead and say hey
um we've computed these numbers and the
reason we've computed these numbers is
if you take the minimum value and it's
less than your Min minimum
IQR uh that means something's going
wrong there and that usually in this
case is going to show us an outlier uh
so we want to go ahead and find the
minimum value if it's less than the
minimum minimum IQR it's an outlier and
if the max value is greater than the uh
Max IQR uh we have an outlier and that's
all this is doing low outlier found uh
minimum value High outlier is found uh
really important actually outliers are
almost everything in data sometimes
sometimes you do this project just to
find the outliers because you want to
know uh crime detection what are we
looking for we're looking for the
outliers what doesn't fit a normal
business deal and then we'll go ahead
and throw in um just throw in a a lot of
code oh my goodness uh so we have if
your max is greater than IQR print
outlier is found what we want to do is
we want to start cleaning up these
outliers and so we want to convert uh
we'll do create a convert Nan x max IQR
equals Max _ IQR Min IQR equal Min IQR
so this is just saying this is the data
we're going to send that's all that is
in Python and if x is greater than the
max IQR and X is less than the Min IQ r
x equals uh null we're going to set it
to null why because we want to clear
these outliers out of the data now again
if you're doing fraud detection you
would do the opposite you would be
cleaning everything else that's not in
that Series so that you can look at just
the outlier uh and then we're going to
convert the Nan hum again we have x uh
Max iqrs 100% Min IQR is min IQR if x is
greater than Max IQR and X is less than
Min IQ QR again we're going to return uh
null value otherwise it's going to
remain the same value x xal
x and you can see um as we go through
the code if I equals um our hm uh then
we go ahead and do that's the that's a
column specific to humidity that's your
huum column uh then we're going to go
ahead and convert do the run a map on
there and convert the
nonm uh you can see here it's this is
just clean up uh we run we found out
that humidity probably has some weird
values in it uh we have our outliers um
that's all this is and so when we go
ahead and finish this and we take a look
at our outliers and we run this code
here uh we have a low outlier 2.04 we
have a high outlier
99.06 outliers have been
interpolated that means we've given them
a new value uh chances are these days
when you're looking at something like um
these sensors coming in they probably
have a failed sensor in there something
went wrong um that's the kind of thing
that you really don't want to do your
data analysis on uh so that's what we're
doing is we're pulling that out and then
uh converting it over and setting it up
method linear so we interpolate leth
linears it's going to fill that data in
based on a linear regression model of
similar data uh same thing with this up
here with the um df2 interpolate that's
what we're doing again this is all data
prep uh we're not actually talking about
tensor flow we're just trying to get all
our data set up correctly so that when
we run it it's not going to cause
problems or have a huge
bias so we've dealt with outliers
specifically in
humidity and again this is one of these
things where when we start running um
we ran through this you can see down
here that we have our um outliers found
high low outliers um we migrated them in
we also know there's other issues going
on with this data uh how do we know that
some of it's just looking at the data
playing with it until you start
understanding what's going on let's take
the temp value and we're going to go
ahead and and use a logarithmic function
on the temp value and uh it's
interesting because it's like how do you
how do you heck do you even know to use
logarithmic on the temp value that's
domain specific we're talking about
being an expert in air care I'm not an
expert in Air Care um you know it's not
what I go look at I don't look at Air
Care data in fact this is probably the
first Air Care data setup I've looked at
but the experts come in there and they
come to you and say hey in data science
um this is a um exponentially VAR
variable on here so we need to go ahead
and do um transform format and use a
logarithmic scale on
that so at that point that would be
coming from your um uh data here we go
data science programmer overview does a
lot of stuff connecting the datab base
and connecting in with the experts data
analytics a lot of times you're talking
about somebody who is a data analysis
might be all the way use a PhD level
data science programming level
interfaces database manager that's going
to be the person who's your admin
working on it so when we're looking at
this we're looking at uh something
they've sent to me and they said hey
domain Air Care this needs to be this is
a skew because the data just goes up
exponentially and affects everything
else and we'll go ahead and take that
data um let me just go ahead and run
this just for another quick look at it
um we have our uh uh we'll do a
distribution DF we'll create another
data frame from the temp values and then
from a data set from the log temp so we
can put them side by side and we'll just
go ahead and do a quick histogram and
this is kind of nice plot of figure
figure size here's our PLT from matplot
library uh and then we'll just do a
distribution umore DF there's our data
frames this is nice because it just
integrates the histogram right into
pandas love pandas and this is a chart
you would send back to your data
analysist and say hey is this what you
wanted this is how the data is converted
in on here as a data science scientist
the first thing I note is we've gone
from a 10 20 30 scales to 2.5 3.0 3.5
scale um and the data itself has kind of
been um uh adjusted a little bit based
on some kind of a skew on there so let's
jump into uh we're getting a little
closer to actually doing our uh um
carass on here we'll go ahead and split
our data up um and this of course is any
good data scientists you want to have a
training set and a test Set uh and we'll
go ahead and do the train
size we're going to use 75% of the data
make sure it's an integer don't want to
take a slice as a float value give you a
nice error uh and we'll have our train
size is 75% and the test size is going
to be um of course the uh train size
minus the length of the data set and
then we can simply do train comma test
here's our data set which is going to be
the size the test size uh and then if we
go and print this let me just go and run
this we can see how these values um
split it's a nice split of 1,98 and then
433 points of value that are going to be
for our um setup on here and if you
remember we're specifically looking at
the data set where did we create that
data set from um that was from up here
that what we called the uh logarithmic
um value of the temp uh that's where the
data set came from so we're looking at
just that column with this train size
and the test with the train and test
data set here and let's go ahead and do
a convert an array of values into a data
set Matrix we're going to create a
little um setup in here we create our
data set our data set's going to come in
we're going to do a look back of one so
we're going to look back one piece of
data going backward and we have our data
X and our data y for ION range length of
data set look back minus one uh this is
creating let me just go ahead and run
this actually the best way do this is to
go ahead and create this data and take a
look at the shape of it uh let me go
ahead and just put that code in here so
we're going to do a look back one here's
our train X our train Y and it's going
to be adding the data on there and then
when we come up here and we take a look
at the shape there we go um and we run
this piece of code here we look at the
shape on this and we have uh a new
slightly different change on here but we
have a shape of x 1296 comma 1 shape of
Y train y Test X test Y and so what
we're looking at is that um the X comes
in and we're only having a single value
out uh we want to predict what the next
one is that's what this little piece of
code is here for what are we looking for
well we want to look back one that's the
um then what we're going to train the
data with is yesterday's data yesterday
says Hey the humidity was at 9 97% what
should today's humidity be at if it's
97% yesterday is it going to go up or is
it going to go down today if 97 does it
go up to 100 what's going on there uh
and so our we're looking forward to the
next piece of data which says Hey
tomorrow's is going to you know today's
humidity is this this is what tomorrow's
humidity is going to be that's all that
is all that is is stacking our data so
that um our Y is basically x + one or X
could be Yus
one
and then a couple things to note is our
X data um we're only dealing with the
one column but you need to have it in a
shape that has it by The Columns so you
have the two different numbers and since
we're doing just a single point of data
we have and you'll see with the train y
we don't need to have the extra shape on
here now this is going to run into a
problem uh and the reason is is that we
have what they call a Time step
and the time step is that long-term
short-term memory layer uh so we're
going to add another reshape on here let
me just go down here and put it into the
next cell and so we want to reshape the
input uh array in the form of sample Tim
step features we're only looking at one
feature and I mean this is one of those
things when you're playing with this
you're like why am I getting an error in
the numpy array why is this giving me
something weird going on uh so we're
going to do is we're going to add one
more uh level on here instead of being $
12991 we want to go one
more and when they put the code together
in the back you can see we kept the same
shape the
1299 uh we added the one dimension and
then we have our trainx shape one um and
this could have depends again on how far
back in the long short-term memory you
want to go that is what that piece of
code is for and that reshape is and you
can see the new shape is now one uh$
12991 1 uh versus the 12 991 and then
the other part of the shape
43211 again this is our TR our xn and of
course our test X and then our Y is just
a single column because we're just doing
one output that we're looking for so now
we've done our
80% um you know that's all the the
writing all the code reformatting our
data um bringing it in now we want to go
ahead and do the fun part which is we're
going to go ahead and create and fit the
lstm neural network uh and if we're
going to do that the first thing we need
is we're going to need to go ahead and
create a model and we'll do the
sequential model and if you remember
sequential means it just goes in order
uh that means we have if you have two
layers the layers go from layer one to
Layer Two or layer zero to layer one
this is different than functional uh
functional allows you to split the data
and run two completely separate models
and then bring them back together we're
doing just sequential on here and then
we decided to do the long short-term
memory uh and we have our input shape uh
which it comes in again this is what all
this switching was we could have easily
made this one two three or four going
back as far as the uh in number on there
we just stuck to going back one and it's
always a good idea when you get to this
point where the heck is this model
coming from um what kind of models do we
have available and uh there's let me go
and put the next model in there uh cuz
we're going to do two models and the
next model model is going to go ahead
and we're going to do dent so we have
model equals sequential and then we're
going to add the lstm model and then
we're going to add a dents model and if
you remember from the very top of our
code where we did the Imports oops there
we go our cross this is it right here
here's our importing a dense model and
here's our importing an
lstm now just about every tensor flow
model uses dents uh your dents model is
your basic forward propagation uh
reverse propagation error or it does
reverse propagation to program the model
uh so any of your neural networks you've
already looked at that uh looks and says
here's the error and sends the error
backwards that's what this is the long
short-term memory is a little different
the real question that we want to look
at right now is where do you find these
models what what kind of models do you
have available and so for that let's go
to the carass website U which is the
cars.io if you go under API SL layers
and I always have to do a search just
search for carass uh API layers it'll
open up and you can see we have um your
base layers right here class trainable
weights all kinds of stuff like there
your activation uh so a lot of your
layers you can switch how it activates
uh railu which is like your smaller
arrays or if you're doing convolutional
neural networks the convolution usually
uses a Ru um your sigmoid um all the way
up to soft Max soft Plus these different
choices as far as how those are set up
and what we want to do is we want to go
ahead and if you scroll down here you'll
see your core layers and here is your
dense layer uh so you have an input
object your dense layer your activation
layer embedding layer this is your your
kind of your one setup on there that's
most common uh convolutional neural
networks or convolutional layers these
are like for doing uh image categorizing
uh so trying to find objects in a
picture that kind of thing uh we have
pooling layers so as you have the layers
come together usually bring them down
into single layer although you can still
do like Global Max pulling 3D and there
is just I mean this list just goes on
and on uh there's all kinds of different
things hidden in here as far as what you
can do and it changes you know go in
here and you just have to do a search
for what you're looking for uh and
figure out what's going to work best for
you as far as what project you're
working on uh long short-term memory is
a big one CU this is when we start
talking about text uh what if someone
saysthe what comes after the' uh The Cat
in the Hat little kid's book there um
starts programming it and so you really
want to know not only um what's going on
but it's going to be something that has
a history the history behind it tells
you what the next one coming up is now
once we've built all our different you
know we built our model we've added our
different layers we went in there um
play with it remember if you're in
functional you can actually link these
layers together and they Branch out and
come back together if you do a uh um the
sub setup then you can create your own
different model you can embed a model in
there that might be comes linear
regression you can embed a linear
regression model uh as part of your
functional split and then have that come
back together with other things so we're
going to go ahead and compile your model
this brings everything together we're
going to put in what the loss is which
we'll use the mean squared error
uh and we'll go a and use the atom
Optimizer clearly there's a lot of
choices on here depending on what you're
doing and just like uh any of these uh
different prediction models if you've
been doing any uh um s kit from python
uh you'll recognize that we have to then
fit the model uh so what are we doing in
here we're going to T send in our train
X our train y um we're going to decide
how many epics we're going to run it
through 500 is probably a lot for this
um I'm guessing it' probably be about
two or 300 probably do just fine our
batch size so how many different uh when
you process it this is the math behind
it if you're in data analytics um you
might try to know what this number is as
a data scientist where I haven't had the
PHD level math that says this is why you
want to use this particular batch size
you kind of play with this number a
little bit um you can dig deeper into
the math see how it affects the results
uh depending on what you're doing and
there's a number of other settings on
here uh we did verbos 2 I'd have to
actually look that up to tell you what
verbos means I think that's actually the
default on there if I remember correctly
uh there's a lot of different settings
when you go to fit it the big ones are
your epic and your bat size those are
what we're looking for and so we're
going to go ahead and run
this and this is going to take a few
minutes to run because it's going
through um 500 times through all the
data so if you have a huge data set this
is the point where you're kind of
wondering oh my God go is this going to
finish tomorrow um if I'm running this
on a single machine and I have a terab
terabyte of data uh going into
it if this is my personal computer and
I'm running a terabyte of data into this
um you know this is running rather
quickly through all 500 iterations uh
but you know at a terabyte of data we're
talking something closer to days week um
you know even with a uh um uh 3.5 GH
machine in in eight cores it's still
going to take a long time to go through
a full terabyte of data and then we want
to start looking at putting it into some
other framework like spark or something
that will'll P to process on there more
across multiple um processors and
multiple
computers and if we scroll all the way
down to the bottom you're going to see
here's our square mean error of
0.0088 if we scroll way up you'll see it
kind of oscillates between 0888 and 0889
it's right around two 2 250 where you
start seeing that oscillation where it's
really not going anywhere so we really
didn't need to go through a full 500
epics uh you know if you're retraining
the stuff over and over again it's kind
of good to note where that error zone is
so you don't have to do all the extra
processing of course if you're going to
build a model uh we want to go ahead and
run a prediction on it so let's go ahead
and make our prediction and remember we
have our training test set and our test
set that we have the train X and the
train y for training it or train predict
and then we have our test X and our test
y going in there uh so we can test to
see how good it did uh and when we come
in here we have um uh you'll see right
here we go ahead and do our train
predict equals uh model predict train X
and Test predict model predict test X
why would we want to run the prediction
on train X well it's not 100% on its
prediction we know it has a certain
amount of error and we want to compare
the error we have on what we programmed
it with with the error we get when we
run it on new data that's never seen the
model's never seen before and one of the
things we can do uh we go ahead and
invert the predictions uh this helps us
level it off a little bit more um get
rid of some of our bias we have train
predict equals an NP um exponential M1
the train predict and then train y
equals the exponential M1 for train Y
and then we do the again that with train
test predict and test
y um again reformatting the data so that
we can it all matches and then we want
to go ahead and calculate the root mean
square error so we have our train score
uh which is your math square root times
the mean square root error train uh Y
and train predict and again we're just
um uh this is just feeding the data
through so we can compare it and the
same thing with the T test and let's
take a look at that cuz really the code
makes sense if you're going through it
line by line you can see what we're
doing but the answer really helps to
zoom in uh so we have a train score
which is
2.40 of our root mean square error and
we have a test score of 3.16 of the root
mean square error if these were reversed
if our test score is better than our
training score then we've overtrained
something's wrong at that point you got
to go back and figure out what you did
wrong uh cuz you should never have a
better result on your test data than you
do on your training data and that's why
we put them both through that's why we
look at the error for both the training
and the testing when you're going out
and quoting your um um publishing this
you're saying hey how good is my model
it's the test score that you're showing
people this is what it did on my test
data that the model had never seen
before this is how good my model is and
a lot of times you actually want to put
together like a little formal code
um where we actually want to print that
out and if we print that out you can see
down here um test prediction and
standard deviation of data set 3.16 is
less than 4. uh 40 I'd have to go back
and we're up here if you remember we did
the square means error this is standard
deviation that's why these numbers are
different it's saying the same thing
that we just talked about uh 3.16 is
less than 4.40 model is good enough
we're saying hey this is this model is
valid we have a valid model here so we
can go ahead and go with that uh and
along with putting a formal print out of
there um we want to go ahead and plot
what's going
on uh and this we just want to pretty
graft here so that people can see what's
going on when I walk into a meeting and
I'm dealing with a number of people they
really don't want these numbers they
don't want to say hey what's I mean
standard deviation unless you know what
statistics are um you might be dealing
with a number of different departments
head of cells might not works with
standard deviation or have any idea what
that really means number-wise and so at
this point we really want to put it in a
graph so we have something to display
and with displaying you got to remember
that we're looking at uh the data today
going into it and what's going to happen
tomorrow so let's take a quick look at
this uh we're going to go ahead and
shift the train predictions for plotting
uh we have our train predict plot uh NP
empty like data set uh train predict
plot
uh set it up with null
values you know it's just kind of it's
kind of a weird thing where we we're
creating the um the data groups as we
like them and then putting the data in
there is what's going on here uh so we
have our train predict plot uh which is
going to be our look back or length plus
look back we're just is going to equal
train uh train predict so we're creating
this basically we're taking this and
we're dumping the train predict into it
so now we have our nice train predict
plot and then we have the shift test
predictions for the plotting uh we're
going to continue more of that oops
looks like I put it in here double no
it's just uh yeah they put it in here
double um didn't mean to do that we
really only need to do it once oh here
we go um this is where the problem was
is because this is the test predict so
we have our training prediction we're
doing the shift on here and then the
test predict we're going to look at that
same thing we're just creating those two
uh data sets uh test predict plot length
prediction set up on there and then
we're going to go through the plotting
the original data set and the
predictions uh so we have a Time axes
always nice to have your time set on
there um set that to the time array time
axes lap all this is setting up the time
variable for the bottom and then we have
a lot of stuff going on here as far as
setting up up our
figure let's go ahead and run that and
then we'll break it
down we have on here uh our main plot we
have two different plots going on here
uh the ispu going up and the data and
the ispu here with all these different
settings on
it and so when we look at this we have
our um ax1 that's the main plot I mean
our ax that's the main plot and we have
our ax1 which is the secondary plot over
here so we're doing a figure PLT or pl.
fig and we're going to dump those two
graphs on there um and so we take and if
you go through the code piece by piece
uh which we're not going to do we're
going to do the um the data set here um
exponential reverse exponential so it
looks correctly we're going to label it
the original data set um we're going to
plot the train predict plot that's what
we just created we're going to make that
orange and we'll label it train
prediction uh test predi plot we're
going to make that red and label it test
prediction and so forth um set our ticks
up this's actually just put ticks um
time axis gets its ticks the little
little marks they going along the axes
that kind of thing and let's take a look
and see what these graphs look
like and these are just kind of fun you
know when you show up into a meeting and
this is the final output and you say hey
this is what we're looking at um here's
here our original data in blue here's
our training prediction um you can see
that it trains pretty close to what the
data is up there I would also probably
put a um like a little little Tim stamp
and do just right before and right after
where we go from uh train to test
prediction and you can see with the test
prediction the data comes in in red um
and then you can also see what the
original data set looked like behind it
and how it differs and then we can just
isolate that here on the right that's
all this is um is just the test
prediction on the right uh and it's you
know there's you you'll see with the
original data set there's a lot of Peaks
were missing and a lot of lows were
missing but as far as the actual test
prediction it's pretty does pretty good
it's pretty right on you can get a good
idea what to expect for your ispu and so
from this we would probably publish it
and say hey this is um what you expect
and this is our area of this is a range
of error that's the kind of thing I put
out on a daily basis maybe we predict
the sales are going to be this or maybe
weekly so you kind of get a nice you
kind of flatten the um data coming out
and you say hey this is what we're
looking at the big takeaway from this is
that we're working with let me go back
up here oops oh too far there we go um
is this model here this is what this is
all about we worked through all of those
pieces um all the tensor flows and that
is to build this sequential model and
we're only putting in the two layers
this can get pretty complicated if you
get too complicated it never um it it
never verges into a usable model uh so
if you have like 30 different layers in
here there's a good chance you might
crash it kind of thing um so don't go
too haywire on that and that you kind of
learn as you go again it's domain
knowledge um and also starting to
understand all these different layers
and what they
mean the data analytics behind those
layers um is something that your data
analysis uh professional would come in
and say this is what we want to try but
I tell you as a data scientist um a lot
of these basic setups are common and I
don't know how many times uh working
with somebody and they're like oh my
gosh if I only did a tangent H instead
of a railu activation I worked for two
weeks to figure that out well as a data
science I can uh run it through the
model in you know 5 minutes instead of
spending two weeks weeks doing the the
math behind it um so that's one of the
advantages of data scientist is we do it
from programming side and a data
analytics is going to look for it how
does it work in math and this is really
the core right here of tensor flow and
carass is being able to build your data
model quickly and efficiently and of
course uh with any data science putting
out a pretty graph so that your
shareholders um again we want to take
and um reduce the information down to
something people can look at and say oh
that's what's going on they can see
stuff what's going on as as far as the
dates and the change in the ispu now
let's talk a little bit about recurrent
neural networks so neural networks are
of different types we have CNN we have
RNN Ann so on now RNN is one type of
neural network RNN stands for recurrent
neural network the networks like CNN
andn are freed forward Network which
means that the information pretty much
only goes from from left to right or
from front to back whichever way you
call it whereas in case of recurrent
neural network there will be some
information traveling backwards as well
so that is why it is known as recurrent
neural network and each of these types
have a specific application so for
example convolutional neural networks or
CNN are very good for doing image
processing and U object detection using
for video and images whereas recurrent
neural networks are pretty good for
doing NLP or speech recognition and so
on okay so for the next few minutes we
will kind of focus on recurrent neural
networks and we will see an example of
how we can use RNN to do a Time series
analysis so in a typical neural network
this is how it looks right so where you
have a neuron and then the inputs are
coming to the neuron and uh then you
have an output which goes to other
neurons in the other layers in case of
recurrent neural network what happens is
you have the inputs let's say at a given
point point in time but then a part of
the previous output also gets fed in
along with the inputs for the given time
now this can be a little confusing so
let's see if we can take a little
expanded view of this so this is another
view of one single neuron which is what
is known as in an unfolded manner okay
so if we are getting inputs or data over
a period of time then this is how the
neuron will look remember these are not
three neurons this is one neuron and it
is what is known as it is shown in a
unfolded way okay we are we have
unfolded this single neuron over a
period of time so at a given time let's
say t minus1 an input of XT minus one is
fed to the neuron and it gets a output
of YT minus one then the next instant
which is XT at a time T right there is
an input of XT and then there is an
output of YT so this is a single neuron
but is displayed in an unfolded way so
this is like expanding it over a period
of time so let's start with this part
here this particular neuron gets an
input at at an instant T minus one let's
say time is equal to T minus one it gets
an input of XT minus1 and it gives an
output of YT minus then when we go to
the instant T here it gets an input of
XT and it also additionally gets an
input from this previous time frame T
minus 1 so this YT minus one gets fed
here and that results in YT all right
then when we go to the time t + 1 there
is an input of XT minus1 at that given
time plus the input from the previous
time frame which is a time frame of T
that also gets fed in here and then we
get an output of YT + 1 okay so let me
explain once again this is a single
neuron this these are not three
different neurons a single neuron seen
over a period of time time from T minus1
to t + 1 and unlike a regular
feedforward neuron which only gets X in
this case the input is X and also
another input which is coming from the
previous time frame and that is what
this Loop is in this on the left hand
side diagram this Loop is indicating
that okay so on the right hand side it
is represented in an unfolded way okay
so the input if we take a time frame T
for example is not only XT which is the
input which is the normal input at the
time frame T but it is also getting an
input from the previous time frame which
is this YT minus one is also being fed
as an input that is the key
differentiator here okay similarly at
the instant t + 1 it is getting a normal
input of XT + 1 plus this YT is actually
being fed here and then the output comes
as YT + 1 okay so this is the construct
of a recurrent neural network now
recurrent neural networks again can be
of different subtypes it can be one to
one one to many many to one and many to
many depending on what kind of
application we want to use one of the
examples is like the stock price so
you're feeding so there is only one
input only thing is it is spread over a
period of time so you're feeding the
stock price input that is what comes
here as an input and you get an output
which is again the stock price which is
probably predicted over the next uh 2
days or 3 days or 10 days or whatever so
the number of outputs and inputs is the
same there is only one input there is
only one output only thing is it is
spread over time so variables are not
many then you have one to many so there
is one input but you're expecting
multiple outputs what is an example of
this let's say you want to caption an
image so how do you want to do that what
is input that will go here is just an
image which is one input but what is
output you're looking for you're looking
for a phrase maybe right not just a word
but a phrase so it's like cat is sitting
on a map right so the images there is
only one image which consists of the cat
sitting on a mat but the output are like
maybe three or four words which is
saying the cat is sitting on a mat so
this is one to many right then you can
have many to one examples of this are
like you're feeding some text and you
want to know the output whether the text
is what kind of sentiment is expressed
by the text it could be positive it
could be negative so that's the output
you're looking for so you feed a large
number of words maybe the text May
consist of words or lines or whatever so
that is what is the multiple inputs but
the output all it says is the sentiment
is positive so it is just one output or
the sentiment is negative just one
output right so this is many to one then
we have many to many so what is an
example of this let's say you want to do
some translation so how do you do a
translation you feed in a sentence maybe
in a particular language English and
then you want another a sentence
actually in another language so that is
like there are multiple inputs one
sentence can consist of multiple words
and the output also is a sentence
consisting of multiple words all right
so how do we Implement RNN this is an
example of implementing an RNN for a
particular use case so in our particular
example we have the data about milk
production over a few months and using
RNN we want to predict because this is
time series analysis so RNN is good to
do time series analysis so using RNN we
want to predict what will be the milk
production in the future so let us see
how we can do that I will first take you
through quickly through the slides and
then I will actually run this in in a
Jupiter notebook the code I will run it
in the Jupiter notebook so this is how
it looks the code looks so while this
extensive flow you still use the
standard python libraries like numpy and
pandas and even matplot live to do some
initial processing getting the data
processing it cleaning it whatever all
that can be still done in within the
same program so that's why what we doing
here we importing some libraries like
numai and pandas and then we read the
data file and if we plot the data we see
here it is the data for for the years
1962 to 75 and we can see that there is
a certain Trend right so this is how a
typical time series data would look
again some of you if you're not familiar
with time series and uh time series
analysis and so on I would recommend you
to go through some videos around that
which will make it easy to understand
this so this is how typical time series
data would look in this case it is
nothing but there is only one variable
which is uh milk production and it is
spread across several years so it's
going from 1962 to 75 and that value has
been plotted so if you see there is a
certain kind of a trend here which is
basically going upwards and there will
be some seasonality so time series data
has these three components right so it
will have a trend it will have a
seasonality it will have seasonality and
then it will have some Randomness so
that's what this graph is uh showing and
and um now if we want to perform
analysis on this time series analysis on
this first thing we need to do is split
the data into train and uh test and in
this case we will just use a
straightforward method which is uh
taking the data for the first 13 years
so the idea here is we need to train our
model right this is time series data so
what and we want to predict for the
future so the way we need to use this is
we have to take the data for a certain
period of time and train our models and
then we use a part of the known data so
that we can then ask our model to
predict for that duration and compare it
with the known information so what do we
mean by that so here if you see this
data I will show you in the notebook as
well Jupiter notebook as well this has
13 years of data so what we are doing is
we are taking the first 12 years and
using that as our training set right so
12 years we doing and this has about I
think 14 years of data so we are taking
13 years of data for training purpose
purpose and then we are using the last
one year remaining one year of data for
testing purpose because here what we can
do is this one-ear data we know the
values right because if we want to
compare the accuracy or anything like
that we need to know the values so in
this case we know the values of this one
particular year so we will use that but
at the same time we train the model for
13 years of data and for the 14th Year
we will ask our model to predict and
then compare it with this known value so
that we know how accurate our model is I
hope that makes sense okay so that's
what we are doing here 156 is nothing
but 12 into 13 on a monthly basis we get
the data the next step is to scale the
data this is all regular data
manipulation data munging activity and
then you split it you are basically
assigning the train and test data to the
to the scaled variables and uh then you
need to read the data in batches so it
is very important as I mentioned earlier
also that instead of reading the entire
data in one shot you feed the data in
batches so in order to do that we are
writing a a function for that that's all
we are doing here so that is till here
what we have done is regular Python
Programming there is no tensor flow as
of now here okay so so far what we have
done is preparation data preparation
data Ming now what we are doing is
actually training our model so this is
where tensorflow now comes into picture
so we are importing first step is to
import the tensorflow library so this is
how you do it input tens oflow SF and
then you can Define some variables or
constants whichever way now here of
course there are a couple of ways of
doing it you can create them as
tensorflow nodes but that is a little
bit of an overhead we will just use the
regular python variables or constant so
here I'm creating regular python
variables and I'm saying number of
inputs is one so instead of hard coding
I'm just storing them as variables so
this is number of inputs is one number
of time steps is 12 number of neurons is
100 and so on right and then learning
rate is 03 and number of iterations we
are seeing is 4,000 then we create
placeholders now we will be storing the
independent variables in X and the
dependent variables in y and this we
will read from an external file remember
I told you placeholders are used for
getting data from outside and then
feeding it to our model so that's the
reason we have two placeholders one for
reading the X values and another for
reading the Y values in this step we are
only just creating the nodes right so
this is just creating the graph and
similarly we are mentioning what is the
loss function and what is the optimizer
and and how to run the optimizer and
once that is done you are initializing
the variables and then you're creating a
sa variable or a sa instance so saver is
basically nothing but in machine
learning you can train your model and
you can save it for later use so that's
where this saving comes into play we
will see how to use that as well and
then the last step is to create your
session and run this graph right so we
are initializing the variables remember
this we run in it so which is nothing
but this one so we are initializing the
variables whatever are there instead of
hard coding remember in earlier case we
were hardcoding how many iterations so
here we are saying for the given number
of iterations which are stored in this
maybe how many iterations We Said is
What is the value of iterations this is
training iterations is 4,000 so we
specify that based on the number of
training iterations next batch will
basically fetch the data and then we run
the session we are basically saying
train is the node which we will run in
the session and and uh this will
basically train our model and this is
more for printing every 100 times you
print it that's all this there's nothing
more to it so for example the output
would look somewhat like this this is
for zero this for 100 next for 200 and
so on okay and then you save the model
you remember saver we created so you
save the model for later use so this is
our test data remember we are doing this
on training data right so once the
training data training is done we then
try to create the inference on the test
data so that we we can compare how
accurate this is right so this is how
the test set would look and uh then we
will basically restore this model okay
because in the previous slide we created
the model and we stored it so now we
have to restore the model and then run
our test data against it and see what
are the values that are predicted what
are the Y values and then compare with X
to see the accuracy so train seed is
what we are seeing here so that is what
will have the the predicted values and
uh these predicted values what we want
to do is we want to create an additional
column because remember we need to
compare because we want to find out the
accuracy of this model so we need to
compare the predicted values with the
actual value so what we are doing here
is adding another column called
generated and uh assign a value to that
all right so this is the result of the
prediction and then if we need to
reshape because we have to show this in
the form of a monthly results so that's
what we doing here and and um once we
generate the results and then display it
we can actually see it month-wise here
and uh the actual and the generated
values okay so we create a data frame
which is a combination of the actual
values and the predicted values from the
test set and then we can plot to see how
the trend is as you can see pretty much
the actual value is in blue color and
the generated or predicted value the
curve is in yellow color the trend is
maintained so it will probably it's not
100% accurate but the trend is
maintained all right so let's do one
thing let's go into the Jupiter notebook
and take a look at how this works in
tensorflow environment actually the code
I will walk you through the code this is
my Jupiter notebook and uh the data is
taken from this particular Link in case
you interested you can uh download it
from there and this is the data for the
years 1962 to 75 the first thing we do
is import these libraries because before
we start with the actual tensorflow
activity we need to prepare the data and
so on so for that you can use your
regular python libraries which are like
numai pandas and so on so that's what we
doing here and then we read the data
using pandas into a data frame so this
is a data frame milk is a data frame and
we will do some quick exploratory
analysis just to see how our data is
looking initial five records that we'll
get 1 2 3 4 5 that is head so it goes
from 1962 January to 1962 May once we
rechange or basically we need to split
this into month specifically separately
so that's what we are doing here date to
time so we kind of do a little bit of a
reindexing and then if we plot this this
is how the data look as you can see
there is a clear upward Trend and U
there is some seasonality and so on but
anyway we will not break that up into
those components we'll just use RNN to
predict and test okay so the next thing
is is to check some if we can do run
like a info it will tell us what is the
information about this data set so let
us just run that okay so it is just
telling us how many total columns and
what is the size of the file and so on
and so forth again in case you're
interested in doing some exploratory
analysis so what we'll do next is we
will take the 13 years of data for our
training data set so what are we going
to do now let me step back so what have
we seen here we have seen that there are
168 records so which is nothing but 14
years of data we now have to split this
into our training and test data set so
how do we do that I think in case of
Time series we cannot do it like 80/20
like we do in normal splitting in normal
machine learning process here it is time
series data so what we are going to do
is we will take out of this 14 years we
will take the first 13 years of data and
we will use that for training and then
we will test it with the last which is
the 14th year data we will use it for
testing okay so that's what we are going
to do here so let's uh split that so
training set will consist of my 156
records which is nothing but 12 13 into
12 right my 13 years of data I'm taking
for training and then my test set will
consist of the bottom 12 observations
which is last one year of data which is
the 14th year okay so that's now done
training and test splitting is done the
next step is to do some normalizing
which is basically we'll use or scaling
rather we will use minmax scaler and uh
we will just scale the data and now we
do it for both test as well as train now
we are ready to create our RNN model but
before that one quick thing in order to
fetch the data we have to create a
function so that's what we are doing
here we create a function called Next
batch and uh how you want to fetch the
steps they are all defined as our
constants if you remember and uh that's
what this uh function is all about so we
Define that function we will be calling
that in our training Method All right so
from here onwards up to there we are
done with uh the preparation of the data
and whatever functions or whatever are
required from here onwards is where the
tensorflow part starts so the first
thing we do is import the tensorflow
library typically this is a very
standard way of importing the library we
say import tens of flow as TF now TF is
nothing but a name so you can change it
to tf1 or ABC or XY Z whatever so this
part you can change but by and large
everybody uses this so we I would rather
recommend you also use the same syntax
so you say importance of flow stf so
it's very easy for others to understand
as well and then you declare or Define a
bunch of constants uh that's what we are
doing here like for example the number
of uh time steps in in this case it is
12 number of neurons there are 100
number of outputs it is only one and so
on right and then the learning rate and
all that we are declaring or defining
those variables in this particular block
next is to create placeholders you
remember the place holders are used for
feeding the data so we have X and Y X is
for the input which is the independent
variable and Y is the output which is
the dependent variable and in our case
these are not different characteristics
or features but it is the same one
feature or one variable but it is over a
period of time so that's the only
difference so that's what we are doing
here and now we need to create our
Network right the neural network so in
our case we said we will create a RNN
layer now there are different ways or
different formats of RNN which is
probably not in scope of this module so
for now we will just assume we are
creating one RNN layer and one type of
RNN is Gru cell so we will use Gru cell
and we use this apis for creating our
layer so each cell will be with an
output projection wrapper that is a need
for doing that and again the details of
this we will probably do in another
video where we talk in detail about
about RNN so for now we are creating a
GRU cell with the wrapper and the the
Syntax for creating the gru cell is uh
like this the number of units which we
we said there should be 100 neurons what
will be the activation function in this
case it is relu and then number of
outputs in our case it is only one okay
so we create the cell here okay then we
got the gru cell and then we say what is
our output which is nothing but we get
the outputs and the state and their
states and which is the way we get that
is tf. nnn do dynamicore RNN so if we
call this and we pass the cell and the
data which is basically in placeholder
again remember all we are doing here is
we are creating just the nodes for the
graph so nothing is actually getting
executed from a tensorflow perspective
okay all right so once that is done now
we need to pass this calculate the
outputs and the states using the
dynamicore Orin method and and we pass
the cell as a parameter and then the X
values as a parameter and if we run that
we will have the outputs and the states
and this is where we actually run the
Training Method so or create not really
run the Training Method but we create
the nodes for the training and Optimizer
then we have the initialization of the
variables and we save this model we
create a saver object just to save the
model because we will then restore it
and run it to do our predictions so this
is what we will do here so that is
another node and this is where we
actually create a session and run the
training okay so let's go ahead and do
that that will take a little while
because we said 4,000 iterations so we
will allow it to finish we will probably
come back once the training is completed
all right so the training is done now
let's go go and U run this on the test
data so let's just quickly take a look
at the test data set so this is our
one-ear data for the year of 1975 so if
we see this this from January February
and so on and we will pass this to our
model so what are we doing here we are
restoring the model here for example
right this is the path that we have
given when we were saving the model
let's go back once and show you let me
show you where we did the saving of the
model yes so we saved the model here so
that again we will restore that and we
will use that to run it on our test data
and see how well it predicts so let's go
ahead and run this and this is just 12
record so this will not take time
remember I told you training is what
takes a lot of time the regular
inference this is called inference
doesn't take much time right so it just
depends on how much data there were only
12 records here so it was very quick but
in training what we do we pass this
multiple times there are iterations
4,000 iterations we did for example so
that takes longer and in general in
machine learning deep learning training
is what takes the maximum amount of time
all right so let's go ahead and see the
results we will in order to plot it we
will have to kind of adjust the format
of the results otherwise we will not be
able to see it in a proper way and then
we will so this is our so what we have
done is we created a data frame which
consists of the predicted value and the
and the actual value so this is the data
frame so this is the actual value this
834 782 and so on this is what our model
has predicted so it may not be so easy
to see in a table format so let's go
ahead and plot it so that we can compare
these two so when we plot it you will
see that the trend is more or less
maintained right so we go from the blue
color is the actual values and the
yellow color or the orange color
whatever is it is the one which is
generated by our model so it pretty much
is following the actual Trend so not bad
for such a quick iteration and uh
training this tutorial is about object
detection we will walk you through a
tensorflow code using which we will do
object detection in images we will tell
you what are the libraries that are
required a little bit about the Coco
data set and then we will show you the
implementation code itself a demo of the
code all right so let's get started so
what is the pensil flow object detection
API this is an open-source framework
which is actually provided by the
tensorflow team and there are train
models available and the sample code is
also available which we can use in order
to easily detect objects in images and
videos this is pretty robust and can
detect objects fairly quickly and this
is very easy for people to use as well
people with very less or no knowledge of
machine learning or deep learning can
also with a little bit of Python
Programming knowledge can actually use
this API this library to build object
detection applications this is a list of
libraries that are required and they
have been shown in the code as well the
exact purpose of each of this Library
why it is required is out of the scope
of this tutorial but we will see in the
code AS as we walk through some of these
libraries how and why they are used the
Coco data set Coco stands for common
objects in context so this data set
consists of 300,000 images of uh 90 most
commonly found objects like chairs and
tables and so on and so forth so this
model has been trained or in fact a set
of models have been trained on this data
set and this is pretty good to detect
the most common objects in the images
and videos so with that let's get into
the code all right so the first part is
to import all these libraries and this
we have shown you in uh the slides as
well again large part of this will be
for doing some helper functions and
maybe for visualizing the images and so
on and so forth so that's the reason
they are required as I said the exact
details of of each and every Library
probably is out of scope but these are
needed so as a first step maybe you just
go ahead and include these libraries and
run the code and maybe at later point we
can discuss what each of these libraries
does now this will work with tensorflow
version higher than 1.4 so if you are
having tensorflow version below 1.4 you
may have to upgrade to a higher version
so let me go ahead and execute the cell
and um we also need this line of code to
make sure that once we run this object
detection the labeled images are
displayed within this uh notebook and
many of you by now must be familiar with
this and we will import a few utility
libraries and you will see that we will
be using some of these for visualization
purpose so once the objects are detected
we need to display the information
what that object is and then what
percentage of confidence the model has
so all these details that's the utility
functions that stored here and then the
next part is to prepare the model as I
mentioned we will be using an existing
trained model the tensorflow team has
actually provided these models the one
that we will be using is SSD with the
mobile net but you can actually use any
one of the ones that are listed in this
URL let me just quickly take you through
this URL these are a bunch of models
trained models that are readily
available for anybody to use it is open
source and let me scroll down the only
thing is that if there are some of them
where the accuracy is much higher but
they take longer and there are some
where the accuracy is not so high and
they are much faster so they are faster
but the accuracy may not be that very
high so you can play around with some of
these and we in this particular exercise
or in this particular tutorial we are
using this SSD model which is SSD
mobilet version one so that's the model
that we'll be using so in this cell we
are primarily creating a bunch of
variables with the various for example
the name of the model the path and so on
and so forth so that we will be using
these names in The Next Step which is to
download this model and install it
locally these are also referred to as
Frozen model so once they are trained
and then you kind of extract or you you
freeze the model so that's the reason
they are called Frozen model so that
others can just use this without any
further training so this is where we
download and extract our model locally
so this will take a little while let me
see if I can wait or maybe pause the
video and come back once it is done
might take a little while let's see if
it uh completes I have a pretty
highspeed network but even then it takes
some time so that's good but this part
is over now let us see this part and yes
both are done so once that is done we
need to load some label mapping uh
basically what this will do is your
model as you may be aware by now if you
do some classification the model will
actually not give any output a text it
will give some number so if there are
five classes it will say okay this
belongs to mod class one or two or three
or five and so on the numbers now each
of these will obviously the numbers will
not make any sense to the outside world
so we need to do some small mapping so
in this case let's say one may be a
chair two may be a table three may be a
balloon and so on so that kind of number
to text mapping we need to do and that
is what is being done in this particular
cell and then we have a a code which
will load the image and convert it into
a num by array so that the num by array
is what gets processed and used by the
model to do the detection part of it so
that is what this uh method is all about
so we will be that later on we will be
calling that function and next is
preparation for detection so here we are
basically telling where the images are
stored and how many images or what is
the naming conven di menion or format of
the images now if you want you can
modify this code for example currently I
have testore images as my folder so let
me go and show this to you so this is
under my object detection folder I have
another subfolder where I'm storing my
images which is textor images now you
can rename this folder and give some
other name and then in your code you can
probably give that particular name for
the sfold similarly the format of these
files what is the name and format of
this files here it is in a very simple
format which is the names of the files
are like beach one beach 2 Beach 3 and
so on so I have taken Beach as the theme
so I have images which are related to
beaches so this is beach one beach 2 and
then Beach three a few others but we
will use these three for our demo and so
that's what I'm saying here the name of
the images will be Beach some something.
jpeg which is U jpeg format and in this
curly braces basically we will will be
filled with either one two or three
based on in this particular for Loop
okay so that is what this is doing all
right so the next step is to run
inference on these images in a loop and
what we are basically doing here is um
getting these images one by one and then
running through the model to find out
what are the objects that can be
detected Ed and then against each of the
object a box will be drawn and it will
be labeled with the name and the
percentage of accuracy or confidence
that the model detects these objects
okay so that is U the function here and
so let me just run that piece of code
and here is basically where we are
calling this function so we are loading
this images and then we are calling this
function for each image and then we are
displaying this using the Mac plot lib
Library so let's run this it will take
one image at a time and then detect the
images now the beauty is that the same
format of the code can be used for doing
object detection in a video so we have
another video for doing object dection
in a video so most of the code out there
will be reused from here and only thing
is that instead of reading the images
from the local storage we read the
frames from the video and there is a
neat little video reader that is
available and it will be shown in the
other video and frame by frame we read
the video and then pass on to this
function and it will act as if each of
these frames is an image and then it
will do the same object detection on the
entire video so that's in a separate
video just uh look out for that and
actually the information about that is
uh provided uh in the cards the I symbol
so that's the the video object detection
in video that's the separate uh tutorial
all right so now that we have all the
pieces together this the last cell is
where the whole action takes place so
let's run this and see how it looks so
it will take probably a little while and
there are about three images let's see
what it detects there he goes so good so
the first one it has detected a person
and that to with 97% accuracy which is
uh I think pretty good okay and then the
next image it detects umbrella and chair
there a few other objects but it's not
able to detect it has detected umbrella
with 63% accuracy or confidence rather
and uh the chair with 58% again not bad
then let's see the next image so here
these are actually balloons hot air
balloons but the model thinks it is a
kite which is uh probably not that bad
it sees there's something in the sky and
therefore probably it thinks it is a
kite and it detects that with 65% uh
confidence okay so that was pretty much
all I wanted to show you in this
particular tutorial about uh object
detection in images and in this video I
will walk you through the tensorflow
code to perform object detection in a
video so let's get started this part is
basically you're importing all the
libraries we need a lot of these
libraries for example lpai we need image
IO date time and pill and so on and so
forth and of course mat plot lib so we
import all these libraries and then
there are a bunch of variables which
have some paths for the files and
folders so this is regular stuff let's
keep moving then we import the ma plot
lib and make it in line and uh a few
more inputs all right and then these are
some warnings we can just ignore them so
if I run this code once again it will go
away all right and then here onwards we
do the model preparation and what we're
going to do is we're going to use an
existing neural network model so we are
not going to train a new one because
that really will take a long time and uh
it needs a lot of computation resources
and so on and it is really not required
there already models that have been
trained and in this case it is the SSD
with mobile net that's the model that we
are going to use and uh this model is
trained to detect objects and uh it is
readily available as open source so we
can actually use this and if you want to
use other models there are a few more
models available so you can click on the
this link here and uh let me just take
you there there are a few more models
but we have chosen this particular one
because this is faster it may not be
very accurate but that is one of the
faster models but on this link you will
see a lot of other models that are
readily available these are trained
models some of them would take a little
longer but they may be more accurate and
so on so you can probably play around
with these other models okay so we will
be using that model so this piece of
code this line is basically importing
that model and this is also known as uh
Frozen model the term we use is frozen
model so we import download and import
that and then we will actually use that
model in our code right so these two
cells we have downloaded and imported
the model and then once it is available
locally we will then load this into our
program all right so we are loading this
into memory and uh you need to perform a
couple of additional steps which is
basically we need to to map the numbers
to text as you may be aware when we
actually build the model and when we run
predictions the model will not give a
text the output of the model is usually
a number so we need to map that to a
text so for example if the network
predicts that the output is five we know
that five means it is an airplane things
like that so this mapping is done in
this next cell all right so let's keep
moving and then we have a helper code
which will basically load the data or
load the images and transform into numpy
arrays this is also used in doing object
detection in images so we are actually
going to reuse because video is nothing
but it consists of frames which in turn
are images so we we are going to pretty
much use reuse the same code which we
used for doing object detection in
images so this is where the actual
detection starts so here this is the
path for where the images are stored so
this is here once again we are reusing
the code which we wrote for detecting
objects in an image so this is the path
where the images were stored and this is
the extension and this was done for
about two or three images so we will
continue to use this and uh if we go
down I'll skip this section so this is
the cell where we are actually loading
the video and converting it into frames
and then using frame by frame we are
detecting the objects in the image so in
this code what we are doing basically is
there a few lines of code what they do
is basically once they find an object a
box will be drawn around those uh each
of those objects and the input file the
name of the input video file is uh tra
trffic it is the extension is MP4 and uh
we have this video reader it's a
excellent object which is basically part
of this class called image iio so we can
read and write videos using that and uh
the video that we going to use is
traffic. MP4 you can use any mp4 file
but in our case I picked up video which
has uh like car so let me just show you
so this is in this object detection
folder I have this mp4 file I'll just
quickly play this video it's a little
slow yeah okay so here we go this is the
video it's a short one relatively small
video so that for this particular demo
and what it will do is once we run our
code it will detect each of these cars
and it will annotate them as cars so in
this particular video we only have cars
we can later on see with another video I
think I have cat here so we can also try
with that but let's first check with
this uh traffic video so let me go back
so we will be reading this frame by
frame and um no actually we will be
reading the video file but then we will
be analyzing it frame by frame and we
will be reading them at 10 frames per
second that is the rate we are
mentioning here and analyzing it and
then annotating and then writing it back
so you will see that we will have a
video file named something like this
traffic annotated and uh um we will see
the annotated video so let's go back and
run through this piece of code and then
we will come back and see the annotated
uh video this might take a little while
so I will pause the video after running
this particular cell and then come back
to show you the results all right so
let's go ahead and run it so it is
running now and it is also important
that at the end you close the video
writer so that it is similar to a file
pointer when you open a file you should
also make sure you close it so that it
doesn't hog the resources so it's very
similar the at the end of it the last
piece or last line of code should be
video writer. close all right so I'll
pause and then I'll come back okay so I
will see you in a little bit all right
so now as you can see here the
processing is done the our glass is
disappeared that means the video has
been processed so let's go back and
check the annotated video we'll go back
to my file manager so this was the
original traffic. MP4 and now you have
here traffic annotated MP4 so let's go
and run this and see how it
looks you see here it has got each of
these cars are getting detected let me
pause and show you so we pause here it
says car 70% let us allow it to go a
little further it detects something on
top what is that truck okay so I think
because of the board on top it somehow
thinks there is a truck let's play some
more and see if it detects anything else
so this is again a car looks like so let
us yeah so this is a car and it has
confidence level of 69% okay this is
again a car all right so basically till
the end it goes and detects each and
every car that is passing by now we can
quickly repeat this process for another
video let me just show you the other
video which is a cat again there is uh
this cat is not really moving or
anything but it is just standing there
staring and moving a little slowly and
uh our application will our network will
detect that this is a cat and uh even
when the cat moves a little bit in the
other direction it'll continue to detect
and show that it is a cat Okay so yeah
so this is how the original video is
let's go ahead and change our code to
analyze this one and see if it detects
our Network detects this cat close this
here we go and I'll go back to my code
all we need to do is change this traffic
to cat the extension it will
automatically pick up because it is
given here and then it will run through
so very quickly once again what it is
doing is this video reader video uncore
reader has a a neat little feature or
interface whereby you can say for frame
in video or read up so it will basically
provide frame by frame so you are in a
loop frame by frame and then you take
that each frame that is given to you you
take it and analyze it as if it is an
image individual image so that's the way
it works so it is very easy to handle
this all right so now let's once again
run just this cell rest of the stuff
Remains the Same so I will run this cell
again it will take a little while so the
our glasses come back I will pause and
then come back in a little while all
right so the processing is done let's go
and check the annotated video go here so
we have getat annotated MP4 let's play
this all right so you can see here it is
detecting the cat and in the beginning
you also saw it detected something else
here there looks like it detected one
more object so let's just go back and
see what it has detected here let's see
yes so what is it trying to show here
it's too small not able to see but uh it
is trying to detect something I think it
is saying it is a car I don't know all
right okay so in this video there's only
pretty much only one object which is the
cat and uh let's wait for some time and
see if it continues to detect it when
the cat turns around and moves as well
just in a little bit that's going to
happen and we will see there we go and
in spite of turning the other way I
think our network is able to detect that
it is a cat so let me freeze and then
show here it is actually still continues
to detect it as a cat all right so
that's pretty much it I think that's the
only object that it detects in this
particular video okay so close this so
that's pretty much it thank you very
much for watching this video hey there
learner simply learn brings you master's
program in artificial intelligence
created in collaboration with IBM to
learn more about this course you can
find the course Link in the description
box below in this tutorial we will take
the use case of recognizing handwritten
digits this is like a hollow world of
deep learning and this is a nice little
Ms database is a nice little database
that has images of handwritten digits
nicely formatted because very often in
deep learning and neural networks we end
up spending a lot of time in preparing
the data for training and with amness
database we can avoid that you already
have the data in the right format which
can be directly used for training and
amnest also offers a bunch of built-in
utility functions that we can straight
away use and call those functions
without worrying about writing our own
functions and that's one of the reasons
why Ms database is very popular for
training purposes initially when people
want to learn about deep learning and
tens of flow this is the database that
is used and it has a collection of
70,000 handwritten digits and a large
part of them are for training then you
have test just like in any machine
learning process and then you have
validation and all of them are labeled
so you have the images and they're label
and these images they look somewhat like
this so they are handwritten images
collected from a lot of individuals
people
have these are samples written by human
beings they have handwritten these
numbers these numbers going from 0 to 9
so people have written these numbers and
then the images of those have been taken
and formatted in such a way that it is
very easy to handle so that is Mist
database and the way we are going to
implement this in our tensor flow is we
will feed this data especially the
training data along with the label in
information and uh the data is basically
these images are stored in the form of
the pixel information as we have seen in
one of the previous slides all the
images are nothing but these are pixels
so an image is nothing but an
arrangement of pixels and the value of
the pixel either it is lit up or it is
not or in somewhere in between that's
how the images are stored and that is
how they are fed into the neural network
and for training once the network is is
a train when you provide a new image it
will be able to identify within a
certain error of course and for this we
will use one of the simpler neural
network configurations called softmax
and for Simplicity what we will do is we
will flatten these pixels so instead of
taking them in a two-dimensional
arrangement we just flatten them out so
for example it starts from here it is a
28 by 28 so there are
7484 pixels so pixel number one starts
here it goes all the way up to 28 then
29 starts here and goes up to 56 and so
on and the pixel number 784 is here so
we take all these pixels flatten them
out and feed them like one single line
into our neural network and this is a
what is known as a soft Max layer what
it does is once it is trained it will
will be able to identify what digit this
is so there are in this output layer
there are 10 neurons each signifying a
digit and at any given point of time
when you feed an image only one of these
10 neurons gets activated so for example
if this is strained properly and if you
feed a number nine like this then this
particular neuron gets activated so you
get a output from this neuron let me
just use uh a pen or a laser to show you
here okay so you feeding a number nine
let's say this has been trained and now
if you're feeding a number nine this
will get activated now let's say you
feed one to the trained Network then
this neuron will get activated if you
feed two this neuron will get activated
and so on I hope you get the idea so
this is one type of a neural Network or
an activation function known as softmax
layer so that's what we will be using
here this is one of the simpler ones for
quick and easy understanding so this is
how the code would look we will go into
our lab environment in the cloud and uh
we will show you there directly but very
quickly this is how the code looks and
uh let me run you through briefly here
and then we will go into the Jupiter
notebook where the actual code is and we
will run that as well so as a first step
first of all we are using python here
and that's why the syntax of the
language is Python and the first step is
to import the tensorflow library so and
we do this by using this line of code
saying import tensor flow as TF TF is
just for convenience so you can name
give any name and once you do this TF is
tensor flow is available as an object in
the name of TF and then you can run its
uh methods and access its attributes and
so on and so forth and mless database is
actually an integral part of tensorflow
and that's again another reason why we
as a first step we always use this
example Mist database example so you
just simply import Mist database as well
using this line of code and you slightly
modify this so that the labels are in
this format what is known as one hot
true which means that the label
information is Lo like an array and uh
let me just uh use the pen to show what
exactly it is so when you do this one
hot true what happens is each label is
stored in the form of an array of 10
digits and let's say the number is uh8
okay so in this case all the remaining
values there will be a bunch of zeros so
this is like array at position zero this
is is at position one position two and
so on and so forth let's say this is
position 7 then this is position 8 that
will be one because our input is eight
and again position 9 will be zero okay
so one hot encoding this one hot
encoding true will kind of load the data
in such a way that the labels are in
such a way that only one of the digits
has a value of one and that indicates So
based on which digit is one we know what
is the label so in this case the eighth
position is one therefore we know this
sample data the value is eight similarly
if you have a two here let's say then
the labeled information will be somewhat
like this so you have your labels so you
have this as zero the zeroth position
the first position is also zero the
second position is one because this
indicates number two and then you have
third as zero and so on okay so that is
the significance of this one hot true
all right and then we can check how the
data is uh looking by displaying the the
data and as I mentioned earlier this is
pretty much in the form of digital form
like numbers so all these are like pixel
values so you will not really see an
image in this format but there is a way
to visualize that image I will show you
in a bit and uh this tells you how many
images are there in each set so the
training there are 55,000 images in
training and in the test set there are
10,000 and then validation there are
5,000 so altogether there are 70,000
images all right so let's uh move on and
we can view the actual image by uh using
the matplot flip library and this is how
you can view this is the code for
viewing the images and you can view them
in color or you can view them in gray
scale so the cmap is what tells in what
way we want to view it and what are the
maximum values and the minimum values of
the pixel values so these are the Max
and minimum values so of the pixel
values so maximum is one because this is
a scaled value so one means it is uh
White and zero means it is black and in
between is it can be anywhere in between
black and white and the way to train the
model there is a certain way in which
you write your tensorflow code and um
the first step is to create some
placeholders and then you create a model
in this case we will use the softmax
model one of the simplest ones and um
placeholders are primarily to get the
data from outside into the neural
network so this is a very common
mechanism that is used and uh then of
course you will have variables which are
your remember these are your weights and
and biases so for in our case there are
10 neurons and each neuron actually has
784 because each neuron takes all the
inputs if we go back to our slide here
actually every neuron takes all the 784
inputs right this is the first neuron it
has it receives all the 784 this is the
second neuron this also receives all the
78 so each of these inputs needs to be
multiplied with the weight and that's
what we are talking about here so these
are this is a a matrix of
784 values for each of the neurons and
uh so it is like a 10x 784 Matrix
because there are 10 neurons and uh
similarly there are biases now remember
I mentioned biases only one per neuron
so it is not one per input unlike the
weights so therefore there are only 10
biases because there are only 10 neurons
in this case so that is what we are
creating a variable for biases so this
is uh something little new in tensor
flow you will see unlike our regular
programming languages where everything
is a variable here the variables can be
of three different types you have
placeholders which are primarily used
for feeding data you have variables
which can change during the course of
computation and then a third type which
is not shown here are constant so these
are like fixed numbers all right so in a
regular programming language you may
have everything as variables or at the
most variables and constants but in tens
oflow you have three different types
placeholders variables and constants and
then you create what is known as a graph
so tensorflow programming consists of
graphs and tensors as I mentioned
earlier so this can be considered
ultimately as a tensor and then the
graph tells how to execute the whole
implementation so that the execution is
stored in the form of a graph and in
this case what we are doing is we are
doing a multiplication TF you remember
this TF was created as a tensorflow
object here one more level one more so
TF is available here now tensor flow has
what is known as a matrix multiplication
or matal function so that is what is
being used here in this case so we are
using the matrix multiplication of
tensor flow so that you multiply your
input values x with W right this is what
we were doing x w+ b you're just adding
B and this is in very similar to one of
the earlier slides where we saw Sigma XI
wi so that's what we are doing here
matrix multiplication is multiplying all
the input values with the corresponding
weights and then adding the bias so that
is the graph we created and then we need
to Define what is our loss function and
what is our Optimizer so in this case we
again use the tensor flows apis so tf.
NN softmax cross entropy with logits is
the uh API that we will use and reduce
mean is what is like the mechanism
whereby which says that you reduce the
error and Optimizer for doing deduction
of the error what Optimizer are we using
so we are using gradient descent
Optimizer we discussed about this in
couple of slides uh earlier and for that
you need to specify the learning rate
you remember we saw that there was a a
slide somewhat like this and then you
define what should be the learning rate
how fast you need to come down that is
the learning rate and this again needs
to be tested and tried and to find out
the optimum level of this learning rate
it shouldn't be very high in which case
it will not converge or shouldn't be
very low because it will in that case it
will take very long so you define the
optimizer and then you call the method
minimize for that Optimizer and that
will Kickstart the training process and
so far we've been creating the graph and
in order to actually execute that graph
we create what is known as a session and
then we run that session and once the
training is completed we specify how
many times how many iterations we want
it to run so for example in this case we
are saying Thousand Steps so that is a
exit strategy in a way so you specify
the exit condition so a training will
run for th000 iterations and once that
is done we can then evaluate the model
using some of the techniques shown here
so let us get into the code quickly and
see how it works so this is our Cloud
environment now you can install
tensorflow on your local machine as well
I'm showing this demo on our existing
Cloud but you can also install denlow on
your local machine and uh there is a
separate video on how to set up your Tor
flow environment you can watch that if
you want to install your local
environment or you can go for other any
cloud service like for example Google
Cloud Amazon or Cloud Labs any of these
you can use and U run and try the code
okay so it has got
started
we will
login all right so this is our deep
learning tutorial uh code and uh this is
our tensorflow
environment and uh so let's get started
the first we have seen a little bit of a
code walk through uh in the slides as
well now you will see the actual code in
action so the first thing we need to do
is is import tensorflow and then we will
import the data and we need to adjust
the data in such a way that the one hot
is encoding is set to True one hot
encoding right as I explained earlier so
in this case the label values will be
shown appropriately and if we just check
what is the type of the data so you can
see that this is a data sets python data
sets and if we check the number of
images the way it looks so this is how
it looks it is an array of type float 32
similarly the number if you want to see
what is the number
of training images there are 55,000 then
there are test images 10,000 and then
validation images 5,000 now let's take a
quick look at the data itself
visualization so we will use um matte
plot lip for this and um if we take take
a look at the shape now shape gives us
like the dimension of the tensors or or
or the arrays if you will so in this
case the training data set if we sees
the size of the training data set using
the method shape it says there are
55,000 and 55,000 by 784 so remember the
784 is nothing but the 28 by 28 28 into
28 so that is equal to 784 so that's
what it is uh showing now we can take
just uh one image and just see what is
the the first image and see what is the
shape so again size obviously it is only
784 similarly you can look at the image
itself the data of the first image
itself so this is how it it shows so
large part of it will probably be zeros
because as you can imagine in the image
only certain areas are written rest is U
black so that's why you will mostly see
zeros either it is black or white but
then there are these values are so the
values are actually they are scaled so
the values are between zero and one okay
so this is what you're seeing so certain
locations there are some values and then
other locations there are zeros so that
is how the data is stored and loaded if
we want to actually see what is the
value of the handwritten image if you
want to view it this is how you view it
so you create like do reshape and um
matplot lib has this um feature to show
you these images so we will actually use
the function called um IM show and then
if you pass this parameters
appropriately you will be able to see
the different images now I can change
the values in this position so which
image we are looking at right so we can
say if I want to see what is there in
maybe 5,000
right
so 5,000 has three similarly you can
just say five what is in five five as 8
what is in
[Music]
50 again eight so basically by the way
if you're wondering uh how I'm executing
this code shift enter in case you're not
familiar with jupyter notebooks shift
enter is how you execute each cell
individual cell and if you want to
execute the entire program you can go
here and say run all so that is
how this code gets executed and um here
again we can check what is the maximum
value and what is the minimum value of
this pixel values as I mentioned this is
it is scaled so therefore it is between
the values lie between 1 and zero now
this is where we create our
model the first thing is to create the
required placeholders and variables and
that's what we are doing here as we have
seen in the slides so we create one
placeholder and we create two variables
which is for the weights and biases
these two variables are actually
matrices so each variable has 784 by 10
values okay so one for this 10 is for
each neuron there are 10 neurons and 784
is for the pixel values inputs that are
given which is 28 into 28 and the biases
as I mentioned one for each neuron so
there will be 10 biases they are stored
in a variable by the name b and this is
the graph which is basically the
multiplication of these matrix
multiplication of X into W and then the
bias is added for each of the neurons
and the whole idea is to minimize the
error so let me just execute I think
this code is executed then we Define
what is our the Y value is basically the
label value so this is another
placeholder we had X as one placeholder
and Yore true as a second placeholder
and this will have values in the form of
uh 10 digigit 10 digigit uh arrays and
uh since we said one hot encoded the
position which has a one value indicates
what is the label for that particular
particular number all right then we have
cross entropy which is nothing but the
loss loss function and we have the
optimizer we have chosen gradient
descent as our Optimizer then the
training process itself so the training
process is nothing but to minimize the
cross entropy which is again nothing but
the loss function so we Define all of
this in the form of a graph so the up to
here remember what we have done is we
have not exactly executed any tensorflow
code till now we are just preparing the
graph the execution plan that's how the
tensorflow code works so the whole
structure and format of this code will
be completely different from how we
normally do programming so even with
people with programming experience may
find this a little difficult to
understand it and it needs quite a bit
of practice so you may want to view this
uh video also maybe a couple of times to
understand this flow because the way
tensorflow programming is done is
slightly different from the normal
programming some of you who let's say
have done uh maybe spark programming to
some extent will be able to easily
understand this uh but even in spark the
the programming the code itself is
pretty straightforward behind the scenes
the execution happen happens slightly
differently but in tens oflow even the
code has to be written in a completely
different way so the code doesn't get
executed uh in the same way as you have
written so that that's something you
need to understand and a little bit of
practice is needed for this so so far
what we have done up to here is creating
the variables and feeding the variables
and um or rather not feeding but setting
up the variables and uh the graph that's
all defining maybe the uh what kind of a
network you want to use for example we
want to use softmax and so on so you
have created the variables have to load
the data loaded the data viewed the data
and prepared everything but you have not
yet executed anything in tens of flow
now the next step is the execution in
tens of flow so the first step for doing
any execution in tensor flow is to
initialize the variables so anytime you
have any variables defined in your code
you have to run this piece of code
always so you need to basically create
what is known as a a node for
initializing so this is a node you still
are not yet executing anything here you
just created a node for the
initialization so let us go ahead and
create that and here onwards is where
you will actually execute your code uh
intensive flow and in order to execute
the code what you will need need is a
session tensor flow session so tf.
session will give you a session and
there are a couple of different ways in
which you can do this but one of the
most common methods of doing this is
with what is known as a with Loop so you
have a with tf. session as SS and with a
colon here and this is like a block
starting of the block and these
indentations tell how far this block
goes and this session is valid till this
block gets executed so that is the
purpose of creating this width block
this is known as a width block so with
tf. session as SS you say cs. run in it
now cs. run will execute a node that is
specified here so for example here we
are saying cs. run cess is basically an
instance of the session right so here we
are saying tf. session so an instance of
the session gets created and we are
calling that cess and then we run a node
within that one of the nodes in the
graph so one of the nodes here is in it
so we say run that particular node and
that is when the initialization of the
variables happens now what this does is
if you have any variables in your code
in our case we have W is a variable and
B is a variable so any variables that we
created you have to run this code you
have to run the initialization of these
variables otherwise you will get an
error okay so that is the that's what
this is doing then we within this width
block we specify a for Loop and we are
saying we want the system to iterate for
thousand steps and perform the training
that's what this for Loop does run
training for thousand
iterations and what it is doing
basically is it is fetching the data or
these images remember there are about
50,000 images but it cannot get all the
images in one shot because it will take
up a lot of memory and performance
issues will be there so this is a very
common way of Performing deep learning
training you always do in batches so we
have maybe 50,000 images but you always
do it in batches of 100 or maybe 500
depending on the size of your system and
so on and so forth so in this case we
are saying okay get me 100 uh images at
a time and get me only the training
images remember we use only the training
data for training purpose and then we
use test data for test purpose you must
be familiar with machine learning so you
must be aware of this but in case you
are not in machine learning also so not
this is not specific to deep learning
but in machine learning in general you
have what is known as training data set
and test data set your available data
typically you will be splitting into two
parts and using the training data set
for training purpose and then to see how
well the model has been trained you use
the test data set to check or test the
validity or the accuracy of the model so
that's what we are doing here and You
observe here that we we are actually
calling an mnist function here so we are
saying mnist train. nextt batch right so
this is the advantage of using mes
database because they have provided some
very nice helper functions which are
readily available otherwise this
activity itself we would have had to
write a piece of code to fetch this data
in batches that itself is a a lengthy
exercise so we can avoid all that if we
are using amness database and that's why
we use this for the initial learning
face okay so when we say fetch what it
will do is it will fetch the images into
X and the labels into Y and then you use
this batch of 100 images and you run the
training so cs. run basically what we
are doing here is we are running the
training mechanism which is nothing but
it passes this through the neural
network passes the images through the
neural network finds out what is the
output and if the output obviously the
initially it will be wrong so all that
feedback is given back to the neural
network and thereby all the W's and Bs
get updated till it reaches thousand
iterations in this case the exit
criteria is th000 but you can also
specify probably accuracy rate or
something like that for the as an exit
criteria so here it is it just says that
okay this particular image was wrongly
predicted so you need to update your
weights and biases that's the feedback
given to each neuron and that is run for
thousand iterations and typically by the
end of this thousand iterations the
model would have learned to recognize
these handwritten images obviously it
will not be 100% accurate okay so once
that is
done after so this happens for th000
iterations once that is done you then
test the accuracy of of these models by
using the test data set right so this is
what we are trying to do here the code
may appear a little complicated because
if you're seeing this for the first time
you need to understand uh the various
methods of tensor flow and so on but it
is basically comparing the output with
what has been what is actually there
that's all it is doing so you have your
test data and uh you trying to find out
what is the actual value and what is the
predicted value and seeing whether they
are equal or not TF do equal right and
how many of them are correct and so on
and so forth and based on that the
accuracy is uh calculated as well so
this is the accuracy and uh that is what
we are trying to see how accurate the
model is in predicting these uh numbers
or these digits okay so let us run this
this entire thing is in one cell so we
will have to just run it in one shot it
may take a little while let us see and
and uh not bad so it has finished the
thousand iterations and what we see here
as an output is the accuracy so we see
that the accuracy of this model is
around
91% okay now which is pretty good for
such a short exercise within such a
short time we got 90% accuracy however
in real life this is probably not
sufficient so there are other ways in to
increase that accuracy we will see
probably in some of the later tutorials
how to improve this accuracy how to
change maybe the hyper parameters like
number of neurons or number of layers
and so on and so forth and uh so that
this accuracy can be increased Beyond
90% hey there learner simply learn
brings you master's program in
artificial intelligence created in
collaboration with IBM to learn more
about this course you can find the
course Link in the description box below
we're going to Dive Right into what is
carass we'll also go all the way through
this into a couple of tutorials because
that's where you really learn a lot is
when you roll up your sleeves so we talk
about what is carass carass is a
highlevel deep learning API written in
Python for easy Implement implementation
of neural networks uses deep learning
Frameworks such as tensorflow pytorch
Etc as backend to make computation
faster and this is really nice because
as a program there is so much stuff out
there and it's evolving so fast it can
get confusing and having some kind of
high level order in there we can
actually view it and easily program
these different neural networks uh is
really powerful it's really powerful to
to um uh have something out really quick
and also be able to start testing your
models and seeing where you're going so
cross works by using complex deep
learning Frameworks such as tensorflow
pytorch um mlpl Etc as a back end for
fast computation while providing a
userfriendly and easy tolearn front end
and you can see here we have the carass
API uh specifications and under that
you'd have like TF carass for tensor
flow thano carass and so on and then you
have your tensor flow workflow that this
is all sitting on top
of and this is like I said it organizes
everything the heavy lifting is still
done by tensor flow or whatever you know
underlying package you put in there and
this is really nice because you don't
have to um dig as deeply into the heavy
end stuff while still having a very
robust package you can get up and
running rather quickly and it doesn't
distract from the processing time
because all the heavy lifting is done by
packages like tensor flow this is the
organization on top of it so the working
principle of carass uh the working
principle of carass is carass uses
computational graphs to express and
evaluate mathematical iCal
Expressions you can see here we put them
in blue they have the expression um
expressing complex problems as a
combination of simple mathematical
operators uh where we have like the
percentage or in this case in Python
that's usually your uh left your um
remainder or multiplication uh you might
have the operator of x uh to the power
of3 and it us is useful for calculating
derivatives by using uh back propagation
so if we're doing with neural networks
we send the error back back up to figure
out how to change it uh this makes it
really easy to do that without really
having not banging your head and having
to hand write everything it's easier to
implement distributed computation and
for solving complex problems uh specify
input and outputs and make sure all
nodes are
connected and so this is really nice as
you come in through is that um as your
layers are going in there you can get
some very complicated uh different
setups nowadays which we'll look at in
just a second and this just makes it
really easy to start spinning this stuff
up and trying out the different models
so when we look at Cross models uh cross
model you have a sequential model
sequential model is a linear stack of
layers where the previous layer leads
into the next
layer and this if you've done anything
else even like the sklearn with their
neural networks and propagation and any
of these setups this should look
familiar you should have your input
layer it goes into your layer one layer
two and to the output layer
and it's useful for simple classifier
decoder models and you can see down here
we have the model equals a coros
sequential and this is the actual code
you can see how easy it is uh we have a
layer that's dense your layer one has an
activation now they're using the Rao in
this particular example and then you
have your name layer one layer dense Ru
name Layer Two and so forth uh and they
just feed right into each other so it's
really easy just to stack them as you
can see here and it automatically takes
care of everything else for you and then
there's a functional model and this is
really where things are at this is new
make sure you update your cross or
you'll find yourself running this um
doing the functional model you'll run
into an error code because this is a
fairly new release and he uses
multi-input and multi-output model the
complex model which Forks into two or
more branches and you can see here we
have our image inputs equals your carass
input shape equals 32x 32x 3
you have your uh dense layers dense 64
activation Rao this should look similar
to what you already saw before uh but if
you look at the graph on the right it's
going to be a lot easier to see what's
going on you have two different
inputs uh and one way you could think of
this is maybe one of those is a small
image and one of those is a full-sized
image and that feedback goes into you
might feed both of them into one note
because it's looking for one thing and
then only into one node for the other
one and so you can start to get kind of
an idea that there's a lot of use for
this kind of split and this kind of
setup uh where we have multiple
information coming in but the
information's very different even though
it overlaps and you don't want it to
send it through the same neural network
um and they're finding that this trains
faster and is also has a better result
depending on how you split the data up
and and how you Fork the models coming
down and so in here we do have the two
complex uh models coming in uh we have
our image inputs which is a 32x 32 by3
or three channels or four if you're
having an alpha channel uh you have your
dense your layers dense is 64 activation
using the railu very common uh x equals
dense inputs X layers dense x64
activation equals reu x outputs equals
layers dense 10 X model equals coros
model inputs equals inputs outputs
equals outputs name equals ninc model uh
so we add a little name on there and
again this is this kind of split here
this is setting us up to um have the
input go into different areas so if
you're already looking at corus you
probably already have this answer what
are neural networks uh but it's always
good to get on the same page and for
those people who don't fully understand
neural networks to dive into them a
little bit or do a quick overview neural
networks are deep learning algorithms
modeled after the human brain they use
multiple neurons which are mathematical
operations to break down and solve
complex maical
problems and so just like the neuron one
neuron fires in and it fires out to all
these other neurons or nodes as we call
them and eventually they all come down
to your output layer and you can see
here we have the really standard graph
input layer a hidden layer and an output
layer one of the biggest parts of any
data processing is your data
pre-processing uh so we always have to
touch base on that with a neural network
like many of these models they're kind
of uh when you first start using them
they're like a black box you put your
data in you train it and you test it and
see how good it was and you have to
pre-process that data cuz bad data in is
uh bad outputs so in data pre-processing
we will create our own data examples set
with carass the data consists of a
clinical trial conducted on 2100
patients Ching from ages 13 to 100 with
a the patients under 65 and the other
half over 65 years of age we want to
find the possibility of a patient
experiencing side effects due to their
age and you can think of this in today's
world with uh coid uh what's going to
happen on there and we're going to go
ahead and do an example of that in our
uh life Hands-On like I said most of
this you really need to have hands on to
understand so let's go ahead and bring
up our anaconda and uh I'll open that up
and open up a Jupiter notebook for doing
the python code in now if you're not
familiar with those you can use pretty
much any of your uh setups I just like
those for doing demos and uh showing
people especially shareholders it really
helps because it's a nice visual so let
me go and flip over to our anaconda and
the Anaconda has a lot of cool to tools
they just added datal lore and IBM
Watson Studio clad into the Anaconda
framework but we'll be in the Jupiter
lab or Jupiter notebook um I'm do
jupyter notebook for this because I use
the lab for like large projects with
multiple pieces because it has multiple
tabs where the notebook will work fine
for what we're doing and this opens up
in our browser window because that's how
Jupiter notebook so Jupiter notebook is
set to run and we'll go under new create
a new Python 3 and uh it creates an
Untitled python we'll go ahead and give
this a title and we'll just call this uh
carass
tutorial and let's change that to
Capital there we go I'm going and just
rename that and the first thing we want
to go ahead and do is uh get some
pre-processing tools involved and so we
need to go ahead and import some stuff
for that like our numpy do some random
number
Generation Um I mentioned sklearn or
your s kit if you're installing sklearn
the sklearn stuff it's a s kit you want
to look
up that should be a tool of anybody who
is um doing data science if if you're
not if you're not familiar with the
sklearn
toolkit it's huge uh but there's so many
things in there that we always go back
to and we want to go ahead and create
some train labels and train samples uh
for training our
data and then just a note of what we're
we're actually doing in here uh let me
go ahead and change this this is kind of
of a fun thing you can do we can change
the code to
markdown and then markdown code is nice
for doing examples once you've already
built this uh our example data we're
going to do
experimental there we go experimental
drug was tested on 2100 individuals
between 13 to 100 years of age half the
participants are under 65 and 95% of
participants are under 65 experience no
side effects well 95% of particip over
65 um experience side effects so that's
kind of where we're starting at um and
this is just a real quick example
because we're going to do another one
with a little bit more uh complicated
information uh and so we want to go
ahead and
generate our setup uh so we want to do
for I in range and we want to go ahead
and create if you look here we have
random
integers train the labels of pin so
we're just creating some random data
uh let me go ahead and just run
that and so once we've created our
random data and if you if I mean you can
certainly ask for a copy of the code
from Simply learn they'll send you a
copy of this or you can zoom in on the
video and see how we went ahead and did
our train samples a pin um and we're
just using this I do this kind of stuff
all the time I was running a thing on uh
that had to do with errors following a
bell-shaped curve on uh a standard
distribu ution error and so what do I do
I generate the data on a standard
distribution error to see what it looks
like and how my code processes it since
that was the Baseline I was looking for
in this we're just doing uh uh
generating random data for our setup on
here and uh we could actually go in um
print some of the data up let's just do
this
print um we'll do
train
samples and we'll just do the the first
um five pieces of data in there to see
what that looks like and you can see the
first five pieces of data in our train
samples is 4985 41 68 19 just random
numbers generated in there that's all
that is uh and we generated
significantly more than that um let's
see 50 up here 1,000 yeah so there's
1,00 here 1,000 numbers we generated and
we could also if we wanted to find that
out we can do a quick uh print the
length of
it
and so or you could do a shape kind of
thing and if you're using
numpy although the link for this is just
fine and there we go it's actually 2100
like we said in the demo setup in
there and then we want to go ahead and
take our labels oh that was our train
labels we also did samples didn't
we uh so we could also print do the same
thing oh labels
um and let's change this
to
labels and
[Music]
labels and run that just to double check
and sure enough we have 2100 and they're
labeled one Z one0 one0 I guess that's
if they have symptoms or not one
symptoms uh 0 none and so we want to go
ahead and take our train labels and
we'll convert it into a number array and
the same thing with our samples and
let's go ahead and run that and we also
Shuffle uh this is just a neat feature
you can do in uh numpy right here put my
drawing thing on which I didn't have on
earlier um I can take the data and I can
Shuffle it uh so we have our so it's it
just randomizes it that's all that's
doing um we've already randomize it so
it's kind of an Overkill it's not really
necessary but if you're doing uh a
larger package where the data is coming
in and a lot of times it's organized
somehow and you want to randomize it
just to make sure that that you know the
input doesn't follow a certain pattern
uh that might create a bias in your
model and we go ahead and create a
scaler uh the scaler range uh minimum
Max scaler feature range 0 to
one uh then we go ahead and scale the uh
scaled train samples we're going to go
ahead and fit and transform the data uh
so it's nice and scaled and that is the
age uh so you can see up here we have 49
85 41 we're just moving that so it's
going to be uh between zero and one and
so this is true with any of your neural
networks you really want to convert the
data uh to zero and one otherwise you
create a bias uh so if you have like a
100 creates a bias
versus the math behind it gets really
complicated um if you actually start
multiplying stuff because a lot of
ication addition going on in there that
higher end value will eventually
multiply down and it will have a huge
bias as to how the model fits it and
then it will not fit as well and then
one of the fun things we can do in
Jupiter notebook is that if you have a
variable and you're not doing anything
with it it's the last one on the line it
will automatically
print um and we're just going to look at
the first five samples on here and just
going to print the first five samples
and you can see here we go 9 95. 791 so
everything's between zero and one and
that just shows us that we scaled it
properly and it looks good uh it really
helps a lot to do these kind of print
UPS halfway through uh you never know
what's going to go on
there I don't know how many times I've
gotten down and found out that the data
sent to me that I thought was scaled was
not and then I have to go back and track
it down and figure it out on there
uh so let's go ahead and create our
artificial neural
network and for doing that this is where
we start diving into tensor flow and
carass uh tensor
flow if you don't know the history of
tensor
flow it helps to uh jump into we'll just
use
Wikipedia careful don't quote Wikipedia
on these things because you get in
trouble uh but it's a good place to
start uh back in 2011 Google brain built
disbelief as a proprietary machine
learning setup tensor flow became the
open source for it uh so tensorflow was
a Google product and then it became uh
open sourced and now it's just become
probably one of the defos when it comes
for neural networks as far as where
we're at uh so when you see the
tensorflow
setup it it's got like a huge following
there are some other setups like a um
this pit under the sklearn has our own
little neural network uh but the
tensorflow is the most robust one out
there right now and carass sitting on
top of it makes it a very powerful tool
so we can leverage both the carass uh
easiness in which we can build a
sequential setup on top of tensor flow
and so in here we're going to go ahead
and do our input of tensor flow uh and
then we have the rest of this is all
carass here from number two down uh
we're going to import from tensorflow
the cross uh connection and then you
have your tensorflow cross models import
sequential it's a specific kind of model
we'll look at that in just a second if
you remember from the files that means
it goes from one layer to the next layer
to the next layer there's no funky
splits or anything like
that uh and then we have from tensorflow
Cross layers we're going to import our
activation and our dense
layer and we have our Optimizer at at um
this is a big thing to be aware of how
you optimize uh your data when you first
do it atoms as good as any atom is
usually uh there's a number of Optimizer
out there there's about uh there's a
couple main ons but atom is usually
assigned to bigger data uh it works fine
usually the lower data does it just fine
but atom is probably the mostly used but
there are some more out there and
depending on what you're doing with your
layers your different layers might have
different activ ations on them and then
finally down here you'll see um our
setup where we want to go ahead and use
the
metrics and we're going to use the
tensorflow cross metrics um for
categorical cross entropy uh so we can
see how everything performs when we're
done that's all that is um a lot of
times you'll see us go back and forth
between tensor flow and then pyit has a
lot of really good metrics also for
measuring these things um again it's the
end of the you know at the end end of
the story how good does your model do
and we'll go ahead and load all that and
then comes the fun part um I actually
like to spend hours messing with these
things and uh four lines of code you're
like ah you're G to spend hours on four
lines of code um no we don't spend hours
on four lines of code that's not what
we're talking about when I say spend
hours on four lines of code uh what we
have here I'm going to explain that in
just a second we have a model and it's a
sequential model if you remember
correctly we mentioned the sequential up
here where it goes from one layer to the
next and our first layer is going to be
your
input it's going to be uh what they call
D which is um usually it's just D and
then you have your input and your
activation um how many units are coming
in we have 16 uh what's the shape What's
the activation and this is where it gets
interesting um because we have in here
uh rilu
on two of these and soft Max activation
on one of these there are so many
different options for what these mean um
and how they function how does the ru
how does the softmax
function and they do a lot of different
things um we're not going to go into the
activations in here that is what really
you spend hours doing is looking at
these different
activations um and just some of it is
just U um almost like you're playing
with it like an artist you start getting
a feel for like a uh inverse tangent
activation or the tan
activation takes up a huge processing
amount uh so you don't see it a lot yet
it comes up with a better solution
especially when you're doing uh when
you're analyzing Word documents and
you're tokenizing the words and so
you'll see this shift from one to the
other because you're both trying to
build a better model and if you're
working on a huge data set um it'll
crash the system it'll just take too
long to process um and then you see
things like soft Max uh soft Max
generates an interesting um
setup where a lot of these when you talk
about Ru oops let me do this uh railu
there we go railu has um a setup where
if it's less than zero it's zero and and
then it goes up um and then you might
have what they call lazy uh setup where
it has a slight negative to it so that
the errors can translate better same
thing with softmax it has a slight
laziness to it so that errors translate
better all these little
details make a huge different on your
model um so one of the really cool
things about data science that I like is
you build your uh what they call you
build def fail and it's an interesting
uh design Des setup oops I forgot the
end of my code
here the concept to build a fail is you
want the model as a whole to work so you
can test your model
out so what you can do uh you can get to
the end and you can do your let's see
where was it overshot down here you can
test your test out the the quality of
your setup on there and see where did I
do my tensor flow oh here we go I it was
right above me here we go we start doing
your cross iny and stuff like that is
you need a full functional set of code
so that when you run
it you can then test your model out and
say hey it's either this model works
better than this model and this is why
um and then you can start swapping in
these models and so when I say I spend a
huge amount of time on pre-processing
data is probably 80% of your programming
time um well between those two it's like
8020 you'll spend a lot of time on the
models once you get the model down once
you get the whole code and the flow down
uh set depending on your data your
models get more and more robust as you
start experimenting with different
inputs different data streams and all
kinds of things and we can do a simple
model summary
here uh here's our sequential here's our
layer our output our
parameter this is one of the nice things
about carass is you just you can see
right here here's our sequential one
model boom boom boom boom everything's
set and clear and easy to read so once
we have our model built uh the next
thing we're going to want to do is we're
want to go ahead and train that
model and so the next step is of course
model
training and when we come in here this a
lot of times is just paired with the
model because it's so straightforward
it's nice to print out the model setup
so you can have a
tracking but here's our model model uh
the keyword in Cross is
compile Optimizer atom learning rate
another term right there that we're just
skipping right over that really becomes
the meat of um the setup is your
learning rate uh so whoops I forgot that
I had an arrow but I'll just underline
it a lot of times the learning rate set
to 0.0 uh set to 0.01 uh depending on
what you're doing this learn earning
rate um can overfit and underfit uh so
you'd want to look up I know we have a
number of tutorials out on overfitting
and underfitting that are really worth
reading once you get to that point in
understanding and we have our loss um
sparse categorical cross entropy so this
is going to tell carass how far to go
until it stops and then we're looking
for metrics of accuracy so we'll go
ahead and run that and now that we've
compiled our model we want to go ahead
and um run it fit it so here's our model
fit um we have our scaled train
samples our train labels our validation
split um in this case we're going to use
10% of the data for
validation uh batch size another number
you kind of play with not a huge
difference as far as how it works but it
does affect how long it takes to run and
it can also affect the bias a little bit
uh most of time though batch size is
between 10 to 100 um depending on just
how much data you're processing in there
we want to go ahead and Shuffle it uh
we're going to go through 30 epics and
uh put a verbos of two let me just go
and run this and you can see right here
here's our epic here's our training um
here's our loss now if you remember
correctly up here we set the loss see
where was it um compiled our
data there we go loss uh so it's likeing
at the sparse categorical cross entropy
this tells us that as it goes how how
how much um how how much does the um
error go down uh is the best way to look
at that and you can see here the lower
the number the better it just keeps
going down and vice versa accuracy we
want let's see where's my
accuracy value accuracy at the end uh
and you can see 619 697 4 it's going up
we want the accuracy would be ideal if
it made it all the way to one but we
also the loss is more important because
it's a balance um you can have 100%
accuracy and your model doesn't work
because it's overfitted uh again you w't
look up overfitting and underfitting
models and we went ahead and went
through uh 30 epics it's always fun to
kind of watch your code going um to be
honest I usually uh um the first time I
run it I'm like oh that's cool I get to
see what it does and after the second
time of running it I'm like I like to
just not see that and you can repress
those of course in your code uh repress
the warnings in the
printing and so the next step is going
to be building a test set and predicting
it now uh so here we go we want to go
ahead and build our test set and we have
uh just like we did our training
set a lot of times you just split your
your initial setup uh but we'll go ahead
and do a separate set on here and this
is just what we did above uh there's no
difference as far as
um the randomness that we're using to
build this set on here uh the only
difference is
that we already um did our scaler up
here well it doesn't matter because the
the data is going to be across the same
thing but this should just be just
transform down here instead of fit
transform uh because you don't want to
refit your D data um on your testing
data there we go now we're just
transforming it because you never want
to transform the test data um easy
mistake to make especially on an example
like this where we're not doing um you
know we're randomizing the data anyway
so it doesn't matter too much because
we're not expecting something
weird and then we went ahead and do our
predictions the whole reason we built
the model is we take our model we
predict and we're going to do here's our
xcal data batch size 10 verbose and now
we have our predictions in here and we
could go ahead and do a um oh we'll
print
predictions and then I guess I could
just put down predictions and five so we
can look at the first five of the
predictions and what we have here is we
have our a
and uh the prediction on this age versus
on what what we think it's going to be
what what we think is going to going to
have uh symptoms or not and the first
thing we notice is that's hard to read
because we really want a yes no answer
uh so we'll go ahead and just uh round
off the
predictions using the argmax um the
numpy argmax uh for predictions so just
goes to a
01 and if you remember this is a Jupiter
notebook so I don't have to put the
print I can just put in uh rounded
predictions and we'll just do the first
five and you can see here 0 1 0 0 0 so
that's what the predictions are that we
have coming out of this um is no
symptoms symptoms no symptoms symptoms
no symptoms and just as uh we were
talking about at the beginning we want
to go ahead and um take a look at this
there we go confusion matrixes for
accuracy check um most important part
when you get down down to the end of the
story how accurate is your model before
you go and play with the model and see
if you can get a better accuracy out of
it and for this we'll go ahead and use
the pyit um the SK learn metrics uh pyit
being where that comes from import
confusion Matrix uh some iteration tools
and of course a nice map plot library
that makes a big difference so it's
always nice to
um have a nice graph to look at um
pictures worth a th
words um and then we'll go ahead call it
CM for confusion Matrix y true equals
test labels y predict rounded
predictions and we'll go ahead and load
in our
cm and I'm not going to spend too much
time on the plotting um going over the
different plotting
code um you can spend uh like whole we
have whole tutorials on how to do your
different plotting on there uh but we do
have here is we're going to do a plot
confusion Matrix there's our CM our
classes normalized false title confusion
Matrix cmap is going to be in
blues and you can see here we have uh to
the nearest cmap titles all the
different pieces whether you put tick
marks or not the marks the classes the
color bar um so a lot of different
information on here as far as how we're
doing the printing of the of the
confusion Matrix you can also just dump
the confusion Matrix um into a caborn
and real quick get an output it's worth
knowing how to do all this uh when
you're doing a presentation to the
shareholders you don't want to do this
on the Fly you want to take the time to
make it look really nice uh like our
guys in the back did and uh let's go
ahead and do this forgot to put together
our CM plot labels we'll go and run
that and then we'll go ahead and call
the little the
definition for our mapping
and you can see here plot confusion
Matrix that's our the the little script
we just wrote and we're going to dump
our data into it um so our confusion
Matrix our classes um title confusion
Matrix and let's just go ahead and run
that and you can see here we have our
basic setup uh no side effects
195 had side effects uh 200 no side
effects that had side effects so we
predicted the 10 of them who actually
had side effects and that's pretty good
I mean I I don't know about you but you
know that's 5% error on this and this is
because there's 200 here that's where I
get 5% is uh divide these both by by two
and you get five out of a 100 uh you can
do the same kind of math up here not as
quick on the flight it's 15 and 195 not
an easily rounded number but you can see
here where they have 15
people who predicted to have no uh with
the no side effect effects but had side
effects kind of setup on there and these
confusion Matrix are so important at the
end of the day this is really where
where you show uh whatever you're
working on comes up and you can actually
show them hey this is how good we are or
not how messed up it
is so this was a uh I spent a lot of
time on some of the parts uh but you can
see here is really simple uh we did the
random generation of data but when we
actually built the model coming up here
uh here's our model
summary and we just have the layers on
here that we built with our model on
this and then we went ahead and trained
it and ran the prediction now we can get
a lot more complicated uh let me flip
back on over here because we're going to
do another uh demo so that was our basic
introduction to it we talked about the
uh oops here we go okay so implementing
a neural network with carass after
creating our samples and labels we need
to create our carass neural network
model we will be working with with a
sequential model which has three layers
and this is what we did we had our input
layer our hidden layers and our output
layers and you can see the input layer
uh coming in uh was the age Factor we
had our hidden layer and then we had the
output are you going to have symptoms or
not so we're going to go ahead and go
with something a little bit more
complicated um training our model is a
two-step process we first compile our
model and then we train it in our
training data set uh so we have
compiling compiling converts the code
into a form of understandable by
Machine we used the atom in the last
example a gradient descent algorithm to
optimize a model and then we trained our
model which means it let it uh learn on
training data uh and I actually had a
little backwards there but this is what
we just did is we if you remember from
our code we just had o let me go back
here
um here's our model that we
created
summarized uh we come down here and we
compile it so it tells it hey we're
ready to build this model and use it uh
and then we train it and this is the
part where we go ahead and fit our model
and and put that information in here and
it goes through the training on there
and of course we scaled the data which
was really important to do and then you
saw we did the creating a confusion
Matrix with caras um as we are
performing classifications on our data
we need a confusion Matrix to check the
results a confusion Matrix breaks down
the various misclassifications as well
as correct classifications to get the
accuracy um and so you can see here this
is what we did with the true positive
false positive true negative false
negative and that is what we went over
let me just scroll down
here on the end we printed it out and
you can see we have a nice print out of
our confusion Matrix uh with the true
positive false positive false negative
true negative and so the blue ones uh we
want those to be the the biggest numbers
because those are the better side and
then uh we have our false predictions on
here uh as far as this one so it had no
side effects but we predicted let's see
no side effects predicting side effects
and vice versa if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scaleup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more now uh saving
and loading models with carass we're
going to dive into a more complic ated
demo um and you're going to say oh well
that was a lot of complication before
well if you broke it down we randomized
some data we created the um carass setup
we compiled it we trained it we
predicted and we ran our Matrix uh so
we're going to dive into something a lot
a little bit more fun is we're going to
do a face mask detection with carass uh
so we're going to build a carass model
to check if a person is wearing a mask
or not in real time and this might be
important if you're at the front of a
store this is something today day which
is um might be very useful as far as
some of our you know making sure people
are
safe uh and so we're going to look at
mask and no mask and let's start with a
little bit on the
data and so in my data I have with a
mask you can see they just have a number
of images showing the people in masks
and again if you want some of this
information uh contact simply learn and
they can send you some of the
information as far as people with and
without masks so you can try out on your
own and this is just such a wonderful
example of this setup on here so before
I dive into the mask detection uh
talking about being in the current with
uh coid and seeing that people are
wearing masks this particular example I
had to go ahead and update to a python
3.8 version uh it might run in a 37 I'm
not sure I haven't I kind of skipped 37
and installed 38 uh so I'll be running
in a 3 python 38 uh and then you also
want to make sure your tensor flow is up
to date because the um they call
functional uh layers with that's where
they split if you remember correctly
from back uh oh let's take a look at
this remember from here the functional
model and a functional layer allows us
to feed in the different layers into
different you know different nodes into
different layers and split them uh very
powerful tool very popular right now in
the edge of where things are with neural
networks and creating a better model so
I've upgraded to python 3.8 and let's go
ahead and open that up and go through uh
our next example which includes uh
multiple layers um programming it to
recognize whether someone wears a mask
or not and then uh saving that model so
we can use it in real time so we're
actually almost a full um end to endend
development of a product here uh of
course this is a very simplified version
and there'd be a lot more to it you'd
also have to do like uh recognizing
whether it's someone's face or not all
kinds of other things go into this so
let's go ahead and jump into that code
and we'll open up a new Python 3 oops
Python 3 it's working on it there we
go um and then we want to go ahead and
train our mask we'll just call this
train
mask and we want to go ahead and train
mask and save it uh so it's it's uh save
mask train mask detection not to be
confused with masking data a little bit
different we're actually talking about a
physical mask on your
face and then from the cross standpoint
we got a lot of imports to do here and
I'm not going to dig too deep on the
Imports uh we're just going to go ahead
and notice a few of them uh so we have
in here oops let me go all D there we go
have something to draw with a little bit
here we have our uh image
processing and the image processing
right here me underline that uh deals
with how do we bring images in because
most images are like a a square grid and
then each value in there has three
values for the three different colors uh
cross and tensorflow do a really good
job of uh working with that so you don't
have to do all the heavy list and
figuring out what's going to go on uh
and we have the mobile net average
pooling 2D um this again is how do we
deal with the images and pulling them uh
dropout's a cool thing worth looking up
if you haven't when as you get more and
more into carass and tensor flow uh
it'll Auto drop out certain nodes that
way you'll get a better um the notes
just kind of die uh they find that they
actually create more of a bias and a
help and they also add processing time
so they remove them um and then we have
our flatten that's where you take that
huge array with the three different
colors and you find a way to flatten it
so it's just a one-dimensional array
instead of a 2X two
by3 uh DSE input we did that in the
other one so that should look a little
familiar oops there we go our input um
our model again these are things we had
on the last one here's our Optimizer
with our
atom um we have some pre-processing on
the input that goes along with bringing
in the data in uh more pre-processing
with image to array loading the image um
this stuff is so nice it looks like a
lot of work you have to import all these
different modules in here but the truth
is is it does everything for you you're
not doing a lot of pre-processing you're
letting the software do the
pre-processing um and we're going to be
working with the setting something to
categorical again that's just a
conversion from a number to a category
uh 01 doesn't really mean anything it's
like true false um label binarized the
same thing uh we're changing our labels
around and then there's our train test
split classification report um our IM
utilities let me just go ahead and
scroll down here Notch for these this is
something a little different going on
down here this is not part of the uh
tensor flow or the SK learn this is the
S kit setup and tensor or flow above uh
the path this is part of um open CV and
we'll actually have another tutorial
going out with the open CV so if you
want to know more about Open CV you'll
get a glance on it in uh this software
especially the ne the second piece when
we reload up the data and hook it up to
a video camera we're going to do that on
this round um but this is part of the
open CV thing and you'll see CV2 is
usually how that's referenced um but the
IM utilities has to do with how do you
wrote tape pictures around and stuff
like that uh and resize them and then
the map plot library for plotting
because it's nice to have a graph tells
us how good we're doing and then of
course our numpy numbers array and just
a straight OS access wow so that was a
lot of imports uh like I said I'm not
going to spend I spent a little time
going through them uh but we didn't want
to go too much into
them and then I'm going to create um
some variables that we need to go ahead
and initialize we have the learning rate
number of epics to train for and the
batch size and if you remember correctly
we talked about the learning rate uh to
the
-4.1 um a lot of times it's 0.001 or
0.001 usually it's in that uh variation
depending on what you're doing and how
many epics and they kind of play with
the epics the epics is how many times
are we going to go through all the
data now I have it as two um the actual
setup is for 20 and 20 works great the
reason I have it for two is it takes a
long time to process one of the
downsides of
Jupiter is that Jupiter isolates it to a
single kernel so even though I'm on an8
core processor uh with 16 dedicated
threads only one thread is running on
this no matter what so it doesn't matter
uh so it takes a lot longer to run even
though um tensor flow really scals up
nicely and the batch size is how many
pictures do we load at once in process
again those are numbers you have to
learn to play with depending on your
data and what's coming in and the last
thing we want to go ahead and do is
there's a directory with a data set
we're going to
run uh and this just has images of masks
and not
masks and if we go in here you'll see
data
set um and you have pictures with mass
they're just images of people with mass
on their face uh and then we have the
opposite let me go back up here without
masks so it's pretty straightforward
they look kind of a skew because they
tried to format them into very similar
uh setup on there so they're they're
mostly squares you'll see some that are
slightly different on here and that's
kind of an important thing to do on a
lot of these data sets get them as close
as you can to each other and we'll we
actually will run in the in this
processing of images up here and the
cross uh layers and importing and and
dealing with images it does such a
wonderful job of converting these that a
lot of it we don't have to do a whole
lot with
uh so you have a couple things going on
there and so uh we're now going to be
this is now loading the um images and
let me see and we'll go ahead and uh
create data and labels here's our um uh
here's the features going in which is
going to be our pictures and our labels
going out and then for categories in our
list directory directory and if you
remember I just flashed that at you it
had uh uh face mask or or no face mask
mask those are the two options and we're
just going to load into that we're going
to pin the image itself and the labels
so we're just create a huge array uh and
you can see right now this could be an
issue if you had more data at some point
um thankfully I have a a 32 gig hard
drive or
Ram even that does you could do with a
lot less of that probably under 16 or
even 8 gigs would easily load all this
stuff um and there's a conversion going
on in here I told you about how we are
going to convert the size of the image
so it resizes all the images that way
our data is all identical the way it
comes
in and you can see here with our labels
we have without mask without mask
without mask uh the other one would be
with mask those are the two that we have
going in
there uh and then we need to change it
to the one hot
encoding and this is going to take our
um um up here we had what was it label
and data uh we want the labels uh to be
categorical so we're going to take
labels and change it to categorical and
our labels then equal a categorical list
uh we'll run that and again if we do uh
labels and we just do the last or the
first 10 let's do the last 10 just
because um minus 10 to the end there we
go just so we can see what the other
side looks like we now have one that
means they have a mask one Zer one zero
so on
uh one being they have a mask and zero
no mask and if we did this in
Reverse I just realized that this might
not make sense if you've never done this
before let me run this
01 so zero is uh do they have a mask on
zero do they not have a mask on one so
this is the same as what we saw up here
without mask one equals uh um the second
value is without mask so with masks
without mask uh and that's just a with
any of your data
processing we can't really zero if you
have a 01
output uh it causes issues as far as
training and setting it up so we always
want to use a one hot encoder if the
values are not actual uh linear Val or
regression values they're not actual
numbers if they represent a
thing so now we need to go ahead and do
our train X test X train y test y um
train split test data and we'll go ahead
and make sure it's going to be uh random
and we'll take 20% of it for testing and
the rest for um setting it up as far as
training their model this is something
that's become so cool when they're
training these Set uh they realize we
can augment the data what does augment
mean well if I rotate the data around
and I zoom in I zoom out I rotate it um
share it a little bit flip it
horizontally um fill mode as I do all
these different things to the data it um
is able to it's kind of like increasing
the number of samples I have uh so if I
have all these perfect samples what
happens when we only have part of the
face or the face is tilted sideways or
all those little shifts cause a problem
if you're doing just a standard set of
data so we're going to create an augment
and our image data generator um which is
going to rotate zoom and do all kinds of
cool thing and this is worth looking up
this image data generator and all the
different features it has um a lot of
times I'll the first time through my
models I'll leave that out so I want to
make sure there's a thing we call build
the fail which is just cool to know you
build the whole process and then you
start adding these different things in
uh so you can better train your model
and so we go and run this and then we're
going to load
um and then we need to go ahead and you
probably would have gotten an error if
you hadn't put this piece in right here
um I haven't run it myself cuz the guys
in the back did this uh we take our base
model and one of the things we want to
do is we want to do a mobile net
V2 um and this what we this is a big
thing right here include the top equals
false a lot of data comes in with a
label on the top row uh so we want to
make sure that that is not the case uh
and then the construction the head of
the model that will be placed on the top
of the base model uh we want to go ahead
and set that
up and you'll see a warning here I'm
kind of ignoring the warning because it
has to do with the uh size of the
pictures and the weights for input shape
um so they'll it'll switch things to
defaults just saying hey we're going to
Auto shape some of this stuff for you
you should be aware that with this kind
of imagery we're already augmenting it
by moving it around and flipping it and
doing all kinds of things to it uh so
that's not a bad thing in this but
another data it might be if you're
working in a different
domain and so we're going to go back
here and we're going to have we have our
base model we're going to do our head
model equals our base model
output um and what we got here is we
have an average pooling 2D pool size 77
head model um head model flatten so
we're flattening the data uh so this is
all processing and flattening
the images and the pooling has to do
with some of the ways it can process
some of the data we'll look at that a
little bit when we get down to the lower
level in this processing it um and then
we have our den we've already talked a
little bit about a den just what you
think about and then the head model has
a Dropout of
0.5 uh what we can do with a
Dropout the Dropout says that we're
going to drop out a certain amount of
nodes while training uh so so when you
actually use the model you will use all
the notes but this drops certain ones
out and it helps stop biases from up
forming uh so it's really a cool feature
on here they discovered this a while
back uh we have another dense mode and
this time we're using soft Max
activation lots of different activation
options here softmax is a real popular
one for a lot of things U so is
Ru and you know there we could do a
whole talk on activation formulas um and
why what their different uses are and
how they work when you first start out
you'll you'll use mostly the ru and the
softmax for a lot of them uh just
because they're they're some of the
basic setups it's a good place to
start uh and then we have our model
equals model inputs equals base model.
input outputs equals head model so again
we're still building our model here
we'll go ahead and run
that and then we're going to Loop over
all the layers in the base model and
freeze them so they will will not be
updated during the first training
process uh so for layer and base model
layers layers. trable equals
False A lot of times when you go through
your data um you want to kind of jump in
partway through um I I'm not sure why in
the back they did this for this
particular example um but I do this a
lot when I'm working with series and and
specifically in stock data I want it to
iterate through the first set of 30 Data
before it does anything
um I would have to look deeper to see
why they froze it on this particular one
and then we're going to compile our
model uh so compiling the model
atom andit layer Decay um initial
learning rate over epics and we go ahead
and compile our loss is going to be the
binary cross entropy which we'll have
that print out Optimizer for opt
metric's accuracy same thing we had
before not a huge jump as far as as um
the previous
code and then we go ahead and we've gone
through all this and now we need to go
ahead and fit our model uh so train the
head of the network print info training
head
run now I skipped a little time because
it you'll see the run time here is um at
80 seconds per epic takes a couple
minutes for it to get through on a
single
kernel one of the things I want you to
notice on here while we're while it's
finishing the
processing is that we have up here our
augment going on so anytime the train X
and train y go in there's some
Randomness going on there and is
jiggling it around what's going into our
setup uh of course we're batch sizing it
uh so it's going through whatever we set
for the batch values how many we process
at a time and then we have the steps per
epic uh the train X the batch size
validation data here's our test X and
Test Y where we're sending that
in uh and that's again it's validation
one of the important things to know
about validation is our um when both our
training data and our test data have
about the same accuracy that's when you
want to stop that means that our model
isn't biased if you have a higher
accuracy on your uh testing you know
you've trained it and your accurac se's
higher on your actual test data then
something in there is probably uh has a
bias and it's overfitted uh so that's
what this is really about right here
with the validation data and validation
steps so it looks like it's let me go
ahead and see if it's done processing
looks like we've gone ahead and gone
through two epics again you could run
this through about 20 with this amount
of data and it would give you a nice
refined uh model at the end we're will
to stop at two because I really don't
want to sit around around all afternoon
and I'm running this on a single thread
so now that we've done this we're going
to need to evaluate our model and see
how good it is and to do that we need to
go ahead and make our
predictions um these are predictions on
our test X to see what it thinks are
going to be uh so now it's going to be
evaluating the network and then we'll go
ahead and go down here and we want need
to uh turn the index in remember it's
it's either zero or one it's uh 01 01 so
you have two outputs uh not wearing uh
wearing a mask not wearing a mask and so
we need to go ahead and take that
argument at the end and change those
predictions to a zero or one coming out
uh and then to finish that off we want
to go ahead and let me just put this
right in here and do it all in one shot
we want to show a nicely formatted
classification report so we can see what
that looks like on here and there we
have it we have our Precision uh it's
97% with a mask there's our F1 score
support without a mask
97% um so that's pretty high high setup
on there you know three people are going
to sneak into the store who are without
a mask and that thinks they have a mask
and there's going to be three people
with a mask that's going to flag the
person at the front to go oh hey look at
this person you might not have a mask um
that's if I guess if it's a set up in
front of a store um so there there you
have it and of course one of the other
cool things about this is if someone's
walking into the store and you take
multiple pictures of them um you know
this is just an it it would be a way of
flagging and then you can take that
average of those pictures and make sure
they match or don't match if you're on
the back end and this is an important
step because we're GNA this is just cool
I love doing this stuff uh so we're
going to go ahead and take our model and
we're going to save it uh so model save
Mass detector. model we're going to give
it a name uh we're going to save the
format um in this case we're going to
use the H5
format and so this model we just
programmed has just been saved uh so now
I can load it up into say another
program what's cool about this is let's
say I want to have somebody work on the
other part of the program well I just
saved the model they upload the model
now they can use it for whatever and
then if I get more information uh and we
start working with that at some
point I might want to update this model
um make a better model and this is true
of so many things where I take this
model and maybe I'm uh running a
prediction on uh making money for a
company and as my model gets
better I want to keep updating it and
then it's really easy just to push that
out to the actual end user uh and here
we have a nice graph you can see the
training loss and accuracy as we go
through the epics uh we only did the you
know only shows just the one Epic coming
in here but you can see right here as
the uh
um value loss train accuracy and value
accuracy starts switching and they start
converging and you'll hear converging
this is a convergence they're talking
about when they say you're you're um I
know when I work in the um s kit with
sklearn neural networks this is what
they're talking about a convergence is
our loss and our accuracy come together
and also up here and this is why I'd run
it more than just two epics as you can
see they still haven't converged all the
way uh so that would be a cue for me to
keep
going but what we want to do is we want
to go ahead and create a new Python
program and we just did our train mask
so now we're going to go ahead and
import that and use it and show you in a
live action um get a view of uh both
myself in the afternoon along with my
background of an office which is in the
middle still of construction for another
month and we'll call this uh
mask
detector and then we're going to grab a
bunch of um a few items coming
in uh we have our um mobilet V2 import
pre-processing input we're still going
to need that um we still have our tensor
floral image to array we have our load
model that's where most of the stuff's
going on this is our CV2 or open CV
again I'm not going to dig too deep into
that we're going to flash a little open
CV code at you uh and we actually have a
tutorial on that coming out um our numpy
array our IM utilities which is part of
the open CV or CV2
setup uh and then we have of course time
and just our operating system so those
are the things we're going to go ahead
and set up on here and then we're going
to create
this takes just a
moment our module here which is going to
do all the heavy
lifting uh so we're going to detect and
predict a mask we have frame face net
Mass net these are going to be generated
by our open CV we have our frame coming
in and then we want to go ahead and and
create a mask around the face it's going
to try to detect the face and then set
that up so we know what we're going to
be processing through our
model um and then there's a frame shape
here this is just our height versus
width that's all HW stands for um
they've called it blob which is a CV2
DNN blob form image frame so this is
reformatting this Frame that's going to
be coming in literally from my camera
and we'll show you that in a minute that
little piece of code that shoots that in
here uh and we're going to pass the blob
through the the network and obtain the
face
detections uh so faet do set inport blob
detections faet forward print detections
shape uh so these is this is what's
going on here this is that model we just
created we're going to send that in
there and I'll show you in a second
where that is but it's going to be under
faet uh and then we go ahead and
initialize our list of faces their
corresponding locations and the list of
predictions from our fa mask Network
we're going to Loop over the
detections and this is a little bit more
work than you think um as far as looking
for different faces what happens if you
have a fa a crowd of faces um so We're
looping through the detections and the
shapes going through here and
probability associated with the
detection uh here's our confidence of
detections we're going to filter out
weak detection by ensuring the
confidence is greater than the minimum
confidence uh so we've said it remember
0 to one so 0 five would be our minimal
confidence probably is pretty good um
and then we're going to put in compute
bounding boxes for the object if I'm
zipping through this it's because we're
going to do an open CV and I really want
to stick to just the carass
part and so I'm I'm just kind of jumping
through all this code you can get a copy
of this code from Simply learn and take
it apart or look for the open CV coming
out and we'll create a box uh the box
sets it around the
image ensure the bounding boxes fall
within dimensions of the
frame uh so we create a box around
what's going to what we hope is going to
be the face extract the face Roi convert
it from BGR to RGB
Channel again this is an open CV issue
not really an issue but it has to do
with the order um I don't know how many
times I've forgotten to check the order
colors when working with open CV C it's
all kinds of fun things when red becomes
blue and blue becomes red uh then we're
going to go ahead and resize it process
it frame it uh face frame setup again
the face the CBT color we're going to
convert it uh we're going to resize it
image to array pre-process the input uh
pin the face locate face. x.y and x boy
that was just a huge amount and I
skipped over a ton of it but the bottom
line is we're building a box around the
face and that box cuz the open CV does a
decent job of finding the face and that
box is going to go in there and see hey
does this person have a mask on
it uh and so that's what that's what all
this is doing on here and then finally
we get down to this where it says
predictions equals mass net. predict
faces batch size
32 uh so these different images are
where we're guessing where the face is
are then going to go through an generate
an array of faces if you will and we're
going to look through and say does this
face have a mask on it and that's what's
going right here is our prediction
that's the big thing that we're working
for and then we return the locations and
the predictions the locations just tells
where on the picture it is and then the
um prediction tells us what it is is it
a mask or is it not a mask all right so
we've loaded that all up so we're going
to load our serialized face detector
model from dis um and we have our the
that it was saved in obviously you're
going to put it in a different path
depending on where you have it or
however you want to do it and how you
saved it on the last one where we
trained it uh then we have our weights
path um and so finally our face net here
it is equals CB2 DNN read net uh protot
text path weights path and we're going
to load that up on here so let me go
ahead and run
that and then we also need to I'll just
put it right down here I always hate
separating these things in there
um and then we're going to load the
actual mass detector model from dis this
is the the the model that we saved so
let's go ahead and run that on there
also so this is pulling in all the
different pieces we need for our model
and then the next part is we're going to
create open up our video uh and this is
just kind of fun because it's all part
of the open
CV video
setup and let me just put this all in as
one there we go uh so we're going to go
ahead and open up our video we're going
to start it and we're going to run it
until we're
done and this is where we get some real
like kind of liveaction stuff which is
fun this is what I like working about
with images and videos is that when you
start working with images and videos
it's all like right there in front of
you it's Visual and you can see what's
going on uh so we're going to start our
video streaming this is grabbing our
video stream Source zero
start uh that means it's C grabbing my
main camera I have hooked up
um and then you know starting video
you're going to print it out here's our
video Source equals zero start Loop over
the frames from the video
stream oops a little redundancy there um
let me
close I'll just leave it that's how they
had it in the code so uh so while true
we're going to grab the frame from the
threaded video stream and resize it to
have the maximum width of 400 pixels so
here's our frame we're going to it uh
from our visual uh stream we're going to
resize
it and then we have a returning remember
we returned from the our procedure the
location and the prediction so detect
and predict mask we're sending it the
frame we're sending it the face net and
the mass net so we're sending all the
different pieces that say this is what's
going through on
here and then it returns our location
and predictions and then for our box and
predictions in the location and
predictions um and the boxes is again
this is an open CV set that says hey
this is a box coming in from the
location um because you have the two
different points on there and then we're
going to unpack the box and predictions
and we're going to go ahead and do mask
without a mask equals
prediction we're going to create our
label no mask and create color if the
label equals mask L
00225 and you know this is going to make
a lot more sense when I hit the run
button here uh but we have the
probability of the label we're going to
display the label and bounding box
rectangle on the output
frame uh and then we're going to go
ahead and show the output from the frame
CV2 IM show frame frame and then the key
equals CV2 weight key one we're just
going to wait till the next one comes
through from our
feed and we're going to do this until we
hit the stop button pretty much so are
you ready for this let's see if it works
we've distributed our uh our model we've
loaded it up into our distributed uh
code here we've got it hooked into our
camera and we're going to go ahead and
run
it and there it goes it's going to be
running and we can see the data coming
down here and we're waiting for the
popup and there I am in my office with
my funky headset
on uh and you can see in the background
my unfinished wall and it says up here
no mask oh no I don't have a mask on uh
I wonder if I cover my mouth what
happened uh you can see my no
mask goes down a little bit I wish I
brought a mask into my office it's up at
the house but you can see here that this
says you know there's a 95 98% chance
that I don't have a mask on and it's
true I don't have a mask on right now
and this could be distributed this is
actually an excellent little piece of
script that you could start you know you
install somewhere on a a video feed on a
on a security camera or something and
then you'd have this really neat uh
setup saying hey do you have a mask on
when you enter a store or public
transportation or whatever it is where
they're required to wear a mask uh let
me go and stop
that now if you want a copy of this uh
code definitely give us a hauler we will
be going into open CV in another one so
I skipped a lot of the open CV um code
in here as far as going into detail
really focusing on the carass uh saving
the model uploading the model and then
processing a streaming video through it
so you can see that the model works we
actually have this working model that
hooks into the video
camera which is just pretty cool and a
lot of
fun so I told you we're going to dive in
and really Roll Up Our Sleeve and do a
lot of coing today uh we did the basic
uh demo up above for just pulling in a
carass and then we went into a cross
model uh where we pulled in data to see
whether someone was wearing a mask or
not so very useful in today's world as
far as far as a fully running
application welcome to the neural
network tutorial my name is Richard
kersner I'm with the simply learn team
what's in it for you well today we're
going to cover what is a neural network
what can neural networks do how does a
neural network work types of neural
networks and then we're going to jump
into a use case to classify between the
photos of dogs and cats and we'll do
that on the carass with the tensor flow
in the back but it's a python script so
that's always my favorite part as when
we dive into the actual script so what
is a neural network so hi guys I heard
you want to know what a neural network
is here we have uh looks like he just
went shopping at a red tag sale my
robot's back so as a matter of fact you
have been using neural network on a
daily basis in today's world is just
amazing how much we use our new
technology we're not even aware of it
when you ask your Mobile Assistant to
perform a search for you you know like
saying uh your Google or Siri or whoever
you use Amazon web so self-driving cars
so that's the newest thing coming out
they're just now trying to make those
legal in different states in the US and
around the world even in the UK they
know have a self-driving car is going up
and down the street it's pretty amazing
these are all neural network driven
computer games use it a lot of computer
games are driven by neural networks in
the back end as part of the game system
and how it adjusts to the players and
it's also used in processing the map
images on your phone so every time you
do a navigation someplace and it opens
it up they now use neural networks to
help you find the quickest way to get
there neural network a neural network is
a system or Hardware that is designed to
operate like a human brain in today's
development this is so important to
understand because we don't have
anything else to compare it to I'm sure
someday in the future the computer will
redefine or the neural network or the AI
artificial intelligence will redefine
what these mean but as far as we can
today's world and today's commercial
development we have to compare it to
what humans do so it's we want to
compare and how it operates to a human
brain and how it solves problems like a
human does what can a neural network do
and really we're just going to dive in
deeper to what we just covered and look
at other examples so what can a neural
network do well let's list out the
things neural networks can do for you
translate text boy we got Google
translate and Microsoft has their own
translate they have some really cool
they actually have an earpiece it's
supposed to start translating as you
talk what a cool technology what a cool
time to live identif faces can you
imagine all the uses for facial
identification in the case of our sample
or our code that we're going to look at
later will be identifying dogs and cats
so not quite as detailed as
understanding whose face belongs to who
I I'm waiting for the Google Glasses to
come out so I can see who's who and
identify faces as I'm walking around
have a little name tag over them not out
there yet but boy we are close we could
identify the faces and they have all
kinds of Technologies to bring that
information back to us recognize speeech
goes along with the translate text so
now as you're talking into your
assistant it can use that to do commands
turn lights on all kinds of things you
can do with recognizing speech read had
written text they're starting to
translate all these old text documents
that they've had in storage instead of
doing it individually where somebody's
going through each text by thems in a
room picture like an old Raiders of the
Lost Arc theme where he's in the back
you know archaeologist studying the text
now it's fed into a computer they take a
picture they even use neural networks to
take a scroll that is so messed up that
they can't undo the scroll and they
x-ray it and then they use that x-ray to
translate the text off of it without
ever opening the scroll I mean just way
cool stuff they're starting to do with
all this and of course control robots
what would be a neural network without
bringing in the robots and we have our
own favorite robot in the middle who
goes to our red tag cell and goes
shopping for us so you know these are
just a few of the wonderful things that
neural networks are being applied to
it's such an infant state agage
technology what a wonderful time to jump
in and there are a lot of other things
that goes into I mean we could spend
just forever talking about all the
different applications from business to
whatever you could even imagine they're
now applying neural networks to help us
understand so now we talked a little bit
about all the cool things you can do
with a neural network let's dive in and
say how does a neural network work so
now we've come far enough to understand
how neural network works let's go ahead
and walk through this in a nice
graphical representation they usually
describe a neural network is having
different layers and you'll see that
we've identified a Green Layer an orange
layer and a red layer the Green Layer is
the input so you have your data coming
in it picks up the input signals and
passes them to the next layer the next
layer does all kinds of calculations and
feature extraction it's called The
Hidden layer a lot of times there's more
than one hidden layer we're only showing
one in this uh picture but we'll show
you how it looks like in a more detail
in a little bit and then finally we have
an output layer this layer delivers the
f final result so the only two things we
see is the input layer and the output
layer now let's make use of this neural
network and see how it works wonder how
traffic cameras identify Vehicles
registration plate on the road to detect
speeding vehicles and those breaking the
law they got me going through a red
light the other day well last month
that's like the horrible thing they send
you this picture of you and all your
information cuz they pulled it up off of
your license plate and your picture that
shouldn't have gone through the red
light so here we are and we have an
image of a car and you can see the
license plates on there so let's
consider the image of this vehicle and
find out what's on the number plate the
picture itself is 28x 28 pixels and the
image is fed as an input to identify the
registration plate each neuron has a
number called activation that represents
the grayscale value of the corresponding
pixel range and we range it from 0o to
one one for a white pixel and zero for a
black pixel and you can see down here we
have an example where one of the pixels
is registered as like 082 meaning it's
probably pretty dark each neuron is lit
up when its activation is close to one
so as we get closer to black on white we
can really start seeing the details in
there and you can see again the pixel
shows this one up there it's like part
of the car and so it lights up so pixels
in the form of arrays are fed to the
input layer and so we see here the pixel
of a car image fed as an input and
you're going to see that the input layer
which is green is one dimension while
our image is twood dimension now when we
look at our setup that we're programming
in Python it has a cool feature that
automatically does the work for us if
you're working with an older neural
network pattern package you then convert
each one of those rows so it's all one
array so you'd have like Row one and
then just tack row two onto the end you
can almost feed the image directly into
some of these neural networks the key is
though is that if you're using a 28x 28
and you get a picture of this 30x30
shrink the 30x30 down to fit the 28x 28
so you can't increase a number of input
in this case Green Dots it's very
important to remember when you're
working on neural networks and let's
name the inputs X1 X2 X3 respectively so
each one of those represents one of the
pixels coming in and the input layer
passes it to the hidden layer and you
can see here we now have two hidden
layers in this image in the orange and
each one of those pixels connects to
each one of those hidden layers and the
interconnections are assigned weights at
random so they get these random weights
that come through if X1 lights up then
it's going to be X1 * this weight going
into the hidden layer and we sum those
weights the weights are multiplied with
the input signal and a bias is added to
all of them so as you can see here we
have X1 comes in and it actually goes to
all the different hidden layer nodes or
in this case uh whatever you want to
call them network setup the orange dots
and so you take the value of X1 you
multiply it by the weight for the next
hidden layer so X1 goes to Hidden layer
one X1 goes to Hidden layer 2 X1 goes
hidden layer one node 2 hidden layer one
node three and so on and the bias a lot
of times s they just put the bias in as
like another Green Dot or another orange
Dot and they give the bias a value one
and then all the weights go in from the
bias into the next node so the bias can
change we always just remember that you
need to have that bias in there there's
things that can be done with it
generally most the packages out there
control that for you so you don't have
to worry about figuring out what the
bias is but if you ever dive deep into
neural networks you got to remember
there's a bias or the answer won't come
out correctly the weighted sum of the
input is add as an input to the
activation function to decide which
nodes to Fire and for feature extraction
as a signal flows within the hidden
layers the weighted sum of inputs is
calculated and is fed to the activation
function in each layer to decide which
nodes to fire so here's our feature
extraction of the number plate and you
can see these are still hidden nodes in
the middle and this becomes important
we're going to take a little detour here
and look at the activation function so
we're going to dive just a little bit
into the math so you can start to
understand where some of the games go on
when you're playing playing with neural
networks in your programming so let's
look at the different activation
functions before we move ahead here's
our friendly red tag shopping robot and
so one is a sigmoid function and the
sigmoid function which is 1 over 1 + e
to Theus X takes the x value and you can
see where it generates almost a zero and
almost a one with a very small area in
the Middle where it crosses over and we
can use that value to feed into another
function so if it's really uncertain it
might have a 0.1 or 0 2 or3 but for the
most part it's going to be really close
to one and really close to this case 0o
0 to one the threshold function so if
you don't want to worry about the
uncertainty in the middle you just say
oh if x is greater than or equal to zero
if not then uh X is zero so it's either
zero or one really straightforward
there's no in between in the middle and
then you have the what they call the ru
relo function and you can see here where
it puts out the value but then it says
well if it's over one it's going to be
one and if it's uh less than zero at
zero so it kind of just dead ends it on
those two ends but allows all the values
in the middle and again this like the
sigmoid function allows that information
to go to the next level so it might be
important to know if it's a 0.1 or a
minus 0.1 the next hidden layer might
pick that up and say oh this piece of
information is uncertain or this value
has a very low certainty to it and then
the hyperbolic tangent function and you
can see here it's 1 - e - 2x over 1 + e
- 2x and it's very much along the same
theme a little bit different in here in
that it goes between minus one and one
so you'll see some of these they go 0 to
one but this one goes minus one to one
and if it's less than zero it's you know
it doesn't fire and if it's over zero it
fires and it also still puts out a value
so you still have a value you can get
off of that just like you can with the
sigmoid function and the relo function
very similar in use and I believe the
originally used to be everything was
done in the sigmoid function that was
the most uh commonly used and now they
just kind of use more the relo function
the reason is one it processes faster
because you already have the value and
you don't have to add another compute
the one over 1 plus e Theus X for each
hidden node and the data coming off
works pretty good as far as putting it
into the next level if you want to know
just how close it is to zero how close
is it not to functioning you know is it
minus .1 minus point2 usually they're
float values you get like minus pointus
0138 or something so you know important
information but the relu is most
commonly used these days as far as the
setup we're using but you'll also see
the sigmoid function very commonly used
also now that you know what an
activation function is let's get back to
the neural network so finally the model
would predict the outcome of applying a
suitable activation function to the
output layer so we go in here we look at
this we have the optical character
recognition OCR is used on the images to
convert it into a text in order to
identify was written on the plate and as
it comes out you'll see the red node and
the red node might actually represent
just a letter A so there's usually a lot
of outputs when you're doing text
identification we're not going to show
that on here but you might have it even
in the order it might be um what order
the license plates in so you might have
AB bcde e FG you know the alphabet plus
the numbers and you might have the 1 2 3
4 5 6 7 8 N9 10 places so it's a very
large array that comes out it's not a
small amount of u you know we show three
dots coming in eight hidden layer nodes
you know two sets of four we just saw
one red coming out a lot of times this
is uh you know 28 * 28 if you did 30 *
30 that's you know 900 nodes so 28 is a
little bit less than that uh just on the
input and so you can imagine the hidden
layer is just as big each hidden layer
is just as big if not bigger then the
output is going to be there's so many
digits you know it's a lot it's a huge
amount of input and output but we're
only showing you just you know be hard
to show in one picture and so it comes
up and this is what it finally gets out
in the output is it identifies a number
on the plate and in this case we have 08
- D-
03858 error in the output is back
propagated through the network and
weights are adjusted to minimize the
error rate this is calculated by a cost
function when we're training our data
this is what's used and we'll look at
that in the code when we do the data
training so we have stuff we know the
answer to and then we put the
information through and it says yes that
was correct or no because remember we
randomly set all the weights to begin
with and if it's wrong we take that
error how far off are you you know are
you off by is it if it was like minus
one you're just a little bit off if it's
like minus 300 was your output remember
when we're looking at those different
options you know hyperbolic or whatever
and we looking at the re the RL could
doesn't have an limit on top or bottom
it actually just generates a number so
if it's way off you going have to adjust
those weights a lot but if it's pretty
close you might adjust the weights just
a little bit and you keep adjusting the
weights until they fit all the different
training models you put in so you might
have 500 training models and those
weights will adjust using the back
propagation it sends the error backward
the output is compared with the original
result and multiple iterations are done
to get the maximum accuracy so not only
does it look at each one but it goes
through it and just keeps cycling
through these the data making small
changes in the network until it gets the
right answers with every iteration the
weights at every interconnection are
adjusted based on the error we're not
going to dive into that math because it
is a differential equation and it gets a
little comp licated but I will talk a
little bit about some of the different
options they have when we look at the
code so we've explored a neural network
let's look at the different types of
artificial neural networks and this is
like the biggest area growing is how
these all come together let's see the
different types of neural network and
again we're comparing this to human
learning so here's a human brain I feel
sorry for that poor guy so we have a
feed for forward neural network simplest
form of a a they call it Ann a neural
network data travels only in One
Direction input to Output this is what
we just looked at so as the data comes
in all the weights are added it goes to
the hidden layer all the weights are
added it goes to the next hidden layer
all the weights are added and it goes to
the output the only time you use the
reverse propagation is to train it so
when you actually use it it's very fast
when you're training it it takes a while
because it has to iterate through all
your training data and you start getting
into Big Data because you can train
these with a huge amount of data the
more data you put in the better train
they get the applications vision and
speech recognition actually they're
pretty much everything we talked about a
lot of almost all of them use this form
of neural network at some level radial
basis function neural network this model
classifies the data point based on its
distance from a Center Point what that
means is that you might not have
training data so you want to group
things together and you create Central
points and it looks for all the things
you know some of these things are just
like the other if you've ever watched
the Sesame treat as a kid that dates me
so it brings things together and this is
a great way if you don't have the right
training model you can start finding
things that are connected you might not
have noticed before applications power
restoration systems they try to figure
out what's connected and then based on
that they can fix the problem if you
have a huge power system and
self-organizing neural network vectors
of random dimensions are input to
discrete map comprised of neurons
so they basically find a way to draw
they call them they say Dimensions or
vectors or planes because they actually
chop the data in one dimension two
Dimension three dimension four five six
they keep adding dimensions and finding
ways to separate the data and connect
different data pieces together
applications used to recognize patterns
in data like in medical analysis the
hidden layer saves its output to be used
for future prediction recurrent neural
networks so the hidden layers remember
its output from last time and that
becomes part of its new input uh you
might use that especially in robotics or
flying a drone you want to know what
your last change was and how fast it was
going to help predict what your next
change you need to make is to get to
where the Drone wants to go applications
text to speech conversation model so you
know I talked about drones but you know
just identifying on Lexus or Google
assistant or any of these they're
starting to add in I'd like to play a
song on my Pandora and I'd like it to be
at volume 90% so you now can add
different things in there and it
connects them together the input
features are taken in batches like a
filter this allows a network to remember
an image in Parts convolution neural
network today's world in photo
identification and taking apart photos
and trying to you know have you ever
seen that on Google where you have five
people together this is the kind of
thing separates all those people so then
it can do a face recognition on each
person applications used in signal and
image processing in this case I use
facial images or Google picture images
as one of the options modular neural
network it has a collection of different
neural networks working together to get
the output so wow we just went through
all these different types of neural
networks and the final one is to put
multiple neural networks together and I
mentioned that a little bit when we
separated people in a larger photo in
individuals in the photo and then do the
facial recognition on each person so one
network is used to separate them and the
next network is then used to figure out
who they are and do the facial
recognition applications still
undergoing research this is a Cutting
Edge you hear the term Pipeline and
there's actual in Python code and in
almost all the different neural network
setups out there they now have a
pipeline feature usually and it just
means you take the data from one neural
network and maybe another neural network
or you put it into the next neural
network and then you take three or four
other neural networks and feed them into
another one so how we connect the neural
networks is really just Cutting Edge and
it's so experimental I mean it's almost
creative in its nature there's not
really a science to it because each
specific domain has different things
it's looking at so if you're in the
banking domain it's going to be
different than the medical domain than
the automatic car domain and suddenly
figuring out how those all fit together
is just a lot of fun and really cool so
we have our types of artificial neural
network we have our feat forward neural
network we have a radial basis function
neural network we have our cohenan
self-organizing neural network recurrent
neural network convolution neural
network and modular neural network where
brings them all together and uh know the
colors on the brain do not match what
your brain actually does but they do
bring it out that most of these were
developed by understanding how humans
learn and as we understand more and more
of how humans learn we can build
something in the computer industry to
mimic that to reflect that and that's
how these were developed so exciting
part use case problem state statement so
this is where we jump in this is my
favorite part let's use the system to
identify between a cat and a dog if you
remember correctly I said we're going to
do some python code and you can see over
here my hair is kind of sticking up over
the computer cup of coffee on one side
and a little bit of old school a pencil
and a pen on the other side yeah most
people Now take notes I love the
stickies on the computer that's great
that's that is my computer I have sticky
notes on my computer in different colors
so not too far from uh today's
programmer so the problem is is we want
to classify photos of cats and dogs
using a neural network and you can see
over here we have quite a variety of
dogs in the pictures and cats and you
know just sorting out it is a cat is
pretty amazing and why would anybody
want to even know the difference between
a cat and a dog okay you know why well I
have a cat door it'd be kind of fun that
instead of it identifying instead of
having like a little collar with a
magnet on it which is what my cat has
the door would be able to see oh that's
the cat that's our cat coming in oh
that's the the dog we have a dog too
that's the dog I want to let in maybe I
don't want to let this other animal in
cuz it's a raccoon so you can see where
you could take this one step further and
actually apply this you could actually
start a little startup company idea
self-identifying door so this use case
will be implemented on python I am
actually in Python 3.6 it's always nice
to tell people the version of python
because that does affect sometimes which
modules you load and everything and
we're going to start by importing the
required packages I told you we're going
to do this in carass so we're going to
import from carass Models a sequential
from the carass layers conversion 2D or
Co NV 2D Max pooling 2D flatten and
dents and we'll talk about what each one
of these do in just a second but before
we do that let's talk a little bit about
the environment we're going to work in
and uh you know in fact let me go ahead
and open a uh the website kass's website
so we can learn a little bit more about
carass so here we are on the carass
website and it's a k r
as. that's the official website for
carass and the first thing you'll notice
is that carass runs on top of either
tensorflow cntk and I think it's
pronounced thano or theano what's
important on here is that tensor flow
and the same is true for all these but
tensorflow is probably one of the most
widely used currently packages out there
with the carass and of course you know
tomorrow this is all going to change
it's all going to disappear and they'll
have something new out there so make
sure when you're learning this code that
you understand what's going on and also
know the code I mean look when you look
at the code it's not as complicated once
you understand what's going on the code
itself is pretty straightforward and the
reason we like carass and the reason
that people are jumping on it right now
it's such a big deal is if we come down
here let me just scroll down a little
bit they talk about user friendliness
modularity easy extensibility work with
python Python's a big one because a lot
of people in data science now use Python
although you can actually access cross
other ways is if we continue down here
is layers and this is where it gets it's
really cool when we're working with
carass you just add layers on remember
those hidden layers we were talking
about and we talked about the
ru activation you can see right here let
me just up that a little bit in size
there we go that's big I can add in an
Ru layer and then I can add in a softmax
layer the next instance we didn't talk
about softmax so you can do each layer
separate now if I'm working in some of
the other kits I use I take that and I
have one setup and then I feed the
output into the next one this one I can
just add hidden layer after hidden layer
with the different information in it
which makes it very powerful and very
fast to spin up and try different setups
and see how they work with the data
you're working on and we'll dig a little
bit deeper in here and a lot of this is
very much the same so when we get to
that part I'll point that out to you
also now just a quick side note I'm
using Anaconda with python in it and I
went ahead and created my own package
and I called it the carass python 36 cuz
I'm in Python 36 Anaconda is cool that
way you can create different enir
environments really easily if you're
doing a lot of different experimenting
with these different packages probably
want to create your own environment in
there and the first thing is you can see
right here there's a lot of dependencies
a lot of these you should recognize by
now if you've done any of these videos
if not kudos for you for jumping in
today pip install numpy scipi the S kit
learn pillow and
h5py are both needed for the tensor flow
and then putting the carass on there and
then you'll see here uh and pip is just
a standard installer to use with python
you'll see here that we did pip install
tensorflow since we're going to do
carass on top of tensor flow and then
pip install and I went ahead and used
the GitHub so git plus git and you'll
see here github.com and this is one of
their releases one of the most current
release on there that goes on top of
tensor flow and you can look up these
instructions pretty much anywhere this
is for doing it on Anaconda certainly
you'd want to install these if you're
doing it in a buntu server setup you you
want to get I don't think you need the
h5py in a buntu but you do need the rest
in there CU they are dependencies in
there and it's pretty straightforward
and that's actually in some of the
instructions they have on their website
so you don't have to necessarily go
through this just remember their website
on there and then when I'm under my uh
Anaconda Navigator which I like you'll
see where I have environments and on the
bottom I created a new environment and I
called it carass python 36 just to
separate everything you can say I have
python 3.5 and python 36 I used to have
a bunch of other ones but I kind of
cleaned house recently and of course
once I go in here I can launch my
jupyter notebook making sure I'm using
the right environment that I just set up
this of course opens up my um in this
case I'm using uh Google Chrome and in
here I could go and just create a new
document in here and this is all in your
um browser Winer when you use the
Anaconda do you have to use anaconda and
Jupiter notebook no you can use any kind
of python editor whatever setup you're
comfortable with and whatever you're
doing in there so let's go ahead and go
in here and paste the code in and we're
importing a number of different settings
in here we have import sequential that's
under the models because that's the
model we're going to use as far as our
neural network and then we have layers
and we have conversion 2D Max pooling 2D
flatten DSE and you can actually just
kind of guess at what these do we're
talking we're working in a 2d photograph
and if you remember correctly I talked
about how the actual input layer is a
single array it's not in two Dimensions
it's one dimension all these do is these
are tools to help flatten the image so
it takes a two-dimensional image and
then it creates its own proper setup you
don't have to worry about any of that
you don't have to do anything special
with the photograph you let the carass
do it we're going to run this and you'll
see right here they have some stuff that
is going to be depreciated and changed
because that's what it does everything's
being changed as we go you don't have to
worry about that too much if you have
warnings if you run it a second time the
warning will disappear and this has just
imported these packages for us to use
Jupiter's nice about this that you can
do each thing step by step and I'll go
ahead and also zoom in there it little
control plus that's one of the nice
things about being in a browser
environment so here we are back another
sip of coffee if you're familiar with my
other videos you notice I'm always
sipping coffee I always have a my case
latte next to me an espresso so the next
step is to go ahead and initialize we're
going to call it the CNN or classifier
neural network and the reason we call it
a classifier is because it's going to
classify it between two things it's
going to be cat or dog so when you're
doing classification you're picking
specific objects you're specific it's a
true or false yes no it is something or
it's not so first thing we're going to
create our classifier and it's going to
equal sequential so their sequential
setup is the classifier that's the
actual model we're using that's the
neural network so we call it a
classifier and uh the next step is to
add in our convolution and let me just
do a uh let me shrink that down inside
so you can see the whole line and let's
talk a little bit about what's going on
here I have my classifier and I add
something what am I adding well I'm
adding my first layer this first layer
we're adding in is probably the one that
takes the most work to make sure you
have it set correct and the reason I say
that is this is your actual input and
we're going to jump here to the part
that says input shape equals 64x 64 by 3
what does that mean well that means that
our pictures coming in and there's these
pictures remember we had like the
picture of the car was 128 by 128 pixels
well this one is 64x 64 pixels and each
pixel has three values that's where
these numbers come from and it is so
important that this matches I mentioned
a little bit that if you have like a
larger picture you have to reformat it
to fit this shape if it comes in as
something larger there's no input notes
there's no input neural network there
that will handle that extra space so you
have to reshape your data to fit in here
now the first layer is the most
important because after that carass
knows what your shape is coming in here
and it knows what's coming out and so
that really sets the stage most
important thing is that input shape
matches your data coming in and you'll
get a lot of Errors if it doesn't you'll
go through there and picture number 55
doesn't match it correctly and guess
what it does it usually gives you an
error and then the activation if you
remember we talked about the different
activations on here we're using the reu
model like I said that is the most
commonly used now because one it's fast
doesn't have the added calculations in
it it just says here's a value coming
out based on the weights and the value
going in and um from there you know it's
uh it's if it's over one then it's good
or over zero it's good if it's under
zero then it's considered not active and
then we have this conversion 2D what the
heck is conversion 2D I'm not going to
go into too much detail in this because
this has a couple things it's doing in
here a little bit more in-depth than
we're ready to cover in this tutorial
but this is used to convert from the
photo because we have 64x 64x 3 and
we're just converting it to
two-dimensional kind of setup so it's
very aware that this is a photograph and
that different pieces are next to each
other and then we're going to add in uh
a second convolutional layer that's what
the co NV stands for 2D so it's these
are hidden layers so we have our input
layer and our two hidden layers and they
are two-dimensional because we're doing
with a two-dimensional photograph and
you'll see down here that on the last
one we add a Max pooling 2D and we put a
pool size = 22 and so what this is is
that as you get to the end of these
layers one of the things you always want
to think of is what they call mapping
and then reducing wonderful terminology
from the Big Data we're mapping this
data through all these layers and now we
want to reduce it to only two sets in
this case it's already in two sets
because it's a 2d photograph but we had
you know two Dimensions by we actually
have 64x 64 by 3 so now we're just
getting it down to a 2X two just the
two-dimension two- dimensional instead
of having the Third third dimension of
colors and we'll go ahead and run these
we're not really seeing anything on our
run script because we're just setting up
this is all set up and this is where you
start playing because maybe you'll add a
different layer in here to do something
else to see how it works and see what
your output is that's what makes carass
so nice is I can with just a couple
flips of code put in a whole new layer
that does a whole new processing and see
whether that improves my run or makes it
worse and finally we're going to do the
final setup which is to flatten
classifier as a flatten setup and then
we're going to also add a layer a dense
layer and then we're going to add in
another dense layer and then we're going
to build it we're going to compile this
whole thing together so let's flip over
and see what that looks like and we've
even numbered them for you so we're
going to do the flattening and flatten
is exactly what it sounds like we've
been working in a two-dimensional array
of picture which actually is in three
dimensions because of the pixels the
pixels have a whole another dimension to
it of three different values and we'
kind of resize those down to 2 by too
but now we're just going to flatten it I
don't want to have multiple Dimensions
being worked on by tensor and by carass
I want just a single array so it's
flattened out and then step four full
connection so we add in our final two
layers and you could actually do all
kinds of things with this you could
actually leave out this um some of these
layers and play with them you do need to
flatten it that's very important then we
want to use the dents again we're taking
this and we're taking whatever came into
it so on we take all those different the
two Dimensions or three dimensions as
they are and we flatten it to one
dimension we want to take that and we're
going to pull it into units of 128 they
got that you say where did they get 128
from you could actually play with that
number and get all kinds of weird
results but in this case we took the 64
+ 64 is 128 you could probably even do
this with 64 or 32 usually want to keep
it in the same multiple whatever the
data shape you're already using is in
and we're using the activation the ru
just like we did before and then we
finally filter all that into a single
output and it has how many units one why
cuz we want to know whether true or
false it's either a dog or a cat you
could say one is dog zero is cat or
maybe you're a cat lover and it's one is
cat and zero is dog and if you love both
dogs and cats you're going to have to
choose and then we use the sigmoid
activation if you remember from before
we had the reu and there's also the
sigmoid the sigmoid just makes it clear
it's yes or no we don't want to any kind
of in between number coming out and
we'll go ahead and run this and you'll
see it's still all in setup and then
finally we want to go ahead and compile
and let's put the compiling our um
classifier neural network and we're
going to use the optimizer atom and I
hinted at this just a little bit before
where does atom come in where does an
Optimizer come in well the optimizer is
the reverse propagation when we're
training it it goes all the way through
and says error and then how does it
readjust those weights there are a
number of them atom is the most commonly
used and it works best on large data
most people stick with the atom because
when they're testing on smaller data see
if their model is going to go through
and get all their errors out before they
run it on larger data sets they're going
to run it on atom anyway so they just
leave it on atom most commonly used but
there are some other ones out there you
should be aware of that that you might
try them if you're stuck in a bind or
you might blore that in the future but
usually adom is just fine on there and
then you have two more settings you have
loss and metrics we're not going to dig
too much into loss or metrics these are
things you really have to explore carass
cuz there are so many choices this is
how it computes the error there's so
many different ways to on your back
propagation and your training so we're
using the atom model but you can compute
the error by um standard deviation
standard deviation squared they use
binary crossentropy I'd have to look
that up to even know what that is
there's so many of these a lot of times
you just start with the ones that look
correct that are most commonly used and
then you have to go read the coros site
and actually see what these different
losses and metrics and what different
options they have so we're not going to
get too much into them other than to
reference you over to the carass website
to explore them deeper but we are going
to go ahead and run them and now we've
set up our classifier so we have an
object classifier and if you go back up
here you'll see that we've added in step
one we added in our layer for the input
we added a layer that comes in there and
uses the ru for Activation and then it
pulls the data so this is even though
these are two layers the actual neural
network layer is up here and then it
uses this to pull the data into a 2X two
so into a two-dimensional array from a
three-dimensional array with the colors
then we flatten it so there's our add
our flatten and then we add another
dense what they call dense layer this
dense layer goes in there and it
downsizes it to 128 it reduces it so you
can look at this as uh we're mapping all
this data down the two-dimensional setup
and then we flatten it so we map it to a
flatten map and then we take it and
reduce it down to 128 and we use the reu
again and then finally we reduce that
down to just a single output and we use
the sigmoid to do that to figure out
whether it's yes no true false in this
case cat or dog and then finally once we
put all these layers together we compile
them that's what we've done here and
we've compiled them as far as how it
trains to use these settings for the
training back propagation so if you
remember we talked about training our
setup and when we go into this you'll
see that we have two data sets we have
one called the training set and the
testing set and that's very standard in
any data processing is you need to have
that's pretty common in any data
processing is you need to have a certain
amount of data to train it and then you
got to know whether it works or not is
it any good and that's why you have a
separate set of data for testing it
where you already know the answer but
you don't want to use that as part of
the training set so in here we jump into
part two fitting the classifier nerve
Network to the image images and then
from carass let me just zoom in there I
always love that about working with
Jupiter notebooks you can really see
we're going to come in here we do the
carass pre-processing an image and we
import image data generator so nice of
carass it's such a high-end product
right now going out and since images are
so common they already have all this
stuff to help us process the data which
is great and so we come in here we do
train data gen and we're going to create
our object for helping us train for
reshaping the data so that it's going to
work with our setup and we use an image
data generator and we're going to
rescale it and you'll see here we have
one point which tells us it's a float
value on the rescale over 255 where does
255 come from well that's the scale in
the colors of the pictures we're using
their value from 0 to 255 so we want to
divide it by 255 and it'll generate a
number between 0 and 1 they have sheer
range and zoom range horizontal flip
equals true and this of course has to do
with if the photos are different shapes
and sizes like I said it's a wonderful
package you really need to dig in deep
to see all the different options you
have for setting up your images for
right now though we're going to just
stick with some basic stuff here and let
me go ahead and run this code and again
it doesn't really do anything CU we're
still setting up the pre-processing
let's take a look at this next set of
code and this one is just huge we're
creating the training set so the
training set is going to go in here and
it's going to use our train data genin
we just created flow from directory it's
going to access in this case the path
data set training set that's a folder so
it's going to pull all the images out of
that folder now I'm actually running
this in the folder that the data sets in
so if you're doing the same setup and
you load your data in there and you're
doing this make sure wherever your
Jupiter notebook is saving things to
that you create this path or you can do
the complete path if you need to you
know C colon slash Etc and the target
side the batch size and class mode is
binary so the class is we're switching
everything to a binary value batch size
what the heck is batch size well that's
how many pictures we're going to batch
through the training each time and the
target size 64x 64 a little confusing
but you can see right here that this is
just a general training and you can go
in there and look at all the different
settings for your training set and of
course with different data we're doing
pictures there's all kinds of different
settings depending on what you're
working with let's go ahead and run that
and see what happens and you'll see that
it found 800 images belonging to one
classes so we have 800 images in the
training set and if we're going to do
this with uh the training set we also
have to format the pictures in the test
set now we're not actually doing any
predictions we're not actually
programming the model yet all we're
doing is preparing the data so we're
going to prepare a training set and the
test set so any changes we make to the
training set at this point also have to
be made to the test set so we've done
this thing we've done a train data
generator we've done our training set
and then we also have remember our test
set of data so I'm going to do the same
thing with that I'm going to create a
test data gen and we're going to do this
image data generator we're going to
rescale one over 255 we don't need the
other settings just the single setting
for the test data gen and we're going to
create our test set we're going to do
the same thing we did with the test set
except that we're pulling it from the
test set folder and we'll run that and
you'll see in our test set we found
2,000 images that's about right we're
using 20% of the images as test and 80%
to train it and then finally we've set
up all our data we've set up all our
layers which is where all the work is is
cleaning up that data making sure it's
going in there correctly and we actually
going to fit it we're going to train our
data set and let's see what that looks
like and here we go let's put the
information in here and let's just take
a quick look at what we're looking at
with our fit generator we have our
classifier do fit generator that's our
our back propagation so the information
goes through forward with a picture and
it says oh you're either right or you're
wrong and then the eror goes backward
and reprograms all those weights so
we're training our neural network and of
course we're using the training set
remember we created the training setup
here and then we're going steps per epic
so it's 8,000 steps epic means that
that's how many times we go through all
the pictures so we're going to rerun
each of the pictures and we're going to
go through the whole data set 2 five
times but we're going to look at each
picture during each epic 8,000 times so
we're really programming the heck out of
this and going back over it and then
they have validation data equals test
set so we have our um training set and
then we're going to have our test set to
validate it so we're going to do this
all in one shot and we're going to look
at that and they're going to do 200
steps for each validation and we'll see
what that looks like in just a minute
let's go ahead and run our training here
and we're going to fit our data and as
it goes it says epic one of 25 you start
realizing that this is going to take a
while on my older computer it takes
about 45 minutes I have a dual processor
you we're processing uh 10,000 photos
that's not a small amount of photographs
to process so if you're on your laptop
you know which I am it's going to take a
while so let's go ahead and uh go get
our cup of coffee and a sip and come
back and see what this looks like so I'm
back you didn't know I was gone that was
actually a lengthy pause there I made a
couple changes and let's disc disc those
changes real quick and why I made them
so the first thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to go up here and insert a
cell above and let's paste the original
code back in there and you'll see that
the original thing was steps per epic
8,000 25 epics and validation steps
2,000 and I changed these to 4,000 epics
or 4,000 steps per epic 10 epics and
just 10 validation steps and this will
cause problems if you're doing this as a
commercial release but for demo purposes
this should work and if you remember our
steps per epic that's how many photos
we're going to process in fact let me go
ahead and get my drawing pen out and uh
let's just highlight that right here
well we have 8,000 pictures we're going
through so for each epic I'm going to
change this to 4,000 I'm going to cut
that in half so it's going to randomly
pick 4,000 pictures each time it goes
through an epic and the Epic is how many
processes so this is 25 and I'm just
going to cut that to 10 so instead of
doing 25 runs through 8,000 photos each
which you can do the math of 25 8,000
I'm only going to do 10 through 4,000 so
I'm going to run this 40,000 times
through the processes and the next thing
I not you'll you'll want to notice is
that I also changed the validation step
and this would cause some major problems
in releasing because I dropped it all
the way down to 10 what the validation
step does is it says we have 2,000
photos in our training or in our testing
set and we're going to use that for
validation well I'm only going to use a
random 10 of those to validate so not
really the best settings but let me show
you why why we did that let's scroll
down here just a little bit and let's
look at the output here and see what
that what's going on there so I've got
my drawing tool back on and you'll see
here it lists a run so each time it goes
through an epic it's going to do 4,000
steps and this is where the 4,000 comes
in so that's where we have we have epic
one of 10 4,000 steps it's randomly
picking half the pictures in the file
and going through them and then we're
going to look at this number right here
that is for the whole epic and that's
2,411 seconds and if you remember
correctly you divide that by 60 you get
minutes if you divide that by 60 you get
hours or you can just divide the whole
thing by 60 * 60 which is 3600 if 3600
is an hour this is roughly 45 minutes
right here and that's 45 minutes to
process half the pictures so if I was
doing all the pictures we're talking an
hour and a half per epic times 36 or no
25 they had 25 up above 25 so that's
roughly a couple days a couple couple
days of processing well for this demo we
don't want to do that I don't want to
come back the next day plus my computer
did a reboot in the middle of the night
so we look at this and we say okay let's
we're just testing this out my computer
that I'm running this on is a dual core
processor uh runs 0.9 gigahertz per
second for a laptop you know it was good
about four years ago but for running
something like this it's probably a
little slow so we cut the times down and
the last one was validation we're only
validating it on a random 10 photos and
this comes into effect cuz you're going
to see down here where we have accuracy
value loss value accuracy and loss those
are very important numbers to look at so
the 10 means I'm only validating across
10 pictures that is where here we have
value this is ACC is for accuracy value
loss we're not going to worry about that
too much and accuracy now accuracy is
while it's running it's putting these
two numbers together that's what
accuracy is and value accuracy is at the
end of the Epic what's our accuracy into
the Epic what is it looking at in this
tutorial we're not going to go so deep
but these numbers are really important
when you start talking about these two
numbers reflect bias that is really
important I just put that up there and
bias is a little bit beyond this
tutorial but the short of it is is if
this accuracy which is being our
validation per step is going down and
the value accuracy continues to go up
that means there's a bias that means I'm
memorizing the photos I'm looking at I'm
not actually looking for what makes a
dog a dog what makes a cat a cat I'm
just memorizing them and so the more
this discrepancy grows the bigger the
bias is and that is really the beauty of
the carass neural network it is a lot of
built-in features like this and make
that really easy to track so let's go
ahead and take a look at the next set of
code so here we are into part three
we're going to make a new prediction and
so we're going to bring in a couple
tools for that and then we have to
process the image coming in in and find
out whether it's an actual dog or cat if
we can actually use this to identify it
and of course the final step of part
three is to print prediction we'll go
ahead and combine these and of course
you can see me there adding more sticky
notes to my computer screen hidden
behind the screen and you know last one
was don't forget to feed the cat and the
dog so let's go ah a and take a look at
that and see what that looks like in
code and put that in our Jupiter
notebook all right and let's paste that
in here and we'll start by importing
numpy as NP numpy is a very common
package I pretty much import it on any
python project I'm working on another
one I use regularly is pandas they're
just ways of organizing the data and
then NP is usually the standard in most
machine learning tools as the return for
the data array although you know you can
use a standard data array from Python
and we have coros pre-pressing import
image this that all look familiar
because we're going to take a test image
and we're going to set that equal to in
this case cat or dog one as you can see
over here and you know what let me get
my drawing tool back on so let's take a
look at this we have our test image
we're loading and in here we have test
image one and this one hasn't data
hasn't seen this one at all so this is
all new oh let me shrink the screen down
let me start that over so here we have
my test image and we went ahead in the
coros processing has this nice image
setup so we're going to load the image
and we're going to alter it to a 64x 64
print so right off the bat we're going
to cross this nice that way it
automatically sets it up for us so we
don't have to redo all images and find a
way to reset those and then we use all
those to set the image to an array so
again we're all in pre-processing the
data just like we pre-processed before
with our test information and our
training data and then we use the numpy
here's our numpy that's uh from our
right up here import nump as NP expand
the dimensions test image axis equal
zero so it puts it into a single array
and then finally all that work all that
pre-processing and all we do is we run
the result we click on here we go result
equals classifier predict test image and
then we find out well what is the test
image and let's just take a quick look
and just see what that is and you can
see when I ran it it comes up dog and if
we look at those images there it is cat
or dog image number one that looks like
a nice floppy eared lab friendly with
his tongue hanging out it's either that
or a very floppy eared cat I'm not sure
which but according to our software it
says it's a dog and uh we have a second
picture over here let's just see what
happens when we run the second picture
we can go up here and change this uh
from dog image one to two we'll run that
and it comes down here and says cat you
can see me highlighting it down there as
cat so our process works you're able to
label a dog a dog and a cat a cat just
from the pictures there we go cleared my
drawing tool and the last thing I want
you to notice when we come back up here
to when I ran it you'll see it has an
accuracy of one and the value accuracy
of one well the value accuracy is the
important one because the value accuracy
is what it actually runs on on the test
data remember I'm only testing it on I'm
only validating it on random 10 photos
and those 10 photos just happen to come
up one now when they ran this on the
server it actually came up about
86% this is why cutting these numbers
down so far for a commercial release is
bad so you want to make sure you're a
little careful of that when you're
testing your stuff that you change these
numbers back when you run it on a more
Enterprise computer other than your old
laptop that you're just practicing on or
messing with and we come down here and
again you know we had the validation of
cat and so we have successfully built a
neural network that could distinguish
between photos of a cat and a dog
imagine all the other things you could
distinguish imagine all the different
Industries you could dive into with that
just being able to understand those two
difference of pictures what about
mosquitoes could you find the mosquitoes
that bite versus mosquitoes that are
friendly it turns out the mosquitoes
that bite us are only 4% of the mosquito
population if even that maybe 2% there's
all kinds of industries that use this
and there's so many industries that are
just now realizing how powerful these
tools are just in the photos alone there
is a myriad of Industry sprouting up and
I said it before I'll say it again what
an exciting time to live in with these
tools and that we get to play with so
key takeaways well we covered what is a
neural network we use all kinds of
processing the map images on your phone
we talked about things that a neural
network can do translate text identify
faces all the way to control robots you
know lots of exciting things how does a
neural network work so we discussed that
with the different layers going from the
picture to the um input layer to the
hidden layers and their weights to the
final output layer we also talked about
how it does a math in Computing the
output as uh yes or no categorically
true false we discussed types of
artificial neural networks a lot of
vocabulary there from the feed forward
neural network which is the most
commonly used that's the one the neural
network we used is a feed forward neur
Network that does backward propagation
to train and there's a lot of other ones
out there there's a radio biases the
cohenon self-organizing recurrent neural
network convolution neural network
modular neural network the big one was
modular because it incorporates pieces
of all the other ones so that whatever
you're working on now is a huge
conglomerate of multiple networks just
all Cutting Edge all of it's new people
even working on it don't even know where
it's going again very exciting times and
finally we dug through my favorite part
you can see with my latte on one side my
old school pens and pencil and all my
sticky notes working away that's not
actually me by the way you probably
guessed that and we walked through and
actually did a cat and dog photo a
simple cat and dog photo and you could
see where some of the problems are in
processing large amounts of photographs
and data where that starts to become
going from a single machine on my laptop
with its you know lower amount of
resources all the way to Big Data how if
you're processing hundreds and thousands
of these photos this now needs to be set
up on an Enterprise machine or even on a
cluster of computers again significantly
past the scope of this the neat part
about it though is once you write this
code most of this code they now have
tools that you can almost take the same
ideas if not the actual code and push it
right onto a cluster computation so
really cool times for this so what are
generative adversarial networks
generative adversarial networks or Gans
introduced in 2014 byan J Goodfellow and
co-authors became very popular in the
field of machine learning Gan is an
unsupervised learning task in machine
learning it consists of two models that
automatically discover and learn the
patterns in input data the two models
called generator and discriminator
compete with each other to analyze
capture and copy the variations within a
data set Gans can be used to generate
new examples that possibly could have
been drawn from the original data
set in the image below you can see that
there is a database that has real 100
rupe notes the generator which is
basically a neural network generates
fake 100 rupees notes the discriminator
network will identify if the notes are
real or fake let us now understand in
brief about what is a generator a
generator in Gans is a neural network
that creates fake data to be trained on
the discriminator it learns to generate
plausible data the generated instances
become negative training examples for
the discriminator it takes a fixed
length random Vector carrying noise as
input and generates a sample now the
main aim of the generator is to make the
discriminator classify its output as
real the portion of the Gan that trains
a generator
includes a noisy input Vector the
generator Network which transforms the
random input into a data instance a
discriminator network which classifies
the generator data and a generator loss
which penalizes the generator for
failing to do the discriminator the back
propagation method is used to adjust
each weight in the right direction by
calculating the weight's impact on the
output
the back propagation method is used to
obtain gradients and these gradients can
help change the generator weights now
let us understand in brief what a
discriminator is a discriminator is a
neural network model that identifies
real data from the fake data generated
by the generator the discriminator
training data comes from two
sources the real data instances such as
real pictures of birds humans currency
notes Etc are used by the discriminator
as positive samples during the training
the fake data instances created by the
generator are used as negative examples
during the training process while
training the discriminator it connects
with two loss functions during
discriminator training the discriminator
ignores the generator loss and just uses
the discriminator law in the process of
training the discriminator the
discriminator classifies both real data
and fake data from the generator the
discriminator laws penalizes the
discriminator from misclassifying a real
data instance as fake or a fake data
instance as real now moving ahead let's
understand how Gans work now Gans
consists of two networks a generator
which is represented as G of X and A
discriminator which is represented as D
of X they both play an adversarial game
where the generator tries to fool the
discriminator by generating data similar
to those in the training set the
discriminator tries not to be fooled by
identifying fake data from the real data
they both work simultaneously to learn
and train complex data like audio video
or image files now you are aware that
Gans consists of two networks a
generator G ofx and discriminator D ofx
now the generator Network takes a sample
and generates a fake sample of data the
generator is stained to increase the
probability of the discriminator network
to make mistakes on the other hand the
discriminator network decides whether
the data is generated or taken from the
real sample using a binary
classification problem with the help of
a sigmoid function that gives the output
in the range 0 and one here is an
example of a generative adversarial
Network trying to identify if the 100
rupe notes are real or fake so first a
noise vector or the input Vector is fed
to the generator Network the generator
creates fake 100 rupe nodes the real
images of 100 rupee notes stored in a
database are passed to the discriminator
along with the fake notes the
discriminator then identifies the notes
and classifies them as real or fake we
train the model calculate the Lost
function at the end of the discriminator
Network and back propagate the loss into
both discriminator and Generator now the
mathematical equation of training again
can be represented as you can see here
now this is the
equation and these are the parameters
here G represents generator D represents
the discriminator now P data of X is the
probability distribution of real data P
of Z is the distribution of Generator X
is the sample of probability data of x z
is the sample size from P of z d of X is
the discriminator network and G of Z is
the generator Network now the
discriminator focuses to maximize the
objective function such that D of X is
close to 1 and Z of Z is close to zero
it simply means that the discriminator
should identify all the images from the
training set as real that is one and all
the generated images as fake that is
zero the generator wants to minimize the
objective function such that D of Z of Z
is one this means that the generator
tries to generate images that are
classified as real that is one by the
discriminator network next let's see the
steps for training a neural network so
we have to first Define the problem and
collect the data then we'll choose the
architecture of Gan now depending on
your problem choose how your Gan should
look like then we need to train the
discriminator in real data that will
help us predict them as real for n
number of times next you need to
generate fake inputs for the generator
after that you need to train the
discriminator on fake data to predict
the generator data is fake finally train
the generator on the output of
discriminator with the discriminator
predictions available train the
generator to fool the discriminator let
us now look at the different types of
Gans so first we have vanilla Gans now
vanilla Gans have minmax optimization
formula that we saw earlier where the
discriminator is a binary classifier and
is using sigmoid cross entropy loss
during
optimization in vanilla ganss the
generator and the discriminator are
simple multi-layer percep droms the
algorithm tries to optimize the
mathematical equation using stochastic
gradient decent up next we have deep
convolutional Gans or DC Gans now DC
Gans support convolutional neural
networks instead of vanilla neural
networks at both discriminator and
Generator they are more stable and
generate higher quality images the
generator is a set of convolutional
layers with fractional strided
convolutions or transpose convolutions
so it unsampled the input image at every
convolutional layer the discriminator is
a set of convolutional layers with
strided convolutions so it down samples
the input image at every convolutional
layer moving ahead the third type you
have is conditional Gans or C Gans
vanilla Gans can be extended into
conditional models by using an extra
label information to generate better
results in cgan an additional parameter
called Y is added to the generator for
generating the corresponding data labels
are fed as input to the discriminator to
help distinguish the real data from fake
data generated finally we have super
resolution Gans now Sr Gans use deep
neural networks along with adversarial
neural network to produce higher
resolution images super resolution Gans
generate a photo realistic high
resolution image when given a low
resolution image let's look at some of
the important applications of
Gans so with the help of DC Gans you can
train images of cartoon characters for
generating faces of Anime characters and
Pokémon characters as well next Gans can
be used on the images of humans to
generate realistic faces the faces that
you see on your screens have been
generated using Gans and do not exist in
reality third application we have is
ganss can be used to build realistic
images from textual descriptions of
objects like birds humans and other
animals we input a sentence and generate
multiple images fitting the description
here is an example of a text to image
translation using Gans for a bird with a
black head yellow body and a short beak
the final application we have is
creating 3D objects so Gans can generate
3D models using 2D pictures of objects
from multiple perspectives Gans are very
popular in the gaming industry Gans can
help automate the task of creating 3D
characters and backgrounds to give them
a realistic do you know how deep
learning recognizes the objects in an
image and really this particular neural
network is how image recognition works
it's very Central one of the biggest
building blocks for image recognition it
does it using convolution neural network
and we over here we have the basic
picture of a uh hummingbird pixels of an
image fed as input you have your input
layer coming in so it takes that graphic
and puts it into the input layer you
have all your hidden layers and then you
have your output layer and your output
layer one of those is going to light up
and say oh it's a bird we're going to go
into depth we're going to actually go
back and forth on this a number of times
today so if you're not catching all the
image um don't worry we're going to get
into the details so we have our input
layer accepts the pixels of the image as
input in the form of arrays and you can
see up here where they've actually um
labeled each block of the bird in
different arrays so we'll dive into deep
as to how that looks like and how those
matrixes are set up your hidden layer
carry out feature extraction by
performing certain calculations and
manipulation so this is the part that
kind of reorganizes that picture
multiple ways until we get some data
that's easy to read for the neural
network this layer uses a matrix filter
and performs convolution operation to
detect patterns in the image and if you
remember that convolution means to coil
or to twist so we're going to twist the
data around and alter it and use that
operation to detect a new pattern there
are multiple hidden layers like
convolution lay layer real U is how that
is pronounced and that's the rectified
linear unit that has to do with the
activation function that's used pooling
layer also uses multiple filters to
detect edges corners eyes feathers beak
Etc and just like the term says pulling
is pulling information together and
we'll look into that a lot closer here
so if you're if it's a little confusing
now we'll dig in deep and try to get you
uh squared away with that and then
finally there is a fully connected layer
layer that identifies the object in the
image so we have these different layers
coming through in the hidden layers and
they come into the final area and that's
where we have say one node or one neural
network entity that lights up that says
it's a bird what's in it for you we're
going to cover an introduction to the
CNN what is convolution neural network
how CNN recognizes images we're going to
dig deeper into that and really look at
the individual layers in the
convolutional neural network and finally
we do a use case implementation using
the C CNN we'll begin our introduction
to the CNN by introducing the pioneer of
convolutional neural network Yan leun he
was the director of Facebook AI research
group built the first convolutional
neural network called lenette in
1988 so these have been around for a
while and have had a chance to mature
over the years it was used for character
recognition tasks like reading zip code
digits imagine processing mail and
automating that process CNN is a feed
forward neural network that is generally
used used to analyze visual images by
producing data with a grid-like topology
a CNN is also known as a convet and very
key to this is we are looking at images
that was what this was designed for and
you'll see the different layers as we
dig in Mirror some of the other some of
them are actually now used since we're
using uh tensorflow and carass in our
code later on you'll see that some of
those layers appear in a lot of your
other neural network Frameworks uh but
in this case this is very Central to
processing images and doing so in a
variety that captures multiple images
and really drills down into their
different features in this example here
you see flowers of two varieties Orchid
and a rose I think the Orchid is much
more dainty and beautiful and the rose
smells quite beautiful I have a couple
rose bushes in my yard uh they go into
the input layer that data is then sent
to all the different nodes in the next
layer of one of the Hidden layers based
on its different weights and its setup
it then comes out and gives those a new
value those values then are multiplied
by their weights and go to the next next
hidden layer and so on and then you have
the output layer and one of those notes
comes out and says it's an orchid and
the other one comes out and says it's a
rose depending on how was well it was
trained what separates the CNN or the
convolutional neural network from other
neural networks is a convolutional
operation forms the basis of any
convolutional neural network in a CNN
every image is represented in the form
of array a pixel values so here we have
a real image of the digit 8 uh that then
gets put onto its pixel values
represented in the form of an array in
this case you have a two-dimensional
array and then you can see in the final
in form we transform the digit 8 into
its representational form of pixels of
zeros and on where the ones represent in
this case the black part of the eight
and the zeros represent the white
background to understand the convolution
neural network or how that convolutional
operation Works we're going to take a
side step and look at matrixes in this
case we're going to simplify it we're
going to take two matrices A and B of
one dimension now kind of separate this
from your thinking as we learned that
you want to focus just on the Matrix
aspect of this and then we'll bring that
back together and see what that looks
like when we put the pieces for the
convolutional operation here we've set
up two arrays we have a in this case are
a single Dimension Matrix and we have a
= 5
37597 and we have b equal one two 3 so
in the convolution as it comes in there
it's going to look at these two and
we're going to start by doing
multiplying them a * B and so we
multiply the arrays element wise and we
get 5
66 where five is the 5 * 1 6 is 3 * 2
and then the other six is 2 * 3 and
since the two arrays aren't the same
size they're not the same setup we're
going to just truncate the first one and
we're going to look at the second array
multiplied just by the first three
elements of the first array now that's
going to be a little confusing remember
a computer gets to repeat these
processes hundreds of times so we're not
going to just forget those other numbers
later on we'll see we'll bring those
back in and then we have the sum of the
product in this case 5 + 6 + 6 = 17 so
in our a * B our very first digit in
that Matrix of a * B is 17 and if you
remember I said we're not going to
forget the other digits so we now have
325 we move one set over and we take 325
and we multiply that times B and you'll
see that 3 * 1 is 3 2 * 2 is 4 and so on
and so on WE sum it up so now we have
the second digit of our a * B product in
The Matrix and we continue on with that
same thing so on and so on so then we
would go from uh 375 to 759 to 597 this
short Matrix that we have for a we've
now covered all the different entities
in a that match three different levels
of B now in a little bit we're going to
cover where we use this math at this
multiplying of matrixes and how that
works uh but it's important to
understand that we're going through the
Matrix and multiplying the different
parts to it to match the smaller Matrix
with the larger Matrix I know a lot of
people get lost at is you know what's
going on here with these matrixes uh oh
scary math not really that scary when
you break it down we're looking at a
section of a and we're comparing it to B
so when you break that down your mind
like that you realize okay so I'm I'm
just taking these two matrixes and
comparing them and I'm bringing the
value down into one Matrix a * B we're
producing that information in a way that
will help the computer see different
aspects let's go ahead and flip over
again back to our images here we are
back to our images talking about going
to the most basic two-dimensional image
you can get to consider the following
two images the image for the symbol
backslash when you press the backslash
the above image is processed and you can
see there for the image for the forward
slash is the opposite so we click the
forward slash button that flips uh very
basic we have four pixels going in can't
get any more basic than that here we
have a little bit more complicated
picture we take a real image of a smiley
face um then we represent that in the
form of black and white pixels so if
this was an image in the computer it's
black and white and like we saw before
we convert this into the zeros and one
so with the other one would have just
been a matrix of just four dots now we
have a significantly larger image coming
in so don't worry we're going to bring
this all together here in just a little
bit layers in convolutional neural
Network when we're looking at this we
have our convolution layer and that
really is the central aspect of
processing images in the convolutional
neural network that's why we have it and
then that's going to be feeding in and
you have your reu layer which is you
know as we talked about the rectified
linear unit we'll talk about that a
little bit layer the reu is an how it
Act is how that layer is activated is
the math behind it what makes the
neurons fire you'll see that in a lot of
other neural networks when you're using
using it just by itself is for
processing smaller amounts of data where
you use the atom activation feature for
large data coming in now because we're
processing small amounts of data in each
image the reu layer works great you have
your pooling layer that's where you're
pulling the data together pooling is a
neural network term it's very commonly
used I like to use a term reduce so if
you're coming from the map and reduce
side you'll see that we're mapping all
this data through all these networks and
then we're going to reduce it we're
going to pull it together and then
finally we have the fully connected
layer that's where our output's going to
come out so we have started to look at
matrixes we've started to look at the
convolutional layer and where it fits in
and everything we've taken a look at
images so we're going to focus more on
the convolution layer since this is a
convolutional neural network a
convolution layer has a number of
filters and perform convolution
operation every image is considered as a
matrix of pixel values consider the
following 5x5 image whose pixel values
are only zero and one now obviously when
we're dealing with color there's all
kinds of things that come in on color
processing but we want to keep it simple
and just keep it black and white and so
we have our image pixels uh so we're
sliding the filter Matrix over the image
and Computing the dot product to detect
the patterns and right here you're going
to ask where does this filter come from
this is a bit confusing because the
filter is going to be derived uh later
on we build the filters when we program
or train our model so you don't need to
worry what the filter actually is what
you do need to understand how a
convolution layer works is what is the
filter doing filter and you'll have many
filters you don't have just one filter
you'll have lots of filters that are
going to look for different aspects and
so the filter might be looking for just
edges it might be looking for different
parts we'll cover that a little bit more
detail in a minute right now we're just
focusing on how the filter works as a
matrix remember earlier we talked about
multiplying matrixes together and here
we have our two-dimensional Matrix matx
and you can see we take the filter and
we multiply it in the upper left image
and you can see right here 1 * 1 1 * 0 1
* 1 we multiply those all together then
sum them and we end up with a convolved
feature of four we're going to take that
and sliding the filter Matrix over the
image and Computing the dot product to
detect patterns so we're just going to
slide this over we're going to predict
the first one and slide it over one
notch predict the second one and so on
and so on all the way through until we
have a new Matrix and this Matrix which
is the same size as a filter has reduced
the image and whatever filter whatever
that's filtering out is going to be
looking at just those features reduced
down to a smaller uh Matrix so once the
feature maps are extracted the next step
is to move them to the reu layer so the
reu layer The Next Step first is going
to perform an element wise operation so
each of those Maps coming in if there's
negative pixels so it says all all the
negative pixels to zero um and you can
see this nice graph where it just zeros
out the negatives and then you have a
value that goes from zero up to whatever
value is um coming out of the Matrix
this introduces nonlinearity to the
network uh so up until now we have a we
say linearity we're talking about the
fact that the feature has a value so
it's a linear feature this feature um
came up and it has let's say the feature
is the edge of the beak you know it's
like or that backslash that we saw um
you'll look at that and say okay this
feature has a value from -10 to 10 in
this case um if it was one it say yeah
this might be a beak it might not might
be an edge right there a minus 5 means
no we're not even going to look at it a
zero and so we end up with an output and
the output takes all these fature all
these filtered features remember we're
not just running one filter on this
we're running a number of filters on
this image and so we end up with an
rectified feature map that is looking at
just the features coming through and how
they weigh in from our filters so here
we have an input of a looks like a
twocan
bird very exotic looking real image is
scanned in multiple convolution and the
reu layers for locating features and you
can see up here it's turned it into a
black and white image and in this case
we're looking in the upper right hand
corner for a feature and that box scans
over a lot of times it doesn't scan one
pixel at a time a lot of times it will
Skip by two or three or four pixels uh
to speed up the process that's one of
the ways you can compensate if you don't
have enough resources on your
computation for large images and it's
not just one filter slowly goes across
the image uh you have multiple filters
have been programmed in there so you're
looking at a lot of different filters
going over the different aspects of the
image and just sliding across there and
forming a new Matrix one more aspect to
note about the reu layer is we're not
just having one relu coming in uh so not
only do we have multiple features going
through but we're generating multip
multiple reu layers for locating the
features that's very important to note
you know so we have a quite a bundle we
have multiple filters multiple reu uh
which brings us to the next step forward
propagation now we're going to look at
the pooling layer the rectified feature
map now goes through a pooling layer
pooling is a downsampling operation that
reduces the dimensionality of the
feature map that's all we're trying to
do we're trying to take a huge amount of
information and reduce it down to a
single answer this is a specific kind of
bird this is an iris this is a rose so
you have a rectified feature map and you
see here we have a rectified feature map
coming in um we set the max pooling with
a 2X two filters and a stride of Two And
if you remember correctly I talked about
not going one pixel at a time uh well
that's where the stride comes in we end
up with a 2X two pulled feature map but
instead of moving one over each time and
looking at every possible combination we
skip a we skip a few there we go by two
we skip every other pixel and we just do
every other one um and this reduces our
rectified feature map which as you can
see over here 16x 16 to a 4x4 so we're
continually trying to filter and reduce
our data so that we can get to something
we can manage and over here you see that
we have the Max uh 3 4 1 and two and in
the max pooling we're looking for the
max value a little bit different than
what we were looking at before so coming
from the rectified feature we're now
finding the max value and then we're
pulling those features together so
instead of think of this as image of the
map think of this as how valuable is a
feature in that area how much of a
feature value do we have and we just
want to find the best or the maximum
feature for that area they might have
that one piece of the filter of the beak
said oh I see a one in this beak in this
image and then it skips over and says I
see a three in this image and says oh
this one is rated as a four we don't
want to Summit together because then you
know you might have like five ones and
it'll say ah five but you might have uh
four zeros and 11 10 and that 10 says
well this is definitely a beak where the
ones will say probably not a beak a
little strange analogy since we're
looking at a bird but you can see how
that pulled feature map comes down and
we're just looking for the max value in
each one of those matrixes pooling layer
uses different filters to identify
different parts of the image like edges
corners body feathers eyes beak Etc um I
know I focus mainly on the beak but
obviously uh each feature could be each
a different part of the bird coming in
so let's take a look at what that looks
like structure of a convolution neural
network so far this is where we're at
right now we have our input image coming
in and then we use our uh filters and
there's multiple filters on there that
are being developed to kind of twist and
change that data and so we multiply the
matrixes we take that little filter
maybe it's a 2 by two we multiply it by
each piece of the image and if we step
two then it's every other piece of the
image that generates multiple
convolution ution layers so we have a
number of convolution layers we have um
set up in there just looking at that
data we then take those convolution
layers we run them through the reu setup
and then once we've done through the reu
setup and we have multiple reu going on
multiple layers that are reu then we're
going to take those multiple layers and
we're going to be pooling them so now we
have the pooling layers or multiple
poolings going on up until this point
we're dealing with uh sometimes it's
multiple Dimensions you can have three
dimensions some strange data setups that
aren't doing images but looking at other
things things they can have four five
six seven dimensions uh so right now
we're looking at 2D image Dimensions
coming in into the pooling layer so the
next step is we want to reduce those
Dimensions or flatten them so flattening
flattening is a process of converting
all of the resultant two dimensional
arrays from pulled feature map into a
single long continuous linear Vector so
over here you see where we have a pulled
feature map maybe that's the bird wing
and it has values 6847 and we want to
just flatten this out and turn it into
6847 or a single linear vector and we
find out that not only do we do each of
the pulled feature Maps we do all of
them into one long linear Vector so now
we've gone through our convolutional
neural network part and we have the
input layer into the next setup all
we've done is taken all those different
pooling layers and we flatten them out
and combined them into a single linear
Vector going in so after we've done the
flattening we have just a quick recap
because we've covered so much so it's
important to go back and take a look at
each of the steps we've gone through the
structure of the network so far is we
have our convolution where we twist it
and we filter it multiply the matrixes
we end up with our convolutional layer
which uses the reu to figure out the
values going out into the pooling and
you have numerous convolution layers
that then create numerous pooling layers
pulling that data together which is the
max value which one we want to send
forward we want to send the best value
and then we're going to take all of that
from each of the pooling layers and
we're going to flatten it and we're
going to combine them into a single
input going into the final layer once
you get to that step you might be
looking at that going boy that looks
like the normal inut to most neural
network and you're correct it is so once
we have the flatten Matrix from the
pooling layer that becomes our input so
the pooling layer is fed as an input to
the fully connected layer to classify
the image and so you can see as our
flattened Matrix comes in in this case
we have the pixels from the flattened
Matrix fed as an input back to our
twocan or whatever that kind of bird
that is um I need one of these to
identify what kind of bird that is it
comes into our Ford propagation network
uh and that will then have the different
weights coming down across and then
finally it selects that that's a bird
and that it's not a dog or a cat in this
case even though it's not labeled the
final layer there in red is our output
layer our final output layer that says
bird cat or dog so quick recap of
everything we've covered so far we have
our input image which is twisted and
multiply the filters are multiplied
times the uh matri the two matrixes
multiplied all the filters to create our
convolution layer our convolution layers
there's multiple layers in there because
it's all building multiple layers off
the different filters then goes through
the reu as say activation and that
creates our pooling and so once we get
into the pooling layer we then on the
pooling look for who's the best what's
the max value coming in from our
convolution and then we take that layer
and we flatten it and then it goes into
a fully connected layer or fully
connected neural network and then to the
output and here we can see the entire
process how the CNN recognizes a bird
this is kind of nice cuz it's showing
the little pixels and where they're
going you can see the filter is
generating this convolution network and
that filter shows up in the bottom part
of the convolution network and then
based on that it uses the relo for the
pooling the pooling then find out which
one's the best and so on all the way to
the fully connected layer at the end or
the classification in the output layer
so that'd be a classification neural
network at the end so we covered a lot
of theory up till now and you can
imagine each one of these steps has to
be broken down in code so putting that
together can be a little complicated not
that each step of the process is overly
complicated but because we have so many
steps uh we have 1 2 3 four five
different steps going on here with
substeps in there we're going to break
that down and walk through that in code
so in our use case implementation using
the CNN we'll be using the sear 10 data
set from Canadian Institute for advanced
research for classifying images across
10 categories Unfortunately they don't
let me know whether it's going to be a
twocan or some other kind of bird but we
do get to find out whether it can
categorized between a ship a frog deer
bird airplane automobile cat dog horse
truck so that's a lot of fun and if
you're looking anything in the news at
all of our automated cars and everything
else you can see where this kind of
process processing is so important in
today's world and very Cutting Edge as
far as what's coming out in the
commercial deployment I mean this is
really cool stuff we're starting to see
this just about everywhere in Industry
uh so great time to be playing with this
and figuring it all out let's go ahead
and dive into the code and see what that
looks like when we're actually writing
our script before we go on let's do uh
one more quick look at what we have here
let's just take a look at data batch one
keys and remember in Jupiter notebook I
can get by with not doing the print
statement if I put a variable down there
it'll just display the variable and you
can see under data batch one for the
keys since this is a dictionary we have
the batch one label data and file names
uh so you can actually see how it's
broken up in our data set so for the
next step or step four as we're calling
it uh we want to display the image using
Matt plot Library there's many ways to
display the images you could even uh
well there's other ways to drill into it
but M plot library is really good for
this and we'll also look at at our first
reshape uh setup or shaping the data so
you can have a little glimpse into what
that means uh so we're going to start by
importing our map plot and of course
since I am doing Jupiter notebook I need
to do the map plot inline command so it
shows up on my page so here we go we're
going to import matplot library. pyplot
is PLT and if you remember matplot
Library the PIP plot is like a canvas
that we paint stuff onto and there's my
percentage sign map plot library in line
so it's going to show up in my notebook
and then of course we're going to import
numpy as NP for our numbers python array
setup and let's go ahead and set um x
equals to data batch one so this will
pull in all the data going into the x
value and then because this is just a
long stream of binary data uh we need to
go a little bit of reshaping so in here
we have to go ahead and reshape the data
we have 10,000 images okay that looks
correct and this is kind of an
interesting thing it took me a little
bit to I had to go research this myself
to figure out what's going on with this
data and what it is is it's a 32x 32
picture and let me do this let me go
ahead and do a drawing pad on here uh so
we have 32 bits by 32 bits and it's in
color so there's three bits of color now
I don't know why the data is
particularly like this it probably has
to do with how they originally encoded
it but most pictures put the three
afterward so what we're doing here is
we're going to take uh the shape we're
going to take the data which is just a
long stream of information and we're
going to break it up into 10,000 pieces
and those 10,000 pieces then are broken
into three pieces each and those three
pieces then are 32 by 32 you can look at
this like an oldfashioned projector
where they have the red screen or the
red projector the blue projector and the
green projector and they add them all
together and each one of those is a 32x
32 bit so that's probably how this was
originally formatted within that kind of
ideal things have changed so we're going
to transpose it and we're going to take
the three which was here and we're going
to put it at the end so the first part
is reshaping the data from a single line
of bit data or whatever format it is
into 10,000 by 3x 32x 32 and then we're
going to transpose the color factor to
the last place so it's the image then
the 32x 32 in the middle that's this
part right here and then finally we're
going to take this uh which is three
bits of data and put it at the end so
it's more like we do we process images
now and then as type this is really
important that we're going to use an
integer 8 you can come in here and
you'll see a lot of these they'll try to
do this with a float or float 64 what
you got to remember though is a float
uses a lot of memory so once you switch
this into uh something that's not
integer 8 which is goes up to 128 you
are just going to the the amount of ram
let just put that in here it's going to
go way up the amount of ram that it
loads uh so you want to go ahead and use
this you can try the other ones and see
what happens if you have a lot of RAM on
your computer but for this exercise this
will work just fine and let's go ahead
and take that and run this so now our X
variable is all loaded and it has all
the images in it from the batch one data
batch one and just to show we are
talking about with the as type on there
if we go ahead and take x0 and just look
for its max value let me go ahead and
run that uh you'll see it doesn't oops I
said 128 it's 255 uh you'll see it
doesn't go over 255 because it's an
basically an asky character is what
we're keeping that down to we're keeping
those values down so they're only 255 0
to 255 versus a float value which would
bring this up um exponentially in size
and since we're using the map plot
Library we can do um oops that's not
what I wanted since we're using the map
plot Library we can take our canvas and
just do a PLT do IM for image show and
let's just take a look at what x0 looks
like and it comes in I'm not sure what
that is but you can see it's a very low
grade image uh broken down to the
minimal pixels on there and if we did
the same thing oh let's do uh let's see
what one looks like hopefully it's a
little easier to see run on there not
enter let's hit the run on that uh and
we can see this is probably a semi TR
that's a good guess on there and I can
just go back up here instead of typing
the same line in over and over we'll
look at three uh that looks like a dump
truck unloading uh and so on you can do
any of the 10,000 images we can just
jump to 55 uh looks like some kind of
animal looking at us there probably a
dog and just for fun let's do just one
more uh uh run on there and we can see a
nice car for image number four uh so you
can see we pce through all the different
images and it's very easy to look at
them and they've been reshaped to fit
our view and what the uh map plot
Library uses for its format so the next
step is we're going to start creating
some helper functions we'll start by a
one hot encoder to help us we're
processing the data remember that your
labels they can't just be words they
have to switch it and we use the one hot
encoder to do that and then we'll also
create a uh class uh sear helper so it's
going to have a knit and a setup for the
images and then finally we'll go ahead
and run that code so you can see what
that looks like and then we get into the
fun part where we're actually going to
start creating our model our actual
neural network model so let's start by
creating our one hot encoder we're going
to create our own here uh and it's going
to return an out and we'll have our
Vector coming in and our values equal 10
what this means is that we have the 10
values the 10 possible labels and
remember we don't look at the labels as
a number because a car isn't one more
than a horse and that'd be just kind of
bizarre to have horse equals zero car
equals 1 Plaine equals 2 cat equals 3 so
a cat plus a car equals what uh so in
instead we create a numpy array of zeros
and there's going to be 10 values so we
have a 10 different values in there so
you have uh zero or one one means it's a
cat zero means it's not a cat um in the
next line it might be that uh one means
it's a car zero means it's not a car so
instead of having one output with a
value of 0 to 10 you have 10 outputs
with the values of 0 to one that's what
the one hot encoder is doing here and
we're going to utilize this encode in
just a minute so let's go ahead and take
a look at the next helpers we have a few
of these helper functions we're going to
build and when you're working with a
very complicated python project dividing
it up into separate definitions and
classes is very important otherwise it
just becomes really ungainly to work
with so let's go ahead and put in our
next helper uh which is a class and this
is's a lot in this class so we we'll
break it down here let's just start uh
oops we can put a space right in there
there we go that look a little bit more
readable at a second space so we're
going to to create our class the cipher
Helper and we'll start by initializing
it now there's a lot going on in here so
let's start with the uh a nit part uh
self. I equals z that'll come in in a
little bit we'll come back to that in
the lower part we want to initialize our
training batches so when we went through
this there was like a meta batch we
don't need the meta batch but we do need
the data batch one two 3 four five and
we do not want the testing batch in here
this is just the self all train batches
so we're going to come make an array of
of all those different images and then
of course we left the test batch out so
we have our self. test batch uh we're
going to initialize the training images
and the training labels and also the
test images and the test labels so these
are just this is just to initialize
these variables in here then we create
another definition down here and this is
going to set up the images let's just
take a look and see what's going on in
there now we could have all just put
this as part of the uh in knit part uh
since this is all just helper stuff but
breaking it up again makes it easier to
read it also makes it easier when we
start executing the different pieces to
see what's going on so that way we have
a nice print statement to say hey we're
now running this and this is what's
going on in here we're going to set up
the self-training images at this point
and that's going to go to a numpy array
vstack and in there we're going to load
up uh in this case the data for D and
self all trained batches again that
points right up to here so we're going
to go through each one of these uh files
or each one of these data sets CU
they're not a file anymore we've brought
them in data batch one points to the
actual data and so our self-training
images is going to stack them all into
our into a numpy array and then it's
always nice to get the training length
and that's just a total number of uh
self-training images in there and then
we're going to take the self trining
images and let me switch marker colors
because I am getting a little too much
on the markers up here oops there we go
bring down our marker change so we can
see it a little better and at this point
this should look familiar where did we
see this well when we wanted to uh uh
look at this above and we wanted to look
at the images in the matplot library we
had to reshape it so we're doing the
same thing here we're taking our
self-training images and uh based on the
training length total number of images
because we stacked them all together so
now it's just one large file of images
we're going to take and look at it as
our our three video cameras that are
each displaying uh 32x 32 we're going to
switch that around so that now we have
um each of our images that stays the
same place and then we have our 32 by 32
and then by our three our last our three
different values for the color and of
course we want to go ahead and uh they
run this where we say divide by 255 that
was from earlier it just brings all the
data into 0 to one that's what this is
doing so we're turning this into a z to
one array which is uh all the pictures
32x 32 by 3 and then we're going to take
the self trining labels and we're going
to pump those through our one hot
encoder we just made and we're going to
stack them together and uh again we're
converting this into an array that goes
from uh instead of having horse equals 1
dog equals 2 and then horse plus dog
would equal three which would be cat no
it's going to be uh you know an array of
10 where each one is 0o to one then we
want to go ahead and set up our test
images and labels and uh when we're
doing this you're going to see it's the
same thing we just did with the rest of
them let me just change colors right
here this is no different than what we
were doing up here with our training Set
uh we're going to stack the different uh
images uh we're going to get the length
of them so we know how many images are
in there uh you certainly could add them
by hand but it's nice to let the
computer do it especially if it ever
changes on the other end and you're
using other data and again we reshape
them and transpose them and we also do
the one hot in code coder same thing we
just did on our training images so now
our test images are in the same format
so now we have a definition which sets
up all our images in there and then the
next step is to go ahead and batch them
or next batch and let's do another
breakout here for batches because this
is really important to understand tends
to throw me for a little Loop when I'm
working with tensor flow or coros or a
lot of these we have our data coming in
if you remember we had like 10,000
photos let me just put 10,000 down here
we don't want to run all 10,000 at once
so we want to break this up into batch
sizes and you also remember that we had
the number of photos in this case uh
length of test or whatever number is in
there uh we also have 32 by 32 by 3 so
when we're looking at the batch size we
want to change this from 10,000 to um a
batch of in this case I think we're
going to do batches of 100 so we want to
look at just 100 the first 100 of the
photos and if you remember we set selfi
equal to zero uh so what we're looking
at here is we're going to create X we're
going to get the next batch from the
very initialized we've already
initialized it for zero so we're going
to look at X from zero to batch size
which we set to 100 so just the first
100 images and then we're going to
reshape that into uh and this is
important to let the data know that
we're looking at 100x 32x 32x 3 now
we've formatted it to the 32x 32x 3 this
just sets everything up correctly so
that X has the data in there in the
correct order in the correct shape and
then the Y just like the X uh is our
labels so our training labels again they
go from zero to batch size in this case
they do selfi plus batch size because
the selfi is going to keep changing and
then finally we increment the selfi
because we have zero so we so the next
time we call it we're going to get the
next batch size and so basically we have
X and Y X being the photograph data
coming in and Y being the label and that
of course is labeled through one hot
encoder so if you remember correctly if
it was say a horse is equal to zero it
would be um one for the zero position
since this is the horse and then
everything else would be zero in here me
just put lines through there there we go
there's our array hard to see that array
so let's go ahead and take that and uh
we're going to finish loading it since
this is our class and now we're armed
with all this um uh our setup over here
let's go ahead and load that up and so
we're going to create a variable CH with
the CFR helper in it and then we're
going to do ch. setup images uh now we
could have just put all the setup images
under the init but by breaking this up
into two parts it makes it much more
readable and um also if you're doing
other work there's reasons to do that as
far as the setup let's go ahead and run
that and you can see where it says uh
setting up training images and labels
setting up test images and that's one of
the reasons we broke it up is so that if
you're testing this out you can actually
have print statements in there telling
you what's going on which is really nice
uh they did a good job with this setup I
like the way that it was broken up in
the back and then one quick note you
want to remember that batch to set up
the next batch is we have to run uh
batch equals CH next batch of 100
because we're going to use the 100 size
uh but we'll come back to that we're
going to use that just remember that
that's part of our code we're going to
be using in a minute from the definition
we just made so now we're ready to
create our model first thing want to do
is we want to import our tensor flow as
TF I'll just go ahead and run that so
it's loaded up and you can see we got a
a warning here uh that's because they're
making some changes it's always growing
and they're going to be depreciating one
of the uh values from float 64 to float
type or it's treated as an NP float 64
uh nothing to really worry about cuz
this doesn't even affect what we're
working on because we've set all of our
stuff to a 255 value or 0 to one and do
keep in mind that 0 to one value that we
converted the 255 is still a float value
uh but it'll easily work with either the
uh numpy float 64 or the numpy D type
float it doesn't matter which one it
goes through so the depreciation would
not affect our code as we have it and in
our tensor flow uh we'll go ahead let me
just increase the size in there just a
moment so you can get better view of the
um what we're typing in uh we're going
to set a couple placeholders here and so
we have we're going to set x equals TF
placeholder TF float 32 we just talked
about the float 64 versus the numpy
float we're actually just going to keep
this at float 32 more than uh
significant number of decimals for what
we're working with and since it's a
placeholder we're going to set the shape
equal to and we've set it equal to none
because at this point we're just hold
holding the place on there we'll be
setting up as we run the batches that's
what the first value is and then 32x 32x
3 that's what we've reshaped our data to
fit in and then we have our y true
equals placeholder TF float 3 2 and the
shape equals none comma 10 10 is the 10
different labels we have so it's an
array of 10 and then let's create one
more placeholder we'll call this a hold
prob or hold probability and we're going
to use this we don't have to have a
shape or anything for this this
placeholder is for what we call Dropout
if you remember from our Theory before
we drop out so many nodes is looking at
or the different values going through
which helps decrease bias so we need to
go ahead and put a a placeholder for
that all also and we'll run this so it's
all loaded up in there so we have our
three different placeholders and since
we're in tensor flow when you use carass
it does some of this automatically but
we're in tensorflow direct sits on
tensor flow we're going to go ahead and
create some more helper functions we're
going to create something to help us
initialize the weights initialize our
bias if you remember that each uh layer
has to have a bias going in we're going
to go ahead and work on our our
conversional 2D our Max pool so we have
our pooling layer our convolutional
layer and then our normal full layer so
we're going to go ahead and put those
all into definitions and let's see what
that looks like in code and you can also
grab some of these helper functions from
the MN s the uh nist setup let me just
put that in there if you're under the
tensor flow so a lot of these are
already in there but we're going to go
ahead and do our own and we're going to
create our uh a knit weights and one of
the reasons we're doing this is so that
you can actually start thinking about
what's going on in the back end so even
though there's ways to do this with an
automation sometimes these have to be
tweaked and you have to put in your own
setup in here uh now we're not going to
be doing that we're just going to
recreate them for our code and let's
take a look at this we have our weights
and so what comes in is going to be the
shape and what comes out is going to be
uh random numbers so we're going to go
ahead and just knit some random numbers
based on the shape with a standard
deviation of 0.1 kind of a fun way to do
that and then the TF variable uh in nit
random distribution so we're just
creating a random distribution on there
that's all that is for the weights now
you might change that you might have a a
higher standard deviation in some cases
you actually load preset weights that's
pretty rare usually you're testing that
against another model or something like
that and you want to see how those
weights configure with each other uh now
remember we have our bias so we need to
go ahead and initialize the bias with a
constant uh in this case we're using 0.1
a lot of times the bias is just put in
as one and then you have your weights to
add on to that uh but we're going to set
this as 0.1 uh so we want to return a
convolutional 2d in this case a neural
network this is uh would be a layer on
here what's going on with the con 2D is
we're taking our data coming in uh we're
going to filter it strides if you
remember correctly strides came from
here's our image and then we only look
at this picture here and then maybe we
have a stride of one so we look at this
picture here and we continue to look at
the different filters going on there the
other thing this does is that we have
our data coming in as 32 by
32 by 3 and we want to change this so
that it's just this is three dimensions
and it's going to reformat this as just
two Dimensions so it's going to take
this number here and combine it with the
32x 32 so this is a very important layer
here because it's reducing our data down
using different means and it connects
down I'm just going to jump down one
here uh it goes with the convolutional
layer so you have your your kind of your
pre- formatting and the setup and then
you have your actual convolution layer
goes through on there and you can see
here we have a knit weights by the shape
a knit bias shape of three because we
have the three different uh here's our
three again and then we return the tfnn
relu with the convention 2D so this
convolutional uh has this feeding into
it right there it's using that as part
of it and of course the input is the XY
plus b the bias so that's quite a
mouthful but these two are the are the
keys here to creating the convolutional
layers there the convolutional 2D coming
in and then the convolutional layer
which then steps through and creates all
those filters we saw then of course we
have our pooling uh so after each time
we run it through the convectional layer
we want to pull the data uh if you
remember correctly on the on the pool
side and let me just get rid of all my
marks it's getting a little crazy there
and in fact let's go ahead and jump back
to that slide let's just take a look at
that slide over here uh so we have our
image coming in we create our
convolutional layer with all the filters
remember the filters go um you know the
filters coming in here and it looks at
these four boxes and if it's a step
let's say step two it then goes to these
four boxes and then the next step and so
on uh so we have our convolutional layer
that we generate or convolutional layers
they use the uh reu function um there's
other functions out there for this
though the reu is the uh most the one
that works the best at least so far I'm
sure that will change then we have our
pooling now if you remember correctly
the pooling was Max uh so if we had the
filter coming in and they did the
multiplication on there and we have a
one and maybe a two here and another one
here and a three here three is the max
and so out of all of these you then
create an array that would be three and
if the max is over here two or whatever
it is that's what goes into the pooling
of what's going on in our pooling uh so
again we're reducing that data down
we're reducing it down as small as we
can and then finally we're going to
flatten it out into a single array and
that goes into our fully connected layer
and you can see that here in the the
code right here we're going to create
our normal full layer um so at some
point we're going to take from our
pooling layer this will go into some
kind of flattening process and then that
will be fed into the full the different
layers going in down here um and so we
have our input size you'll see our input
layer get shape which is just going to
get the shape for whatever is coming in
uh and then input size initial weights
is also based on uh the input layer
coming in and the input size down here
is based on the input layer shape so
we're just just going to already use the
shape and already have our size coming
in and of course uh you have to make
sure you init the bias always put your
bias on there and we'll do that based on
the size so this will return tf. matmo
input layer w+b this is just a normal
full layer that's what this means right
down here that's what we're going to
return so that was a lot of steps we
went through let's go ahead and run that
so those are all loaded in there and
let's go ahead and uh create the layers
let's see what that looks like now that
we've done all the heavy lifting and
everything uh we get to do all the easy
part let's go ahead and create our
layers we'll create a convolution layer
one and two two different convolutional
layers and then we'll take that and
we'll flatten that out create a a
reshape pooling in there for our reshape
and then we'll have our full uh layer at
the end so let's start by creating our
first uh convolutional layer then we
come in here and let me just run that
real quick and I want you to notice on
here the three and and the 32 this is
important because coming into this
convolutional layer we have three
different channels and 32 pixels each uh
so that has to be in there the four and
four you can play with this is your
filter size so if you remember you have
a filter and you have your image and the
filter slowly steps over and filters out
this image depending on what your step
is for this particular setup 44 is just
fine that should work pretty good for
what we're doing and for the size of the
image and then of course at the end once
you have your convolutional layer set up
you also need to pull it and you'll see
that the pooling is automatically set up
so that it would see the different shape
based on what's coming in so here we
have Max two 2 by two and we put in the
convolutional one that we just created
the convolutional layer we just created
goes right back into it and that right
up here as you can see is the X it's
coming in from here so it knows to look
at the first model and set the the data
accordingly set that up so it matches
and we went ahead and ran this already I
think I ran let me go and run it again
and if we're going to do one layer let's
go ahead and do a second layer down here
and it's we'll call it convo 2 it's also
a convolutional layer on this and you'll
see that we're feeding convolutional one
in the pooling so it goes from
convolutional one into convolutional one
pooling from convolutional one pooling
into convolutional two and then from
convolutional two into convolutional two
pooling and we'll go ahead and take this
and run this so these variables are all
loaded into memory and for our flatten
layer uh let's go ahead and we'll do uh
since we have 64 coming out of here and
we have uh 4x4 going in let's do 8X 8X
64 so let's do
4,096 this is going to be the flat layer
so that's how many bits are coming
through on the flat layer and we'll
reshape this so we'll reshape our uh
convo 2 pooling and that will feed into
here the convo two pooling and then
we're going to set it up as a single
layer that's 4,096 in size that's what
that means there we'll go ahead and run
this so we've now created this variable
the convo two flat and then we have our
first full layer this is the final uh
neural network where we have the flat
layer going in and we're going to again
use the uh reu for our uh setup on there
on a neural network for evaluation and
you'll notice that we're going to create
our first full layer our normal full
layer that's our definition so we
created that that's creating the normal
full layer and our input for the data
comes right here from the this goes
right into it uh the convo 2 flat so
this tells it how big the data is and
we're going to have it come out it's
going to have uh 1024 that's how big the
layer is coming out we'll go ahead and
run this so now we have our full layer
one and with the full layer one we want
to also Define the full one Dropout to
go with that so our full layer one comes
in uh keep probability equals whole
probability remember we created that
earlier and the full layer one is what's
coming into it and this is going
backwards and training the data we're
not training every weight we're only
training a percentage of them each time
which helps get rid of the bias so let
me go ahead and run that and uh finally
we'll go ahead and create a y predict
which is going to equal the normal full
one Dropout and 10 because we have 10
labels in there now in this neural
network we could have added additional
layers that would be another option to
play with you can also play with instead
of 1024 you can use other numbers for
the way that sets up and what's coming
out going into the next one we're only
going to do just the one layer and the
one layer Dropout and you can see if we
did another layer it'd be really easy
just to feed in the full one Dropout
into full layer two and then full Layer
Two Dropout would have full Layer Two
feed into it and then you'd switch that
here for the Y prediction for right now
this is great this particular data set
is tried and true and we know that this
will work on it and if we just type in y
predict and we run that uh we'll see
that this is a tensor object uh shape
question mark 10 dtype 32 uh quick way
to double check what we're working on so
now we've got all of our uh we've done a
setup all the way to the Y predict which
we just did uh we want to go ahead and
apply the loss function and make sure
that's set up in there uh create the
optimizer and then uh trainer Optimizer
and create a variable to initialize all
the global TF variables so before we
dive into the um loss function let me
point out one quick thing or just kind
of a rehap over a couple things and that
is when we're playing with this these
setups um we pointed out up here we can
change the 44 and use different numbers
there they change your outcome so
depending on what numbers you use here
will have a huge impact on how well your
model fits and that's the same here of
the 1024 also this is also another
number that if you continue to raise
that number you'll get um possibly a
better fit you might overfit and if you
lower that number you'll use less
resources and generally you want to use
this in um the exponential growth an
exponential being 2 4 8 16 and in this
case the next one down would be 512 you
can use any number there but those would
be the ideal numbers uh when you look at
this data so the next step in all this
is we need to also create uh a way of
tracking how good our model is and we're
going to call this a lot function and so
we're going to create a cross entropy
loss function and so before we discuss
exactly what that is let's take a look
and see what we're feeding it uh we're
going to feed it our labels and we have
our true labels and our prediction
labels uh so coming in here as we're the
two different uh variables we're sending
in or the two different probability
distributions is one that we know is
true and what we think it's going to be
now this function right here when they
talk about cross entropy uh in
information Theory the cross entrop
between two probability distributions
over the same underlying set of events
measures the average number of bits
needed to identify an event drawn from
the set that's a mouthful uh really
we're just looking at the amount of
error in here how many of these are
correct and how many of these um are
incorrect so how much of it matches and
we're going to look at that we're just
going to look at the average that's what
the mean the reduced to the mean means
here so we're looking at the average
error on this and so the next step is
we're going to take the error we want to
know our cross entropy or our loss
function how much loss we have that's
going to be part of how we train the
model so when you know what the loss is
and we're training it you feed that back
into the back propagation setup and so
we want to go ahead and optimize that
here's our Optimizer we're going to
create the optimizer using an atom
Optimizer remember there's a lot of
different ways of optimizing the data
atoms the most popular used uh so our
Optimizer is going to equal the TF train
atom Optimizer if you don't remember
what the learning rate is let me just
pop this back into here here's our
learning rate when you have your weights
you have all your weights in your
different nodes that are coming out
here's our node coming out um and it has
all its weights and then the error is
being prop sent back through in reverse
on our neural network so we take this
error and we adjust these weights based
on the different formulas in this case
the atom formulas what we're using we
don't want to just adjust them
completely we don't want to change this
weight so it exactly fits the data
coming through cuz if we made that kind
of adjustment it's going to be biased to
whatever the last data we sent through
is instead we're going to multiply that
by 0.001 and make a very small shift in
this weight so our Delta W is only 0.001
of the actual Delta W of the full change
we're going to compute from the atom and
then we want to go ahead and train it so
our training or set up a training uh uh
variable or function and this is going
to equal our Optimizer minimize cross
entropy and we make sure we go ahead and
run this so so it's loaded in there and
then we're almost ready to train our
model but before we do that we need to
create one more um variable in here and
we're going to create a variable to
initialize all the global TF variables
and when we look at this um the TF
Global variable initializer this is a
tensor flow um object it goes through
there and it looks at all our different
setup that we have going under our
tensor flow and then initializes those
variables uh so it's kind of like a
magic one because it's all hidden in the
back end of 10 flow all you need to know
about this is that you have to have the
initialization on there which is an
operation um and you have to run that
once you have your setup going so we'll
go ahead and run this piece of code and
then we're going to go ahead and train
our data so let me run this so it's
loaded up there and so now we're going
to go ahead and run the model by
creating a graph session graph session
is a tensorflow term so you'll see that
coming up it's one of the things that
throws me because I always think of
graphics and Spark and graph as just
general graphing uh but they talk about
a graph session so we're going to go
ahead and run the model and let's go
ahead and walk through this uh what's
going on here and let's paste this data
in here and here we go so we're going to
start off with the with a TF session as
sess so that's our actual TF session
we've created uh so we're right here
with the TF uh session our session we're
creating we're going to run TF Global
variable initializer so right off the
bat we're initializing our variables
here uh and then we have for I in range
500 so what's going on here remember 500
we're going to break the data up and
we're going to batch it in at 500 points
each we've created our session run so
we're going to do with TF session as
session right here we've created our
variable session uh and then we're going
to run and we're going to go ahead and
initialize it so we have our TF Global
variables initializer that we created um
that initializes our our session in here
the next thing we're going to do is
we're going to go for or I in range of
500 batch equals ch. next batch so if
you remember correctly this is loading
up um 100 pictures at a time and uh this
is going to Loop through that 500 times
so we are literally doing uh what is
that uh 500 * 100 is uh 50,000 so that's
50,000 pictures we're going to process
right there in the first process is
we're going to do a session run we're
going to take our train we created our
train variable or Optimizer in there
we're going to feed it the dictionary uh
we had our feed dictionary that created
and we have x equals batch 0 coming in y
true batch one hold the probability 0.5
and then just so that we can keep track
of what's going on we're going to every
uh 100 steps we're going to run a print
So currently on step format C accuracy
is um and we're going to look at matches
equals tf. equal TF argument y
prediction one tf. AR match X Y true
comma one so we're going to look at this
as how many matches it has and here our
ACC uh all we're doing here is we're
going to take the matches how many
matches they have it creates it
generates a chart we're going to convert
that to float that's what the TF cast
does and then we just want to know the
average we just want to know the average
of the um accuracy and then we'll go
ahead and print that out uh print
session run accuracy feed dictionary so
it takes all this and it prints out our
accuracy on there so let's go ahead and
take this oops FP screens there let's go
ahead and take this and let's run it and
this is going to take a little bit to
run uh so let's see what happens on my
old laptop and we'll see here that we
have our current uh we're currently on
Step Zero it takes a little bit to get
through the accuracy and this will take
just a moment to run we can see that on
our Step Zero it has an accuracy of 0.1
or
0.128 um and as this running we'll go
ahead you don't need to watch it run all
the way but uh this accuracy is going to
change a little bit up and down so we've
actually locked L some accuracy during
our step two um but we'll see how that
comes out let's come back after we run
it all the way through and see how the
different steps come out I was actually
reading that backwards uh the way this
works is the closer we get to one the
more accuracy we have uh so you can see
here we've gone from a 0.1 to a 39 um
and we'll go ahead and pause this and
come back and see what happens when
we're done with the uh full run all
right now that we've uh prepared the
meal got it in the oven and pulled out
my finished disc here if you've ever
watched uh any of the old cooking shows
let's discuss a little bit about this
accuracy going on here and how do you
interpret that we've done a couple
things first we've defined accuracy um
the reason I got it backwards before is
you have uh loss or accuracy and with
loss you'll get a graph that looks like
this it goes oops that's an S by the way
there we go you get a graph that curves
down like this and with accuracy you get
a graph that curves up this is how good
it's doing doing now in this case uh one
is supposed to be really good accuracy
that means it gets close to one but it
never crosses one so if you have an
accuracy of one that is phenomenal um in
fact that's pretty much un you know
unheard of and the same thing with loss
if you have a loss of zero that's also
unheard of the Zero's actually on this
this axis right here as we go in there
so how do we interpret that because you
know if I was looking at this and I go
oh 51 that's uh 51% you're doing 50/50
no this is not percent
let me just put that in there it is not
percentage uh this is
logarithmic what that means is that 0 2
is twice as good as 0.1 and uh when we
see 0 4 that's twice as good as 0 2 real
way to convert this into a percentage
you really can't say this is is a direct
percentage conversion what you can do
though is in your head if we were to
give this a percentage uh we might look
at this as uh 50% we're just guessing
equals 0.1 and if 50% roughly equals 0.1
that's where we started up here at the
top remember at the top here here's our
0.128 the accuracy of 50% then 75% is
about .2 and so on and so on don't quote
those numbers because that doesn't work
that way they say that if you have
.95 that's pretty much saying 100% And
if you have a anywhere between you'd
have to go look this up let me go and
remove all my drawings there uh so the
magic number is 0.5 we really want to be
over a 05 in this whole thing and we
have uh both 0504 remember this is
accuracy if we were looking at loss then
we'd be looking the other way but 0.0
you know instead of how high it is we
want how low it is uh but with accuracy
being over a 0 five is pretty valid that
means this is pretty solid and if you
get to a 0.95 then it's a direct
correlation that's what we're looking
for here in these numbers you can see we
finished with this model at0 5135 so
still good um and if we look at uh when
they ran this in the other end remember
there's a lot of Randomness that goes
into it when we see the weights uh they
got 0. 5251 so a little better than ours
but that's fine you'll find your own uh
comes up a little bit better or worse
depending on uh just that Randomness and
so we've gone through the whole model
we've created we trained the model and
we've also gone through on every 100th
run to test the model to see how
accurate it
is what's in it for you we will start
with a course of fundamentals what is a
neural network and popular neural
networks it's important to know the
framework we're in and what we're going
to be looking at specifically then we'll
touch on why a recurrent neural network
what is a recurrent neural network and
how does an RNN work uh one of the big
things about rnns is what they call the
vanishing and exploding gradient problem
so we'll look at that and then we're
going to be using a use case uh study
that's going to be in carass on tensor
flow carass is a python module for doing
neural networks in deep learning and uh
in there there's the what they call long
shortterm memory lstm and then we'll use
the use case to implement our lstm on
the carass so when you see that lstm
that is basically the RNN Network and
we'll get into that the use case is
always my favorite part before we dive
into any of this we're going to take a
look at what is an RNN or an
introduction to the RNN do you know how
Google's autocomplete feature predicts
the rest of the words a user is typing I
love that autocomplete feature as I'm
typing away saves me a lot of time I can
just kind of Hit the enter key and it
autofills everything and I don't have to
type as much well first there's a
collection of large volumes of most
frequently occurring consecutive words
uh this is fed into a recurrent neural
network analysis the data by finding the
sequence of words occurring frequently
and builds a model to predict the next
word in the sentence and then Google
what is the best food to eat in loss I'm
guessing you're going to say l Mexico no
it's going to be Las Vegas uh so the
Google search will take a look at that
and say hey the most common auto
complete is going to be Vegas in there
and usually gives you three or four
different choices so it's a very
powerful tool it saves us a lot of time
especially when we're doing a Google
search or even in Microsoft Words has a
some people get very mad at it it auto
fills with the wrong stuff uh but you
know you're typing away and it helps you
autofill I have that in a lot of my
different packages it's just a standard
feature that we're all used to now so
before we dive into the RNN and getting
Into the Depths let's go ahead and talk
about what is a neural network neural
networks used in deep learning consist
of different layers connected to each
other and work on the structure and
functions of a human brain you're going
to see that thread human in human brain
and human thinking throughout deep
learning the only way we can evaluate an
artificial intelligence or anything like
that is to compare it to human function
very important note on there and it
learns from a huge volumes of data and
it uses complex algorithm to train a
neural net so in here we have image
pixels of two different breeds of dog uh
one looks like a nice floppy eared lab
and one a German Shepherd you know both
wonderful breeds of animals that image
then goes into an input layer uh that
input layer might be formatted at some
point because you have to let it know
like you know different pictures are
going to be different sizes and
different color content then it'll feed
into hidden layers so each of those
pixels or each pointed data goes in and
then um splits into the hidden layer
which then goes into another hidden
layer which then goes to an output layer
RNN there's some changes in there which
we're going to get into so it's not just
a straightforward propagation of data
like we've covered in many other
tutorials and finally you have an output
layer and the output layer has two
outputs it has one that lights up if
it's a German shepherd and another that
lights up it's if it's a labador so
identifies the dog's breed such networks
do not require memorizing the past
output so our forward propagation is
just that it goes forward it doesn't
have to rememorize stuff and you can see
there that's not actually me in the
picture uh dressed up in my
suit I haven't worn a suit in years so
as we're looking at this we're going to
change it up a little bit before we
cover that let's talk about popular
neural networks first there's the feed
forward neural network used in general
regression and classific if ation
problems and we have the convolution
neural network used for image
recognition deep neural network used for
acoustic modeling deep belief Network
used for cancer detection and recurrent
neural network used for speech
recognition now taking a lot of these
and mix them around a little bit so just
because it's used for one thing doesn't
mean it can't be used for other modeling
but generally this is where the field is
and this is how those models are
generally being used right now so we
talk about a feed forward neural n
Network in a feed forward neural network
information flows only in the forward
direction from the input nodes through
the hidden layers if any into the output
nodes there are no Cycles or Loops in
the network and so you can see here we
have our input layer I was talking about
how it just goes straight forward into
the hidden layers so each one of those
connects and then connects to the next
hidden layer connects to the output
layer and of course we have a nice
simplified version where it has a
predicted output and they refer to the
input is X a lot of times and the output
as y decisions are based on current
input no memory about the past no future
scope why recurrent neural network
issues in feed forward neural network so
one of the biggest issues is because it
doesn't have a scope of memory or time a
feed forward neural network doesn't know
how to handle sequential data uh it only
considers only the current input so if
you have a series of things and because
three points back affects what's
happening now and what your output
affects what's happening that's very
important so whatever I put as an output
is going to affect the next one um a
feed forward doesn't look at any any of
that it just looks at this is what's
coming in and it cannot memorize
previous inputs so it doesn't have that
list of inputs coming in solution to
feed forward neural network you'll see
here where it says recurrent neural
network and we have our X on the bottom
going to H going to Y that's your feed
forward uh but right in the middle it
has a value C so it's a whole another
process it's memorizing what's going on
in the hidden layers and the hidden
layers as they produce data feed into
the next one so your hidden layer might
have an output that goes off to why uh
but that output goes back into the next
prediction coming in what this does is
this allows it to handle sequential data
it considers the current input and also
the previously received inputs and if
we're going to look at General drawings
and um Solutions we should also look at
applications of the RNN image captioning
RNN is used to caption an image by
analyzing the activities present in it a
dog catching a ball in midair uh that's
very tough I mean you know we have a lot
of stuff that analyzes images of a dog
and the image of a ball but it's able to
add one more feature in there that's
actually catching the ball in midair
time series prediction any time series
problem like predicting the prices of
stocks in a particular month can be
solved using RNN and we'll dive into
that in our use case and actually take a
look at some stock one of the things you
should know about analyzing stock today
is that it is very difficult and if
you're analyzing the whole stock the
stock market at the New York Stock
Exchange in the US produces somewhere in
the neighborhood if you count all the
individual trades and fluctuations by
the second um it's like 3 terabytes a
day of data so we're only to look at one
stock just analyzing One stock is really
tricky in here we'll give you a little
jump on that so that's exciting but
don't expect to get rich off of it
immediately another application of the
RNN is natural language processing text
Mining and sentiment analysis can be
carried out using RNN for natural
language processing and you can see
right here the term natural language
processing when you stream those three
words together is very different than I
if I said processing language natural
leave so the time series is very
important when we're analyzing
sentiments it can change the whole value
of a sentence just by switching the
words around or if you're just counting
the words you might get one sentiment
where if you actually look at the order
there in you get a completely different
sentiment when it rains look for
rainbows when it's dark look for stars
both of these are positive sentiments
and they're based upon the order of
which the sentence is going in machine
translate given an input in one language
RNN can be used to translate the input
into a different languages as output I
myself very linguistically challenged
but if you study languages and you're
good with languages you know right away
that if you're speaking English you
would say big cat and if you're speaking
Spanish you would say cat big so that
translation is really important to get
the right order to get there's all kinds
of parts of speech that are important to
know by the order of the words here this
person is speaking in English and
getting translated and you can see here
a person is speaking in English in this
little diagram I guess that's denoted by
the flags I have a flag I own it no um
but they're speaking in English and it's
getting translated into Chinese Italian
French German and Spanish languages some
of the tools coming out are just so cool
so somebody like myself who's very
linguistically challenged I can now
travel into Worlds I would never think
of because I can have something
translate my English back and forth
readily and I'm not stuck with a
communication gap so let's dive into
what is a recurrent neural network
recurrent neural network works on the
principle of saving the output of a
layer and feeding this back to the input
in order to predict the output of the
layer sounds a little confusing when we
start breaking it down it'll make more
sense and usually we have a propagation
forward neural network with the input
layers the hidden layers the output
layer with the recurrent neural network
we turn that on its side so here it is
and now our X comes up from the bottom
into the hidden layers into Y and they
usually draw very simplified X to H with
c as a loop a to Y where a B and C are
the perimeters a lot of times you'll see
this kind of drawing in here digging
closer and closer into the H and how it
works going from left to right you'll
see that the C goes in and then the X
goes in so the x is going Upward Bound
and C is going to the right a is going
out and C is also going out that's where
it gets a little confusing so here we
have xn CN and then we have y out and C
out and C is based on HT minus one so
our value is based on the Y and the H
value are connected to each other
they're not necessarily the same value
because H can be its own thing and
usually we draw this or we represent it
as a function h of T equals a function
of C where H of T minus one that's the
last H output and x a t going in so it's
the last output of H combined with the
new input of x uh where HT is the new
state FC is a function with the
parameter C that's a common way of
denoting it uh HT minus one is the Old
State coming out and then xit T is an
input Vector at time of Step T well we
need to cover types of recurrent neural
networks and so the first one is the
most common one which is a onetoone
single output one toone neural network
is usually known as a vanilla neural
network used for regular machine
learning problems why because vanilla's
us considered kind of a just a real
basic flavor but because it's a very
basic a lot of times they'll call it the
vanilla neural network uh which is not
the common term but it is you know like
kind of a slang term people will know
what you're talking about usually if you
say that then we run one to mini so you
have a single input and you might have a
multiple outputs in this case uh image
captioning as we looked at earlier where
we have not just looking at it as a dog
but a dog catching a ball in the air and
then you have many to One Network takes
in a sequence of inputs examples
sentiment analysis where a given
sentence can be classified as expressing
positive or negative sentiments and we
looked at that as we were discussing if
it rains look for a rainbow so positive
sentiment where rain might be a negative
sentiment if you were just adding up the
words in there and then of course if
you're going to do a one to one many to
one one to many there's many to many
networks takes in a sequence of inputs
and generates a sequence of outputs
example machine translation so we have a
lengthy sentence coming in in English
and then going out in all the different
languages uh you know just a wonderful
tool very complicated set of
computations you know if you're a
translator you realize just how
difficult it is to translate into
different languages one of the biggest
things you need to understand when we're
working with this neural network is
what's called The Vanishing gradient
problem while training an RNN your slope
can be either too small or very large
and this makes training difficult when
the slope is too small the problem is
known as Vanishing gradient and you'll
see here they have a nice U image loss
of information through time so if you're
pushing not enough information forward
that information is lost and then when
you go to train it you start losing the
third word in the sentence or something
like that or it doesn't quite follow the
full logic of what you're working on
exploding gradient problem Oh this is
one that runs into everybody when you're
working with this particular neural
network when the slope tends to grow
exponentially instead of decaying this
problem is called exploding gradient
issues in gradient problem Long training
time poor performance bad accuracy and
I'll add one more in there uh your
computer if you're on a lower-end
computer testing out a model will lock
up and give you the memory error
explaining gradient problem consider the
following two examples to understand
what should be the next word in the
sequence the person who took my bike and
blank a thief the students who got into
engineering with blank from Asia and you
can see in here we have our x value
going in we have the previous value
going forward and then you back
propagate the error like you do with any
neural network and as we're looking for
that missing word maybe we'll have the
person took my bike and blank was a
thief and the student who got into
engineering with a blank were from Asia
consider the following example the
person who took the bike so we'll go
back to the person who took the bike was
blank a thief in order to understand
what would be the next word in the
sequence the RNN must memorize the
previous context whether the subject was
singular noun or a plural noun so was a
thief is singular the student who got
into engineering well in order to
understand what would be the next word
in the sequence the RNN must memorize
the previous context whether the subject
was singular noun or a plural noun and
so you can see here the students who got
into engineering with blank were from
Asia it might be sometimes difficult for
the eror to back propagate to the
beginning of the sequence to predict
what should be the output so when you
run into the gradient problem we need a
solution the the solution to the
gradient problem first we're going to
look at exploding gradient where we have
three different solutions depending on
what's going on one is identity
initialization so the first thing we
want to do is see if we can find a way
to minimize the identities coming in
instead of having it identify everything
just the important information we're
looking at next is to truncate the back
propagation so instead of having uh
whatever information it's sending to the
next series we can truncate what it's
sending we can low for that particular
uh set of layers make those smaller and
finally is a gradient clipping so when
we're training it we can clip with that
gradient looks like and narrow the
training model that we're using when you
have a Vanishing gradient the option
problem uh we can take a look at weight
initialization very similar to the
identity but we're going to add more
weights in there so it can identify
different aspects of what's coming in
better choosing the right activation
function that's huge so we might be
activating based on one thing and we
need to limit that we haven't talked too
much about activation function so we'll
look at that just minimally uh there's a
lot of choices out there and then
finally there's long short-term memory
networks the
lstms and we can make adjustments to
that so just like we can clip the
gradient as it comes out we can also um
expand on that we can increase the
memory Network the size of it so it
handles more information and one of the
most common problems in today's uh setup
is what they call longterm dependencies
suppose we try to predict the last word
in the text the clouds are in the and
you probably said sky here we do not
need any further context it's pretty
clear that the last word is going to be
Sky suppose we try to predict the last
word in the text I have been staying in
Spain for the last 10 years I can speak
fluent maybe you said Portuguese or
French no you probably said Spanish the
word we predict will depend on the
previous few words in context here we
need the context of Spain to predict the
last word in the text it's POS possible
that the gap between the relevant
information and the point where it is
needed to become very large
lstms help us solve this problem so the
lstms are a special kind of recurrent
neural network capable of learning
long-term dependencies remembering
information for long periods of time is
their default Behavior All recurrent
neural networks have the form of a chain
of repeating modules of neural network
connections in standard rnns this
repeating module have a very simple
structure such as a single tangent H
layer lstm s's also have a chain-like
structure but the repeating module has a
different structure instead of having a
single neural network layer there are
four interacting layers communicating in
a very special way lstms are a special
kind of recurrent neural network capable
of learning long-term dependencies
remembering information for long periods
of time is their default Behavior LST
tms's also have a chain-like structure
but the repeating module has a different
structure instead of having a single
neural network layer there are four
interacting layers communicating in a
very special way as you can see the
deeper we dig into this the more
complicated the graphs kit in here I
want you to note that you have X of T
minus one coming in you have X of T
coming in and you have X of t + one and
you have H of T minus one and H of T
coming in and H of t+ one going out and
of course uh on the other side is the
output a um in the middle we have our
tangent H but it occurs in two different
places so not only when we're Computing
the x of t + one are we getting the
tangent H from X of T but we're also
getting that value coming in from the X
of T minus one so the short of it is as
you look at these layers not only does
it does the propagate through the first
layer goes into the second layer back
into itself but it's also going into the
third layer so now we're kind of
stacking those up and this can get very
complicated as you grow that inside it
also grows in memory too and in the
amount of resources it takes uh but it's
a very powerful tool to help us address
the problem of complicated long
sequential information coming in like we
were just looking at in the sentence and
when we're looking at our long shortterm
memory network uh there's three steps of
processing assing in the lstms that we
look at the first one is we want to
forget irrelevant parts of the previous
state you know a lot of times like you
know is as in a unless we're trying to
look at whether it's a plural noun or
not they don't really play a huge part
in the language so we want to get rid of
them then selectively update cell State
values so we only want to update the
cell State values that reflect what
we're working on and finally we want to
put only output certain parts of the
cell state so whatever is coming out we
want to limit what's going out too and
let's dig a little deeper into this
let's just see what this really looks
like uh so step one decides how much of
the past it should remember first step
in the lstm is to decide which
information to be omitted in from the
cell in that particular time step it is
decided by the sigmoid function it looks
at the previous state h of T minus one
and the current input X of T and
computes the function so you can see
over here we have a function of T equals
the sigmoid function of the weight of f
the H at T minus one and then X at t
plus of course you have a bias in there
with any ver neural networks so we have
a bias function so F of T equals forget
gate
decides which information to delete that
is not important from the previous time
step considering an L STM is fed with
the following inputs from the previous
and present time step Alice is good in
physics JN on the other hand is good in
chemistry so previous output John plays
football well he told me yesterday over
the phone that he had served as a
captain of his college football team
that's our current input so as we look
at this the first step is the forget
gate realizes there might be a change in
context after encountering the First
full stop Compares with the current
input sentence of xit so we're looking
at that full stop and then Compares it
with the input of the new sentence the
next sentence talks about John so the
information on Alice is deleted okay
that's important to know so we have this
input coming in and if we're going to
continue on with John then that's going
to be the primary information we're
looking at the position of the subject
is vacated and is assigned to John and
so in this one we've seen that we've
weeded out a whole bunch of information
and we're only pass information on John
since that's now the new topic so step
two is then to decide how much should
this unit add to the current state in
the second layer there are two parts one
is a sigmoid function and the other is a
tangent H in the sigmoid function it
decides which values to let through zero
or one tangent 8 function gives the
weightage to the values which are passed
deciding their level of importance minus
one to one and you can see the two
formulas that come up uh the I of T
equals the sigmoid of the weight weight
of i h of t minus1 x of t plus the bias
of I and the C of T equals the tangent
of H of the weight of C of H of T minus
one X of t plus the bias of C so our I
of T equals the input gate determines
which information to let through based
on its significance in the current time
step if this seems a little complicated
don't worry because a lot of the
programming is already done when we get
to the case study understanding though
that this is part of the program is
important when you're trying to figure
out these what to set your settings at
you should also note when you're looking
at this it should have some semblance to
your forward propagation neural networks
where we have a value assigned to a
weight plus a bias very important steps
than any of the neural network layers
whether we're propagating into them the
information from one to the next or
we're just doing a straightforward
neural network propagation let's take a
quick look at this what it looks like
from the human standpoint um as I step
out of my suit again consider the
current input at of te John plays
football well he told me yesterday over
the phone that he had served as a
captain of his college football team
that's our input input gate analysis the
important information John plays
football and he was a captain of his
college team is important he told me
over the phone yesterday is less
important hence it is forgotten this
process of adding some new information
can be done via the input gate now this
example is as a human form and we'll
look at training this stuff in just a
minute uh but as a human being if I
wanted to get this information from a
conversation maybe it's a Google Voice
listening in on you or something like
that um how do we weed out the
information that he was talking to me on
the phone yesterday well I don't want to
memorize that he talked to me on the
phone yesterday or maybe that is
important but in this case it's not I
want to know that he was the captain of
the football team I want to know that he
sered I want to know that John plays
football and he was the captain of the
college football team those are the two
things that I want to take away as a
human being again we measure a lot of
this from the human viewpoint and that's
also how we try to train them so we can
understand these neural networks finally
we get to step three decides what part
of the current cell State makes it to
the output the third step is to decide
what will be our output first we run a
sigmoid layer which decides what parts
of the cell State make it to the output
then we put the cell State through the
tangent H to push the values to be
between minus one and one and multiply
it by the output of the sigmoid gate so
when we talk about the output of T we
set that equal to the Sig
of the weight of zero of the H of T
minus one you know back One Step in Time
by the x of t plus of course the bias
the H of T equals the out of T times the
tangent of the tangent h of C of T so
our o t equals the output gate allows
the past in information to impact the
output in the current time step let's
consider the example to predicting the
next word in the sentence John played
tremendously well against the opponent
and won for his team for his
contributions Brave blank was awarded
player of the match there could be a lot
of choices for the empty space current
input Brave is an adjective adjectives
describe a noun Jon could be the best
output after Brave thumbs up for JN
awarded player of the match and if you
were to pull just the nouns out of the
sentence team doesn't look right because
that's not really the subject we're
talking about contributions you know
Brave contributions or Brave team Brave
player Brave match um so you look at
this and you can start to train this
these this neural network so it starts
looking at and goes oh no JN is what
we're talking about so brave is an
adjective Jon's going to be the best
output and we give JN a big thumbs up
and then of course we jump into my
favorite part the case study use case
implementation of lstm let's predict the
prices of stocks using the lstm network
based on the stock price data between
2012 2016 we're going to try to predict
the stock prices of 2017 and this will
be a narrow set of data we're not going
to do the whole stock market it turns
out that the New York Stock Exchange
generates roughly three terabytes of
data per day that's all the different
trades up and down of all the different
stocks going on and each individual one
uh second to second or nanc to nanc uh
but we're going to limit that to just
some very basic fundamental information
so don't think you're going to get rich
off this today but at least you can give
an a you can give a step forward in how
to start prod processing something like
stock prices a very valid use for
machine learning in today's markets use
case implementation of
lstm let's dive in we're going to import
our libraries we're going to import the
training set and uh get the scaling
going um now if you watch any of our
other tutorials a lot of these pieces
should start to look very familiar CU
it's very similar setup uh but let's
take a look at that and um just a
reminder we're going to be using
Anaconda the Jupiter notebook so here I
have my anaconda Navigator when we go
under environments I've actually set up
a carass python 36 I'm in Python 36 and
U nice thing about Anaconda especially
the newer version remember a year ago
messing with anaconda in different
versions of python and different
environments um Anaconda now has a nice
interface um and I have this installed
both on a Ubuntu Linux machine and on
window so it works fine on there you can
go in here and open a terminal window
and then in here once you're in the
terminal window this is where you're
going to start uh installing using pip
to install your different modules and
everything now we've already
pre-installed them so we don't need to
do that in here uh but if you don't have
them installed on your particular
environment you'll need to do that and
of course you don't need to use the
anaconda or the Jupiter you can use
whatever favorite python ID you like I'm
just a big fan of this because it keeps
all my stuff separate you can see on
this machine I have specifically
installed one for carass since we're
going to be working with carass under
tensorflow we go back to home I've gone
up here to application and that's the
environment I've loaded on here and then
we'll click on the launch Jupiter
notebook now I've already in my Jupiter
notebook um have set up a lot of stuff
so that we're ready to go kind of like
uh Martha Stewarts and the old cooking
show so we want to make sure we have all
our tools for you so you're not waiting
for them to load and uh if we go up here
to where it says new you can see where
you can um create a new Python 3 that's
what we did here underneath the setup so
it already has all the modules installed
on on it and I'm actually renamed this
so if you go under file you can rename
it we I'm calling it RNN stock and let's
just take a look and start diving into
the code let's get into the exciting
part now we've looked at the tool and of
course you might be using a different
tool which is fine uh let's start
putting that code in there and seeing
what those Imports and uploading
everything looks like now first half is
kind of boring when we hit the rum
button because we're going to be
importing numpy as NP that's uh uh the
number python which is your numpy array
and the matap plot Library CU we're
going to do some plotting at the end and
our pandas for our data set our pandas
is PD and when I hit run uh it really
doesn't do anything except for load
those modules just a quick note let me
just do a quick uh draw here oops shift
alt there we go you'll notice when we're
doing this setup if I was to divide this
up oops I'm going to actually U let
overlap these here we
go uh this first part that we're going
to do
is our
data prep a lot of prepping
involved um in fact depending on what
your system and say we're using carass I
put an overlap here uh but you'll find
that almost maybe even half of the code
we do is all about the data prep and the
reason I overlap this with uh carass me
just put that down because that's what
we're working in uh is because carass
has like their own preset stuff so it's
already pre-built in which is really
nice so there's a couple Steps A lot of
times that are in the Kass setup uh
we'll take a look at that to see what
comes up in our code as we go through
and look at stock and then the last part
is to evaluate and if you're working
with um shareholders or uh you know
classroom whatever it is you're working
with uh the evaluate is the next biggest
piece um so the actual code here crossed
is a little bit more but when you're
working with uh some of the other
packages you might have like three lines
that might be it all your stuff is in
your pre-processing and your data since
carass has is is Cutting Edge and you
load the individual layers you'll see
that there's a few more lines here and
carass is a little bit more robust and
then you spend a lot of times uh like I
said with the evaluate you want to have
something you present to everybody else
to say hey this is what I did this is
what it looks like so let's go through
those steps this is like a kind of just
general overview and let's just take a
look and see what the next set of code
looks like and in here we have a data
set train and it's going to be read
using the PD or pandas read CS V and
it's the Google stock pric train.csv and
so under this we have training set
equals data set train. iocation and
we've kind of sorted out part of that so
what's going on here let's just take a
look at let's let's look at the actual
file and see what's going on there now
if we look at this ignore all the extra
files on this um I already have a train
and a test set where it's sorted out
this is important to notice because a
lot of times we do that as part of the
pre-processing of the data we take take
20% of the data out so we can test it
and then we train the rest of it that's
what we use to create our neural network
that way we can find out how good it is
uh but let's go ahead and just take a
look and see what that looks like as far
as the file itself and I went ahead and
just opened this up in a basic word pad
text editor just so we can take a look
at it certainly you can open up an Excel
or any other kind of spreadsheet um and
we note that this is a comma separated
variables we have a date uh open high
low close volume volume this is the
standard stuff that we import into our
stock one the most basic set of
information you can look at in stock
it's all free to download um in this
case we downloaded it from uh Google
that's why we call it the Google stock
price um and it specifically is Google
this is the Google stock values from uh
as you can see here we started off at 13
20102 so when we look at this first
setup up here uh we have a data set
train equals pdor CSV and if you noticed
on the original frame
um let me just go back there they had it
set to home Ubuntu downloads Google
stock price train I went ahead and
change that because we're in the same
file where I'm running the code so I've
saved this particular python code and I
don't need to go through any special
paths or have the full path on there and
then of course we want to take out um
certain values in here and you're going
to notice that we're using um our data
set and we're now in pandas uh so p do
basically it looks like a spreadsheet um
and in this case we're going to do
iocation which is going to get specific
locations the first value is going to
show us that we're pulling all the rows
in the data and the second one is we're
only going to look at columns one and
two and if you remember here from our
data as we switch back on over columns
we always start with zero which is the
date and we're going to be looking at
open and high which would be one and two
I'll just label that right there so you
can see now when you go back and do this
you certainly can extrapolate and do
this on all the columns um but for the
example let's just limit a little bit
here so that we can focus on just some
key aspects of
stock and then we'll go up here and run
the code and uh again I said the first
half is very boring whenever you hit the
Run button it doesn't do anything cuz
we're still just loading the data and
setting it up now that we've loaded at
our data we want to go ahead and scale
it we want to do what they call feature
scaling and in here we're going to pull
it up from the SK learn or the SK kit
pre-processing import min max scaler and
when you look at this you got to
remember that um biases in our data we
want to get rid of that so if you have
something that's like a really high
value U let's just draw a quick graph
and I have something here like the maybe
the stock has a value One stock has a
value of 100 and another stock has a
value of
five um you start to get a bias between
different stocks and so when we do this
we go ahead and say okay 100's going to
be the Max and five is going to be the
Min and then everything else goes and
then we change this so we just squish it
down I like the word squish so it's
between one and zero so 100 equal 1 or 1
equal 100 and 0 equal 5 and you can just
multiply it's usually just a the simple
multiplication we're using uh
multiplication so it's going to be uh
minus5 and then 100 divided or 95
divided by one so or whatever value is
is divided by
95 and uh once we've actually created
our scale we've toing it's going to be
from 0o to one we want to take our
training set and we're going to create a
training set scaled and we're going to
use our scaler SC and we're going to fit
we're going to fit and transform the
training Set uh so we can now use the SC
this this particular object we'll use it
later on our testing set because
remember we have to also scale that when
we go to test our uh model and see how
it works and we'll go ahead and click on
the run again uh it's not going to have
any output yet because we're just
setting up all the
variables okay so we pasted the data in
here and we're going to create the data
structure with the 60 time steps and
output first note we're running 60 EPs
and that is where this value here also
comes in so the first thing we do is we
create our X train and Y train variables
we set them to an empty python array
very important to remember what kind of
array we're in what we're working with
and then we're going to come in here
we're going to go for I in range 60 to
1258 there's our 60 60 time steps and
the reason we want to do this is as
we're adding the data in there there's
nothing below the 60 so if we're going
to use 60 time steps uh we have to start
at 60 because it includes everything
underneath of it otherwise you'll get a
pointer error and then we're going to
take our X train and we're going to
append training set scaled this is a
scaled value between zero and one and
then as I is equal to 60 this value is
going to be um 60 minus 60 is 0o so this
actually is 0 to I so it's going to be 0
to 60 1 to 61 let me just circle this
part right here 1 to 61 uh 2 to 62 and
so on and so on and if you remember I
said 0 to 60 that's incorrect because it
does not count remember it starts at
zero so this is a count of 60 so it's
actually 59 important to remember that
as we're looking at this and then the
second part of this that we're looking
at so if you remember correctly here we
go we go from uh 0 to 59 of I and then
we have a comma a zero right here and so
finally we're just going to look at the
open value now I know we did put it in
there for 1 to two um if you remember
correctly it doesn't count the second
one so it's just the open value we're
looking at just open um and then finally
we have y train. append training set I
to zero and if you remember correctly I2
or I comma 0 if you remember correctly
this is 0 to 59 so there's 60 values in
it uh so we do I down here this is
number 60 so we're going to do this is
we're creating an array and we have 0 to
59 and over here we have number 60 which
is going into the Y train it's being
appended on there and then this just
goes all the way up so this is down here
is a 0 to 59 and we'll call it 60 since
that's the value over here and it goes
all the way up to 12 58 that's where
this value here comes in that's the
length of the data we're loading so
we've loaded two arrays we've loaded one
array that has uh which is filled with
arrays from 0 to 59 and we loaded one
array which is just the value and what
we're looking at you want to think about
this as a Time sequence uh here's my
open open open open open open what's the
next one in the series so we're looking
at the Google stock and each time it
opens we want to know what the next one
uh 0 through 59 what's 60 1 through 60
what's 61 2 through 62 what's 62 and so
on and so on going up and then once
we've loaded those in our for Loop we go
ahead and take XT train and Y train
equals np. array XT tr. NP array YT
train we're just just converting this
back into a numpy array that way we can
use all the cool tools that we get with
numpy array including reshaping so if we
take a look and see what's going on here
we're going to take our X
train we're going to reshape it wow what
the heck does reshape me uh that means
we have an array if you remember
correctly um so many numbers by
60 that's how wide it is and so we're
when you when you do xtrain do shape
that gets one of the shapes and you get
um XT train. shape of one gets the other
shape and we're just making sure the
data is formatted correctly and so you
use this to pull the fact that it's 60
by um in this case where's that value 60
by
1199 1258 minus
60199 and we're making sure that that is
shaped correctly so the data is grouped
into uh
1199 by 60 different arrays and then the
one on the end just means at the end
because this when you're dealing with
shapes and numpy they look at this as
layers and so the in layer needs to be
one value that's like the leaf of a tree
where this is the branch and then it
branches out some more um and then you
get the Leaf in p. reshape comes from
and using the existing shapes to form it
we'll go ahead and run this piece of
code again there's no real output and
then we'll import our different carass
modules that we need so from carass
Models we're going to support the
sequential model we're dealing with
sequential data we have our dense layers
we have actually three layers we're
going to bring in our DSE our lstm which
is what we're focusing on and our
Dropout and we'll discuss these three
layers more in just a moment but you do
need the with the lstm you do need the
Dropout and then the final layer will be
the dents but let's go ahead and run
this and that'll bring P our modules and
you'll see we get an error on here and
if you read it closer it's not actually
an error it's a warning what does this
warning mean these things come up all
the time when you working with such
Cutting Edge modules that are completely
being updated all the time we're not
going to worry too much about the
warning all it's saying is that the
h5py module which is part of carass is
going to be updated at some point and uh
if you're running new stuff on caros and
you start updating your carass system
you better make sure that your H5 Pi is
updated too otherwise you're going to
have an error later on and you can
actually just run an update on the H5 Pi
now if you wanted to not a big deal
we're not going to worry about that
today and I said we were going to jump
in and start looking at what those
layers mean I meant that and uh we're
going to start off with initializing the
RNN and then we'll start adding those
layers in and you'll see that we have
the lstm and then the Dropout lstm then
Dropout lstm then Dropout what the heck
is that doing so let's explore that
we'll start by initializing the RNN
regressor equals sequential because
we're using the sequential model and
we'll run that and load that up and then
we're going to start adding our LS TM
layer and some Dropout regularization
and right there should be the Q Dropout
regularization and if we go back here
and remember our exploding gradient well
that's what we're talking about the uh
Dropout drops out unnecessary data so
we're not just shifting huge amount of
data through um the network so and so we
go in here let's just go ahead and uh
add this in I'll go ahead and run this
and we had three of them so let me go
and put all three of them in and then we
can go back over them there's the second
one and let's put one more in let's put
that in and we'll go and put two more in
I meant to I said one more in but it's
actually two more in and then let's add
one more after that and as you can see
each time I run these they don't
actually have an output so let's take a
closer look and see what's going on here
so we're going to add our first lstm
layer in here we're going to have units
50 the units is the positive integer and
it's the dimensionality of the output
space this is what's going out into the
next layer so we might have 60 coming in
but we have 50 going out we have a
return sequence because it is a sequence
data so we want to keep that true and
then you have to tell it what shape it's
in well we already know the shape by
just going in here and looking at xtrain
shape so input shape equals the XT train
shape of one comma one makes it really
easy you don't have to remember all the
numbers that put in 60 or whatever else
is in there you just let it tell the
regressor what model to use and so we
follow our STM with a Dropout layer now
understanding the Dropout layer is kind
of exciting because one of the things
that happens is we can overtrain our
Network that means that our neural
network will memorize such specific data
that it has trouble predicting anything
that's not in that specific realm to fix
for that each time we run through the
training mode we're going to take 02 or
20% of our neurons and just turn them
off so we're only going to train on the
other ones and it's going to be random
that way each time we pass through this
we don't overtrain these nodes come back
in in the next training cycle we
randomly pick a different 20 and finally
I see a big difference as we go from the
first to the second and third and fourth
the first thing is we don't have to
input the shape because the shape's
already the output units is 50 here this
Auto The Next Step automatically knows
this layer is putting out 50 and because
it's the next layer it automatically
sets that and says oh 50 is coming out
from our last layer it's coming out you
know goes into the regressor and of
course you have our Dropout and that's
what's coming into this one and so on
and so on and so the next three layers
we don't have to let it know what the
shape is it automatically understands
that and we're going to keep the units
the same we're still going to do 50
units it's still a sequence coming
through 50 units and a sequence now the
next piece of code is what brings it all
together let's go ahead and take a look
at that and we come in here we put the
output layer the dense layer and if you
remember up here we had the three layers
we had uh lstm Dropout and dense uh Den
just says we're going to bring this all
down into one output instead of putting
out a sequence we just know it want to
know the answer at this point and let's
go ahead and run that and so in here you
notice all we're doing is setting things
up one step at a time so far we've
brought in our uh way up here we brought
in our data we brought in our different
modules we formatted the data for
training it we've set it up you know we
have our y x train and our y train we
have our source of data and the answers
we're we know so far that we're going to
put in there we've reshaped that we've
come in and built our carass we've
imported our different layers and we
have in here if you look we have what uh
five total layers now carass is a little
different than a lot of other systems
because a lot of other systems put this
all in one line and do it automatic but
they don't give you the options of how
those layers interface and they don't
give you the options of how the data
comes in carass is Cutting Edge for this
reason so even though there's a lot of
extra steps in building the model this
has a huge impact on the output and what
we can do with this these new models
from carass so we brought in our den we
have our full model model put together a
regressor so we need to go ahead and
compile it and then we're going to go
ahead and fit the data we're going to
compile the pieces so they all come
together and then we're going to run our
training data on there and actually
recreate our regressor so it's ready to
be used so let's go ahead and compile
that and I can go ah and run that and uh
if you've been looking at any of our
other tutorials on neural networks
you'll see we're going to use the
optimizer atom adom is optimized for Big
Data there's a couple other optimizers
out there uh beyond the scope of this
tutorial but certainly Adam will work
pretty good for this and loss equals
mean squared value so when we're
training it this is what we want to base
the loss on how bad is our error well
we're going to use the mean squared
value for our error and the atom
Optimizer for its differential equations
you don't have to know the math behind
them but certainly it helps to know what
they're doing and where they fit into
the bigger models and then finally we're
going to do our fit fitting the RN into
the training set we have the regressor
do fit XT Trin yrain epics and batch
size so we know where this is this is
our data coming in for the X train our y
train is the answer we're looking for of
our data our sequential input appex is
how many times we're going to go over
the whole data set we created a whole
data set of XT Trin so this is each each
of those rows which includes a Time
sequence of 60 and badge size another
one of those things where carass really
shines is if you were pulling to save
from a large file instead of trying to
load it all into RAM it can now pick
smaller batches up and load those
indirectly we're not worried about
pulling them off a file today this isn't
big enough to uh cause the computer too
much of a problem to run not too
straining on the resources but as we run
this you can imagine what would happen
if I was doing a lot more than just one
column in one set of stock in this case
Google stock imagine if I was doing this
across all the stocks and I had instead
of just the open I had open close high
low and you can actually find yourself
with about 13 different variables times
60 cuz it's a time sequence suddenly you
find yourself with a gig of memory
you're loading into your RAM which will
just completely you know if it's just if
you're not on multiple computers or
cluster you're going to start running
into resource problems but for this we
don't have to worry about that so let's
go ahead and run this and this will
actually take a little bit on my
computer it's an older laptop and give
it a second to kick in there there we go
all right so we have epic so this is
going to tell me it's running the first
run through all the data and as it's
going through it's batching them in 32
pieces so 32 lines each time and there's
1198 I think I said 1199 earlier but
it's 1198 I was off by one and each one
of these is 13 seconds so you can
imagine this is roughly 20 to 30 minutes
run time on this computer like I said
it's an older laptop running at uh 0.9
gigahertz on a dual processor and that's
fine what we'll do is I'll go ahead and
stop go get a drink of coffee and come
back and let's see what happens at the
end and where this takes us and like any
good cooking show I've kind of gotten my
latte I also had some other stuff r in
the background so you'll see these
numbers jumped up to like 19 seconds 15
seconds which you can scroll through and
you can see we've run it through 100
steps or 100 epics so the question is
what does all this mean one of the first
things you'll notice is that our loss
can is over here kind of stopped at
0.0014 you can see it kind of goes down
until we hit about 0.0014 three times in
a row so we guessed our epic pretty
close since our loss has remain the same
on there so to find out what we're
looking at we're going to go ahead and
load up our test data the test data we
didn't process yet and uh real stock
price data set test ey location this is
the same thing we did when we prepped
the data in the first place so let's go
ahead and go through this code and we
can see we've labeled it part three
making the predictions and visualizing
the results so the first thing we need
to do is go ahead and read the data in
from our test CSV you see I've changed
the path on it for my computer and uh
then we'll call it the real stock price
and again we're doing just the one
column here and the values from ication
so it's all the rows and just the values
from these that one location that's the
open Stock open let's go ahead and run
that so that's loaded in there and then
let's go ahead and uh create we have our
inputs we're going to create inputs here
and this should all look familiar this
is the same thing we did before we're
going to take our data set total we're
going to do a little Panda concap from
the data State train now remember the
end of the data set train is part of the
data going in and let's just visualize
that just a little bit here's our train
data let me just put TR for train and it
went up to this value here but each one
of these values generated a bunch of
columns it was 60 across and this value
here equals this one and this value here
equals this one and this value here
equals this one and so we need these top
60 to go into our new data so to find
out what we're looking at we're going to
go ahead and load up our test data the
test data that we didn't process yet and
uh real stock price data set test test
ey location this is the same thing we
did when we prepped the data in the
first place so let's go ahead and go
through this code and we can see we've
labeled it part three making the
predictions and visualizing the results
so the first thing we need to do is go
ahead and read the data in from our test
CSV and you see I've changed the path on
it for my computer and uh then we'll
call it the real stock price and again
we're doing just the one column here and
the values from ication so it's all the
rows and just the values from these one
location that's the open Stock open
let's go ahead and run that so that's
loaded in there and then let's go ahead
and uh create we have our inputs we're
going to create inputs here and this
should all look familiar this is the
same thing we did before we're going to
take our data set total we're going to
do a little Panda concap from the data
seate train now remember the end of the
data set train is part of the data going
in and let's just visualize that just a
little bit here's our train data let me
just put TR for train and it went up to
this value here but each one of these
values generated a bunch of columns it
was 60 across and this value here equals
this one and this value here equals this
one and this value here equals this one
and so we need these top 60 to go into
our new data cuz that's part of the next
data or it's actually the top 59 so
that's what this first setup is over
here is we're going in we're doing the
real stock price and we're going to just
take the data set test and we're going
to load that in and then the real stock
price is our data test. test location so
we're just looking at that first uh
column the open price and then our data
set total we're going to take pandas and
we're going to concat and we're going to
take our data set train for the open and
our data set test open and this is one
way you can reference these columns
we've referenced them a couple different
ways we've referenced them up here with
the one two but we know it's labeled as
a panda set is open so pandas is great
that way lots of Versatility there and
we'll go ahead and go back up here and
run this there we go and uh you'll
notice this is the same as what we did
before we have our open data set we
pended our two different or concatenated
our two data sets together we have our
inputs equals data set total length data
set total minus length of data set minus
test minus 60 values so we're going to
run this over all of them and you'll see
why this works because normally when
you're running your test set versus your
training set you run them completely
separate but when we graph this you'll
see that we're just going to be we'll be
looking at the part that uh we didn't
train it with to see how well it graphs
and we have our inputs equals inputs.
reshaped or reshaping like we did before
we're Transforming Our inputs so if you
remember from the transform between zero
and one and finally we're going to go
ahead and take our X test and we're
going to create that X test and for I in
range 60 to 80 so here's our X test and
we're pending our inputs I to 60 which
remember is 0 to 59 and I comma 0 on the
other side so that's just the First
Column which is our open column and uh
once again we take our X test we convert
it to a numpy array we do the same
reshape we did before and uh then we get
down to the final two lines and here we
have something new right here on these
last two lines let me just highlight
those or or mark them predicted stock
price equals regressor do predicts X
test so we're predicting all the stock
including both the training and the
testing model here and then we want to
take this prediction and we want to
inverse the transform so remember we put
them between zero and one well that's
not going to mean very much to me to
look at a at a float number between zero
and one I want the dollar amounts I want
to know what the cash value is and we'll
go ahead and run this and you'll see it
runs much quicker than the training
that's what's so wonderful about these
neural networks once you put them
together takes just a second to run the
same neural network that took us what a
half hour to train ahead and plot the
data we're going to plot what we think
it's going to be and we're going to plot
it against the real data what what the
Google stock actually did so let's go
ahead and take a look at that in code
and let's uh pull this code up so we
have our PLT that's our uh oh if you
remember from the very beginning let me
just go back up to the top we have our
matap plot Library library. pyplot as
PLT that's where that comes in and we
come down here we're going to plot let
me get my drawing thing out again we're
going to go ahead and PLT is basically
kind of like an object it's one of the
things that always threw me when I'm
doing graphs in Python because I always
think you have to create an object and
then it loads that class in there well
in this case PLT is like a canvas you're
putting stuff on so if you've done HTML
5 you'll have the canvas object this is
the canvas so we're going to plot the
real stock price that's what it actually
is and we're going to give that color
red so it's going to be in bright red
we're going to label it real Google
stock price and then we're going to do
our predicted stock and we're going to
do it in blue and it's going to be
labeled predicted and we'll give it a
title because it's always nice to give a
title to your uh graph especially if
you're going to present this to somebody
you know to your shareholders in the
office and uh the X label is going to be
time because it's a Time series and we
didn't actually put the actual date and
times on here but that's fine we just
know they're incremented by time and
then of course the Y Lael is the actual
stock price pt. Legend tells us to build
the legend on here so that the color red
and and real Google stock price show up
on there and then the plot shows us that
actual graph so let's go ahead and run
this and see what that looks like and
you can see here we have a nice graph
and let's talk just a little bit about
this graph before we wrap it up here's
our Legend I was telling you about
that's why we have the legend to showed
the prices we have our title and
everything and you'll notice on the
bottom we have a Time sequence we didn't
put the actual time in here now we could
have we could have gone ahead and um
plotted the X since we know what the the
dates are and plotted this to dates but
we also know this only the last piece of
data that we're looking at so last piece
of data which ends somewhere probably
around here on the graph I think it's
like about 20% of the data probably less
than that we have the Google price and
the Google price has this little up jump
and then down and you'll see that the
actual Google instead of a a turn down
here just didn't go up as high and
didn't low go uh down so our prediction
has the same pattern but the overall
value is pretty far off as far as um
stock but then again we're only looking
at one column we're only looking at the
open price we're not looking at how many
volumes were traded like I was pointing
out earlier we talk about stock just
right off the bat there's six columns
there's open high low close volume then
there's weather uh I mean volume shares
then there's the adjusted open adjusted
High adjusted low adjusted close they
have a special formula to predict
exactly what it would really be worth
based on the value of the stock and then
from there there's all kinds of other
stuff you can put in here so we're only
looking at one small aspect the opening
price of the stock and as you can see
here we did a pretty good job this curve
follows the curve pretty well it has
like a you know little jumps on it bends
they don't quite match up so this Bend
here does not quite match up with that
bin there but it's pretty darn close we
have the basic shape of it and the
prediction isn't too far off and you can
imagine that as we add more data in and
look at different aspects in the
specific domain of stock we should be
able to get a better representation each
time we drill in deeper of course this
took a half hour for my program my
computer to train so you can imagine
that if I was running it across all
those different variables might take a
little bit longer to train the data now
let's talk about our first deep learning
project we have image classification
using the cifar 10 data set now this
data set was created by the Canadian
Institute for advanced research the
cifar 10 data set contains 6,32 cross 32
color images in 10 different classes the
10 different classes are airplanes cars
Birds cats deer and others which you can
see on the screen there are 6,000 images
of each class now there are 50,000
training images and 10,000 test images
you can build a convolutional neural
network model using the Caris library to
classify each image into a category so
it is more of an image recognition kind
of a project that is recommended for
beginners who are new to deep learning
the next project in our list is brain
tumor detection such projects are
heavily used in the healthcare
Industries for detecting diseases before
they occur brain tumors are the
consequence of abnormal growths and
uncontrolled cell division in the brain
they can lead to death if they are not
detected early and accurately brain
tumors can be classified into two types
benign and malignant
deep learning can help Radiologists in
tumor Diagnostics without invasive
measures a deep learning algorithm that
has achieved significant results in
image segmentation and classification is
the convolutional neural network it can
be used to detect a tumor through brain
using magnetic resonance imaging or MRI
image pixels are First Fed as input to
the CNN soft Max fully connected layers
are used to classify the images the
accuracy of the convolutional neural
network can be obtained with the radial
BAS function classifier next we have
Anna chatbot now this chatbot is the
world's first open source conversation
platform which comes with a graphical
chart flow designer and chat simulator
it's supported channels of web chat
Android iOS and Facebook Messenger the
Anna chatboard is available to answer
your questions 24 hours a day 365 days a
year Anna is free for personal and
commercial use with the Anna Studio
server simulator and SDK which is
software development kit your
development time is cut from days to
hours using Anna you can create chat
Bots to suit your needs chat Bots play
an important role in customer support
for an e-commerce website you can seeare
realtime order and sipping updates
personalized product recommendations and
targeted offers within the conversation
similarly automobile Brands showrooms
and service centers can use a chatbot
for lead generation scheduling test
drives and roadside assistance you can
check the GitHub repository that's on
the screen to know more about working on
this project the next project we have in
deep learning is image captioning now
image captioning is the process of
generating textual description of an
image it uses both methods from computer
vision to understand the content of the
image and a language model from the
field of natural language processing to
turn the understanding of the image into
words in the right order Microsoft has
built its own caption bot where you can
upload an image or the URL of an image
and it will display the textual
description of the image on the screen
you can see we have the picture of Alon
musk and the caption bot has generated a
description that says I think it's Alon
musk wearing a shoot and a tie and he
seems it ends with an
emoticon another such application that
suggests a perfect caption and best
hashtags for a picture is caption AI
automatic image caption generation
software can be built using recurring
neural networks and long shortterm
memory networks or
lstms now we have image colorization as
our next project image colorization has
seen significant advancements using deep
learning image colorization is the
process of taking an input of a
grayscale image and then producing an
output of a colored image or a colorized
image colorization is a highly
undetermined problem that requires
mapping a real valued luminance image to
a three-dimensional colored value one
that has not a unique solution chromag
gan is an example of a picture
colorization Model A generative network
is framed in an adversarial model that
learns to colorize by incorporating
perceptual and semantic understanding of
color and class distributions the model
is trained using a fully supervised
strategy if you want to implement
chroman check the GitHub link that's on
the screen below next in our list of
projects we have open nmt machine
translation open nmt is an open source
ecosystem for neural machine translation
and neural sequence learning it started
in December 2016 by the Harvard NLP
group an cyran the project has since
been used in several research and
Industry applications neural machine
translation or nmt is a new methodology
for machine translation that has led to
significant improvements particularly in
terms of human evaluation compared to
rule based and statistical machine
translation systems open and empty
provides implementations in two popular
deep learning Frameworks py torch and
tensorflow please feel free to refer to
the below GitHub link to learn more
about neural machine
translation now we have music generation
using deep learning it is possible for a
machine to learn the notes structures
and patterns of Music and start
producing music automatically music 21
is a python toolkit used for computer
readed musicology it allows us to teach
the fundamentals of Music Theory
generate music examples and study music
the toolkit provides a simple interface
to acquire the music notation of midi
files which stands for musical
instrument digital interface using webet
architecture and long shortterm memory
networks you can generate music without
human intervention Amper music mubert
and Juke deck produce smart music
powered by Deep learning
algorithms then we have Alpha go now
Alpha go was created by Google Deep Mind
and is the first computer program to
defeat a professional human go player
Alpha goes algorithm uses a combination
of machine learning and Tre search
techniques combined with extensive
training both from human and computer
play it uses Monte carot tree search
Guided by a value Network and a policy
Network both implemented using deep
neural network technology alphao was
initially trained to mimic human play by
attempting to match the moves of expert
players from recorded historical games
it was done using a database of around
30 million moves once it had reached a
certain degree of proficiency by being
set to play large number of games
against other instances of itself using
reinforcement learning to improve its
play next in our list of projects we
have deep dream deep dream is a computer
vision program which uses a
convolutional neural network to find and
enhance patterns in images bya
algorithmic paradia it then creates a
dream like helicogenic
appearance in the overprocessed images
deep dream is an experiment that
visualizes the patterns learned by a
neural
network similar to when a child watches
clouds and interprets and tries to
interpret random saves deep dream over
interprets and enhances the patterns it
sees in an image do check the given
GitHub link to install dependencies
listed in the notebook and play with the
code locally then we have deep voice
deep voice was developed by BYU which is
an AI system that can clone an
individual's voice the train model takes
just 3 seconds to replicate the output
of a person's voice deep voice 3 is a
fully convolutional attention based
neural text to speech system that
converts text to spectrograms or other
acostic parameters to be used with an
audio waveform synthesis method below
you can find the GitHub link for pytorch
implementation of convolutional networks
based text to speech synthesis
models now we have IBM Watson IBM Watson
helps run machine learning models
anywhere across any cloud using IBM
Watson machine learning you can build
analytical models and neural networks
trained with your own data that you can
deploy for use in
applications with its open extensible
model operation Watson machine learning
helps businesses simplify and harness AI
at scale across any Cloud it is used in
healthcare teaching assistant chatbot as
well as for weather forecasting and
finally in our list of deep learning
projects we have the YOLO realtime
object detection you only look once or
YOLO is a state-of-the-art real-time
object detection system it frames object
detection in images as a regression
problem to spatially separated bounding
boxes and Associated class
probabilities using this approach a
single neural network divides the image
into regions and predicts bounding boxes
and probabilities for each region the
neural network predicts bounding boxes
and class probabilities directly from
full images in one evaluation the base
YOLO model processes images in real time
at 45 frames per second you can use the
Coco data set and tensorflow library to
train and test the model to learn more
about YOLO object detection check the
GitHub link that's shown on the screen
below deep learning interview questions
and we're going to go from the very
basics of neural networks and deep
learning into some of the more commonly
used models so you can have an
understanding of what kind of questions
are going to come up and what you need
to know in interview questions we'll
start start with a very general concept
of what is deep learning this is where
we take large volumes of data in this
case on cats and dogs or whatever A lot
of times you use um a training setup to
train your model remember it's kind like
a magic Black Box going on there then we
use that to extract features or extract
information and in this case classify
the image of a cat and a dog so the
primary takeaway we're talking about
deep learning is that learns from large
volumes of structured and even
unstructured data and uses complex
algorithms to train neural network it
also performs complex operations to
extract hidden patterns and features and
if we're going to discuss deep learning
in this very uh simplified overview and
we also have to go over what is a neural
network this is a common image you'll
see of a drawing of a forward
propagation neural network and it's it's
a human brain inspired system which
replicate the way humans learn so this
is inspired how our own neurons in our
brain fire but at a much simplified
level obviously it's not ready to take
over the human uh population and and be
our leader yet not for many years it's
very much in its infant stage but it's
inspired by how our brains work um and
they use a lot of other Inspirations you
can study brains of moths and other
animals that they've used to figure out
how to improve these neural networks the
most common one consist of three layers
of network and this is generally how you
view these networks is you have an input
you have a hidden layer and an output
and the neural network is uh broken up
into many pieces but when we focus just
on the neural network it's always on the
hidden layer that we're making all the
adjustments and figuring out how to best
set up those hidden layers for their
functions to both train faster and to
function better when we look at this of
course we have our input hidden and
output each layer contains neurons
called as nodes perform various
operations and you can see here we have
the list of the nodes we have both our
input nodes and our output nodes and
then our hidden layer nodes and it's
used in deep learning algorithm like CNN
RNN GN Etc we'll address some of these
models a little closer at least the most
common models as we go down the list and
we study the Deep learning and the
neural network framework let's start
with what is a multi-layer patron or MLP
a lot of time is it referred to and
you'll see these abbreviations I'll be
honest I have to write them down on a
piece of paper and go through them
because I never remember what they all
mean even though I play with them all
the time what is a multi-layer patron
well if you look at the image on the
right it's very similar to what we just
looked at you have your input layer your
hidden layer and your output layer and
that's exactly what this is it has the
same structure of a single layer Perron
with one or more hidden layers except
the input layer each node in the other
layers uses a nonlinear activation
function what that means is your input
layers your data coming in and then your
activation function is based upon all
those nodes and weights being added
together and then it has the output MLP
uses supervised learning method called
back propagation for training the model
very key word there is back propagation
single layer perp Ron can classify only
linear separable classes with binary
output 01 but the MLP can classify
nonlinear classes so let's break this
down just a little bit the multi-layer
Perron with an input layer and a hidden
layer and an output layer as you see
that it comes in there it has adds up
all the numbers and weights depending on
how your setup is that then goes to the
next layer that then goes to the next
hidden layer if you have multiple hidden
layers and finally to the output layer
the back propagation takes the error
that it so whatever the output is it
says hey this has an error to it it's
wrong and then sends that error
backwards from where it came from and
there's a lot of different functions
used to uh train this based on that
error and how that error goes backwards
in the noes uh so forward is you get
your answers back where it is for
training you see this every day even my
uh Google pixel phone has this it they
train the neural network which takes a
lot more data to train than it does to
use and then they load up that neural
network into in this case I have a pixel
2 which actually has a built-in neural
network for processing pictures and so
it's just the forward propagation I use
when it processes my photos but when
they were training it you used the back
propagation to train it with the errors
they had we'll be coming back to
different models that are used for right
now though multi-layer prron MLP put
that down as your vocabulary word and of
course back propagation what is data
normalization and why do we need it this
is so important we spend so much time
normalizing our data and getting our
data clean and setting it up uh so we
talk about data there's a pre-processing
step to standardize the data so whatever
we have coming in we don't want it to be
a uh you know 1 Gigabyte file here a 2
gigabyte picture here and a 3 kilobyte
text there even as a human I can't
process those all in the same group I
have to reformat them in some way that
Loops them together so that a
standardized format we use this uh data
normalization in pre-processing to
reduce it and eliminate data redundancy
a lot of times the data comes in and you
end up with two of the same images or
the same information in different
formats then we want to rescale values
to fit into a particular range for
achieving better convergence what this
means is with most neural networks they
form a bias we've seen this recently in
attacks on neural networks where they
light up one pixel or one piece of the
view and it skews the whole answer so
suddenly um because one pixel is really
bright uh it doesn't know what to do
well when we start rescaling it we put
all the values between say minus one and
one and we change them and refit them to
those values it helps get rid of that
bias helps fix for some of those
problems and then finally we restructure
the data and improve the Integrity we
want to make sure that we're not missing
values U or we don't have partial data
coming in one way to look at this is uh
bad data in bad data out so you want
clean data in and you want good answers
coming out one of the most basic models
used is a boltzman machine so let's
address what is a boltzman machine and
if you know we just did the MLP
multi-layer prron so now we're going to
come into almost a simplified version of
that and in this we have our visible
input layer and we have our hidden layer
the bolman machines are almost always
shallow they're usually just two layer
neural Nets that make stochastic
decisions whether a neuron should be on
or off true false yes no first layer is
the visible layer and second layer is
the hidden layer no are connected to
each other across layers but no two
nodes of the same layer are connected
hence it is also known as restricted
boltzman machine now that we've covered
a basic MLP or multi-layer Patron and
we've gone over the boltzman machine
also known as the restricted boltzman
machine let's talk a little bit about
activation formulas and this is a huge
topic that can get really complicated
but it also is automated so it's very
simple so you have both a complicated
and a simple at the same time so so what
is the role of activation functions in a
neural network activation function
decides whether a neuron should be fired
or not that's the most basic one and
that actually changes a little bit
because it's either whether fired or not
in this case activation function or what
value should come out when it's fired
but in these models we're looking at
just the boltzman restricted layers so
this is what causes them to fire either
they don't or they do it's a yes or no
true false All or Nothing it accepts a
weighted sum of the inputs the B as
input to any activation function so
whatever our activation function is it
needs to have the sum of the weights
times the input so each input if you
remember on that model and let's just go
back to that model real quick and then
you always have to add a bias and you
can look at the bias if you remember
from your ukian geometry you draw a
straight line formula for that line has
a y-coordinate at the end it's always um
CX plus M or something like that where m
is where it crosses the Y coordinates if
you're doing a straight line with these
weights it's very similar but a lot of
times we just add it in as its own
weight we take it as a node of a one
value coming in and then we compute its
new weight and that's how we compute
that bias just like we compute all the
other weights coming in the node which
gets fires depends on the Y value and
then we have a step function and the
step function this is where remember I
said it's going to get complicated and
simple all at the same time we have a
lot of different step functions we have
the sigmoid function we have just the
standard step function we have the um
rayu is pronounced like Ray the ray of
from the Sun and L like a name so rayu
function and we have the tangent H
function and if you look at these they
all have something similar they all
either force it to be um one value or
the other they force it to be in the
case of the first three is zero or one
and in the last one it's either a minus
one or one and you can easily convert
that to a z one yes no true false and on
this one of the most common ones is the
step function itself because there is no
middle value there is no um uh
discrepancy that says well I'm not quite
sure but as you get into different
models probably the most commonly used
used to be the sigmoid was most commonly
used but I see the ru used more often
really depending on what you're doing
you just have to play with these and
find out which one works best depending
on the data in your output the reason to
have a non Z1 answer or something kind
of in the middle is when you're looking
at this and it's coming out you can
actually process that middle ground as
part of the answer into another neural
network so it might be that The Rao
function says hey this is only a 6 not a
one and uh even though the one is what's
going into the next neural network or
the next hidden layer as an input the
point six value might also be going in
there to let you know hey this is not a
straight up one or straight up zero it's
someplace in the middle this is a little
uncertain what's coming out here so it's
a very powerful tool but in the basic
neural network you usually just use the
step function it's yes or no let's take
a um a big step back and take a kind of
an overview the next function is what is
a cost function that we're going to
cover this is so important because this
is your end result that you're going to
do over and over again and use to decide
whether the model is working or not
whether you need to try a different step
function whether you need to try a
different activation whether you need to
try a fully different model used uh so
what is the cost function cost function
is a measure to evaluate how good your
model's performance is it is also
referred as loss or error used to
compute the error of the output layer
during back propagation there's a back
propagation where we're training our
model that's one of our key words mean
squared error is an example of a popular
cost function and so here we have the
cost function Cal half of y - y
predicted um and then you square that so
the first thing is um you know real
quick if you haven't done statistics
this is not a percentage it's not a
percentage of how accurate it is it's
just a measurement of the error and we
take that error for training it and we
push that error backwards through the
neural network and we use that through
the different training functions
depending on what model you're using to
train the neural network so when you
diso the network you're usually done
training it because it takes a lot of
computational force to train it um this
is a very simple model and so you deploy
the trained one uh but we want to know
how your error is and so how do we do
that well you split your data part of
your data is for trading and part of
your data is for testing and then we can
also test the error on there so it's
very important and then we're going to
go one more step on this we got to look
at both the local and the global setup
it might work great to test your data on
what you have on your computer but
that's different than in the field so
when we're talking about all these
different tests and the error test as
far as your loss you don't you want to
make sure that you're in a closed
environment when you do initial testing
but you also want to open that up and
make sure you follow up with the testing
on the larger scale of data because it
will change it might not fit the larger
scale there might be something in there
in the way you brought the data in
specifically or the data group you used
or um any of those could cause an error
so it's very important to remember that
we're looking at both the local and the
global context of our error and just one
other side note on a lot of the newer
models of neural networks by comparing
the error we get on the data our
training data with a portion of the test
data we can actually figure out how good
the model is whether it's overfitted or
not we'll go into that a little bit more
as we go into some of the different
models so we have our output we're able
to um figure out the error on it based
on the Square means usually although
there's other uh functions used so we
want to talk about what is gradient
descent another vocabulary word gradient
descent is an optimation algorithm to
minimize the cost function uh or to
minimize the error aim is to find the
local or Global Minima of a function
determine the direction the model should
take to reduce the error so as we're
looking at this we have our uh squared
error that we just f figured out the C
based on the cost function it says how
bad is my model fitting the data I just
put through it and then we want to
reduce that error so how do you figure
out what direction to do that in well
you could be that you're looking at just
that line of that line of data coming in
so that would be a local Minima we want
to know the error of that particular
setup coming in and then you have your
Global your Global Minima we want to
minimize it based on the overall data
we're putting through it and with this
we can figure out the global minimum
cost we want to take all those local
minimum costs of each piece of data
coming in and figure out the global one
how are we going to adjust this model to
fit all the data we don't want it to be
biased just on three or four lines of
data coming in we want it to kind of
extrapolate a general answer for all the
data coming in at this of course uh we
mentioned it briefly about back
propagation this is where really comes
in handy is training our model neural
network technique to minimize the cost
function helps to improve the
performance of the network back
propagates the error and updates the
weights to reduce the error so as you
can see here is a very nice depiction of
a back propagation we have our U
predicted y coming out and then we have
since it's a training set we already
know the answer and the answer comes
back and based on case the square means
was one of the functions we looked at uh
one of the activation functions based on
cost function that cost function then
depending on what you choose for your
back propagation method and there's a
number of them will change the weights
it will change the weight going to each
of one of those nodes in the hidden
layer and then based upon the error
that's still being carried back it'll
change the weights going to the next
hidden layer and then it computes an
error level on that and sends that back
up and you're going to say well if it
computes the error into the first hidden
layer and fixes it why would it stop
there well remember we don't want to
create a biased neural network so we
only make small adjustments on these
weights we don't make a big adjustment
that changes everything right off the
bat so no matter how far back you go
you're always going to have a small
amount of error and that's still going
to continue to go all the way back up
the hidden layers for right now focus on
the back propagation is taking that
error and moving it backwards on the
neural network to change the weights and
help program it so that it'll have the
correct answers so far we've been
talking about forward propagation naral
networks everything goes forwards goes
left to right uh but this let's take a
little detour and let's see what is the
difference between a feed forward neural
network and a recurrent neural network
now this is in the function not when
we're training it using the back
propagation so you've got new
information coming in and you want to
get the answer and there's a couple
different networks out there and we want
to know we have a feed forward neural
network and we have a new uh vocabulary
term recurrent neural network a feed
forward neural network signals travel in
one direction from input to Output no
feedback loops considers only the
current input cannot memorize previous
inputs one example of one of these feed
forward neural networks and we've
covered number of them but one of the
ones this has a big highlight nowadays
is the CNN a convolutional neural
network tensorflow the one put out by
Google is probably most known for their
CNN where the information goes forward
it uh first takes a picture splits it
apart goes through the individual pixels
on the picture so it picks up a
different reading then calculates based
on that goes into a regular feed forward
neural network and then gives your
categorization on there now we're not
covering the CNN today but we do have a
video out that you can look up on
YouTube put out by simply learn the
convolutional neural network wonderful
tutorial check that out and learn a lot
more about the convolutional neural
network but you do need to know that the
CNN is a forward propagation neural
network only so it's only moving in One
Direction so we want to look at a
recurrent neural network signals travel
in both directions making it a looped
Network consid the current input along
with the previous received inputs for
generating the output of a layer has the
ability to memorize past data due to its
internal memory and you can see they
have a nice uh image here we have our um
input and for some reason they always do
the recurrent neural network um in
Reverse from bottom up in the images
kind of a standard although I'm not sure
why your X goes into your hidden layer
and your hidden layer the answer part of
the answer from that it generates feeds
back into the hidden layer so now you
have an input of both X and part of the
Hidden layer and then that feeds into
your output now if we go back to the
forward let me just go back a slide and
we're looking at uh our forward
propagation Network one of the tricks
you can do to use just a forward
propagation network is if you're in a
what they call a Time sequence that's a
good uh term to remember or a Time
series meaning that it's sequential data
each term comes after the other you can
trick this by creating your input nodes
as with the history so if you know that
uh you have values one five and seven
going in and you know what the output is
from one what those outputs are you can
expand the the input to include the
history input that's one of the ways to
trick a forward propagation Network into
looking at that but when you deal with
the recurrent neural network you let the
hidden layer do that for you it sends
that data and reprocesses it back into
itself what are some of the applications
of recurrent neural network the RNN can
be used for sentiment analysis and text
mining getting up early in the morning
is good for health it's a positive
sentiment one of the catches you really
want to look at this when you're looking
at the language is that I could switch
this around and totally negate the
meaning of what I'm doing so it no
longer be positive so when you're
looking at a sentence knowing the order
of the words is as important as the
meaning of the words you can't just
count how many good words there are
versus bad words to get a positive
sentiment you now have to know what
they're addressing and there's lots of
other different uses uh kids are playing
football or soccer as we call it in the
US RN can help you caption an image So
based on previous information coming in
it refeeds that back in and you have a
uh image Setter and then time series
problems like predicting the prices of
stocks in a month or quarter or sale of
products can be solved using an RNN and
this is a really good example you have
whatever your stocks were doing earlier
this month will have a huge effect on
what they're doing today if you're
investing so having an RNN Model A
recurrent neural network feeding into
itself what was happening previously
allows it to take that model and program
in that whole series without having to
put in the whole a month at a time of
data you can only put in one day at a
time but if you keep them in order it
will look back and say oh this because
of what happened yesterday I need some
information from that and I'm going to
use that to help predict today and so on
and so on we're going to go back to our
activation functions remember I told you
uh railu is one of the most common
functions used uh so let's talk a little
bit more about Ru and also softmax
softmax is an activation function that
generates the output between zero and
one it divides each output such that the
total sum of the outputs is equal to one
it is often used in the output layers
soft Max L of the N equals e to L on the
N over the absolute value of e to the L
so what does this function mean I mean
what is actually going on here so we
have our output nodes and our output
nodes are giving us uh let's say they
gave us
1.29 and 04 as a human being I look at
that and I say well the greatest value
is 1.2 so whatever category that is if
you have three different categories
maybe you're not just doing if it's a
cat or it's a dog or um oh let's say
it's a cow may we have cats and dogs
earlier why the cats and dogs are
hanging out with a cow I don't know but
we have a value and it might say 1.2 is
a cat 0.9 is the dog and 04 is a cow uh
for some reason it SS that there's a
chance of it being any one of these
three items and that's how it comes out
of the output layer well as a human I
can look at 1.2 and say this is
definitely what it is it's definitely a
cat or whatever it is uh maybe looking
at different kinds of cars might be a
better whether it's a car truck or
motorcycle maybe that'd be a better
example well from a computer standpoint
that might be a little confusing because
they're just numbers waving at us and so
with the soft Max we want all those
numbers to always add up to one so when
I add three numbers together I want the
final output to be one on there and so
it goes through this formula changes
each of these numbers in this case it
changes them to0 46 34 and .20 they all
add up to one and that's a lot easier to
register cuz it's very set it's a set
output it's never going to be more than
one it's never going to be less than
zero and so you can see here that
there's probably a pretty High chance
that it's the first one so you're as a
human being we have no problem knowing
that but this output can then also go
into say another input so it might be an
automated car that's picking up images
and it says that image in front of us is
probably a big truck we should deal with
it like it's a big truck it's probably
not a motorcycle um or whatever those
categories are that's the softmax part
of it but now we have the railu well
what where's the railu coming from well
the Rayo is what's generating the 1.2
and the 0.9 and the point4 and so if you
remember our ra stands for rectified
linear unit and is the most widely used
activation function we looked at a
number of different activation functions
including tangent H the step function
remember I said the step function is
really used if that's what your actual
output is because then you know it's a
zero or one but the railu if you have
that as your output you now have a
discrepancy in there and if that's going
into another neural network or another
process having that discrepancy is
really important and it gives an output
of x if x is positive and Z otherwise so
it says my x value is going to be
somewhere between 0er or one and then
the uh usually unless it's really
uncertain the output's usually a one or
zero and then you have that little piece
of uncertainty there that you can send
forward to another Network or you can
look at to know that there's uncertainty
involved and is often used in the hidden
layers this is what's coming out of the
Hidden layers into the output layer
usually or as we reference the uh
convolution neural network the CNN you'd
have to go to another video to review
the railu is the most common used for
convolutional part of that Network it
has a bunch of little pieces that are
very simplified looking at all the
different images or different sections
of the map and the ru works really good
for that like I said there's other
formulas used but that this is the most
common one and you'll see that in the
hidden layer is going maybe between one
layer and the next layer so just a quick
recap we have our soft Max which means
that if you have uh numerous categories
only one of them is going to be picked
but you also want to have some value
attached to it how well it picked it and
you put that between zero one so it's
very uh standardized so we have our soft
Max we looked at that let's go back one
we looked at that here where it
transforms in numbers and then we have
our railu function which takes the
information and the summation and puts
it between a zero and a one where it's
either clearly a zero or depending on
how confident our model is it'll go
between the zero and one value what are
hyperparameters oh this is a great
interview question hyperparameters when
you are doing neural networks this is
what you're playing with most of the
time once you gotten the data formatted
correctly a hyperparameter is a
parameter whose value is set before the
learning process begins determines how a
network is trained and the structure of
the network this includes things like
the number of hidden units how many
hidden layers are you going to have and
how many nodes in each layer learning
rate learning rate is usually multiplied
once you figured out the error and how
much you want to change the weights we
talked about or I mentioned it early
just brief briefly you don't want to
just make a huge change otherwise you're
going to have a biased model so you only
take little incremental changes and
that's what the learning rate is is a
small incremental changes epics how many
times are you going to go through all
the data in your training set so one
Epic is one trip through all the data
and there's a lot of other things
depending on which model you're working
with and which programming script you're
working with like the python sklearn
package will have it slightly different
than say Google's tensor flow package
which will be a little bit different
than the spark machine learning package
so these are just some examples of the
hyperparameters and so you see in here
we have a nice image of our data coming
in and we train our model then we do a
comparison to see how good our model is
and then we go back and we say hey this
this model is pretty good but it's
biased so then we send it back and we
change our hyperparameters to see if we
can get an unbiased model or we can have
a better prediction on it that matches
our data closer what will happen if
learning rate is set too low or too high
we have a nice couple graphs here we
have one over here says a learning rate
set too low you can see that it slowly
Works its way down the curve and on the
right you can see a learning rate set
too high it's just bouncing back and
forth when your learning rate is too low
that's what we studied at two slides
over asked what the learning rate was
training of the model will progress very
slowly as we are making very tiny
updates to the weights we'll take many
updates before reaching the minimum
point so I just mentioned epic going
through all the data you might have to
go through all the data a thousand times
instead of 500 times for it to train
learning rate too high causes
undesirable Divergent Behavior to the
loss function due to drastic updates in
weights at times it may fail to converge
or even diverge so if you have your
learning rate set too high and it's
training too quickly maybe you'll get
lucky and it trains after one epic run
but a lot of times it might never be
able to train because the weights are
changing too fast they they flip back
and forth too easy and you see down here
we've introduced uh two new terms
converge and diverge a converge means
that our model has reached a point where
it's able to give a fairly good answer
for all the data we put in all those
weights have adjusted and it's minimized
the error diverg means that the data is
so chaotic that it can never manage to
to train to that data the data is just
too chaotic for it to train so we have
two new words there converge and diverge
are important to know also what is
Dropout and batch normalization Dropout
is a technique of dropping out hidden
and visible units of a network randomly
to prevent overfitting of data it
doubles the number of iterations needed
to converge the network so here we have
our standard neural network and then
after applying Dropout now it doesn't
mean we actually delete the node the
node is still there and we're still
going to use that node what it means is
that we're only going to work with a few
of the nodes um a lot of times I think
the most common one right now used is
20% uh so you'll drop out 20% of the
nodes when you do your training you
reverse propagate your data and then
you'll randomly pick another 20 nodes
the next time you go through an epic
data training so each time you go
through one Epic you will randomly pick
20 of those nodes not to not to mess
with and this allows for less
overfitting of the data so by randomly
doing this you create some I guess it
just kind of pull some nodes off to the
Sid it says we're going to handle the
data later on so we don't overfit batch
normalization is a technique to improve
the performance and stability of neural
network the idea is to normalize the
inputs in every layer so that they have
mean output and activation of zero and
standard deviation of one this question
covers a lot of different things which
is great it's a great uh interview
question because it pulls in that you
have to understand what the mean value
is so a mean output activation of zero
that means our average activation is
zero so when you normalize it remember
usually we're going between minus one
and one on a lot of these it's a very
standard setup so you have to be very
aware that this is your mean output
activation of zero and then we have our
standard deviation of one so we want to
keep our error down to just a one value
the benefits of this doing a batch
normalization is it provides
regularization it trains faster Higher
Learning rates and weights are easier to
initialize what is the difference
between batch gradient descent and
stochastic gradient descent batch
gradient descent batch gradient computes
the gradient using the entire data set
it takes time to converge because the
volume of data is huge and weights
update slowly so you can look at the
batches a lot of times if you're using
big data batch the data in but you still
go through a full epic you still go
through all the data on there so batch
gradient descent means you're going to
use it to fit all the data and look for
a convergence there stochastic gradient
descent stochastic gradient computes the
gradient using a single sample it
converges much faster than batch
gradient because it updates weight more
frequently explain overfitting and
underfitting and how to combat them
overfitting happens when a model learns
the details and noise and the training
data to the degree that it adversely
impacts the execution of the model on
the new information it is more likely to
occur with nonlinear models that have
more flexibility when learning a Target
function an example of this would be um
if you're looking at say cars and trucks
and motorcycles it might only recognize
trucks that have a certain box-like
shape it might not be able to notice a
flatbed truck unless it's only a
specific kind of flatbed truck or only
Ford trucks because that's what it saw
on the training set this means that your
model performs great on your train data
and great on maybe a small test amount
of data but when you go to use it in the
real world it leaves out a lot and start
is not very functional outside of your
small area your slow laboratory data
coming in underfitting doing the
opposite when you underfit your data
underfitting alludes to a model that is
neither well Tred on training data nor
can generalize to new information
usually happens when there is less and
improper data to train a model has a
performance and accuracy so if you're
using underfitted data and you generate
a model and you distribute that in a
commercial Zone you'll have a lot of
people unhappy with you because it's not
going to give them very good answers so
we've explained overfitting and
underfitting so now we want to ask how
to combat them combating overfitting and
underfitting resampling the data to
estimate the model accuracy kfold cross
validation having a validation data set
to evaluate the model so we do the
resampling we're randomly going to be
picking out data and we'll run it a few
times to see how that works depending on
our random data and how we U sample the
data to generate our model and then we
want to go ahead and validate the data
set by having our training data and then
keeping some data on the side uh testing
data to validate it how are weights
initialized in a network initializing
all weights to zero all the weights are
set to zero this makes your model
similar to a linear model so if you have
linear data coming in doing a basic
setup like that might work all the
neurons in every layer perform the same
operation given the same output and
making the deep net useless right there
is a key word it's going to be useless
if you initialize everything to zero at
that point be looking into some other uh
machine learning tools initializing all
weights randomly here the weights are
assigned randomly by initializing them
very close to zero it gives better
accuracy to the model since every neuron
performs different computations and here
we have the weights are set randomly we
have our input layer the hidden layers
and the output layer and W equals NP
random random n layer size L layer size
L minus one this is a the most commonly
used is to randomly generate your
weights what are the different layers in
CNN convolutional neural network first
is the convolutional layer that performs
a convolutional operation we have our
other video out if you want to explore
that more so go into detail exactly how
the C the convolutional layer works in
the CNN as far as creating a number of
smaller uh picture windows that go over
the data uh the second step is has a
railu layer railu brings nonlinearity to
the network and converts all the
negative pixels to zero output is
rectified feature map so it goes into a
mapping feature there pooling layer
pooling is a down sampling operation
that reduces the dimensionality of the
feature map so we have all our Rao layer
which is pulling all these little Maps
out of our convolutional layer is taking
that picture and little creating little
tiny neural networks to look at
different parts of the picture uh then
we need to pull it together and then
finally the fully connected layer so we
flatten our pulling layer out and we
have a fully connected layer recognizes
and classifies the objects in the image
and that's actually your Ford
propagation reverse propagation training
model usually I mean there's number of
different models out there of course
what is pooling in CNN and how does it
work pooling used to reduce the spatial
dimensions of a CNN performs down
sampling operation to reduce the
dimensionality creates a pulled feature
map by sliding a filter Matrix over the
input Matrix I mentioned that briefly on
the previous slide um it's important to
know that you have have if you can see
here they have a rectified feature map
and so each one of those colors like the
yellow color that might be one of the a
smaller little neural network using the
ru you'll look at it'll just kind of um
go over the main picture and look at all
the different areas on the main picture
so you might step one two three four
spaces um and then you have another one
that's also looking at features and it
has a 2785 each one of those is a map so
it might be the first one might be a map
looking for cat ears and the second one
looking for human eyes when it does this
you then have this rectified feature map
looking at these different features and
the max pooling with a 2X two filters
and a stride of two stride means instead
of skipping every pixel you're going to
go every two pixels you take the maximum
values and you can see over here when we
look at a pulled feature map one of the
feature says hey I had a max value of
eight so somewhere in here we saw a
human eye labeled as eight pretty high
label and maybe seven was a human hand
and maybe four was cat whiskers or
something that we thought might be cat
whiskers four is kind of a low number
number in this particular case compared
to the other ones so you have your full
pulled feature map you can see the
process here as we have our stepping we
look for the max value and then we
create a pulled feature map of the maxed
values how does a lstm network work
that's long shortterm memory so the
first thing to know is that an lstms are
a special kind of recurrent neural
network capable of learning long-term
dependencies remembering information for
long periods of time is their default
Behavior we did look at the RNA in
briefly talked about how the hidden
layer feeds back into itself with the
lstm as a much more complicated feedback
and you can see here we have um the
hidden layer of T minus one and hidden
layer that's what the H stands for
hidden layer of T and the formula is
going in as we can see here we have the
hidden layers we have T minus one and
then h of T where T stands for time so
this is a series remember working with
series and we want to remember the past
and you can see you have your your input
of t and that might be a frame in a
video as a frame comes in they usually
use in this one the tangent H activation
formula but you also see that it goes
through a couple other formulas the
Omega formula and so when it combines
these that thing goes into the next
layer your next hidden layer that then
goes into the data that's submitted to
the next input so you have your X of t +
one so when you have that coming in then
you have your H value that's coming
forward from the last process and
depending on how many of these Omega
structures you put in there depends on
how long-term the memory gets so it's
important to remember this is more for
your long-term recurrent neural networks
the three steps in an lstm step one
decides what to forget and what to
remember step two selectively update
cell State values So based on what we
want to remember and forget we want to
update those cell values and then
decides what part of the current state
make it to the output so now we have to
also have an output on there what are
Vanishing and exploding gradients this
is a great question that affects all our
neural networks while training an RNN
your slope can become either too small
or too large and this makes the training
difficult when the slope is too small
the problem is known as Vanishing
gradient so our slope we have our change
in X and our change in y when the slope
decreases gradually to a very small
value sometimes negative and makes
training difficult when the slope tends
to grow exponentially instead of
decaying this problem is called
exploding gradient the slope grows EXP
exponentially you can see a nice graph
of that here issues in gradient problem
Long training time poor performance and
low accuracy what is the difference
between Epic bat and iteration in deep
learning epic an epic represents one
iteration over the entire data set so
it's everything you're going to go ahead
and put into that training model batch
we cannot pass the entire data set into
the neural network at once so we divide
the data set into a number of batches
and then iteration if we have 10,000
images as data and batch size of 200
then the Epic should run 10,000 times
over 200 so that means we have our total
number over the 200 equals 50 iteration
so in each epic we're running over all
the data set we're going to have 50
iterations and each of those iterations
includes a batch of 200 images in this
case why tensorflow is the most
preferred library in deep learning uh
well first tensorflow provides both C++
and python apis that makes it easier to
work on has a faster compilation time
than and other deep learning libraries
like carass and torch tensorflow
supports both CPUs and gpus Computing
devices so right now tensor flow is at
the top of the market because it's so
easy to use for both programmer side and
for Hardware side and for the speed of
getting something up and running what do
you mean by tensor and tensor flow
tensor is a mathematical object
represented as arrays of higher
Dimension these arrays of data with
different dimensions and ranks that are
fed as input to the neural network are
called tensors you here we have a tensor
of Dimensions 5 comma 4 so it's a
two-dimensional tensor coming in um you
can look at an image like this that each
one of those pixels is a different value
if it's a black and white so it might be
zero and ones and then each one
represents a black and white image in a
color photo you might um either find a
different value system or you might have
a tensor value that has the XY
coordinates as we see here plus the
colors so you might have three more
different dimensions for the three
different images the red the blue and
the yellow coming in and even as you go
from one layer or one tensor to the next
these layers might change we might
flatten them might bring in numerous in
the case of the convergence neural
network we have all those smaller
different mappings of features that come
in so each one of those layers coming
through is a tensor if it has multiple
Dimensions coming in and weights
attached to it what are the programming
elements in tensor flow well we have our
constants constants are parameters whose
value does not change to define a
constant we use tf. constant command
example a ALS tf. constant 2.0 TF float
32 so it's a tensor float value of 32 b
equal TF constant 3.0 print AB if we did
a print of ab we'd have um tf. constant
and then of course uh B is that instance
of it variables variables allow us to
add new trainable parameters to graph to
Define a variable we use tf. variable
command and initialize them before
running the graph in session example wal
TF variable 3 dtype TF float 32 or B
equal a TF variable minus 3 comma dtype
float 32 placeholders placeholders allow
us to feed data to a tensor flow model
from outside a model it permits a value
to be assigned later to define a
placeholder we use TF placeholder
command example a equal TF placeholder
Bal a * 2 with the TF session as sess
result equals session run B comma feed
dictionary equals a 3.0 print result uh
so we have a nice example there of a
placeholder session a session is run to
evaluate the noes this is called as the
tensor flow runtime so for example you
have AAL TF constant 2.0 Bal TF constant
4.0 Cal a plus b and at this point you'd
go ahead and create a session equals TF
session and then you could evaluate the
tensor C print session run C that would
input c as an input into your session
what do you understand by a
computational graph everything in tensor
flow is based on creating a
computational graph it has a network of
nodes where each node performs an
operation nodes represent mathematical
operation and edges represent tensors
since data flows in a form of a graph it
is also called a data flow graph and we
have a nice visual of this graph or
graphic image of a computational graph
and you can see here we have our input
nodes our add multiply nodes and our
multiply node at the end and then we
have the edges where the data flows so
we have from a going to C A going to D
you can see we have a two- flowing a
four flowing explain gener adversarial
Network along with an example suppose
there's a wine shop that purchases wine
from dealers which they will resell
later so have our dealer point to the
wine or shop owner that then sells it
for a profit but there are some malactor
dealers who sell fake wine in this case
the shop owner should be able to
distinguish between fake and authentic
wine the forger will try to different
techniques to sell fake wine and make
sure certain techniques go past the shop
owner's check so here's our forger fake
wine shop owner the shop owner would
probably get some feedback from from the
wine experts that some of the wine is
not original the owner would have to
improve how he determines whether a wine
is fake or authentic goal of forger to
create wines that are indistinguishable
from the authentic ones goal of shop
owner to accurately tell if the wine is
real or not there are two main
components of generative adversarial
Network and we refer it to as a noise
Vector coming in where we have our
forger who's going to generate fake wine
and then we have our real authentic wine
and of course our shop owner has to
figure out whether it's real or fake the
generator is a CNN that keeps producing
images that are closer in appearance to
the real images while the discriminator
tries to determine the difference
between real and fake images the
ultimate aim is to make the
discriminator learn to identify real and
fake images what is an auto encoder the
network is trained to reconstruct its
inputs it is a neural network that has
three layers here the input neurons are
equal to the output neuron the Network's
Target outside is same as the input it
uses dimensional ity reduction to
restructure the input input image comes
in we have our Latin space
representation and then it goes back out
reconstructing the image it works by
compressing the input to a Latin space
representation and then reconstructing
the output from this representation what
is bagging and boosting bagging and
boosting are Ensemble techniques where
the idea is to train multiple models
using the same learning algorithm and
then take a call so we have in here
where we're bagging we take a data set
and we split it we're going to have our
training data and test data very
standard thing to do then we're going to
randomly select data into the bags and
train your model separately so we might
have bag one model one bag two model two
bag three model 3 and so on in boosting
the infanist is to select the data
points which give wrong output in order
to improve the accuracy so in boosting
we have our data set again we split it
to test data and train data and we'll
take a bag one and we'll train the model
data points with wrong predictions then
go into Bag two and we then train that
model and repeat
and with that we have come to the end of
this deep learning and NLP course please
ask any question about the topics
covered in this video in the comment
section below our experts will assist
you in addressing your problems thank
you for watching stay safe and keep
learning staying ahead in your career
requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here